GOOD MORNING. I WAS WAITING FOR
MAKING SURE ADVISED PLAN
ATTENTION I WILL CONTINUE TO
TAKE SOME OF THE- CAUTIONS IN
ORDER MANAGE CODE NINETEEN ROSE
THE SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME. THE SENATE CONTINUES TO WALK
ON THE PUBLIC IMAGE PROVIDED
ACCESS TO BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCES POTION. FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT BE A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICES THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WILL B DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
I WANT BUT NOW TODAY'S REDUCE
THE DISSERTATION PARTICIPANTS.
TODAY'S PARTICIPATE NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AT. EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOR.
AN ACCESS CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE
ONE ONE FOUR ONE THAT'S ONE FOUR
ONE ONE ONE FOUR ONE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING HEARING
AS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE NEEDING SERVICES
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS.
NEEDED WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY IN THE
CAPITOL BUILDING AND WE ASK THE
MEMBERS ON THE- PLEASE REPORT TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE SO WE KIND OF
STOPS FOREMAN BEGAN. OUR
HEARING. TODAY WE HAVE SEVEN
BILLS ON OUR AGENDA THREE OF
WHICH ARE ON CONSENT. SB TWELVE
SEVENTY TWO BY SENATOR BACKER S.
B. TEN EIGHTY SEVEN BY SENATOR.
GONZALEZ AND SB FOURTEEN NINETY
WHICH IS OUR COMMITTEE OMNIBUS
BILL. AND S. B. EIGHT SEVEN FIVE
HAS BEEN PULLED TODAY BY SENATOR
SKINNER- WELL WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM BUT WE'RE GONNA START AS
SUBCOMMITTEE AND I HEAR SENATOR
BATES IS WHERE WELL WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM WITH. WELL MANSERGH ALSO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS A WORK OKAY WE'RE GONNA
. BRADFORD YOUR RECORD HERE TO
SHOW BOTH TROUBLED HERE COM
LAGER KAMLAGER HERE SKINNER
WIENER WE HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE
A QUORUM ON LET'S FOR SUSPENSE
WITH OUR CONSENT CALENDAR WE
HAVE THREE ITEMS AS I STATED. WE
GET MOTION ON THE CONSENT
DOLLARS. SOME OF. CANCEL PLEASE
CALDERON CONSENT CONSENT
CALENDAR BRADFORD HI REDFORD I'D
SHOW BOTH TURBO GUY COME LONGER
COMMAGER AYE SKINNER WINNER
LOSER ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS ARE CONCERNED- NOW THE
REFORMS BEEN ESTABLISHED WE WILL
FIRST HEAR FROM OUR OUR FIRST
AUTHOR. AND AGAIN IN CENTER
FIRST WALK TO CENTER ON BURKE.
AND CENTER ON BURGERS PRESENTING
S. B. NINE EIGHT SIX WHEN YOU'RE
PREPARED YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES FOR YOUR
ACCOMMODATION- I WANT TO. IN
ADDITION I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND HIS STAFF IN
PARTICULAR STILICHO E. FOR THEIR
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL I'M HERE
TODAY WITH THE JOINT AUTHORS
CENTER PORTANTINO. ON S. B. NINE
EIGHT SIX PREVENTING CATTLE
OCCURRED CONVERTER THEFT AS I
THINK ALL OF US KNOW KELLY
CONVERTER THEFTS BECOME IT
THAT'S A BECOME AN EPIDEMIC
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT LEGAL CHALLENGES OF
PROSECUTING THE THEFT CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS. CURRENTLY UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW. SB NINE EIGHT
SIX WOULD ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND
WILL PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S BY
REQUIRING CAR DEALERS TO MARK
VEHICLES EQUIPPED WITH CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS- FOR SALE. THE
ETCHING PROCESS CAN BE EASY
INEXPENSIVE IN FACT I HAVE H.
SOME CATHOLIC CONVERTERS MYSELF
ALSO CURRENTLY THE EXISTING LAWS
INSUFFICIENT BECAUSE IT LACKS
THE OBLIGATION OF A CORE
RECYCLER TO OBTAIN INFORMATION
NECESSARY TO IDENTIFY THE ORIGIN
OF A USE CATALYTIC CONVERTER
THAT IS THAT THE CORE RECYCLER
PURCHASED THEREFORE SB NINE
EIGHT SIX WOMAN THE CODE BY
REQUIRING CORE RECYCLERS TO LOG
THE UNIQUE IDENTIFICATION NUMBER
OF EACH CATALYTIC CONVERTER. IN
ADDITION. OTHER CURRENT IDEA.
CARMEN'S WESLEY S. B. NINE EIGHT
SIX WOULD REQUIRE CORPS
RECYCLERS PROVIDE PAYMENT. FOR
CATHOLIC CONVERTERS- THAT THEY
BE MADE TRACEABLE BY FOR PAYMENT
OTHER THAN CASH I HAVE WITH ME
ALEXANDER- CANAAN WITH LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN ROSEMARY
SHAKE HAND WITH CONSUMERS FOR
AUTO RELIABILITY AND SAFETY. BOB
PROVIDES THOSE TWO WITNESSES TOO
MANY EACH SO FAR WHAT NO
PARTICULAR ORDER WHOEVER'S READY
WE CAN GO WITH YOUR FIRST
WITNESS. AND ALSO- IF YOU MIGHT-
ALLOW JOINT AUTHORS CENTER
PORTANTINO TO MAKE AN OPENING
STATEMENT RIGHT HERE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST ECHO MY
COLLEAGUES' COMMENTS CATALYTIC
CONVERTER CONVERTER THEFT IS OUT
OF CONTROL ACROSS CALIFORNIA-
AND WE MUST TAKE PRUDENT STEPS
TO ADDRESS IT AND I THINK THIS
BILL DOES AND THAT'S- OBVIOUSLY
THE APPROPRIATE. WE S. RIVAL.
WE'LL START WITH YOUR FIRST-
LEAD AUTHOR I MEAN WITNESS SOME
SORRY- SHANAHAN ON THE LINE
MODERATOR TO WE HAVE EITHER THE
TO. WHEN THIS IS ON THE LINE.
MODERATOR. DO WE HAVE THE
MODERATOR ONLINE. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE THIS IS ALEX. MAKE. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL START WITH OUR
FIRST WITNESS IN SUPPORT YOU
HAVE TO MANAGE. HEY GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE MY NAME IS ALEX KIRK
JANET I'M A DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY WITH LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WITH
THE SPONSORS OF THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION. ABILITY A FOR
TWENTY NINE YEARS FOURTEEN OF
WHICH WERE WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AUTO THEFT TASK FORCE
WHERE HE SERVED AS THE DEPUTY IN
CHARGE. I'M HERE TO TALK TO YOU
TODAY ABOUT THE DRAMATIC
INCREASE IN CATALYTIC CONVERTER
THEFT THEY'RE NOT GONNA BELIEVER
THE CATALYTIC CONVERTER PROBLEM
WILL OPEN UP AT THAT MAKE IT'S
BEEN A DISASTER. I WOULD LOVE
HOWEVER- HOW WE ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE PROSECUTORS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ARE ALL FACING THE SAME
PROBLEM A LIZARD IN IDENTIFYING
NUMBERS ON THE CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS IT'S ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE FOR US TO
SUCCESSFULLY PROSECUTE CATALYTIC
CONVERTER THEFT. EVERYONE KNOWS
THAT ALL OF OUR CARS HAVE I
DON'T SERIAL NUMBERS CALLED VIN
THE NUMBER THAT'S ON YOUR
DASHBOARD. BUT WHAT YOU MIGHT
NOT KNOW IS THAT SAME BEEN
NUMBERS ALL OVER THE INSIDE OF
YOUR CAR. IT'S AN ANTI THEFT
DEVICE. VIRTUALLY EVERY.
COMPONENT INSIDE YOUR CAR'S MORE
WITH YOUR VIN NUMBER EXCEPT FOR
ONE THAT YOUR CATALYTIC
CONVERTER. THEFTS OF CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS HAS EXPLODED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THIS CRIME IS
A LOT OF MONEY AND IT'S
VIRTUALLY RISK FREE. UNLESS THE
THIEVES ARE ACTUALLY CAUGHT IN
THE ACT THE POLICE CAN DO
NOTHING. BECAUSE WE CAN'T PROVE
THAT THE CONVERSAR. R. TWO THEN
FOR CAT OFTENTIMES RECYCLERS.
AND WE CAN'T CURRENTLY HOLD THE
RECYCLERS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
PURCHASE OF STOLEN GOODS BECAUSE
WITHOUT THAT IDENTIFYING NUMBER
THERE'S NO WAY TO PROVE THAT THE
CUTS ARE STOLEN. THIS BILL
ADDRESSES BOTH ISSUES AND WILL
HAVE IMMEDIATE IMPACT. SHOULD
THIS BILL GOING TO AFFECT IF THE
THIEVES ARE CAUGHT WITH EVEN IF
YOU CATALYTIC CONVERTERS THAT
CAN BE PROVEN TO BE STOLEN. WE
CAN HOLD THEM RESPONSIBLE FOR
THEIR ACTIONS. WHAT THE
CATALYTIC CONVERTERS CAN BE
IDENTIFIED WIDESPREAD MARKET FOR
THE STOLEN PARTS SHOULD
COLLAPSE. NO CATALYTIC CONVERTER
THEFTS LIKE ALL OF THAT IS NEVER
GOING TO COMPLETELY GO AWAY. BUT
THIS BILL WILL DRAMATICALLY
REDUCE THE PROBLEM. OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT COLLEAGUES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY ARE ALL CONSIDERING
A SIMILAR APPROACH AND WE URGE
YOU TO DO THE SAME. IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER THEM OTHERWISE I JUST ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. MOVE TO OUR NEXT
WITNESS. ROSE MERRY SHATTERED
BRAG. RIGHT THERE ARE CHORE
BOGEY AND MEMBERS I'M WITH MARY
SHEA HAND PRESIDENT CONSUMERS
FOR AUTO RELIABILITY AND SAFETY
OR CARS SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
SIX CARS HAVE SPEARHEADED
ENACTMENT OF NUMEROUS LAWS IN
CALIFORNIA AND NATIONALLY TO
IMPROVE PROTECTION FOR OWNERS OF
NEW AND USED VEHICLES CARS DRUM
WE SUPPORT PASSAGE OF SB NINETY
EIGHTY SIX AND WE APPLAUD
SENATOR I'M BURKE AND IN ORDER
PORTANTINO FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP.
IN CHAMPIONING THIS IMPORTANT
AND TIMELY MEASURE AS YOU'VE
ALREADY HEARD AND I WILL REPEAT-
THAT THE CATALYTIC CONVERTERS
HAVE BEEN. SKYROCKETING AND-
MAKE THEM. CATTLE CONVERTERS
HAVE BEEN. OFTEN FACE REAL
HARDSHIP AS A RESULT. WHILE
INSURANCE USUALLY COVERS THE
BULK OF THE REPLACEMENT COST
VEHICLE OWNERS ARE OFTEN THAT
HAVING TO PAY HEFTY DEDUCTIBLES
AND SOMETIMES ALSO SEE THEIR
INSURANCE RATE INCREASE. NOT TO
MENTION THE HASSLE FACTOR OF
HAVING TO MAKE ARRANGEMENTS FOR
REPAIRS AND TAKING TIME FROM
BUSY WORK SCHEDULE TO GET THE
REPAIRS DONE. AND IN ADDITION-
UNFORTUNATELY SOME VEHICLE
OWNERS IN HIGH RISK AREAS OR
WITH CARS THAT TEND TO BE
TARGETED BY THIEVES ARE
VICTIMIZED REPEATEDLY AND NAM
ESTABLISHMENTS HAVE BEEN HAVING
TO INVEST- VERY SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT IN SECURITY EXPENSES AND
OTHER- ATTEMPTS TO. HE TURNED
BASS SB NINE EIGHTY SIX WILL
ADDRESS BOTH ENDS OF THE
TRANSACTION AND WE RESPECTFULLY
I VOTE I REQUEST YOUR IPHONE
THANK YOU. YOU KNOW WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM WE
HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. NINE EIGHT SIX RED HAT. KIM
STONE STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
. KEEP. WARMEST CHAIR MEMBERS
RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT AS WELL AS THE POLICE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATIONS OF
CLAREMONT CORONA AMONA PALACE
VERDES NEWPORT BEACH. UPLAND
SANTA ANA BURBANK INGLEWOOD
ARCADIA RIVERSIDE ELLIE SCHOOL
POLICE FULLERTON AND CULVER CITY
PO A HOLLAND SUPPORT THANK YOU
HERE. JERRY BROWN FOR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE RUSTY CAN YOU TURN
ON BEHALF OF THE AUTOMOBILE CLUB
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR THE
MEASURE. THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES HERE IN.
ROOM ONE TWELVE SUPPORTING. IF
NOT. MODERATE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES ARE THEIR OWN
WITNESSES WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE EIGHT SIX.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT NINE
EIGHT SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. BLANK SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CARE AND NUMBER EIGHTY ANY
CANDLE KAISER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. HERE I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
NOW WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION IS
OR ANY WITNESSES HERE IN THE
ROOM- I GUESS WE HAVE ANTHONY
SAMPSON AND JOHN MOFFETT- YOU
MAY BEGIN YOUR TESTIMONY OF TWO
MINUTES EACH GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN WAS ANTHONY SAMPSON THE
SAMPSON ADVISERS HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA NEW CAR
DEALERS ASSOCIATION. C. IN CDA
HAS TAKEN AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON SB NINETY
SIX VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS
WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE IN A
DIALOGUE WITH US REGARDING OUR
CONCERNS I VERY MUCH SUPPORT THE
UNDERLYING INTENT OF THE BILL
INTO THIS END SUPPORTS. LAKE
CONVERTER- MEASURES PENDING IN
THE LEGISLATURE RIGHT NOW
FOCUSED. ON ENFORCEMENT. AS IT
RELATES TO THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
ASEAN CTAS CONCERNS RELATE
SPECIFICALLY TO THE REQUIREMENT
THAT DEALERSHIPS PERMANENTLY
MARKER ETCH THE VIN NUMBER INTO
THE- CONVERTER BEFORE. TOLD AS A
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT
AND AS WE'VE DISCUSSED WITH THE
AUTHOR AS WELL AS THE SPONSORS-
MANY VEHICLE MODELS INCORPORATE
THE CATALYTIC CONVERTER IS PART
OF THE EXHAUST MANIFOLD. REQUIRE
DEALERSHIP TECHNICIANS TO
DISASSEMBLE A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF THE VEHICLE ENGINE
JUST ACCESS THE CATALYTIC
CONVERTER. TO BROUGHT PROVIDE
JUST TWO EXAMPLES TO PERMANENTLY
MARK ONE VOLVO MODEL WOULD TAKE
DEAL PROTECT. TO FOUR HOURS THE
PERMANENTLY MARK ONE VEHICLE
DEPENDING ON ENGINE VARIANTS.
AND FOR CERTAIN ACCURATE MODELS
IT CAN TAKE TWO TO FIVE HOURS.
BUT EVEN ASSUMING A PERMANENT
MARKING VIN NUMBERS INTO
CATALYTIC CONVERTERS WAS SIMPLE
AND INEXPENSIVE WE WOULD JUST
NOTE FOR THE COMMITTEE THAT MANY
OF THE MOST TARGETED VEHICLES
ARE NOT BEING SOLD. THE CARD FOR
SHIPS. DATA FROM THE SERVICE
DEPARTMENT ONE LARGE TOYOTA
DEALERSHIP. FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS THAT THE MOST
TARGETED VEHICLE. ARE THOUSAND
SIXTY TWO THOUSAND NINE PRIUS IS
WHICH VERY NEW CAR DEALERS EVEN
SELF. RATHER THOSE ARE SOLD
THROUGH PRIVATE VENDOR SELLERS
LIKE REGULAR THE VOTER. AGAIN.
AUTHOR I'M MORE. SOLELY WHILE
ALSO THE YOU CARTY. ARE NOT
SADDLED WITH THE LABOR
INTENSIVE. AND COSTLY OBLIGATION
OF PERMANENTLY MARKING EACH
VEHICLE THEY SELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT THIS. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JOHN MOFFETT ON BEHALF
OF THE ALLIANCE FOR AUTOMOTIVE
INNOVATION OR THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR THE AUTO MAKERS
HERE TODAY. STANDING WITH OUR
OUR DEALER PARTNERS- WITH AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THE BILL WE HAVE BEEN IN
CONTACT WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICES
AND THEIR STAFF AND APPRECIATE
THE ONGOING CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THIS BILL- ONE AGREE WITH WITH
MISTER SAMPSON THAT WE BELIEVE
AS AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED THE BILL
IS OVERLY BROAD. CATALYTIC
CONVERTER THEFT IS A IS A CRIME
OF EXPEDIENCY AND IF- IF IT
TAKES TWO TO THREE HOURS FOR A
TRAINED TECHNICIAN TO GET TO A
CATALYTIC CONVERTER IT'S
PROBABLY NOT A PRIME TARGET FOR
CATALYTIC CONVERTER THEFT- IS.
THE BILL IT'S TO BE NARROWED IN
ITS SCOPE IN ADDITION. WE
BELIEVE- MANDATING ETCHING
ENGRAVING- YOU KNOW THE
CATALYTIC CONVERTERS PUT ON THE
VEHICLE FOR AN AIR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT PURPOSE WE ARE
CONCERNED NOT ALL DEALERS. THAT
THE BILL APPLIES TO OUR MISTER
SAMPSON'S MEMBERS. THEY'RE LESS
SOPHISTICATED OPERATORS OUT
THERE IN THE SPACE IN THE
MANDATE THEM TO START PUNCHING
HOLES. INTO CATTLE IT. IS NOT A
GOOD THING WE PREFER WORD
PHRASES LIKE CARMEN AND MARKING
AND THE EXPLORATION OF OTHER
APPROACHES TO THIS. IN ADDITION
WE THINK THAT THE BILLS A LITTLE
NARROW IN ITS APPLICATION WITH
RESPECT TO SOLUTIONS- THE BUREAU
OF AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR AS WELL AS
MANY INSURANCE COMPANIES HAVE
COME OUT WITH GUIDELINES FOR
CONSUMERS TO HELP. DETER
CATALYTIC CONVERTER THEFT
OBVIOUSLY VENN MARKING IS ONE OF
THEIR- SOLUTIONS BUT THOSE PUT
SALUTE. SO INCLUDE AFTERMARKET
ARE PROTECTIVE DEVICES- MOTION
SENSING ALARMS OTHER. OTHER
TOOLS THAT THE CONSUMER CAN USE
THAT ACTUALLY. EVENT THE
CATALYTIC CONVERTER FROM BEING
STOLEN IN THE FIRST PLACE NOT
JUST PROVIDE A CHAIN OF EVIDENCE
AFTER IT'S ALREADY BEEN STOLEN
WE THINK THAT'S A WORTHWHILE
DISCUSSION HAVE- AS THE BILL
CONTINUES TO MOVE FORWARD AND
AGAIN WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
TIME. AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ARE THERE
ARE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION HERE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WISHES TO
SPEAK. IN OPPOSITION OF US THREE
NINE EIGHT SIX. JINAN MODERATOR
LET'S GO TO OUR PHONE LINES INTO
AFTER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT AND
OPPOSITION OUT SB NINE EIGHT SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND
THERE ARE NONE RIGHT WE'LL BRING
YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
BY COMMITTEE MEMBER SENATOR CALM
WATER. THANK YOU I AM JUST HAD A
FEW AND THIS SEEMS TO BE-
CATALYTIC CONVERTER DAY. AND
THIS IS A COMMITTEE. SO I DID
HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS- ARE THE
ISSUES FROM THE OPPOSITION BEING
ADDRESSED IS OUR WAY TO. I THINK
THAT'S RIGHT- SINCE INTRODUCTION
THE BILL WE HAVE BECOME AWARE
THAT IS MORE CHALLENGING ON
CERTAIN MODELS- TO ETCH. THE
CATALYTIC CONVERTER YOU HAVE TO
DISASSEMBLE AND REASSEMBLE AND I
THINK THE OPPONENTS ARE
CORRECTED SOMETIMES TAKES HOURS
THE BILL CORRECT IN THAT-
THIEVES. MOST LIKELY AREN'T
GOING TO ATTACK A VEHICLE THAT
REQUIRES YOU KNOW SEVERAL
MINUTES OF NON OUR TO
DISASSEMBLE AND SOLD US IN
APPROPRIATIONS ORGAN AMEND THE
BILL TO AMEND OUT. OF THOSE.
THOSE MODELS. THAT DO NOT ALLOW
FOR READY ACCESS THE CATALYTIC
CONVERTER CORE SETS DEPEND UPON
THE CHEER OF APPROPRIATIONS AND
WHETHER HE OR NOT HE GREASE THAT
ARE NOT. FEATURE TO- EVEN THOUGH
I IS A CO AUTHOR JOIN- THE
SECOND IS THIS JUST FOR. DEALERS
OR DOES IT ALSO WOULD ALSO
INCLUDE- CAPTURE INDIVIDUAL
SELLERS JUST DEALERS OKAY AND
THEN- THE THIRD QUESTION WAS. SO
CURRENTLY FOR EXAMPLE- NGUYEN
DEALERS ARE SELLING- AS A YOU
KNOW A VEHICLE THAT'S BEEN IN M.
ACCIDENT THEY'RE REQUIRED TO
HAVE A- THE TITLE THAT SAYS IT
SALVAGED AND SO IT'S UP TO THE
BUYER TO MAKE THEIR OWN
DETERMINATION ABOUT IF THEY WANT
TO PURCHASE THE VEHICLE- IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION ABOUT MAYBE
HAVING SOMETHING SIMILAR TO THAT
FOR THIS- BECAUSE- I MEAN AT THE
END OF THE DAY. I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS WHAT'S THE OUTCOME
THAT YOU DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO
PURCHASE CARS THAT HAVE A STOLEN
CATALYTIC CONVERTER OR YOU DON'T
WANT. IT SO BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE IT'S HITTING THE PERSON IN
THE MIDDLE WHO MAY BE KNOWINGLY
OR UNKNOWINGLY RIGHT SELLING A
VEHICLE THAT HAS A STOLEN. WHAT
IS THE- SO FAR AS I KNOW THE
STOLEN CATALYTIC CONVERTERS ARE
ARE NOT PLACED ON OTHER VEHICLES
THEIR THEIR OWN FOR PURPOSES OF
PRECIOUS METALS AND SO I THINK
IT'S UNLIKELY THAT SOMEONE WOULD
PURCHASE A VEHICLE THAT HAS A OF
PREVIOUSLY STOLEN CATALYTIC
CONVERTER WHICH WAS A FIX TO
THAT VEHICLE. OKAY AND THEN THE
LAST QUESTION IS- IT DOES SAY IN
HERE THAT THE BILL WOULD INSTEAD
I. WOULD INSTEAD OF PAYMENT BY
CHECK REQUIRE PAYMENT BY ANY
TRACEABLE MATH OTHER THING AXE
SO- I WANT TO KNOW DOES THAT
INCLUDE OR PRECLUDE DIGITAL
CURRENCY- THAT'S A VERY GOOD
QUESTION US. COM LONGER. I THINK
WE HAVE A DRESS THAT UP TO THE
EXTENT THE DIGITAL TUR CURRENCY
CANNOT BE TRACED IT WOULD NOT BE
A VALID FORM OF PAYMENT. BUT IT
IT CAN BE SO THEN. SO JUST
BECAUSE THAT SILENT DOESN'T MEAN
IT PROHIBITS- THAT'S CORRECT BUT
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET AROUND
IT OUR FOLKS WHO STILL CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS. THEN THEY SELL THEM
TO A RECYCLER FOR EXAMPLE FOR
CASH AND SO WE CAN'T IDENTIFY
THOSE WHO'VE STOLEN OR THOSE ARE
IN THE BUSINESS OF COLLECTING
STOLEN CATALYTIC CONVERTERS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
ARMED COMMITTEE. I HAVE ONE IN
EACH HAS TO DO WITH THE FACT
THAT AND I THINK THE NEW COLLAR
CAR DEALERS PRESENTATION STATED
THAT- THE NUMBERS ARE INJURED
VARIOUS LOCATIONS ON THE CAR WHY
SHOULDN'T MANUFACTURES JUST NOW
START. ON THE PRODUCTION SIDE OF
INCLUDING THE VIN NUMBER THAT
WOULD BE A LOT SIMPLER THAN
HAVING A CAR IT IS SIMPLE AND
THEN ON THE DEALER'S SHOWROOM
AND NOW HAVING TO HAVE TO. GO
BACK IN AT THAT NUMBER AND NEW
CAR DEALERS OR ALLIANCE CAN
ANSWER THAT QUESTION. YEAH
MISTER CHAIR HAPPY TO ADDRESS
THAT THAT QUESTION. THAT WOULD.
AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE- PRODUCTION
FACILITIES THROUGHOUT THE WORLD
TRYING TO SUPPLY THE ENTIRE
WORLD WITH CARS SOME OF THOSE
ARE BUILT HERE IN CENTER.
OVERSEAS SUMMER BILL PERVERSE
AND SENT HERE- THE CATALYTIC
CONVERTER AND OTHER COMPONENTS
OF THE VEHICLE OR SOME OF THE
LAST THINGS PUT ON THE VEHICLE
BUT THERE BEFORE THEY'RE
SHIPPED. AND WE DON'T KNOW WHERE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE SHIPPED
WHICH COUNTRY AND SO TO RETOOL
ALL OF OUR PRODUCTION FACILITIES
WOULD COST HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS TO STAMP THE YOU KNOW
TO STAMP THE VAN ON THE
CATALYTIC CONVERTER AND AS I
PREVIOUSLY STATED WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT POTENTIAL DAMAGE
TO CATALYTIC CONVERTERS AND
THEIR AIR QUALITY IMPACT IF THEY
ARE STAMPED OR ENGRAVED LASTLY-
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS I
THINK THE COMMITTEE TO KEEP IN
MIND IS THIS YOU KNOW IF THAT
WERE. A SALUTE OF. LOVINS AS WE
CONTINUE TO MARCH TOWARDS THE
ADOPTION OF THE A. R. P.'S-
ADVANCED CLEAN CARS TO RULE- BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE AND STAGES
YOU KNOW EARNS HIS THROUGHOUT-
WE WILL BE SELLING MORE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES IN THE STATE
WHICH DON'T HAVE CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS. GOT A- ALL RIGHT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS KERN TINA
TURNER- BURKE CENTER FOR
INTERNAL TALK CLOSE UP THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF TO
ADDRESS THE QUESTION.
SOLUTION IT WOULD BE BEST IF THE
MANUFACTURERS ACTUALLY HAD THE
NUMBER ON THE CATALYTIC
CONVERTER THE POINT OF
MANUFACTURE WE DON'T HAVE
JURISDICTION THOUGH TO- REQUIRE
THAT MANUFACTURERS DO SO- THE
POINT'S WELL TAKEN THAT
ULTIMATELY PRESS WILL ALL HAVE
ELECTRIC VEHICLES WITHOUT THAT'S
SEVERAL YEARS FROM NOW IN THE
MEANTIME THIS IS AN EPIDEMIC
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED- AND
FOR ALL THOSE REASONS I URGE A
NO VOTE AND PORTANTINO. NO I
THINK MY COLLEAGUE SAID IT WELL
THIS IS A PROBLEM THAT NEEDS TO
BE SOLVED- THESE PARTS ARE BEING
SOLD FOR THE PRECIOUS METALS AND
IF WE CAN DETER THAT- A LOT OF
FOLKS TO GO OUT A LOT OF FOLKS
TO GO OUT INTO THEIR JOB. AND
CARS IN OPERABLE WILL BE ABLE TO
GO TO WORK CONSERVE RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. ALL RIGHT AND WE'RE
LOOKING FOR MOTION THAT WOULD DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
UNDERSTANDING THAT AMENDMENTS
WILL BE TAKEN IN APPROPRIATIONS
TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED BY. NEW CAR
DEALERS. THIS MOVE BY SENATOR
SCANNER COUNCIL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON S. B. NINE H. SIX. SB
EIGHT NINE SYSTEM OKAY SB NINE
EIGHT SIX DO PASSED HER
PREPARATIONS BRADFORD. BRADFORD
AYE THE TROUBLE OKAY. THE
TROUBLE GUY COME AUGER COME
LONGER NOT VOTING SKINNER
SKINNER I. THE MEASURE HAS THREE
VOTES WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS NOW
WILL GO TO CENTER BATES THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- SERVICE. EACH YEAR
PRESENTING SB NINE OH EIGHT
FINAL FOUR.
SIGN UP FOR GRABS THAT'S CORRECT. MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO BRING
BACK SB NINE OH FOUR WHICH
CLARIFIES THE STANDARDS OF
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE EDUCATION
AND TREATMENT PROGRAMS FOR THE
THIRTIES PROBATIONERS AND
PRISONERS AND I TRULY APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE'S WILLINGNESS TO
GIVE THIS BILL A SECOND HEARING
I DO UNDERSTAND THAT YOU HAVE A
VERY LONG AGENDA TODAY SO I'M
GOING TO KEEP IT SHORT SINCE I.
BROUGHT THE BILL BLASS WROTE THE
BILL UP AND COMMITTEE MY STAFF
WHO WORKED WITH OPPOSITION TO
FORMULATE AMENDMENTS WHICH
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS AS WELL
AS THE CONCERNS THAT WERE
BROUGHT UP HERE- BY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE WHICH IS AMENDMENT
SEVERAL GROUPS HAVE RESPONDED BY
REMOVING THEIR OPPOSITION THE
AMENDMENTS FIX THE- DIFF.
WELCOME EDUCATION PROGRAM WHICH
WILL TELL ME TENDON HAS COME DID
THE DRUG TREATMENT WITH IT
WITHOUT ANY REQUIREMENT THE
DEFENDANT WILL NOT RELAPSE IN
THE FUTURE THIS WAS DONE BY
STRIKING CURRENT COAL THAT
STATES THAT SESIL COMPLETION
INCLUDES REASONABLE CAUSE TO
BELIEVE THAT THE DEFENDANT WILL
NOT ABUSE CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES
IN THE FUTURE THIS COMPLETING
THE PROGRAMS THAT IT'S BEEN
REMOVED WE ARE. I'M FOR HIMSELF
. WILL BE BASED TEST AVAILABLE
IN CURRENT SCIENCE AND EVIDENCE
THE AMENDMENTS WOULD ALSO ENSURE
THE EDUCATION COMPONENT WILL BE
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
APPROPRIATE TO THE DEFENDANT.
AND ADDITIONALLY THEY WILL BE
EDUCATED ON HOW TO RECOGNIZE AND
RESPOND TO THE SIGNS OF A DRUG
OVERDOSE I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE IN PARTICULAR AND THE
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE. FOR THEIR
HARD WORK AND COMMUTE WITH MY
OFFICE IN FORMULATING THURMOND
FANDOM HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY
WITH ME AS RIVERSIDE COUNTY
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY. ROBERT
HIGHTOWER AND WILL BE AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ARE YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU. SHARJAH ON THE LINE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AYE I
WILL ALSO KEEP IT BRIEF I WANNA
SPECIFICALLY THANK ALL THE
MEMBERS FOR THEIR COMMENT IT WAS
EXTREMELY HELPFUL- AND WE WERE
ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT NOT ONLY
DID WE TAKE AMENDMENTS TO THIS
BILL- THAT WOULD- COUPLES WORK
TOGETHER BUT ALSO TO TAKE A LOOK
AT OUR CURRENT. LAW TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE KEEPING UP WITH
OUR MODERN UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
IT MEANS TO HAVE AN ADDITION AND
HOW IT WORKS RIGHT NOW WITH THAT
UNLESS THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS-
I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE MIGHT YOU
WANT TO EXTEND MY THANKS AND
GRATITUDE TO THE DROPOFF WILL
OPEN UP. WITH POLLUTION. IN THE
- GETTING APPROPRIATE TREATMENT
IN DURING THE GULF CRISIS. THANK
YOU. NOW BACK TO THE ROOM THERE
ANY HERE ROOM TWELVE WHICH SPEAK
IN FAVOR OF THE MEASURE. MORNING
MR MEMBERS RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
THE CORONA POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE RIVERSIDE
POLICE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION ON
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SHINO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES HERE
IN THE ROOM MODERATE ALERTS GO
TO OUR PHONE LINES AND SHIFTERS.
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE OH
FOUR. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT AND SUPPORT OF THE BILL
SB ENTITLED. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AND THERE. WILL BE
JUST A MOMENT WE HAVE ONE IN Q.
HI GOOD MORNING. BUT BEING WITH
A POLICY ONLINE- WE- I THINK
WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND SENATOR ON THE
BALLOT- WE HAVE A LOT OF TOPIC.
THANK YOU. YOU NEED TO SHOW
WITNESSES ONLINE WISHING TO
SPEAK- IN SUPPORT NINE FOUR. A
LINE EIGHTY THREE LINE EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HEY
TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON BEHALF OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN COURT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU.
MISS STONE HERE SO I GUESS SHE'S
HERE IN SUPPORT IN STONE STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WARNICK MEDICAL ITALY
ON FROM THEIR SIDE SHARES FARMAN
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINETEEN
NO MORE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NOW
WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION THERE'S
NO LEAD OPPOSITION. MODERATORS
ARE ANYONE HERE IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY AND
OPPOSITION OF S. B. NINE A4.
LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION I JUST WANTED TO
ENSURE THAT THE COMMITTEE AND
THE AUTHOR DO YOU KNOW THAT WE
HAVE WITHDRAWN OUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. BUT IS IT BASED ON
THE AMENDMENTS- HELLO MY NAME IS
OSCAR SORIANO FROM RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. GOT A- ALL RIGHT ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO A THREE NINE FOUR
. NCINO HERE IN THE ROOM
MODERATE LET'S GO TO PHONE LINES
INTO IF THERE'S WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT ON OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL SB NINE OH FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND THERE'S
NO WANTING TO AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS IN REGARDS TO THIS
MEASURE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ALL
RIGHT IT'S BEEN MODE BY CENTER
TO ABOVE CENTER SKINNER. MMS I'M
BECAUSE MY SUPPORTERS- IS THE IN
ORDER BILL OF BEING AMENDED AS
WAS DESCRIBED IN THE ANALYSIS.
SURVEYS AS A CORRECT TO JEFF
YESTERDAY OF. GREAT OUR ARE YOU
LIKE CLOSER TO RAGE I JUST
THOUGHT I WANT TO THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR RECONSIDERATION
OF S. B. AND I DON'T FOR WITH
MANSON I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE CARE. WE HAVE A DEEP
ROSTER PREPARATIONS- AS AMENDED
. AND COUNCIL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. YES ARE THEY BEING TAKEN
IN THE AFTERMATH. WANT TO
CLARIFY SB NINE OH FOUR DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
BRADFORD BRADFORD I'D SHOW BOKE
TROUBLE GUY COME LONGER NINE
FROM LONGER AYE SKINNER. SKINNER
AYE WIENER. THE MEASURE HAS FOR
VIRTUALLY THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES THANK YOU NOW WE'LL MOVE
ON TO SENATE REPORT ARE YOU
HAVING OTHER MEASURES I JUST I
THINK THERE'S A VOTE ONLY ON SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE. WHICH WE
TOOK AMENDMENTS FOR DO YOU HAVE
THAT ON. PLEASE SB THIRTEEN
THIRTY THREE SEXUALLY IS THAT A
VOTE ONLY ON YOUR AGENDA OKAY.
CENTER PORTANTINO WE ARE SB NINE
OH SIX.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING
SP NINE OH SIX WHICH WILL
REQUIRE LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES
. TO INCLUDE INFORMATION ON
FIREARM STORAGE IN THEIR ANNUAL
NOTIFICATION PROVIDED TO PARENTS
AND GUARDIANS AS THE AUTHOR OF
SOME OF THE SAFE STORAGE
LEGISLATION IT'S IMPORTANT. THAT
FAMILIES AT HOME KNOW THE
RESPONSIBILITIES WITH THEIR
FIREARMS- THIS WILL INCREASE
ACCOUNTABILITY IN AWARENESS OF
SAFETY PRECAUTIONS TO HELP KEEP
OUR CHILDREN SAFE. WILL ALSO
ALLOW CONCERNED- SCHOOL
PERSONNEL TO ACT ON A PERCEIVED
FIREARM THREAT. BY ALERTING
SCHOOL CAMPUS LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
INVESTIGATE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
CREDIBLE THREATS- WHICH WILL
PRIORITIZE THE SAFETY OF IN
STUDENTS- TO INSURE WHEN THEY GO
TO SCHOOL WHEN TEACHERS GO TO
SCHOOL WHEN STAFF GO TO SCHOOL
WHEN ADMINISTRATORS GO TO
SCHOOL. THEY COME HOME WE SAW IN
MICHIGAN WHEN A SCHOOL RECEIVED
NOTICE OF A CREDIBLE THREAT AND
THEN THERE WAS INACTION ON THE
PART OF THE ADMINISTRATORS WE
SAW THE TRAGEDY TOOK AS ONE OF
MY COLLEAGUES IN THE PRIOR
COMMITTEE MENTIONED- WE DON'T
EVER WANT TO READ IN THE PAPER
AND SAY WE WISH WE COULD HAVE
DONE MORE WE WISH WE COULD HAVE
SAVED A LIFE. AND SO WITH THIS
BILL DOES IS SAY WHEN YOU HAVE
THE INFORMATION OF A CREDIBLE
THREAT SIT ON IT. DON'T SIT ON
EXCUSE ME- ACT UPON IT- IT'S-
REASONABLE THAT SOME PEOPLE
MIGHT HESITATE- AN ADMINISTRATOR
MIGHT SAY WE KNOW THIS WON'T
HAPPEN HERE. OR WHAT HAPPENS IF
FOR WRONG WHAT WE WHAT WE ANGER
APPARENT IF WE'RE WRONG AND SO
WHAT I WANNA DO IS TAKE THAT OFF
THE TABLE AND SAY YOU KNOW WHAT.
WHEN THAT EIGHTEEN YOUR POST
THAT THREAT ON SOCIAL MEDIA OR
TALK ABOUT IT WITH THEIR FRIENDS
AND YOU KNOW IT'S REAL. YOU MUST
ACT UPON IT AND SO THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL DOES- I DON'T THINK
ANY GRANDPARENT SHOULD EVER IN
THE NEWSPAPER ABOUT. A CHILD
BEING SHOT ON A CAMPUS AND WE
NEED TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN. TODAY I HAVE- TIFFANY
FROM CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS. AND MARGOT THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF WOMEN
AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. WE HAVE IN
PERSON WE HAVE TO MOCK. YES YOU
MAY BEGIN THANK YOU THANK YOU
MEMBERS KAREN MEMBERS TIFFANY
MARC ON BEHALF OF CFT I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
AND THE TIME. AND SEE IF HE IS
IN A UNION OF EDUCATORS AND
CLASSIFY PROFESSIONALS AS WE
LIVE IN THIS MODERN ERA WE LIVE
WITH THE REALITY OF MANY
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS OFTEN AND
WE HOPE THAT WE CAN DO
SOMETHING. THIS BILL IS AN
ATTEMPT TO DO THAT. AS FOLKS
WILL MNTION AND AS YOU READ AND
THEN ALICE'S IT IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS BUT WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT BECAUSE ARE. CLASSIFIED
PERFECT EDUCATORS EACH DAY.
FEARED THE DAILY THREAT OF.
FIRST WITH YOUR IT FOR TEACHERS
WE FEAR FOR OUR STUDENTS AND WE
FEAR FOR OUR PARENTS. AND FOR
OUR WHOLE COMMUNITY AND SERVE
WITH THIS BILL IT JUST PROVIDES
US A FORM TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
BE. A LITTLE BIT MORE. BOB THIS
UNNECESSARILY VIOLENCE. AND SO
WITH THAT MEMBERS I URGE HER AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
. AND DO WE HAVE MARGOT BENNETT
ALONG. YES I'M HERE YOU MAY
BEGIN YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
OH SIX. EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
WOMEN AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE AND
ALMOST THIRTY YEAR OLD NONPROFIT
VIOLENCE PREVENTION AND
ORGANIZATIONS QUARTER LOS
ANGELES. I HAVE SEVERAL YEARS
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS HAVE BECOME
MORE AND MORE FREQUENT ADULT HER
SHIFTED THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
SCHOOL SAFETY TO THE STUDENTS.
WE'VE PUT IN PLACE PROGRAMS SUCH
AS ACTIVE SHOOTER DRILLS SEE
SOMETHING SAY SOMETHING SIGNS OF
SUICIDE ALSO KNOWN AS SOS WHICH
IS A PROGRAM FOR MIDDLE AND HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS IT TEACHES THEM
TO IDENTIFY SIGNS OF DEPRESSION
AND SUICIDE IN THEIR PEERS.
WE'RE TRAINING STUDENTS. TO
LEARN. THIRTEEN YEARS DURING A
SCHOOL SHOOTING. M. WAS AN
ACTIVE SHOOTER DRILL THAT
INCLUDES TEACHING OUR CHILDREN
HOW TO BY. THE GOVERNMENT. AS
THEY TOLD AND- I AM EMBARRASSED
AND ASHAMED WHETHER WE THE
ADULTS GOING TO ASSUME THE
RESPONSIBILITY THAT IS OURS THE
SAFETY OF OUR CHILDREN. WE NOW
HAVE THAT. HELLO THE STATE'S. A
PORTENT HAS INTRODUCED SB NINE
OH SIX A STRONG AND
COMPREHENSIVE BILL THAT WILL
HELP PREVENT SCHOOL SHOOTINGS
AND HELP KEEP ALL OUR CHILDREN
STREET WHILE IN SCHOOL. OUR TURN
TO ACT IT'S OUR TURN TO ACCEPT
RESPONSIBILITY WHEN MANY KIDS
GOOD VIOLENCE ASK THAT YOU VOTE
YES ON THIS IMPORTANT BELL OUR
CHILDREN SHOULD BE ABLE TO. ON
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW WILL
BRING IT BACK TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
OR OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE WISHING TO TESTIFY
HERE IN PERSON. HEARING AND
SEEING NINE WILL GO TO OUR PHONE
LINES MODERATORS. MODERATORS ARE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF SB NINE
OF. I'M SORRY IF IT WAS A COMMON
IN SUPPORT OF BILL OF THE FINAL
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. NINE
EIGHT ZERO NINE ZERO NINE OR SIX
MODERATOR SB SIX. WELL I
APOLOGIZE. BY EIGHT NINE EIGHTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CARE NUMBERS PERSONAL
CHAOS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY ACCOUNT
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS. FIND EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN LINE EIGHTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU JEFF AKA REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS IN SUPPORT. WHAT
DOES. NOT OUT THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL BRING IT TO THE
ROOM IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE OH SIX.
OSKAR'S ORGANIZER READ THE BILL
DEEPLY I OPPOSE THIS BILL. ALL
RIGHT ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
HERE IN CHINO AND BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE. YOUR ANY QUESTIONS
OR CONCERNS AS RELEASES MEASURES
CENTER COME. IT EXCUSE ME. YOU
DO OKAY I DIDN'T HEAR OPPOSITION
CALLS FOR ARE WE STILL HIGH I
THOUGHT IT WAS LAS ON WE HAVE
SOME PHONE OKAY LET'S GO TO
PHONE LINES I'M SORRY. YES GOOD
MORNING- THIS IS KATHY SHERER ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION- I WANT TO START BY
THANKING SENATOR PORTANTINO. FOR
WORKING WITH US TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES THAT WE AND REYES
REGARDING THE BILL- WE VERY MUCH
WANT TO KEEP WORKING WITH THEM
TO MAKE SURE WE GET THIS RIGHT.
SO THAT WE CAN KEEP STUDENTS
SAFE FROM GUN VIOLENCE AND FROM
POTENTIALLY HARMFUL INTERACTIONS
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT. WHEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT RESPONDED NOT NEEDED
. THERE ARE SEVERAL CONCERNS
THAT WE GIVE BELIEVE STILL NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED. FIRST WE
BELIEVE USE OF THE TERM
REASONABLE SUSPICION IN THIS
CONTEXT IS CONFUSING AND WE WANT
TO WORK TO REFINE THE
SUBSTANTIVE STANDARD AS WELL.
SURE WE WE'RE BASING.
QUIRK-SILVA THREATS ON ACTUAL
EVIDENCE THAT THERE REALLY IS A
THREAT. THE SECOND STANDARD FOR
ONE STUDENT BEHAVIOR IS
CLASSIFIED AS A THREAT BECAUSE
THE THREAT REMAINS VERY BROAD
GOING FAR BEYOND BEHAVIORS THAT
INDICATE THAT YOU CAN FIND A LOT
VIOLENT ACTS. FIREMAN'S
REPORTING OF THREATS MUST ALL
FOCUS ON OUR PACKED IN ACTUAL.
NOT KIND OF EXPRESS THAT ARE
TYPICAL OF YOUNG PEOPLE
STRUGGLING WITH DIFFICULT
EMOTIONS. HAVE NO INTENT
WHATSOEVER TO HARM ANYONE.
OTHERWISE WE KNOW WHO WILL
SUFFER MOST. FROM FROM
UNNECESSARY INTERACTION WITH
BOND. AND THAT IT DIDN'T OF
COLOR AND STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. THIRD WORLD NEED
TO RETAIN INTEREST THE LIST TO.
WHETHER OR NOT LAW ENFORCEMENT
INVOLVED IS THE RIGHT RESPONSE
AND THE BEST WAY TO PREVENT
FILE. WE HOPE THAT SCHOOLS WILL
BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY STUDENTS WHO
NEED HELP EARLY BEFORE THERE IS
AN IMMEDIATE RISK OF VIOLENCE.
AND APPROPRIATE SUPPORT. BETTER
TO PREVENT VIOLENCE DONNELLAN
PORTION INVESTIGATION ONE. IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT STUDENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO ADEQUATE MENTAL HEALTH
RECORDS. AND THOSE RESOURCES ARE
ESSENTIAL TO PREVENTING VIOLENCE
IN OUR SCHOOLS SCHOOLS SHOULD
KNOW THAT THEY CAN CHOOSE THOSE
TOOLS. WHEN BACK LEFT THE
PROGRAM. I'M FINALLY WE ARE CAN
THAT THE GROUND ABSOLUTE
IMMUNITY TO SCHOOL OFFICIALS IS
OVERBROAD AND WOULD LIKE TO KEEP
. AGAIN WE LOOK FORWARD TO CAN
TO WITH THE SENATOR AND HIS
STAFF TO MAKE SURE THAT THE BILL
FOCUSES ON TRUE TRAP. AGAINST
SCHOOL PRESSURE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOW WILL MOVE TO
GENERATE. MODERATORS JOHN REED
AVAILABLE. MODERATOR. ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE'RE LOOKING ONE MOMENT.
NO I DO NOT SEE GENERAL READ.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ONE MORE TIME IS
THERE ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
PERSON WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO. SB NINE OH FOUR.
NONSECTION WELCOME TO USERS MORE
SO I JUST IT'S FINE WRITER- MY
NAME IS VERONICA I'M FROM YUBA
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE S. B. NINE
SIX. RIGHT NOW WILL BRING YOU
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
REGARDING S. B. NINE OH SIX ZERO
COMMA. THE MESSAGE CARE I'VE
JUST HAD A FEW. YEAH THIS ONE AS
WELL SO I'M- IS IT EXCLUSIVE
JUST TO FIRE ARMS. ARE YOU SAID-
MASS CASUALTIES AND- THREAT OF
MASS CASUALTY INCIDENTS SO I
DIDN'T KNOW IF THAT IS AND
THERE'S BEEN DISCUSSIONS ABOUT-
IN IN THE ANALYSIS OF TALKS
ABOUT GUNS SO I DIDN'T KNOW IF
THERE WAS IF IT WAS- ONLY
EXCLUSIVE TO CASUALTIES THAT CAN
HAPPEN BECAUSE OF. THE USE OF
FIREARMS OR DOES IT ALSO
INCLUDE- YOU KNOW SELLING DRUGS
THAT COULD CAUSE MASS CASUALTIES
IF FOLKS ARE YOU KNOW. WE'RE
VERY FOCUSED ON VIOLENT CREDIBLE
THREAT I MEAN IF THERE IS A
TEENAGER ON FACEBOOK. MAKING A
THREAT. OF VIOLENCE AGAINST
THEIR PEERS ARE AGAINST THEIR
TEACHER AGAINST THE COUNSELOR-
THEY DON'T OFTEN IDENTIFY WHICH
WEAPON OF CHOICE THEY'RE GOING
TO BE. COMING TO SCHOOL WITH BUT
IT'S ABOUT VIOLENT THREATS IT'S
NOT ABOUT. FRANKLY DRUGS OR
ALCOHOL OR THOSE OTHER. SOCIAL
THINGS THAT'S NOT THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL THIS IS A N. AND AGAIN
WE KNOW AND I THINK I MAY BE
WRONG WHEN 90% OF THESE
INSTANCES THERE HAS BEEN SOME.
FREE WARNING SOME PRECURSOR- AND
IN 67% OF THESE INSTANCES THE
WEAPONS COME FROM THE HOME- SO.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT
VIOLENT. THREAT TO THE SAFETY OF
A SCHOOL- AND AGAIN I GO BACK TO
MICHIGAN WHERE THAT SCHOOL WAS
ALERTED TO THE INTENT OF THAT
SHOOTER. AND DID NOTHING THAT'S
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT. SO IN THIS
INSTANCE- ALSO I IN VIEW YOU IF
IT'S OKAY TO IF YOU HAVE- SOME
OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION I DON'T KNOW IF THOSE
ARE STILL BEING SORT OF A
DISCUSS- BUT I WILL SAY THAT
EIGHTY I'M CURIOUS TO KNOW HOW A
THREAT IS DEEMED CREDIT CREDIBLE
WHOIN THIS INSTANCE WOULD BE
MAKING THAT DETERMINATION IS
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT MAY
NOT KNOW THAT CHILDREN. THEN
WHICH- HOW THEY'RE BEHAVING IN
SCHOOL IS AT THE SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS- AND THEN- IF IT
TURNS OUT THAT THAT IS NOT
CREDIBLE RIGHT YOU STILL GONE
THROUGH THIS INVESTIGATION YOU
HAVE TARGETED PEOPLE YOUNG KIDS
YOU HAVE CALLED THEM YOU'VE DONE
ALL OF THIS AND SO THEN WHEN
THAT HAPPENS- THERE'S A- SIMPLE
. AS YOU'VE ALSO CREATED A
SITUATION WHERE YOU SORT OF
CREATED A SCAPEGOAT OUT OF A
CHILD. NGUYEN IN THE INSTANCE
THE THREAT IS NOT DEEMED
CREDIBLE CREDIBLE OR MAYBE
ACTIONS HAVE BEEN TAKEN IT TURNS
OUT THAT IT WAS FALSE- I AM MOST
CURIOUS ABOUT SORT OF THE
CONSEQUENCES IN AFTER EFFECTS.
OF THAT BECAUSE I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT SORT OF SPECULATIVE WHICH
ON. THAT COULD THEN HAPPEN UNDER
THE AUSPICES OF THE BILL. SO IF.
THE FOLKS OUT OF SCHOOL
DETERMINE IT NOT TO BE A
CREDIBLE THREAT. I'M NOT GOING
TO INVESTIGATE. SO THAT'S THE
WHOLE CRUX OF IT. IF IT'S A
CREDIBLE THREAT AND LET ME BACK
UP RIGHT NOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HAVE THE AUTHORITY. TO DO THE
INVESTIGATION WERE NOT CHANGING
ANY RIGHTS PRIVILEGES ARE
AUTHORITIES OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS-
THEY ALREADY CAN DO THIS AND IT
IS A LOWER STANDARD ALREADY IN
CALIFORNIA LAW THEN PROBABLY
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT CHANGING ANY
OF THAT. WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS
JUST LIKE A- MANDATORY REPORTER-
PSYCHOLOGIST OR PSYCHIATRIST IN
A- ABUSE CASE WHEN THAT PERSON
RECEIVES THE INFORMATION THAT.
THEY'RE SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO
BE REPORTED THEY'RE THEY'RE
MANDATED TO DO IT THAT'S THE
SAME PRINCIPLE HERE WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO PROFILE ANYBODY WE'RE
NOT TRYING TO- TO GO AFTER
THINGS THAT ARE UNNECESSARY OR
NOT GERMANE OR NOT ADDED TO A
VIOLENT THREAT- WE HAVE
NARROWED. SOME OF THE
DEFINITIONS BASED ON THE
FEEDBACK WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS BUT
THE POINT IS IF USE PREVENT A
VIOLENT THREAT FROM HAPPENING IF
YOU'VE PREVENTIVE VIOLENT
ACTION. THANK GOODNESS WE
PREVENTED IT- IF THEY LOOK AT
THIS INFORMATION AND THEY
DETERMINED THAT IT'S NOT A
CREDIBLE THREAT AND THEY DON'T
TAKE IT TO THE NEXT STEP THAT'S
GOOD BUT IF THEY DETERMINE IT'S
A VIOLENT THREAT AND THEY
INVESTIGATED AND WE PREVENT
SOMETHING. YOU CAN'T THEN SAY
WELL THEY PREVENTED IT
THEREFORE. THERE WAS NO. BENEFIT
AND SO THAT'S THE SWEET SPOT
WE'RE TRYING TO HIT- AND WILL
CONTINUE TO REFINE IT AS
APPROPRIATELY AND WE HAVE MADE
WE'VE TAKEN A NUMBER OF-
SUGGESTIONS. AND ACCESS THE
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS- WE'VE
BEEN TALKING WITH THE ACLU. BUT
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS. HAVE
A SITUATION WHERE WE DON'T WAKE
UP AFTER A MASS SHOOTING AND SAY
I WISH WE COULD HAVE. WERE WE
SHOULD HAVE. AND NOT. AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS
WILL WE EVER MAKE EVERYBODY
HAPPY OF COURSE THERE'S NEVER
GOING TO BE A BILL. ON THE
SUBJECT OF THIS SENSITIVITY.
THAT EVERYBODY GETS EXACTLY WHAT
THEY WANT. BECAUSE THERE ARE
SOME FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCES- AS
FAR AS THE MENTAL HEALTH
COMPONENT I HAVE ANOTHER BILL TO
ACTUALLY EXPAND. MENTAL HEALTH-
WELL THE CENTERS ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES BECAUSE I THINK THAT IS
A GERMANE. ASPECT OF IT WE
SHOULD BE WE SHOULD BE ENGAGING
IN THE MENTAL HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF OUR STUDENTS AS WELL.
BUT WE SHOULD NOT LET THAT
TEENAGER WHO HAS ACCESS TO AN
ASSAULT RIFLE. WHO IS MADE A
THRET ON SOCIAL MEDIA. COME TO
SCHOOL AND CREATE MA'AM. AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
PREVENT THANK YOU I THINK I AM
AT A PRIOR COMMITTEE I AM SHARED
A STORY WHICH I'M NOT GOING TO
GO BACK INTO ABOUT AN INSTANCE
AT A SCHOOL- WHERE THERE WERE
TWO INCIDENTS- AND- YOU KNOW. I
DON'T TALK ABOUT IT TOO MUCH IN
DEPTH BECAUSE THERE'S MINOR IS
INVOLVED- IN TRYING TO SUPPORT
THEIR PRIVACY BUT THERE. WERE
INCONSISTENCIES WHICH HAPPENED
WITH HOW DOES SCHOOL INTERPRETED
THE THREATS THAT WERE MADE AND
WHAT WAS DONE- AND AT THE END OF
THE DAY- IT'S A BALANCE BETWEEN
SAFETY. AND PRIVACY- AND ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
TIPPING THE SCALES- OF
INTRUSION- AND MAKING SURE THAT-
SCHOOLS REMAIN SCHOOLS. YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO GO AND LEARN-
AND SO I JUST AND ALWAYS-
SENSITIVE TO. THE INCREMENTAL
PUSH TO KIND OF. PRISON EYES-
SCHOOLS. WITH THE ACCESS THAT WE
OFFER TO LAW ENFORCEMENT WHEN
THERE'S SO MUCH SUBJECTIVITY
THAT'S INCLUDED IN- DECIDING IF
THREATS ARE CREDIBLE AND ALSO
TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION. THE
GROWTH THAT STILL HAS TO HAPPEN
WITH YOUNG PEOPLE- SO THOSE ARE
WHY ASK BECAUSE I WAS JUST
REALLY INTRIGUED BY SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT THE OPPOSITION
OFFERED UP. THANK YOU. YOUR ANY
OTHER CONCERNS OR QUESTIONS WAS
COMMITTEE. I'M INTO- THAT-
THEY'RE STILL FOLKS ONLINE WHICH
IS SPEAKING OPPOSITION EVEN
THOUGH IT ASKS CLEARLY IF THERE
WERE WILL GO BACK TO THE
MODERATE AND GIVE THEM
OPPORTUNITIES. STATER NAME IN A
POSITION. IT WAS A COMMON IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL SB NINE
OH SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. FIND OF NINETY FOUR NINETY
FOUR AIRLINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME. MY NAME IS TERRY
BOLLEA REPRESENTING PARENTS FOR
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB NINE OH SIX
THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN LINE SEVENTY TWO.
HI MY NAME IS JEANETTE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB NINE OF SIX.
MY NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN LINE
NINETY. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
FOR HEARING US I'M TERRY THE
KOBE AND- WITH PARENTS ON
PURPOSE TEACHING TRAINING AND
BEING INVOLVED WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS PRIVATE HOME
INVASION SB NINE OH SIX THANK
YOU. BY NINETY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN LINE NINETY THREE.
GABRIELLE INGRAM FOUNDER OF
SANTA SACRAMENTO COUNTY
REPRESENTING THOUSANDS OF
SACRAMENTO RESIDENT THAT HAS
ITSELF THANK YOUNG. NINE FIFTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN LINE FIFTY.
OKAY SURE ALLOW ALLIED BROADWAY
OPPOSE SB NINE OH SIX. NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT. KRESS
SACRAMENTO RESIDENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. AMERICORPS MARC YOU'LL BE
JUST A MOMENT. HI MY NINETY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN LINE NINETY
SIX. I CAN'T WAIT THEY TENDED.
AND WE HAVE HEARD THAT THAT.
NOBODY ELSE Q. YOU AND WE'LL
COME BACK TO THE COMMISSIONER
SKINNER. THE CHAIR SO THIS. ONE
IT IS WE WILL BE. I COMPLETELY
APPRECIATE AND WE KNOW THAT
THEIR BEEN INCIDENTS THAT HAD.
AN AUTHORITY WHERE THERE WAS THE
SCHOOL OR LAW ENFORCEMENT OR THE
PARENT ACTED. THAT WE WOULD HAVE
PREVENTED THE SHOOTING SO WE
KNOW THAT. HOWEVER WE ALSO KNOW.
THAT SOME OF THE CHILDREN THAT
MAKE SUCH THREATS ARE REALLY
HAVE MIDDLE. ILLNESS PROBLEMS
AND NOW SOME OF THE SHOOTERS THE
KIDS THAT ACTUALLY SHOOT TO DO
SO I MEAN THIS IS A FINE. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT RIGHT NOW WHILE.
R. WE'VE BECOME MORE. MUCH MORE
AWARE OF THIS FINE LINE BETWEEN
THE ROLE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THE ACTIONS OF THOSE WHO ARE IN
A DESPERATE MENTAL HEALTH STATE
. AN LAW ENFORCEMENT IS NOT YET
AND MAYBE IT'LL NET MAYBE IT'S
JUST NOT EVER GOING TO BE AT THE
PLACE WHERE IT IS REALLY THE
APPROPRIATE ENTITY TO DEAL WITH
. THE MENTAL HEALTH CONCERNS.
AND WE HAVE TOOLS NOW THINGS
LIKE BE A RED FLAG LOWERED THE
GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER
WHICH- AND OFF I FELT CONFIDENT
THAT THE INVOLVEMENT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT WOULD IT WOULD
RESULT IN SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
WHERE BUT THE FAMILY BECAUSE IN
MY OPINION AND I'M SURE THOSE
WHO ARE- YOU KNOW THOSE
AFFILIATED WITH THE NRA AND SUCH
NOW FOR IT WOULD NOT AGREE WITH
ME BUT I FEEL LIKE. WITH THERE'S
A KID MAKING CREDIBLE THREATS-
THAT'S A RED FLAG SHOULD BE PUT
ON THE WHOLE FAMILY BECAUSE
THERE SHOULD BE A GUN IN THE
HOUSE THERE'S A GUN IN THE HOUSE
THE KID MIGHT USE IT REGARDLESS
OF THAT YOU KNOW WHAT THE-
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THAT. AND I
RATHER SEE TOOLS LIKE THAT USE.
THEN THE TYPE OF TOOLS THAT
RESULT IN CRIMINALIZING THE
CHILD OR- ANYWAY SO WHAT I'M
STRUGGLING WITH IS THAT. WELL I
WANT I TOTALLY APPRECIATE-
CENTER PORTANTINO YOUR INTENTION
THAT WE ARE WE WANT WE WANT TO
PREVENT THE SCHOOL SHOOTINGS WE
WANT TAKE THE THREATS CREDIBLY.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE THIS FINE LINE
OF HOW THESE CHILDREN ARE
TREATED WHAT'S THE CONSEQUENCE
AND WHAT THAT YOU KNOW AFTER IF
IT'S LAW ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE
IT'S NOT ALWAYS. NEITHER THE
SCHOOL OR LAW ENFORCEMENT ALWAYS
HAS EITHER. ONE AND SO I'M I'M
NOT GOING TO OPPOSE THE BILL I
WILL SUPPORT THE BILL BUT I AND
I DON'T KNOW IF I WERE IN YOUR
POSITION CHAIR AS BEING FOREIGN
CARE WHAT TYPE OF AMENDMENT
MIGHT HELP WHAT I'M STRUGGLING
WITH BUT THAT IS WHAT I'M
STRUGGLING. SO AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT KIND OF CONVERSATIONS
HAPPEN WHETHER THERE'S ANY WAY
TO. BUT ANYWAY. THANK YOU IF I
COULD COMMENT RIGHT HERE AT THE
CONVERSATIONS HAVE BEEN
CONTINUOUS BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING
TO WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS A
PROBLEM AND WE'RE TRYING TO GET
IT RIGHT- I CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT
THE FINAL VERSION IS GOING TO
LOOK LIKE- BUT WE ARE HAVING
PRODUCTIVE- FRANKLY I THINK ONE
OF THE PROVISIONS THAT'S BEEN
TAKEN OUT OF THE BILL WHICH IS
TO KNOW WHAT. ACTUAL WEAPONS
WERE AVAILABLE IN THE HOUSEHOLD
I THINK MAYBE THERE'S EVEN A
STRONGER BILL BUT UNFORTUNATELY
THAT WAS TWO POINT TWO FAR FOR
SOME FOLKS ROM BUT WE'RE TRYING
TO HIT THE SWEET SPOT I MEAN I
THINK THAT THE QUESTION YOU'RE
ASKING IS THE- BUT WE DO. THAT
THE SHOOTERS MAKE IT KNOWN THEY
MAKE THEIR INTENT KNOWN. WE KNOW
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO A WEAPON
WHEN THEY PROBABLY SHOULDN'T-
AND WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO EMPOWER THE DISTRICT. TO
DEAL WITH IT APPROPRIATELY AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT. SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY AND WILL KEEP YOU
APPRISED OF HOW IT IF IT
OBVIOUSLY HOPEFULLY MOOSE IT
CONTINUES TO MOVE. BUT IT'S THE
RIGHT QUESTION. QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS SIMILAR TO A BOOK- SOME
IMPORTANT TO KNOW. NO WE'VE BEEN
HAVING CONVERSATIONS AND I'VE
JUST BEEN VERY CONFLICTED BUT-
HOW WOULD YOU ADDRESS THE
CONCERN THAT- FIRST OF ALL DO
YOU BELIEVE THAT THERE HAS BEEN
A NEEDING CALIFORNIA TO ADDRESS
THE SITUATIONS BECAUSE JUST
COMING FROM MARK MY LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT. I KNOW THAT IF THERE'S
EVER BEEN IS WHEN THERE WAS A
SUSPICION OF EIGHTY SOMEONE
HAVING A GUN OR I THINK IT WAS A
GUN- AT THAT TIME. THE SCHOOL
ACTED SWIFTLY IN ADDRESSING THE
CONCERN. I'M JUST KIND OF
CURIOUS AS TO I MEAN I KNOW WHAT
THE MOTIVATION IS YOU WANT TO
PREVENT THAT WHAT IS- COMPELS
YOU TO THINK THAT WE DON'T
ALREADY HAVE SOMETHING LOCALLY
THROUGH OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
CALIFORNIA. YOUR CONCERN YOU-
MISSING QUITE A BIT BUT- WHAT
COMPELS YOU TO THINK THAT
THERE'S ACTUALLY A NEED FOR SUCH
A BILL IN CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA
BEING A SENSITIVE AS WE ARE
WITH. VARIOUS ISSUES HERE IN IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT WE ACTUALLY
NEED THIS TYPE OF BUILT TO BE IN
PLACE THAT- THAT ADDRESSES THE
ISSUE THAT WE MAY OR MAY NOT
ACTUALLY NEED BECAUSE OF THE
PROTOCOLS ARE ALREADY IN PLACE
IN LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS. TWO
THINGS FOR THOSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT. TAKE CREDIBLE
THREATS I SERIOUSLY IS THE ONE
YOU'RE YOU'RE REFERENCING. FRANK
FOR THE BE NO IMPACT ON THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICT BECAUSE- THEY
GET A THREAT NAY THEY ACT UPON
BUT I HAVE HEARD FROM OTHER
DISTRICTS WHERE. THEY WRESTLE
WITH. DO WE DO WE INVESTIGATE
DON'T WE INVESTIGATE DOES THIS
HAPPEN HERE AND I HAVE I HAVE
BEEN MADE AWARE OF SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE WRESTLED
WITH THIS ISSUE- I CAN'T NAME
THOSE SCHOOL DISTRICTS BECAUSE
I'M IN CONFIDENCE ON ON SOME OF
THAT STUFF- BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT
WE'VE HAD. THE SHOOTINGS IN
CALIFORNIA- AND SO. YOU NEVER
KNOW WHEN YOU PREVENT SOMETHING.
BECAUSE YOU DON'T KNOW. IF THAT
ACTUALLY LEADS TO A PREVENTION
BUT WE KNOW THIS WELL. AND SO
THAT'S SORT OF. GETTING OUT OF
FROM BOTH SIDES THE DISTRICTS
THAT ARE PROACTIVE. WE'RE GOING
TO SEE NO EFFECT THE DISTRICTS
THAT ARE. ONLY GOING TO BE
FORCED TO DO SOMETHING. AND
THAT'S THAT'S THE PROBLEM WE'RE
TRYING TO SOLVE AND I AM USING
MICHIGAN BECAUSE THAT'S THE MOST
RECENT EXAMPLE WHERE THEY
RECEIVED A CREDIBLE THREAT SAT
ON IT AND THEN THERE WAS A
TRAGEDY. AND THEN A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION WOULD BE TO YOUR
COMMENTS. DO YOU FEEL THAT IT
WOULD BE. SINCE MANY OF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT ARE ACTING IN
CONFIDENCE OR SPEAKING-CONFIDENCE DO YOU THINK THAT WE
SHOULD PROCEED WITH DATA
COLLECTION TO SEE IF THERE IS
SUCH A NEED. IDON'T WANT TO
WAIT ANOTHER YEAR AND HAVE
ANOTHER TRAGEDY. THAT'S JUST MY
PERSONAL I DON'T WANT TO READ
SIX MONTHS FROM NOW THAT WE
COULD HAVE DONE SOMETHING AND A
TEENAGER WAS ON SOCIAL MEDIA
TALKING ABOUT. A VIOLENT DEADLY
THREAT AND INACTION LED TO
SOMEBODY DYING. AND SO. I DON'T
WANT TO LET MORE TIME I WANT TO
GET THIS IN THE GOVERNOR'S DESK
THIS LEGISLATIVE CYCLE HOPEFULLY
GET A SIGNATURE AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THIS IN PLACE GOING
FORWARD. BECAUSE THE WORLD IS
MORE COMPLICATED THAN EVER
BEFORE THE PRESENCE OF GUNS. IS
MORE PREVALENT THAN EVER BEFORE
THE UNREST IS THERE- AND I JUST
DON'T WANT TO READ ABOUT ANOTHER
TRAGEDY. OR SEE ANOTHER PHOTO.
OR HAVE ANOTHER COLUMBINE. I
JUST DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT.
IT'S JUST IT'S JUST IT'S JUST
TOO HEARTBREAKING I DON'T WANT
TO EVER MAKE A QUOTE AND SEND MY
PRAYERS AND THOUGHTS AND WELL
WISHES TO A FAMILY MEMBER THAT
HAS TO DEAL WITH THIS WHEN WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY AS THE
LEGISLATURE TO PUT IN PLACE
SOMETHING. TO PREVENT IT. SORRY
KEEP MAKING REALLY GOOD POINTS
HE MAKES ME THINK ABOUT A FOLLOW
UP QUESTIONS I APOLOGIZE SO.
ANOTHER FOLLOW UP QUESTION WOULD
BE- FOR THOSE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT YOU SAY THAT WOULD BE
HESITANT WOULD NOT ACT AND PUT
IN PERIL SCHOOL CHILDREN AND-STAFF AND SO FORTH- SPEAKING AS
A FORMER SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER. I
HAVE TO SAY THAT I WOULD BE
INCREDIBLY- HESITANT NOT TO ACT
ON IT ON A ON A THREAD WERE A
CREDIBLE THREAT- JUST BECAUSE OF
. IF YOU FAIL TO ACT ON A-
SAFETY- PROTOCOL OR SAFETY
THREAT. THE LIABILITY BEHIND
THAT- WOULD BE HORRIBLE AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND- AND
ADMINISTRATORS AND I'M NOT SURE
IF THAT IN IN GOOD
ADMINISTRATIVE PRACTICE ANYBODY
WOULD WANT THAT LIABILITY UPON
THEMSELVES- SO JUST ON THAT.
THAT IDEA THAT'S RIGHT
ESPECIALLY CALIFORNIA AND THE
THOUGHT THAT UNDER MY WATCH. ANY
STUDENT WOULD BE HARMED OR ANY
STAFF MEMBER WOULD BE HEART HARM
. I'M NOT SURE THAT AND MEASURES
IN CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT WOULD EVER NOT
TAKE A THREAT SERIOUSLY AND
THAT'S JUST MY PERSONAL OPINION
I JUST WANT THAT FOR THE RECORD-
IN IN IN ADDRESSING YOUR
COMMENTS. THAT FROM THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT I'VE HAD MANY
MANY ADMINISTRATORS. THEY TAKE
THEIR THEIR THEIR RESPONSIBILITY
TO OVERSEE THE SAFETY OF THEIR
SCHOOLS. VERY VERY- SERIOUSLY ON
ON MANY LEVELS OF COURSE BECAUSE
THEY ARE YOUR- THEY'RE THE ONES
YOUR RESPONSE WITH LIKE A
PARENT. YOU KNOW OVERSEEING THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THEIR
CHILDREN SO- I JUST WANTED TO
PUT THAT ON THERE BECAUSE TO
INFER THAT THEY WOULDN'T I JUST.
HAVE A HARD TIME THINKING THAT
THEY WOULD NOT. AND AGAIN IF I
MAY MISTER CHAIR FOR THOSE
DISTRICTS THAT ARE AS PROACTIVE
AS AS YOU DESCRIBE AND
RESPONSIBLE. THEY ALREADY HAVE
THE ABILITY TO DO THE SEARCH TO
DO THE INVESTIGATION- SO THEY'LL
SEE NO NET EFFECT. FROM THIS BUT
THE DISTRICT THAT. MAY BE PRONE
TO INACTION WILL. AND IF YOU
WANT MISTER CHAIR I RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONOMICAL OUR- ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS CONCERNS CENTERS CAN.
IT'S BEEN MOVE A SEVENTY
SKINNER- WE HAVE AN AMENDMENT IS
. NOW I TO EARN A RAISE MY
CONCERNS IN THEIR- FOLLOWING
LARGER WHAT SENATOR SKINNER
STATED I THINK THE INTENTION OF
BUT I'M ALSO FEARFUL OF.
IMPACTING PRIOR LOWER INCOME
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND HAVING MORE
CALLS ON IN IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
WORDS IN A FLUENT COMMUNITIES
YOU KNOW I THINK. THE THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO MORE GUNS AND I'M
PRETTY SURE THAT INFORMATION
WILL BE PROBABLY STE SUPPRESSED
AND FIND A WAY TO NOT TARGET
THEM AND NOT SEE THEM AS A
THREAT AS MUCH AS YOU WOULD SEE.
LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES-
BECAUSE WE SEE IT AND I HAVE A
BILL RIGHT NOW I TRIED TO DE
ESCALATE REPORTING ON INCIDENTS
ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES AND GIVING A
MINIATURE GREATER AUTHORITY. TO
DECIDE WHEN TO REPORT A
SITUATION VERSUS NOT SO JUST
CURIOUS ON YOUR. HOW DO WE
ADDRESS THAT BECAUSE I THINK
THERE WILL BE SOME BIASES HERE
AND HOW THIS IS. AN ACTIVE IT IS
TO PUT THE PAST. I ACTUALLY
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE THE
OPPOSITE I THINK I THINK YOU'RE
GONNA SEE. MORE MORE OF AN
IMPACT ON THE SUBURBAN
COMMUNITIES I THINK YOU'RE GONNA
SEE. BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
WHERE THE GREATER FEAR OF ACTION
COMES OR INACTION COMES- AND-
AGAIN WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
PROFILING WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT TARGETING ANYBODY WE'RE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. DEFINING
WHAT A CREDIBLE THREAT IS AN
ACTING UPON IT SO IT'S
COUNTERINTUITIVE MISTER CHAIRMAN
I THINK YOU'RE GONNA SEE A
GREATER IMPACT OF THIS BILL- ON
SUBURBAN COMMUNITIES WHERE YOU
KNOW HOW REPRESENT URBAN AND
SUBURBAN COMMITTEE. WHERE THE
THAT WON'T HAPPEN HERE. IS MUCH
MORE PREVALENT AND I THINK
THAT'S WHY THIS IS GOING TO HAVE
MORE OF A DRAMATIC IMPACT ON
THOSE COMMUNITIES THAN THE URBAN
COMMUNITIES. THAT'S DESPITE MY
AGAIN THAT'S AN EMPIRICAL
OPINION. BUT I YOU'RE AGAIN
YOU'RE ASKING THE RIGHT%
QUESTION. YOU KNOW WE'RE GOING
TO FOCUS ON THE DEFINITION TO
MAKE SURE WE GO AFTER IT THE
RIGHT WAY. BUT I THINK THIS IS
GOING TO HAVE A GREATER EFFECT-
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES NOT NOT THE
ONES THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE
REFERENCING IN MY OPINION- WHICH
I CLOSE. WITH THAT THAT YOU KNOW
YOUR STAFF HAS BEEN GREAT AS WE
MOVE THIS FROM ONE COMMITTED TO
THAN OTHERS TO PROCESS THE IMAGE
THAT WE TOOK IN IN EDUCATION TO
GET IT TO WHERE WE'RE AT TODAY
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND- OBVIOUSLY IF
THE CHAIR. ONCE HAVE CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS- I'M OPEN TO THOSE
IF THERE'S AND YOUR COMMITTEE IF
YOU HAVE. ANY THOUGHTS MOVING
FORWARD- THIS IS TOO IMPORTANT
NOT TO CONTINUE TO GET IT
THROUGH SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NOT. THANK YOU. CAN SO WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR SKINNER
WE HAVE DO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
ON S. B. NINE OH SIX. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. REFEREE ARE. NOT
VOTING. THE MEASURE HAS TO GO
THROUGH THE ROLE OPEN FORUMS
MEMBERS THANK YOU. OBSCENITY
JONES YES TO MEASURES YOU HAVE
SB NINE NINETEEN INDUSTRY
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE. WE'LL START
WITH NINE NINETEEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS AS SOMEBODY
MENTIONED EARLIER IT'S CATALYTIC
CONVERTER DAY WE HAD THIS DAY
LAST WEEK IN BNP- SO I WILL BE
PRESENTING SB NINE NINETEEN
WHICH WILL HELP COMBAT KELLY
CONVERTER THEFTS WITH A HREE
PRONGED APPROACH. FIRST THIS
BILL REQUIRES NEW AND USED MOTOR
VEHICLE DEALERS APPARENTLY
MARKED THE VEHICLE
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER ON THE
CATALYTIC CONVERTER OF ANY
VEHICLE BEFORE THEY SELL. THIS
REQUIREMENT WILL READ WILL
CREATE A WAY TO IDENTIFY
CALIBERS. IF IT IS ILLEGALLY
REMOVED FROM THE CAR. SECOND
THIS BILL ALLOWS METAL RECYCLERS
TO BY KELLY CONVERTERS ONLY IF
THEY HAVE A CLEARLY VISIBLE AND
UN TAMPERED BEEN ON THEM.
RECYCLES IT ASO BE REQUIRED TO
KEEP DETAILED RECORDS OF ALL
SALES FROM BOTH BUSINESSES AND
INDIVIDUALS AND MAKE THOSE
RECORDS AVAILABLE TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. THIRD THIS BILL
ADDS FINES TO THE CURRENT.
PENALTIES FOR CALIFORNIA THEFT
AND MAKES IT EASIER TO ESTABLISH
PROBABLE CAUSE FOR ARREST AND
PROSECUTION. I KNOW ADDITIONAL
PENALTIES TEND TO BE DIFFICULT
IN THIS COMMITTEE BUT WE REALLY
DO BELIEVE THIS PORTION IS
CRUCIAL TO MAKING IT NOT WORK
THE THIEVES TIME TO KEEP
STEALING THESE DEVICES. SOME OF
YOU MAY SEE MY VIDEO ON HOW EASY
IT IS TO STEAL A CATALYTIC
CONVERTER AND I WANTED TO SHOW
THE COMMITTEE WITH A CATALOG
NUMBER ACTUALLY LOOKS LIKE. THIS
IS A- A REAL AFTERMARKET- KELLY
CONVERTER. AND IT IS THE HOT
COMMODITY BECAUSE OF THE
PRECIOUS METALS. AND THE RISING
COST OF THESE METALS CALIFORNIA
IS THE NUMBER ONE STATE. IN THE
NATION FOR CALCULATOR THEFTS.
WITH EIGHTEEN THOUSAND DEATHS
JUST LAST YEAR. THAT'S A 13100%
INCREASE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. WHAT IF CAN STILL
CALIBURN UNDER TWO MINUTES AND
MAKE A QUICK TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS. THE VICTIMS OF THESE
STEPS FACE UP TO FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO REPLACE THE CONVERTER
AND THE LOSS OF THE VEHICLE WELL
THERE'S GET FIXED AND WE'VE ALSO
HEARD STORIES OF. THE VALUE OF
REPLACING THE CALCULATOR
ACTUALLY TOTALS THE VEHICLE AND
MAKES IT NOT WORTHREPAIRING.
THIS PROBLEM HAS ONLY GOTTEN
WORSE OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS
AND DOES NOT APPEAR TO BE
SLOWING DOWN. THUS MAKING OUR
ACTION TODAY ON THIS AND OTHER
CATALYTIC CONVERTER MAJORS OF
MOST IMPORTANCE. THIS BILL
INCORPORATES A COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGY TACKLE CATALYTIC
CONVERTER THEFTS OF FROM ALL
ANGLES. BUT I DO ALSO PLAN TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH MY
COLLEAGUES TO SIMMER BILLS. AND
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO FIND AN
ADEQUATE SOLUTION. IF THIS BILL
MOVES OUT COMMITTEE TODAY I'LL
CONTINUE WORKING ON AMENDMENTS
TO MITIGATE CONCERNS. ABOUT
ADDITIONAL MANDATES ON
BUSINESSES AND I'M COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS TO
FIND A SOLUTION THAT ADDRESSES
THEIR CONCERNS AND SO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC. FROM KELLY CONVERTER
THEFT. ON THE PHONE TODAY HAVE
TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL TO GIVE TESTIMONY THE FIRST
DETECTIVE SAMPSON LEONARD. FROM
THE CHILL VISTA POLICE
DEPARTMENT. A PROPERTY CRIMES
UNIT AND ALISON ATTY FROM THE
FOR PERSONAL INSURANCE RATE.
WHICH WITNESSES OUT AB TWO
MINUTES EACH TO. THE TESTIMONY.
DR MINOR. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SAMSON LEONARD AND I'M DETECTIVE
WITH THE TO THE TO POLICE
DEPARTMENT. CATALYTIC CONVERTERS
ALL CATS ARE THE PERFECT TARGET
FOR THIEVES BECAUSE THEY'RE
VALUABLE FOR SIMPLE THE STEEL
IMPOSSIBLE TO TRACE. AND
UNFORTUNATELY HAS NO RECOURSE.
ADDITIONAL STOLEN PROPERTY IS A
CRIME AGAINST A PERSON. SO THAT
A PERSON OR VICTIM THERE'S NO
CRIME OFFICERS LOCATE CATS
DURING TRAFFIC STOPS KNOW THAT
THEIR STOLEN. BUT CAN'T PROVE IT
THE SUSPECTS ARE NEVER HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. SAN DIEGO COUNTY
HAD OVER TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED CAT
DEATHS REPORTED IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND DEBT IN MY CITY
INCREASED BY SEVEN HUNDRED
PERCENT. THIS YEAR'S LOOKING
WORSE LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
WHERE PEOPLE PARK ON THE STREET
OR UNSECURE LOTS ARE SPECIALLY
VULNERABLE. AND I'VE MET VICTIMS
LIKE CLAUDIAN JORGE WHO CAN'T
AFFORD TO REPAIR THEIR STOLEN
CATS SO NOW THEY MAKE PAYMENTS
ON CARS THAT THEY CAN'T USE.%
PART OF THE PROBLEM IS THAT
CURRENT LAW CREATED A BLACK
MARKET THROUGH MINIMAL OVERSIGHT
OF BUSINESS TO BUSINESS CAP
TRANSACTIONS. SO IF I WERE TO
FILE A FICTITIOUS BUSINESS NAME
APPLICATION WITH THE COUNTY. I
COULD SELL CATS TO RECYCLE IT
NOW THE ONLY LOG MY BUSINESS
THING. THE RECYCLERS ARE ACTING
WITHIN THE LAW AND THEY CAN
COMMITMENTS BECAUSE THE STOLEN
CAT HAS ALREADY BEEN LAUNDERED
BY THE PREVIOUS TRANSACTION
BETWEEN THE TEETH IN MY SHOW
BUSINESS. I EXPECTED A RECYCLING
WAREHOUSE WHERE THOUSANDS OF
CATS LOADED UP AWAITING SHIPMENT
TO OHIO TO THE TRAIN DIE THESE
CATS HAD JAGGED CUTS. BEING THE
WIRES AND THEY WERE OBVIOUSLY
STOLEN. HOW DO YOU PROVE.
SOMETHING UNTRACEABLE STOLEN.
THE LITTLE NINE ONE WILL MAKE
STEVE TWICE REACHING FOR A STAR
ALL. THAT'S WILL BE MARKED WITH
VINCE MAKING THEM YOU. ALLOWING
OFFICERS TO LOCATE VICTIMS MAKE
ARRESTS AND RETURN STOLEN
PROPERTY. SENATE NINE ONE NINE
WILL ALLOW OFFICERS TO ACT BASED
ON PROBABLE CAUSE ABSENT A
READILY IDENTIFIABLE VICTIM. AND
FINALLY THIS BILL WILL CLOSE
LOOPHOLES AND AT REQUIREMENTS
MAKING IT MORE DIFFICULT TO
LAUNDER STOLEN CATS. AND THE
BLACK MARKET WILL SLOW
OVERNIGHT. OPPONENTS OF THIS
BILL- COMPANIES WORRIED ABOUT
INCREASED OVERHEAD. BUT
SUPPORTERS ARE JORGE CLAUDIA AND
EVERY CALIFORNIAN IMPACTED
FRUSTRATED BY THIS CRIME. WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY RIGHT NOW
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT. IT LAW
ENFORCEMENT A FIGHTING CHANCE
THAT'S WHY I SUPPORT SENATE BILL
NINE ONE NINE. THANK YOU. YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THE MORNING SHERIN
MEMBERS THIS IS ALTERNATING WITH
THE PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT SEVEN OF THE STATE'S
LARGEST HOME AND AUTO INSURER SB
NINE ONE NINE RESPOND TO A
CRITICAL ISSUE FOR OUR MEMBER
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA
CATALYTIC CONVERTER THAT MAKES
IT NEARLY 30% OF ALL ON ME. THIS
IS AN ISSUE THAT IS BEING STARK
INCREASE OVER THE PAST THREE
YEARS DESPITE THE FACT THAT
CATALYTIC CONVERTERS INCLUDED IN
VEHICLE IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
IT HAS ONLY BEEN SINCE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THAT THIS
ISSUE HAS TAKEN THE FOREGROUND
ONE ONE COMPANY NOTED THAT THE
AVERAGE ANNUAL CATALYTIC
CONVERTER THAT IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. FIFTY SEVEN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE IT WAS THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT THIS IS
CONSISTENT ACROSS THE INDUSTRY
ON AVERAGE OVER TWO MILLION HER
COMPANY COSTING COMPANIES ARE ON
AVERAGE TWENTY THREE MILLION
EIGHT ALREADY CONTRACT ATTIC
DRIVABILITY FOR THOSE WHO SELL
STOLEN CATALYTIC CONVERTER WOULD
BE A BENEFICIAL STEP TOWARD
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF DEATHS
ANNUALLY REDUCE STRAIN ON THE
INDUSTRY AND ON CONSUMERS.
INDUSTRY THAT PART. OF THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
STONE STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MOSKOS ARIANNA
SUPPORT THIS BILL. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT HERE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE IN NINETEEN NINE
LET'S GO TO OUR PHONE LINES
MODERATOR IF THERE'S WITNESSES
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINE ONE NINE. NOW IT'S TIME
. IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT SUPPORT
OF BILL SB NINE ONE NINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND THERE'S
NO ONE IN KILL. NOW WILL. GO TO
OPPOSITION IN FOURTH IN THE SAME
. ATTORNEY WE HAVE. JOHN MOFFETT
LISTED AS OPPOSITION AS YOU
PREPARE. MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AGAIN MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JOHN MOFFETT- IT WITH THE
ALLIANCE FOR AUTOMOTIVE
INNOVATION HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED ON ON THIS BILL AS WELL-
WE APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONS
WE'VE HAD WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE I'LL MOVE THROUGH MY SAME
ISSUES AS AS THE PREVIOUS BILL
ON THIS ONE WE BELIEVE A
PERMANENT MARKING NOT ETCHING
AND ENGRAVING WITH BELIEVE THE
BILLS TO BROAD THIS IS NOT A NEW
CAR ISSUE THIS IS A USED CAR
ISSUE. AND WE BELIEVE THAT OTHER
PROTECTIVE MEASURES SHOULD ARE
ARE BETTER APPROACHES- THAN THAN
PERMANENT MARKING IN ACTUALLY
PREVENTING THE THEFT OF
CATALYTIC CONVERTERS- VERSUS
JUST BEEN MARKING- FOR THOSE
REASONS WE MAINTAIN OUR OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION. NEXT
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. THE
MORNING CHAIR BRADFORD ON THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION WE OPPOSE
SB NINE NINETEEN WHICH CREATES
YET ANOTHER NEW CRIME SB NINE
NINETEEN WOULD PERMIT THE FELONY
ARREST AND PROSECUTION OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR POSSESSING
PERFECTLY LEGAL CARPARTS
CATALYTIC CONVERTERS WITHOUT ANY
EVIDENCE THAT THE PARTS WERE
STOLEN OR ILLEGALLY POSSESSED.
THIS COULD CAUSE INNOCENT
CALIFORNIANS TO BE IMPRISONED
UNDER EXISTING LAW A PERSON MAY
BE PROSECUTED FOR STEALING CAR
PARTS OR FOR ILLEGALLY
POSSESSING STOLEN CAR PARTS
UNDER VARYING CIRCUMSTANCES THE
DEFENDANT COULD BE INCARCERATED
UNDER THESE LAWS FOR UP TO A
YEAR IN JAIL OR UP TO THREE
YEARS DEPENDING ON THE VALUE OF
THE PROPERTY. BEFORE ANY PERSON
MAY BE PROSECUTED FOR THEFT-
ORDER ILLEGAL POSSESSION
EXISTING LAW ALSO REQUIRES PROOF
THAT THE PART IN QUESTION WAS IN
FACT STOLEN AND THE DEFENDANT
KNEW IT TO BE STOLEN. CURRENT
LAW CAREFULLY BALANCES THE
COMMUNITY NEEDS WITH THE
INDIVIDUAL CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS. SB NINE NINETEEN WOULD
ALLOW PROSECUTION. WE OKAY.
SENATOR SKINNER DID YOU TAKE
SOME OF MY TWO MINUTES. SB NINE
NINETEEN WOULD ALLOW PROSECUTION
OF INNOCENT PEOPLE FOR
POSSESSING ILLEGAL CAR PARK
MOREOVER WITHOUT ANY EFFICACY OF
AN INCREASED PENALTY VIS A VIS A
CATALYTIC CONVERTER THIS BILL
SEEKS TO IMPRISON PERSONS WHO
POSSESS THOSE CAR PARTS WITHOUT
PROOF THAT THE PART WAS STOLEN
OR THE POSSESSION KNEW WHAT WAS
STOLEN. WELL OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
SUFFERING FROM MORE THEFT OF
CATALYTIC CONVERTERS THERE ARE
BETTER WAYS THAN THOSE PROPOSED
IN SB NINE NINETEEN TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES FOR THESE REASONS
WE URGE YOUR NO VOTE. THANK YOU
. NOW WILL COME TO THE ROOMS ARE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION HERE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. SHE TO NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. GOOD MORNING DEREK
MORGAN WITH THE OTHER BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. THE MORNING
GREGORY FELT INITIATE JUSTICE
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU
. ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF US THREE NINE ONE
NINE HERE IN THE ROOM. ENCINA
MODERATOR LET'S GO TO OUR PHONE
LINES AND- THERE'S INDIVIDUALS
QUEUED UP WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT ABOUT THE VISION OF BILL
SB NINE ONE NINE. NINE ZERO. MY
MODEL SIXTY LINE IS OPEN WON ALL
SIX. BE SURE ON THE HOUSE EIGHT
YOU KNOW YOU CALIFORNIA ACTION
IN OPPOSITION. AND THERE'S NO
ONE LEFT THANK YOU. BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE IS THERE ANY QUESTIONS
OR CONCERNS SENATOR CALM WATER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. ARM SO I. ONE WAS JUST WONDERING IF
MAYBE THERE WAS ANY INTEREST IN
TRYING TO CONSOLIDATE SOME OF
THE CATALYTIC CONVERTER BILLS SO
THAT WE HAVE SOMETHING THAT'S A
COMPREHENSIVE AND TRIES TO GET
AT THE ISSUE THE A OR ISSUES AT
HAND- BECAUSE I AGREE. THAT
FOLKS WHO ARE DOING THIS ARE
SCAVENGERS WHO WHO MAY BE
DESPERATE WHO MAY BE POOR- WHO
MAY BE LAZY WHO MAY BE CAVALIER
WHATEVER IT IS THEY'RE CERTAINLY
PREYING ON UNSUSPECTING VICTIMS.
I THINK FOLKS THAT HAVE OLDER
MODEL CARS WITH CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS- YOU KNOW CAN'T
REALLY AFFORD TO AND EVEN
WORKING CLASS FOLKS CAN'T EVEN
AFFORD TO GO THROUGH THE PROCESS
OF REPLACING THEM. I THINK IT'S
A HUGE ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUE-
HAVING TO REPLACE THEM AND WE
SHOULD BE MOVING AWAY FROM IT.
AND I DO AGREE WE SHOULD BE
CREATING A CHILLING A FACT- ON
THOSE WHO TRADE ON CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS- AND WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO START THE
BLACK MARKET. ABSOLUTELY TRUE.
ARM AND- ALSO. YOU KNOW I HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT NOT NEEDING
PROBABLE CAUSE TO MAKE AN ARREST
I FEEL LIKE THAT'S A SLIPPERY
SLOPE TOWARDS- POLICY THAT WE
HAVEN'T REALLY SUPPORTED
GENERALLY- IN THIS COMMITTEE AND
YOU KNOW LEANING ON
CIRCUMSTANTIAL EVIDENCE. SEEMS
TO BE AS CAVALIER AS THE FOLKS
WHO ARE OUT HERE YOU KNOW
STEALING THESE CATALYTIC
CONVERTERS AND I ALSO WONDER
BECAUSE OF THE THAT LANGUAGE
THAT'S ALSO IN THE BILL- NO CHEN
CUFFS. IS THE INTENT TO GO
AFTER. THE PERSON WHO STOLE IT.
OR JUST THE PERSON WHO HAPPENS
TO BE HOLDING THE PROPERTY. YOU
KNOW AT THAT MOMENT IN TIME
BECAUSE THAT PERSON COULD
EQUALLY BE UNSUSPECTING AND I
WOULD THINK WE WOULD WANT
LANGUAGE OR BILLS THAT ARE GOING
AFTER THE ACTUAL THIEVES OR EVEN
THINK THE RING OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
INVOLVED IN THIS KIND OF THEFT.
BUT THE PROBABLE CAUSE NOT
HAVING PROBABLE CAUSE IN THE
CIRCUMSTANTIAL EVIDENCE. YOU
KNOW COULD LEAD LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO SAY WELL WE'RE JUST GOING TO.
TRY TO TEACH ALL THESE FOLKS A
LESSON AND SO IF YOU HAPPEN TO
HAVE IT IN YOUR POSSESSION RIGHT
NOW EVEN THOUGH YOU DIDN'T STEAL
IT BUT MAYBE IT WAS LIKE SECOND
HAND THIRD HAND PURCHASE OR
WHATEVER. THEN WE'RE GOING TO GO
AFTER YOU WHICH ISN'T
NECESSARILY ATTACKING B. THE
ISSUE AT HAND WHICH IS HOW DO WE
SORT OF START OF. THIS BLACK
MARKET GO AFTER THOSE THAT ARE
STEALING IT SO I DON'T KNOW IF
THOSE DISCUSSIONS HAVE BEEN
HAPPENING WITH- THE COMMITTEE TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO LEAN
INTO. THAT SWEET SPOT- AND
ESSENTIALLY THIS IS MAYBE A LONG
DIATRIBE TOWARDS ASKING IF
YOU'VE TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION
SOME OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE OPPOSITION. SURE SO. ON THE
FIRST POINT OF CONSOLIDATING I
THINK ALL OF IT I THERE'S THREE
BILLS IN THE SENATE THAT FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING THERE'S A BILL IN
THE ASSEMBLY AT LEAST ONE BILL
IN THE ASSEMBLY. MY STAFF HAS
HAD VERY PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SENATE
OFFICES THAT ARE. PROPOSING
CALIFORNIA BILLS- SO. I WOULD
IMAGINE. YOU KNOW THIS IS THE
PROCESS OF THE YOU KNOW THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE PROCESS IS
TO. GET ALL THESE IDEAS DOWN
INTO ONE IDEA THAT THEY CAN. BE
USEFUL IN AND- EFFECTIVE.
CONCERNING IN THE POSSESSION OF
A STOLEN ITEM AND WHAT YOU KNOW
UNKNOWINGLY- AS AN INNOCENT
INTERMEDIARY OR INNOCENT PERSON
IN THE IN THE- CHAIN OF
POSSESSION BETWEEN THE FAST AND
THE RECYCLER. THERE'S PROBABLY A
VERY LIMITED SITUATION WHERE
THAT MIGHT COME UP I THINK LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S OPINION IS- YOU
KNOW THE PERSON STEALING IN THE-
CALIBRATOR IS THE SAME PERSON
THAT SELLING IT TO THE RECYCLER-
THAT WOULD BE VERY LITTLE REASON
FOR THERE TO BE AN EXCHANGE.
BETWEEN THAT THOSE TWO
TRANSACTIONS- SO I THINK THAT
THIS BILL WITH IDENTIFICATION
BEING REQUIRED ON THE CATALYTIC
CONVERTER TREAT ELIMINATE SOME
OF THAT- A SUSPICION AND- I'M
SORRY I MISSED THE TERM THAT YOU
USED- CIRCUMSTANTIAL EVIDENCE-
BY HAVING THE VIN NUMBER ON
ORIENT I DIVIDE I DIDN'T FIND
NUMBER ON THE- ON THE- KELLY
CONVERTER- EVERY. REMOVE SOME OF
THAT BECAUSE NOW THAT KELLY
CONVERTER IS TRACEABLE TO A
VEHICLE. IT CAN BE PROVEN THAT
IT WAS THAT THAT VEHICLES NOW
MISSING A CATALYTIC CONVERTER
THAT CAL. VEHICLE WITH THIS VIN
NUMBER MATCHES THIS CATALYTIC
CONVERTER. SOMEWHERE SOMEBODY-
REMOVED THAT CATALYTIC CONVERTER
ILLEGALLY AND SO I THINK THAT
CREATES A GIVES A POLICE A
LEGITIMATE TOOL TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE- GOING AFTER THE
PROPER PERSON THAT STOLE THE
VEHICLE OF SOMEBODY IN IN YOUR
SITUATION. IF THERE IS A CASE
WHERE SOMEBODY HAS POSSESSION OF
A STOLEN COUNTY CONVERTER AND
THEY'RE NOT THE ONE THAT STOLE
IT. WELL NOW THE POLICE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO QUESTION THAT
PERSON OR DO YOU GET IT YOU KNOW
WHY DO YOU HAVE IT- AND
HOPEFULLY THEY HAVE. A
LEGITIMATE STORY THAT. PROVES
THEIR INNOCENCE BUT SOMEBODY'S
GUILTY.
THEY DON'T THEY DON'T WANT TO
TAKE POSSESSION OF STOLEN
PROPERTY AND SO. IT IN OREGON
AFTER THE AGAIN WHAT YOU SAID
THE BLACK MARKET THE- THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE FILING THESE FICTITIOUS
BUSINESSES. TO GET AROUND YOU
KNOW ALL OF THIS AND SO I WOULD
SAY. TO YOUR POINT REGARDING-
YOU KNOW THE CRIMINALS LAZIER-
CAVALIER. SOME OF THEM MAY THAT
MAYBE TO SOME OF OUR VERY
REFINED IN VERY. SMARTEN UP TO
SPEED ON THE LAN OUR FILE AND
THAT'S A THAT'S A- PRETTY
THOUGHTFUL THING TO DO IS GO
FILE A FICTITIOUS BUSINESS. TO
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE THIS-
ACTIVITY. SO WE WANT TO OFFER
THAT AS WELL. R. ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS. NO OKAY
BY TWO- HAVE A LITTLE CONCERNED
WITH THE MERIT OF CATALYTIC
CONVERTER BILLS THAT ARE GOING
TO BOTH HOUSES IN THE LIST OF
CONCERNS AT A VENUE. FOR A VOICE
BY A NEW CAR DEALERSHIPS AS WELL
AS THE ALLIANCE SO HOW DO YOU
ADDRESS SOME OF THE- CONCERNS
THAT THEY HAVE A- SO I ON THE-
PREVIOUS- TESTIMONY I KNOW THAT
THERE WAS SOME MENTION-
REGARDING CATALYTIC CONVERTERS
THEY'RE DIFFICULT TO GET TO AND
REQUIRE HOURS OF TIME FOR EVEN
AT TRAINED TECHNICIAN TO GET TO.
THAT THAT IS AN ISSUE LIKE THE
PREVIOUS AUTHOR I WASN'T AWARE
OF UNTIL YOU INTERVIEWS THIS
BILL SO- WE'RE TRYING TO FIND A
WAY TO PUT THAT LANGUAGE. INTO
THE BILL THAT. WOULD BE- EXEMPT
YOU KNOW THOSE TYPES OF VEHICLES
IF THEY CATHOLIC CONVERTERS
PART. INTEGRATED INTO THE
EXHAUST MANIFOLD. THAT IS NOT
GONNA GET STOLEN- WITHOUT CIVIL
STILL THE WHOLE CAR- THEN THE
KEYSTONE BUT YOU'RE NOT GONNA
STILL JUST THE CATALYTIC
CONVERTER. AT A SOMETHING LIKE
THAT SO WE'RE TRYING TO FIND A
WAY YOU KNOW EITHER THROUGH THE
REPAIR MANUALS LANGUAGE OR- YOU
KNOW SOMEONE THAT WE CAN PUT
THAT. MAKE THAT LANGUAGE MAKES
SENSE- WE'VE HAD VERY GOOD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE ALLIANCE
AND WHAT THE NEW CAR DEALERS- I
USED TO WORK IN THE AUTO
INDUSTRY SO YOU KNOW I
UNDERSTAND THEIR CONCERNS- WHEN
WE INTRODUCED THE BILL. I KNEW
THERE WAS GONNA BE CONCERNS BUT
WE HAD TO START A DIALOGUE START
THE CONVERSATION- AND I THINK
WORKING ALL OF US TOGETHER WE'RE
GOING TO GET TO THE POINT WHERE-
THIS BILL MAKES THE MOST SENSE
AND- AND MOVES ON. WE WERE
LOOKING FOR A MOTION ON THIS
MEASURE. IT'S BEEN MOVED VICE
SOONER CHAU BULK- WE HAVE A WELL
WE HAVE NO RECOMMENDATION ON
THIS BUT IT'S A TO PASS TO.
APPROPRIATIONS. COME TO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON S. B. NINE ONE
NINE MISTER CHAIR I CAN JUST
MAKE IT ALL YEAH I'M SORRY IF
YOU WANT WE CAN CLOSING
STATEMENT AND I'LL BE BRIEF-
WELL I ALL THROUGH THESE BILLS
ARE GOING TO GO TO PROBES- I
SENT APPROACH THE PROPS CHAIR
HAS WON THE BILLS- I WOULD
APPRECIATE- THE BILL MOVING
FORWARD SO THAT WE CAN. YOU KNOW
I'M I'M ENVISIONING
APPROPRIATIONS I'VE HAD THIS.
CONVERSATION WITH THE CHAIRMAN
I'M JUST I MEAN WORLD. IN ROGER
LONG OF TROUT WORKS- THEY WERE
GONNA GET TO A POINT IN APPROACH
SO WE GET THIS DOWN TO ONE BILL
SO IF WE CAN MOVE MY BILL
FORWARD TO CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND- GET PIECES
HERE AND PIECES THERE INTO THE
FINAL PRODUCT THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL. COME TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MINISTRY NINE ONE ON. ONE
THREE NINE ONE NINE BRADFORD.
AYE A CHOI BOGUE CHAU BUG EYED
COM LONGER VOTING COME ON YOU'RE
NOT VOTING SKINNER. WIENER.
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU NEXT UP IS S.
B. THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR OF THIS MORNING
I'M ALSO PRESENTING S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE EACH BOARDING BUREAU
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS TO PUBLICLY
POST A LIST OF CRITERIA USED TO
EVALUATE APPLICANTS WITH
CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS. THIS WILL
HELP APPLICANTS UNDERSTAND THEIR
LIKELIHOOD OF BEING GRANTED
BUSINESS LICENSURE BEFORE THEY
APPLY WELL RECENT LEGISLATION
NOW REQUIRES THESE BOARDS AND
BUREAUS DEPOSE CRITERIA DEFINING
WHICH CRIMES CAN DISQUALIFY
APPLICANTS IT IS IMPORTANT TO
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY BY
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
FOR HOW THESE APPLICANTS WILL
ACTUALLY BE EVALUATED. THE BILL
ALSO REQUIRE THE DCA TO DEVELOP
DEVELOP A CLEAR PROCESS FOR
VERIFYING APPLICANT INFORMATION
INCLUDING THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
APPLICANTS TO PROVIDE CERTIFIED
COURT DOCUMENTS SO THAT THEIR
CONVICTION CONVICTIONS ARE
ACCURATELY RECORDED. ALL SOME
BOARDS ALREADY DO THIS
SOLIDIFYING A UNIFORM PROCESS
ACROSS ALL OF DCA WILL PROVIDE
CLARITY FOR ALL FUTURE LICENSEES
FURTHERMORE SB THIRTY SIXTY FIVE
ALSO REQUIRES THESE BOARDS AND
BUREAUS TO DEVELOP A PROCEDURE
FOR PROVIDING AN INFORMAL
APPEALS PROCESS. THIS WILL MAKE
ASKING FOR A BILL EASIER AND
LESS TIME CONSUMING FOR
APPLICANTS WHO HAVE BEEN DENIED
WITH ME TODAY TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MAJORS EVAN
RARICK EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION THE
SPONSOR OF THIS MAJOR. AT THANK
YOU AND GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ETHAN AMERICAN THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION- THE
COMMISSION IS AN INDEPENDENT
BIPARTISAN OVERSIGHT AGENCY
CHARGED WITH MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS. FOR
IMPROVEMENTS TO STATE GOVERNMENT
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE COMMISSION
ISSUED A REPORT EXAMINING
CALIFORNIA'S OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSING SYSTEM JOBS FOR
CALIFORNIANS STRATEGIES TO EASE
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING BARRIERS.
DURING ITS STUDY THE COMMISSION
CONCLUDED THAT CALIFORNIA SHOULD
EASE THE PATH FOR GROUPS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
EXISTING BARRIERS INCLUDING
FORMER OFFENDERS IN OUR REPORT
WE RECOMMENDED SEVERAL STEPS TO
HELP ADDRESS THESE CHALLENGES.
INCLUDING THE CREATION OF AN
INFORMAL APPEALS PROCESS AND THE
POSTING ONLINE OF INFORMATION
THAT WOULD HELP POTENTIAL
ADVOCATE AT APPLICANTS ASSESS
THEIR LIKELIHOOD OF LICENSURE
PRIOR TO APPLYING. SINCE OUR
REPORT WAS ISSUED THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
TOOK IMPORTANT STEPS TO IMPROVE
THE SYSTEM THROUGH THE PASSAGE
OF AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE BELIEVE
S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE WOULD
FURTHER ADVANCE THE COMMISSION'S
RECOMMENDATIONS. BY HELPING TO
MITIGATE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
NOW FACED BY PAST OFFENDERS IN
PARTICULAR AS SENATOR JONES
MENTIONED THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS TO DEVELOP. AN INFORMAL
APPEALS PROCESS. AND WHICH WOULD
OCCUR AFTER AN INITIAL LICENSE
DENIAL BUT BEFORE AN
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW HEARING THIS
WAS SOMETHING THE COMMISSION
RECOMMENDED. THE BILL WOULD ALSO
SPECIFY THAT LICENSING BOARDS
MUST POST ON THEIR WEBSITE THE
CRITERIA USED TO EVALUATE
APPLICANTS SO THE POTENTIAL
APPLICANTS MAY BE BETTER
INFORMED ABOUT THEIR LIKELIHOOD
OF SUCCESS BEFORE. INVESTING
TIME AND RESOURCES IN THE
PROCESS AGAIN THIS AYE SOMEWHERE
SLIGHTLY WHAT THE COMMISSION
RECOMMENDED IN ITS TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN REPORT. AND WE BELIEVE
THIS PROVISION GOES BEYOND THE
CURRENT REQUIREMENTS THE BOARD'S
POST A SUMMARY OF THE CRITERIA
USED TO CONSIDER WHETHER A CRIME
IS SUBSTANTIALLY RELATED TO THE
WORK BEING LICENSED. WANT TO
THANK SENATOR JONES FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND ON
BEHALF LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES HERE AND.
BERMAN TWELVE WHICH TESTIFYING
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE. IN SUPPORT. OSCAR SORIANO AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL THAT WOULD BE GREAT
FOR DEMOCRACY. THANK YOU- OKAY
LET'S NOW GO TO OUR PHONE LINES-
MODERATOR OTHER WITNESSES
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE. IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT FOR PART OF
BILLS SB THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO. AND
THERE'S NO ONE LIKE YOU AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT. NOW HAVING
HEARD FROM OUR SUPPORT NOW WILL
GO TO OPPOSITION. WE HAVE ONE
LEAD WITNESS IN OPPOSITION WE
HAVE WHAT WE HAVE TO WE HAVE
KELLY WALTERS. AND WE HAVE
GALIEN SO NO PARTICULAR ORDER
YOU MAY BEGIN. I THINK THE
SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK MY NAME
IS KELLY WALTERS. YES WE CAN.
JERRY WAS LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS AND CHILDREN. ARE
OPPOSITION AT THE SIXTY FIVE.
STILL I'M FAIRLY AND UNFAIRLY
SHIFTS THE BURDEN TO THE
APPLICANT SEEKING LIKE CHER
OTHER NOTEWORTHY I WILL NOT
BELABOR THE ISSUE OF WHETHER THE
CURRENT. STATION IN. WELL I HAD
MY COLLEAGUE WILL BE DURING ACT
JOB THAT. THIS BILL A THEORY
PURPORTS HIGHLIGHTS AND SHARE
THOSE WITH A HISTORY HOWEVER IN
PRACTICE IT WILL ONLY SERVE TO
OVER GENERALIZE MIGHT BE COURT
HARM APPLICANT WITH A CRIMINAL
RECORD I HAVE A DISCRIMINATORY
WHEN PEOPLE OF COLOR SHE STATED
ANALYSIS THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. ISSUED NEARLY
FOUR MILLION LICENSES YOU'RE
GETTING AN APPROVAL. IN OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY CATEGORY.
INDIVIDUAL BOY UNDER THAT APART.
STANDARD FOR REGULAR RIGHT. WAY
THE NECESSARY FROM LAST MONTH
BOARD BOARD BILLION THERE'S THAT
COMPASSION ANALYZE REQUIRED MOST
IMPORTANTLY THESE BILLS I THANK
THE BOARD UNDERSTAND HOW
PARTICULAR CRIMINAL HISTORY
COULD. HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL
RELATIONSHIP. IN A WAY THAT THE
LARGE PART. MOREOVER AFTER
PROVIDE QUICK DOCKING BECAUSE
BECAUSE BEFORE RESPONSE TO
COLLECT SESSION MISSION THANK
YOU INDIAN TO AT BASED ON THE
FINANCIAL BETWEEN THE PROFESSION
IN THE HOWEVER IT SHOULD BE TO
BE A THIRTY SB THIRTY SIXTY- OF. THERE COURT DOCUMENTS
CONCERNING PRE CONNECTION I IT
APPLICANTS. WE'RE QUITE OF THE
BACKING BY THE COST OF. ABOUT
DOLLARS PER. YOU ARE AMPLIFIED
IT HAPPENED HAS THAN ONE SESSION
. SONOMA COUNTY WHERE THEY NOT
RESIDE OR THEY HAVE DO YOU HAVE
A CALL CONTACT LAW ENFORCEMENT
RESULT. THE RESPONSIBILITY THE
COST AND THE ACTUAL. GETTING
CRITICAL BACKING AFTER THE- WHO
ARE LIKELY. DATE FURTHERMORE
CALIFORNIA ENCOURAGED BLACK
BROWN SPECIFICALLY AT AMERICANS
MAKE 220% OF THE CREDIT DESPITE
ONLY MAKING UP 6% EIGHT
APPLICATION I THINK ONLY IMPACT
OF THE- BY LEARNING ANY OTHER
DEMOCRAT. BECAUSE BILL WOULD
CREATE FURTHER BARRIERS TO THOSE
TRYING TO SPEAKING EMPLOYMENT WE
ARE QUESTIONS YOU VOTE AGAIN
TELL THANK YOU VERY. YOU ARE NOW
WITNESS. GOOD MORNING JERRY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
GAIL YEAH WITH THREE OR LEGAL
ORGANIZED THAT PROVIDES FREE FOR
AND SUPPORT TO ARTS BE PEOPLE TO
HELP THE NAV THROUGH OVERCOME
ENTRY BARRIERS AND HERE IS
ACTUALLY A AT THE THIRTY SIXTY
FIVE WE APPRECIATE A CALL WE
WITH THE AUTHOR AND SPONSOR LOT
YOU CAN ON. THE BILL DOES NOT
TAKE BECAUSE THE STRUCTURE OF
THE I CAN GIVE AFFAIRS BOARD AND
THEN START REFORM AB. ONE THIRTY
EIGHT EIGHT. CURRENTLY PROCESS
AS A RESULT AB ONE THIRTY EIGHT.
IN CONCRETE. AND ALLOW FOR THE
BOARD TO CONSIDER CONVERSION
THAT ALLOW. HAS DEEMED APPROACH
. HOWEVER BILL IS HIS. THE
PROCESS WITH A JOHN. STANDARD I
ACROSS ALL. SO GET RID OF THE
IN. I VALUE. AND ABLUTION AND
THEN YOU WANT TO BATTING. CHANGE
OF HEART BY OF RIGHT QUALIFIED
OUT. FROM BEING MY- IN GETTING
IT. RELATED EACH FOR PROVIDES.
FOR A VALUE CONDITION HAS AND AS
- OF THE ABILITY. ANDPOST
SANTANDER DIED BUT- AGAIN
BECAUSE OF THE ROOF. THAT A
TWENTY THIRTY EIGHT VERY ASIANS
AND BOARD GET INTO. BOARD
DISCRETION AFTER COULD NOT
EXCLUDE. AND BASED CONDITION. I
RELATED TO THE LIGHT THIRTEEN
GET. EIGHTY ONE EIGHTY ONE THREE
CREATED. PROB FOR A CAN HAS
ACROSS BOARD REDUCE OPERATING
AND COMPLICATIONS. WHILE YOU'RE
DOWN THE BILL GO IS TO SIMPLIFY
AND STREAMLINE THE LICENSE
PROCESS. INSTEAD MAKE THE LIFE
PROCESS MORE VIEWS. CONFUSING.
ARE HARMFUL FOR PEOPLE THE
CONVICTION COURAGE TO IMPROVE
THEIR LIFE. BECAUSE THE
AGREEMENT THAT WE FIND IS GOING
TO. A HARMFUL AND THEREFORE
RESPECT OPPOSE AT THE SIX FIVE.
TRANSFERRED TO IS IMPORTANT AND
GAS LOOK FORWARD CONTINUED
CONGRESS THAT THE AND SPONSOR
THANK. THANK YOU. NOW LET'S
RETURN BACK TO ROOM ONE OR THERE
WITH THIS IN ON. OF TO FIVE. IN
MODERATE LET'S GO TO PHONE LINE
DOWN. WERE WITH NOT TO. IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT AND I AM
OPPOSITION SB THIRTEEN SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
NINE ONE OH SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ONE ALL SET. YEAH BE SURE
ON BEHALF OF THE EIGHT OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN OPPOSITION. NINE EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN LINE EIGHTY FOUR. YEAH MY
NAME IS ONLY MARKETS ARE CALLING
ON BEHALF OF LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN COMING
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. AND
THERE'S NO ONE LEFT THANK YOU.
BREXIT COMMITTEE OTHER ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS AS A
RELIGIOUS S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
FIVE. JUST LIKE TO MAKE A MOTION
ON THE ON THE BILL WHEN THE TIME
IS APPROPRIATE. THIS WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE TIME IF YOU WANNA
MAKE MOTION. SOME OF. ROK MISS
JONES RETORT CLOSE THANK YOU-
MISTER SHARON- REGARDING
OPPOSITION- IT IS SOME SOMEHOW
THERE'S BEEN A MISCOMMUNICATION
BETWEEN ME AND THEM- THE HOW THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL IS TO MAKE
IT EASIER FOR FIRM FORMERLY
INCARCERATED CALIFORNIANS TO GET
EMPLOYED AND GET THEIR
PROFESSIONAL LICENSES IN
CALIFORNIA- REGARDING THE COURT
DOCUMENTS AND ALL THAT WERE AYE
I'M COMPLETELY OPEN TO HAVING A
CONVERSATION ON HOW- WE ADDRESS
THAT THE MAIN POINT HERE IS AS
YOU AS A COMMITTEE CAN SEE FROM
THE DCA BOARDS AND BUREAUS
THERE'S A MIX OF SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FROM THE-
CALIFORNIA'S OWN BOARDS AND
BUREAUS. AND SO I THINK THAT WAS
TO THE POINT OF THE BILL THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE A UNIFORM SYSTEM
THROUGHOUT ALL OF DC AID
DEPARTMENT CONSUMER AFFAIRS SO
THAT- CALIFORNIANS THAT ARE
TRYING TO GET EMPLOYED AND LIVE
A PRODUCTIVE LIFE- THIS IS THE
FIRST STEP AND WE NEED TO MAKE
IT AS EASY AS POSSIBLE AND AS
CLEAR AS POSSIBLE FOR WHAT-
LICENSING OPPORTUNITIES THEY
HAVE IN WHICH LICENSING
OPPORTUNITIES THEY DON'T HAVE-
AND SO I WOULD ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND- WITH MY COMMITMENT TO.
CONTINUE WORK WITH HE
OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS I THINK MOST OF THEM
CAN BE ADDRESSED. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. COUNCIL PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL INDUSTRY. THIRTEEN
SIXTY FIVE. SB THIRTEEN SIXTY
FIVE THE BEST APPROPRIATIONS
BRADFORD- A TROUBLED TROUBLED
GUY. LOOKING FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR. EXCEPT WHERE
SENATOR BOOKER. YOU HAVE TO ITEM
JEFFERSON- GENERATE. AND. TWELVE
SEVENTY TWO ZERO. ARE YOU THE
THRIVES ON CONSENT WE HAVE
CONSENT. SO WE HAVE TEN OR-
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. SB ONE
THOUSAND EIGHT ELIMINATES
TELECOMMUNICATION FEES FOR ALL
COMMUNICATIONS TO AND FROM
CURRENT INCARCERATED PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL JAILS AND
STATE PRISONS TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SERVICES INCLUDE PHONE CALLS
VIDEO CONFERENCING AND EMAILS.
CAUSE FOR THE SERVICES PREVENT
MANY CRUSHER TO PEOPLE FROM
ACCESSING VITAL LIFELINES WITH
THEIR FAMILIES MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORTS AND RESOURCES FOR RE
ENTRY. IS THAT THE STRUCTURE
FUELS ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLAR INDUSTRY THAT PRIORITIZES
PROFITS OVER PEOPLE. COULD THE
COUNTIES ARE CAPPED AT SEVEN
CENTS PER MINUTE FOR PHONE CALLS
IN JAILS. AND PRISONS ARE SET AT
THREE CENTS PER MINUTE. RATE
CAPS HAVE GREATLY INCREASED
ACCESS COMMUNICATION. ANYWAY
PRESENTS A BEAR TO ME KENNY
CATION AND CONCRETE FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP FOR FAMILIES OF
INCARCERATED PEOPLE. PARDEE
PANDEMIC MORE THAN ONE IN THREE
FAMILIES WERE DRIVEN INTO DEBT.
WELL STRUGGLING TO MAINTAIN
CONTACT WITH THEIR LOVED ONES ON
THE INSIDE. WITH 87% THIS WEIGHT
FALLING ON WOMEN. SINCE THAT IS
ESTIMATED FINANCIAL BURDEN HAS
INCREASED AND COMMUNICATION IS
BECOMING EVEN MORE LIMITED. THE
COUNTY JAIL SYSTEM IS ESPECIALLY
HARD TO NAVIGATE WITH EACH
OPERATING ON DIFFERENT SYSTEMS
WITH DIFFERENT PROVIDERS THE
CONSISTENCY CAUSES ISSUES AND
TRANSFER MONEY WHEN LOVE WANTS
TO MOVE TO A DIFFERENT FACILITY.
FURTHER DELAYING ESSENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS AND EXASPERATING
FEELINGS OF ISOLATION. BASE
DAMAGING FREE COMMUNICATION
THROUGH SB ONE THOUSAND EIGHT.
BUT STREAMLINED
TELECOMMUNICATION AND SHORT
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO ON COURSE
RATED PEOPLE AND THEIR FAMILIES
. WITH SB ONE THOUSAND EIGHT IN
QUESTION PEOPLE CAN'T CONNECT
WITH THEIR SUPPORT SYSTEMS TO
PLAN FOR THE RELEASE INCLUDING
FINDING A JOB AND HOUSING.
HOWEVER MOST IMPORTANTLY LEBRON
TO BE ABLE TO TALK TO EACH OTHER
AND MAINTAIN ESSENTIAL LIFELINES
TO FRIENDS AND FAMILY. SUPPORT
SYSTEMS AND COMMUNICATIONS ARE
INTEGRAL PART OF THE HUMAN
EXPERIENCE. CUTTING INCARCERATE
PEOPLE OFF THEIR LOVED ONES
HURTS THE INDIVIDUAL THE FAMILY
AND A CHANCE AT SUCCESSFUL
REINTEGRATION. I TESTIFIED TODAY
WE HAVE MARIA CONCEALERS FROM
THE FOUNDER AT THE FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE LEADER PRIDE IN TRUTH
AND THEN THE PHONE BIANCA TYLER
THE EXECUTOR AFTER FOURTH RISES
. GREAT YOU TO IS WHAT TWO
MINUTES APIECE CHAU. THIS
CASSELLS HERE ARE. GOOD MORNING
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS MARIA BECAUSE HE IS I AM THE
FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE LEADER OF
PRIDE IN TRUTH FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.%
ONLY ME TO JOIN YOU TODAY WE'RE
GIVING ME SPACE TO STEP IN ON
BEHALF OF FAMILIES IMPACTED BY
MASS INCARCERATION ACROSS
CALIFORNIA TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
PASSING SB ONE ZERO ZERO EIGHT
WHICH WILL MAKE ALL
TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND ALL JAILS
AND PRISONS. FREE INCLUDING
PHONE CALLS VIDEO CALLS AND
ELECTRONIC MESSAGING THIS WILL
BRING. POSITIVE CHANGES. ARE TO
THE FAMILIES THAT ARE IMPACTED
BY MASS INCARCERATION AT THE
FORMERLY INCARCERATED SINGLE
MOTHER. A PERSON WHO IS
CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING THE
IMPACT OF HAVING A LOVE ONE
INCARCERATED. HAVING FREE PHONE
CALLS WITH MY SON WOULD HELP OUR
FAMILY TREMENDOUSLY. IF S. B.
ONE ZERO ZERO EIGHT PASSES I
WOULD BE ABLE TO STAY CONNECTED
WITH MY SON. THE CONNECTION WITH
MY SON IS JUST IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT CHECKING IN. TO KNOW THAT
HE IS SAFE. TO KNOW THAT HE'S
ALIVE OR TO SAY HI. IT'S ABOUT
SUPPORTING HIS PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH DURING HIS
INCARCERATION. INCARCERATED
PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW THAT THEY
ARE NOT ALONE AND THAT THEY ARE
SUPPORTED AND LOVED. ON PHONE
CALLS AND VISITS OUR HOPE FOR
THESE COMMUNITY AND ITS HOPE TO
STAY ALIVE. MY OWN FAMILY DRAMA
BEGAN HEALING THROUGH A TEN
MINUTE PHONE CALL WHERE ARE
WHICH WERE VERY DIFFICULT TO
AFFORD. AND CAR THREE PEOPLE ARE
CRAMMED IN A DORM LIKE SARDINES
EIGHTY TO A HUNDRED BODIES IN A
DORM. WITH THREE TO FOUR FORMS
IF AVAILABLE. HAVING ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE COMMUNICATION IS HOW
INCARCERATED PEOPLE KEEP
STRUCTURE AND ROUTINE WHICH
HELPS PREVENT HOSTILITIES AND
INCARCERATION. THE LAST EIGHT
MONTHS I HAVE BEEN PAYING FEES
TO TALK TO MY SON DURING HIS
INCARCERATION. PEOPLE ASK ME WHY
AM I SO SUPPORTIVE OF HIM. MY
ANSWER IS BECAUSE I KNOW WHAT
IT'S LIKE TO BE INCARCERATED AND
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR HIM TO
KNOW THAT IF HE'S NOT A FAILURE.
SEVENTEEN YEARS AGO I WAS
INCARCERATED AND TURNED A NEW
LEAF BECAUSE OF MY FAMILY
SUPPORT DURING THE MOST
DIFFICULT TIME OF MY LIFE. NOW
BECAUSE OF ALL THE LOVE AND
SUPPORT OF MY FAMILY AND LOVED
ONES AND FRIENDS THAT WERE THERE
FOR ME. I AM A FORMER HEALTHCARE
WORKER I WAS ABLE TO RETIRE IN
TWENTY NINETEEN FROM NURSING.
AND BEGAN HELPING OTHERS WHO
SHOWS AND BEEN IN. AN I KNOW
THAT IF SB ONE ZERO ZERO EIGHT
PASSES. MORE INCARCERATED PEOPLE
WILL BE ABLE TO EXPERIENCE THE
HEALING POWER OF SPAIN IN
CONNECTION WITH THEIR LOVED ONES
. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH FAMILIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WE ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU WE'LL GO TO OUR
NEXT WITNESS ON THE STOCK. THE
MORNING. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF
THE STATE MY NAME IS BIANCA
GALLAGHER NINETY EXACTLY
DIRECTOR WAS RISING NATIONAL
CRIMINAL JUSTICE ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO ENDING THEIR SEASON
OF THOSE ARE BECAUSE THEY ARE
LOCKED ONE THANK YOU CAN TALK
ABOUT THANKS FOR ASKING ABOUT ME
BEFORE I FOR ONE OR TWO PEOPLE
CONSIDER THE IMPACT FOR TODAY
AND THE HUNDREDS OF LETTERS WHAT
EXACTLY. THE YOU'VE ALREADY
RECEIVED THEIR WORK ARE CRITICAL
AT WORK RIGHT T BE PART IN A
FAMILY THAT IS LEGISLATORS AND
AGENCIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO
INFLATE ENROLLMENT COFFEE
COMMUNICATION OF BRING HER THREE
PEOPLE ON EARTH CALIFORNIA
HAPPENING AT THE. ONE THOUSAND
EIGHT NOTABLY. OKAY WELL. ABOUT
PRESIDENT JOHNSON GREAT A
MASSACHUSETTS MAN AND ALL HAVE A
FOR ON IN THEIR CAR BUDGET TO DO
THAT CALIFORNIA HAVE THE OP TO
BE A THE CORPORATE OF THE
FASHION RECORD WRITTEN UNDER TO
PROVIDE OVERVIEW REALLY KERR
FAMILY ACROSS NOT ONE UNTIL
RECENTLY THE COWBOYS PUBLIC
GOING INITIATED BECAUSE TO
REGULATE PRESIDENTIAL ALREADY AN
INCIDENT IN HAPPENS. A FIFTEEN
MINUTE PHONE CALL FROM THE
CARCERI LEVELING. OCT BUDGET
THIRTEEN DOLLARS. EVEN WITH THE
RESULT HER DARK CALIFORNIA ARE
STILL IT DOWN ANTHONY SIXTY
THREE MILLION EACH. ASSEMBLY CAN
I WITH THEIR ARE THREE NOT WANT
. SB ONE THOUSAND EIGHT WITH
ALLOW TO COMMUNICATE THEIR CARS
LOVED ONES CALIFORNIA NO.
SACRAMENTO STATE AND IT FROM FOR
COMMISSION ON AND PHONE CALL THE
BILL WOULD MEAN A MAN PERSONAL
OF A HUNDRED TWENTY MINUTES
ALLOWING FOR AMPLE TIME IN AT
THE VERY MOMENT SO I WANT TO
FLAG THAT THE DATA HAS SHOWN.
THAT INCARCERATED PEOPLE USE
ONLY ROUGHLY THIRTY MINUTES PER
DAY ON AVERAGE AND GET ON
LIMITED ACCESS. IT WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE THE ONE PHONE FOR EVERY
TEN PEOPLE IN THE FACILITY AND I
KNOW THAT THE CONFIDENCE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS USUALLY
COVERED BY VENDORS. IMPORTANT
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN CARS REYES
PEOPLE AND THEIR SUPPORT
NETWORKS ON THE OUTSIDE
INCREASES HOPE STRENGTHEN
FAMILIES MEDICAID TRAUMA FOR
CHILDREN PEOPLE GRANDSON
GRADUATION AND IMPROVED
RENDERING THE CLASS. NO ONE IS
MORE IMPACTED AND WELL
POSITIONED FOR INCARCERATED
PEOPLE THAN THEY'RE LOCKED ONE
WE ARE HERE TO REPORT A BILLION.
SB ONE THOUSAND. THE QUESTION
WILL BE IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. ONE WHEN I. AND TO.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME YOURS.
MARIN ARE MEMBERS BECAUSE
RESPONSE POLICY AS AND ALONG
POVERTY TO BE A SPONSOR. AND
ALSO IN SUPPORT WITH MIKE. HUMAN
RIGHTS DEFENSE CENTER COLOR
CHANGED YOUR CALIFORNIA POSE THE
COMMUNITY SAN DIEGO AND NATIONAL
CONSUMER LAW CENTER THANK YOU
MISTER. THE MORNING LIVE WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN STRONG SUPPORT
ALONGSIDE VOCAL. NEW AMERICA'S
OPEN TECHNOLOGY INSTITUTE THE
WASHINGTON LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS AND URBAN AFFAIRS
TELECOMMUNICATIONS FOR THE DEAF-AND HARD OF HEARING AND MORE
PRICES THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN NAME IS
CARRIE ARE SAKE. PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF SB ONE ZERO ZERO
EIGHT WITH PRIDE IN TRUTH. AND
ALSO SPONSORING THE BILL IS
TRANSFER MADE OF IMPRISONED
WORKGROUP GRACE IN POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND SAN
FRANCISCO FINANCIAL JUSTICE
PROJECT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS INTO
RICE I'M A CO FOUNDER OF
EMPOWERING WOMEN IMPACTED BY
CORPORATIONS TRUSTS APART. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DR
JEKYLL- FROM PRIDE INTO AND
SUPPORT S. B. ONE CELLS ARE A-
FEW. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ABBY AND I'M A CO FOUNDER OF
EMPOWERING WOMEN IMPACTED BY
INCARCERATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
DEREK MORGAN WITH THE L. BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
SUPPORT. MUSKER SORIANA SUPPORT
THIS BILL. IN MORNING CANACCORD
I'M ON MY PERSONAL CAPACITY AS A
PERSON WITH A LOVED ONE IN A
CALIFORNIA PRISON IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING GREGORY FELT
INITIATE JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NOW MODERATOR WILL GO
TO OUR PHONE LINES INTO IF THERE
ARE WITNESSES WHO WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF S. B. CAN
ALL EIGHT. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
THOUSAND EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO
TO LINE ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
MARVIN FROM LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND I'M
CALLING IN. OR S. B. ZERO. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU BYE ONE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING
MY NAME IS YEAH WHEN. CALLING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M FORTY
THIRD PLEASE CALL AHEAD. DOUG
MAJOR I'M A CERTIFIED AB HELPED
PROVIDER I'D LIKE TO REMIND YOU
THAT THIS COULD HELP BETTER
MENTAL HELD ON TO FIGHT UNTIL IT
IS REDUCED- BOB. DELUSION THIS
IS FROM THE DALLAS COUNTY JAIL
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF BETTER
COMMUNICATION WITH RELATIVES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT YEAR I
ONE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AT A NEW YEAR'S WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. NO WAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU BYE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO DEBRA L. GARVEY PHD
SAN JOSE RESIDENT IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF. ONE ZERO ZERO EIGHT.
THANK YOU I ONE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR MOTHER NEVER READY
WHEN FAMILIES UNITED AND ALL OFF
AND DROPPED A LOT COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORTER SB. TEN ZERO
ZERO EIGHT. YEAH THANK YOU I'M
AT. FOUR CRITICAL F. CALLING ON
BEHALF OF LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRESENCE OF CHILDREN THE
PROPOSAL ANSWERS AND SUPPORT OUT
SB TEN AWAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOUR MIND ONE AWAIT YOUR CALL
HAS. OKAY FOLLOW OKAY AND THEN
ACTING LIKE. THAT WE CAN CONDUCT
THE ANTHONY ARMY DOESN'T BINDING
WITH OF ANY. EIGHT HAVING SOME
NETWORK. I DON'T. OCEAN WERE
NEVER THERE BUT TO COPE WITH
THANK YOU CAN YOU GO. NIGHT
ANYTHING BECAUSE. ALL RIGHT YEAH.
ON HOLDEN INCLINED WE ARE. OKAY
FROM IMMIGRATION THANK YOU WE
JUST NEED YOUR NAME YOU HIS NEXT
WITNESS PUSH. YOU'RE RIGHT ONE
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS KELLY
WILDERNESS STAFF ATTORNEY WITH
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
CHILDREN CROWD COSPONSORED SB-
ONE ZERO ZERO EIGHT AND I'M
CALLING STRONG SUPPORTER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
LUNCH WONDER I AM A MEMBER OF
CALIFORNIA STATE STRONG
INDIVISIBLE INDIVISIBLE SAN
FRANCISCO INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO
AND INDIVISIBLE YELLOW ALL IN
STRONG SUPPORT. ONE THOUSAND
EIGHT. Q. THANK YOU I WON TWENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI WE
SHOULD AHMED ON BEHALF OF AT THE
JUSTICE GROUP IN STRONG SUPPORT
NO WAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE
FOUR FIVE. HI THIS IS RYAN
BAILEY WITH CHANGE BEGINS WITH
ME ANYWHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT AS
SB ONE ZERO ZERO EIGHT THANK YOU
. THANK YOU I WON TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS REBECCA ELLIOT CALLING
ON BEHALF OF INDIVISIBLE SAN
JOSE. COUNCILMEMBER OF THE H.
FROM COALITION AND WE ARE IN
CONSTANT COLLUDED DISPEL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AYE ONE NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. Y. Y. ONE NINE. BY ONE TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS SERRA CENTER
FIGHTERS FROM TEXAS PLAYS
ORGANIZATION WE'RE AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF TEN ZERO ZERO EIGHT
AM PROUD CO SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY ONE
NINETEEN. I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU. AFTER HEARING
FROM ALL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
NOW WILL MOVED OPPOSITION WE
HAVE ONE LEAD- WITNESS LISTED.
HOOSIER NATIONAL HER SHE ON THE
LINE.
NO OKAY ALL RIGHT SURE ANY
WITNESSES HERE PRESIDENT THAT
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
S. B. EIGHT. TEN ZERO EIGHT.
KERN TO NONE MODERATOR CAN WE GO
TO PHONE LINES NOW. PROPOSITION
WITNESSES. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO ASK B.
ONE ZERO ZERO EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
RIGHT ONE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WHO SHALL MATURE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION AT
TWO TEN OH EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE RIGHT ONE TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JIM LINDBERG ON
BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION THAT CALIFORNIA I
WAS ACTUALLY IN THE SUPPORT
QUEUE I JUST WANTED TO VOICE OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR DIGITAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IVANA GONZALEZ FROM THE START OF
DISPROPORTIONATELY CHILDREN ARE
ALSO GOING FOR UP AND HE CAN
WAIT FONG BUT THE THEM. FOR
THANK YOU I HAVE NO COMMENT
THINKING. BRING YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- HAVING HEARD FROM ON
BOTH SIDES ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS BY. COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
CENTER COMMONER I KNOW YOU TIRED
I MEAN MISTER CHAIR I'M SORRY-
SO I JUST WANNA SAY THAT I'M-
GOING TO BE- SUPPORTING THIS
BILL I THINK THAT- GTL IS A RACK
RACKET QUITE FRANKLY- I THINK
THAT EVERYONE HAS A RIGHT TO
CONNECT WITH THEIR FAMILY AND
FRIENDS AND THEIR LOVED ONES. I
THINK THAT HAVING OPERABLE
DEVICES IS KEY I THINK THAT
OFTEN I KNOW THAT OFTENTIMES.
LOCKDOWNS HAPPEN THROUGH NO
FAULT OF CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE THEN DENIED ACCESS TO
COMMUNICATE WITH EITHER COUNCIL
OR THEIR FRIENDS AND FAMILY. I
KNOW THAT CONTRABAND IS AN ISSUE
IN OUR DETENTION CENTERS AND ON
OUR FACILITIES BECAUSE SO MANY
PEOPLE HAVE THROWN UP THEIR
HANDS. AROUND NOT BEING ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE AND LAST I CHECKED
THAT WAS STILL A RIGHT. I KNOW
THAT AS A RESULT OF THE COSTS TO
MAKE PHONE CALLS WHICH ARE
EXORBITANT. THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED ARE PAYING TO BE
INCARCERATED AND THAT PEOPLE ON
THE OUTSIDE ARE PAYING TO HAVE
SOMEONE INCARCERATED AND IT
MAKES NO SENSE SO- AS A RESULT
OF ALL OF THOSE ISSUES THAT I
STATED AND THEN SOME I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND IF THE-
AUTHOR WOULD. BE SO GRACIOUS I'D
LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO OP. AND
I TO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THIS
MEASURE THINK ADDS COMMONSENSE
THAT PRISONERS. WHETHER IN JAIL
OR PRISON- INCARCERATED. NOT
ONLY HAVE THE RIGHT BUT NEED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMUNICATE WITH
NOT ONLY THEIR LEGAL COUNSEL THE
LOVED ONES AS WELL TO HELP KEEP
THEM CONNECTED AND MOTIVATED TO.
DO THE RIGHT THINGS ONCE OUT
SHOW AND AS INDIVIDUAL WHO USED
TO WORK FOR A TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANY I WAS BLOWN AWAY AT. THE
MODEL MONEY THEY MAKE ON PRISON
COSTS IT'S CRIMINAL IN AND OF
ITSELF- HOW MUCH THESE COMPANIES
MAKE- JUST A FORTUNE ONE A- TWO
THREE MINUTE PHONE CALL SO- I'M
- IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
REGION I THINK YOU BRING AFFORD
AND IF YOU. LIKE YOU CAN CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS
THAT'S WHEN I VOTE. WE'RE
SEEKING A MOTION- ON S. B. T. N.
O. EIGHT WE HAVE A TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. HE'S BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR COM LONGER. COUNCIL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON A SPEECH
TEN ZERO EIGHT. SB TEN ZERO
EIGHT BAKER BRADFORD HI REDFORD
I A CHAU BOCA COM LONGER I FROM
LONGER AYE SKINNER. WIENER
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. NEXT UP IS SENATOR
ARCHULETA HEROES S. B. TEN ZERO
SEVEN WALTON SEVEN SIX. THANK
YOU FOR SHARING. AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM HONORED TO BE HERE
I BELIEVE THIS MIGHT BE THE
FIRST TIME I'VE COME BEFORE YOUR
COMMITTEE MISTER CHAIR AND IT'S
GOOD TO SEE YOU. I HOPE NOT.
WELL ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS- I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL TEN SEVENTY SIX OF WHICH
IS- TO WILL HARMONIZE STATE AND
FEDERAL TRAINING AND
CERTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS IN
REGARDS LEAD BASED RELATED
PAINTED IN THE SAFETY THEIR UP.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES CONTRACTORS
AND INDIVIDUALS WHO DO WORK THAT
MIGHT DISRUPT LEAD PAINT TO BE
TRAINED AND CERTIFIED AT BOTH
THE FEDERAL AND STATE LEVELS.
THIS HAS LED TO LOTS OF
CONFUSION IN THE INDUSTRY ABOUT
STATE AND THE FEDERAL. TO
ADDRESSES CONFUSION SENATE BILL
TEN SEVENTY SIX WOULD REQUIRE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO ADOPT AND UPDATE THEIR
TRAINING AND CERTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS TO REFLECT THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS. IN
PRACTICE THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
CONTRACTORS AND INDIVIDUALS TO
BE TRAINED AND CERTIFIED ONCE
AND ONLY ONCE INSTEAD OF THE
CURRENT PRACTICE WHICH REQUIRES
A SEPARATE TRAINING BOTH STATE
AND FEDERAL. ALTHOUGH LEAD PAINT
HAS BEEN BANNED CALIFORNIA FOR
DECADES LEAD POISONING FROM
EXPOSURE TO LEAD PAINT CONTINUES
TO PLAGUE OUR STATE. IN FACT AS
NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS THAT
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSIS OFFICE
ESTIMATES THAT ABOUT 60% OF THE
HOUSES IN CALIFORNIA. WERE BUILT
BEFORE NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
ENTER SHOWN TO HAVE LEAD BASED
PAINT. EXPOSURE LEAD BASED PAINT
AT ANY LEVEL CAN HAVE SERIOUS
NEGATIVE EFFECTS FOR BOTH
CHILDREN AND ADULTS ALIKE.
HOWEVER LEAD EXPOSURE IN
CHILDREN IS PARTICULAR IN
PARTICULAR AREA OF CONCERN
BECAUSE IT IS SO DANGEROUS TO
THE CHILDREN. EVEN A SLIGHT
ELEVATION OF BLOOD LEVEL. IN
LEAD BASED PAINT IN A CHILD CAN
REQUIRE AND REDUCED RATHER
REDUCE IQ. CAUSE BRAIN AND NERVE
DAMAGE AND EVEN STUNT A CHILD'S
GROWTH EXPOSURE TO LEAD IS MOST
COMMON DURING RENOVATION. AN
UNTRAINED INDIVIDUAL WHO DOES
NOT FOLLOW PROPER PROTOCOLS CAN
AND THEN AND ONLY IT CHIP LEAD
PAINT FROM THE SURFACE AND THAT
WILL EXPOSURE WILL TAKE IT IN
THE YARDS INTO NEIGHBORHOODS AND
WHICH IS CRIMINAL. BECAUSE OF
THE FACT THAT IT SENDS UP CLOUDS
OF LEAD PAINT DUST- DURING THE
SANDY AND IT WILL AFFECT
EVERYONE IN THE AREA UNTRAINED
UNCERTIFIED INDIVIDUALS WORKING
WITH LEAD PAINT. THEY DO POSSESS
THEIR POSE A HAZARD NOT JUST FOR
THEMSELVES BUT TO THE GENERAL
PUBLIC. S. B. TEN SEVENTY SIX
ADDRESSES THIS LEAD ISSUE AND BY
STREAMLINING AND HARMONIZING OUR
TRAINING AND CERTIFICATION
PROCESS AND AT THE TIME- WILL
STRENGTHEN OUR OVERSIGHT BY
EMPOWERING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
HANDLE THE ENFORCEMENT. IN
ADDITION THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE BOARD TO COLLABORATE IN
EMPLOYMENT AND EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH PROGRAM. TO INFORM
INDIVIDUALS OF THE HARMS OF LEAD
AND THE REQUIREMENTS TO BE
TRAINED AND CERTIFIED. THIS
OUTREACH PROGRAM WILL RUN FOR
ONE FULL YEAR BEFORE
CERTIFICATION AND TRAINED
REQUIRED TRAINING REQUIREMENTS
WILL BE ENFORCED GIVING EVERYONE
AMPLE TIME TO COMPLY THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION AND
HAS AND IS IN SUPPORT SUPPORT BY
THE NUMBER OF HEALTH AND
ENVIRONMENTAL. ORGANIZATIONS FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS AND WITH ME
TODAY I HAVE SUSAN LITTLE
REPRESENTING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP AND ON THE
TELEPHONE. ON THE LINE HOPEFULLY
HE'S STILL THERE IS LARRY BROOKS
OF REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU WILL FOR YOUR TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES- TWO MINUTES
EACH IN SUPPORT- MISSILE YOU MAY
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU SENATOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR AUTHORING THIS BILL. A GOOD
MORNING MY NAME SUSAN LITTLE I'M
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS OF
SB TEN SEVENTY SIX. AS THE
SENATOR WAS EXPLAINING IT HAD
LET IS VERY HARMFUL TO CHILDREN
AND ADULTS BUT YOUNG CHILDREN
ARE THE MOST SENSITIVE TO NEED
TO THE NEUROTOXINS AFFECTS.
EXPOSURE TO EVEN MINUTE AMOUNTS
OF LEAD CAN CAUSE PERMANENT HARM
TO A CHILD DEVELOPING BRAIN AND
NERVOUS SYSTEM AND BECAUSE OF
THIS HARM THE CNTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL OF DETERMINES
THERE'S NO SAFE LEVEL OF LEAD
EXPOSURE IN CHILDREN AND ADULTS
LEAD POISONING CAN CAUSE HIGH
BLOOD PRESSUREAND REPRODUCTIVE
HARM. AND CAN LEAD TO PREMATURE
BIRTH AND MISCARRIAGE LEAD
POISONING CAN ALSO CAUSE CANCER.
UNFORTUNATELY STATISTICS
INDICATE THAT LOW INCOME
CHILDREN ARE LEAD POISONED MORE
OFTEN THAN CHILDREN FROM HIGHER
INCOME FAMILIES THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH INDICATES THAT
88% OF CALIFORNIA'S LEAD
POISONED CHILDREN ARE ON
MEDICAID I'LL- THIS UNEVEN
DISTRIBUTION IS IN PART BECAUSE
LOW INCOME CHILDREN ARE MORE
LIKELY TO LIVE. IN AND AROUND.
OLDER HOUSING THAT HAS CHIPPED
OR PEELED. PEELING LEAD BASED
PAINT. WHEN THIS PAINTS DISTURB
CHAPTER SANDED LEAD DUST
MOBILIZES INTO THE SURROUNDING
ENVIRONMENT. AND CAN BE INHALED
INGESTED OR TRACK TO OTHER
LOCATIONS AND HOLDS. LET'S SAFE
RENOVATION PRACTICES AREN'T
CONSISTENTLY USED IN CALIFORNIA
DUE TO CONFLICTING STATE AND
FEDERAL LAWS. THIS PROBLEMS BEEN
EXPERIENCED BY OTHER STATES AS
WELL AND SO TO DATE FOURTEEN
STATES HAVE DONE WHAT SB TEN
SEVENTY SIX PROPOSES TO DO. AND
THEY HAD AND HAVE INCORPORATED
THE FEDERAL RENOVATION AND
REPAIR PROGRAM INTO THEIR STATE
REGULATIONS. CALIFORNIA SHOULD
DO THE SAME SO THAT LET'S SAY
FOR INNOVATION PRACTICES ARE
UNIFORMLY EMPLOYED IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS. WE APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB TEN SEVENTY
SIX THANK YOU AND I ALSO WANTED
TO JUST REITERATE THE SUPPORT
FROM THE FAMILIES ADVOCATING FOR
CHEMICALS AND TOXIC SAFETY.
CALPERS PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE- OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA AND CLEAN
WATER ACTION.
OKAY IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM HERE IS SOME
FOR. YES SIR WE HAVE ANOTHER
LEAD WITH US ONLINE. LARRY
BROOKS YOUR PERMISSION TO SPEAK. YOU CAN PROCEED I MEAN WHEN
HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
THANK YOU SIR UP. THANK YOU ARE
ON A ROLL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE I GREET YOU ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WHO ARE CO SPONSORING
THIS BILL AND WE THANK THE
SENATOR FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD.
THE FEDERAL ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY ADMITS THAT
THEY LACK CAPACITY TO
EFFECTIVELY ENFORCE THE LEAD
SAFETY OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
RENOVATION REPAIR PAINTING RULE
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AS A CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER AND HEALTHY
HOUSING SPECIALIST I AND OTHERS
LIKE ME. THROUGHOUT THE STATE
ROUTINELY RECEIVED COMPLAINTS
FROM RESIDENTS REGARDING UNSAFE
AND OFTEN UNLICENSED LABORERS
PERFORMING RENOVATION AND OR
REPAIR WORK ON HOMES IN WHICH
THEY CREATE LEAD PAINT CHIPS AND
DUST DEBRIS THAT CAN BE INHALED
BY ADULTS AND DIRECTLY INGESTED
BY SMALL CHILDREN CRAWLING ON
FLOORS ARE CLEAN AND
CONTAMINATED SOIL. BUSTY
INDIVIDUALS CONDUCTING THESE
UNSAFE RENOVATION REPAIR AND
PAINTING JOBS HAVE BEEN KNOWN TO
NOT ONLY TOWARDS IN THEIR
CUSTOMERS AND NEIGHBORS OF THEIR
CUSTOMERS BUT EVEN THEMSELVES IN
THEIR OWN CHILDREN IN SUCH
TRAGEDIES COULD HAVE BEEN.
AVOIDED IF THESE WORKERS SHOULD
USE LEAD SAFE WORK PRACTICES
PART IN THE ONE DAY ONLY
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
RENOVATION REPAIR AND PAINTING
RULE COURSE ALSO KNOWN AS R. P.
WHICH IS OFFERED BY STATE
CERTIFIED CONSTRUCTION TRAINING
PROVIDERS ALL ACROSS THE STATE.
THEREFORE WE ASK. FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS BILL. OKAY IS THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT IN
FAVOR IN THE ROOM PLEASE COME
FORWARD. THIS IS FOR YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY ON THE FACT
THAT YOUR SUPPORT. OSCAR SERRANO
FROM RICHMOND CALIFORNIA SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OF PUBLIC
COMMENT HERE IN THE ROOM. SEEING
NONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
OF THE MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANY SUPPORT- FOR SB TEN SEVENTY
SIX. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TEN
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU. OKAY WILL
NOW GO TO OPPOSITION- DO WE HAVE
LEAD US OR- WE HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION IDENTIFIED AS OR
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. SB
TEN SEVENTY SIX PLEASE COME
FORWARD I'VE SEEN NINE ROOMS OF
PHONE LINES COULD YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
SP TEN SEVENTY SIX. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO ASK BE TEN SEVENTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU OKAY
WILL BRING ABOUT- TO THE
COMMITTEE- DOES YEAR MAY CENTER
SODA SO- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
YES- THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU FOR SITTING AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. OKAY I
DON'T THINK I CAN MAKE THE MOST
I CAN'T MAKE A MOTION BECAUSE
I'M SHARING TO INOTES. IS. WHICH
I CAN DO MOTIONS AND SHARING- SO
WHAT TAKE A MOTION ONE ANOTHER
SEVEN ARRIVES SO VALUES HONOR.
OKAY I SEE NO OTHER AUTHORS AND
I DON'T THINK I CAN PRESENT
BECAUSE OF IT I'M GOING. TO
PRESENT TO- RECEIVE CENTER
SCANNERS ON OUR WAY BACK. IT WAS
MY.
HE COMES BACK.
PATIENTS WERE TRYING TO ROUND UP
ANOTHER SENATOR NOEL STARTED AND.
SHE I MEAN IT'S LIKE SHE'S SHE'S
AND SHE- RIGHT. BUT IF THEY'RE
NOT COMING BACK EXACERBATING.
NUMBER SEVEN. PART OF. YEAH.
OKAY HERE WE GO- PARALYSIS AND.
OKAY- THE S. M. F. MOTION ON HIS
BE TEN SEVENTY SIX. WITH THE
MOTION SB TEN SEVENTY SIX AND
WILL CALL THE ROLL. SB TEN
SEVENTY SIX BRADFORD. A TURBO I
ABOAGYE COM LONGER. INNER WINNER
I MEAN ARE I. ONE CALL. DO YOU
WANT ME TO YOUR BILL- YES WHEN
WE DO HAVE TWO BILLS- ONE WE
START WITH A THIRTY FOUR.
LET. WELCOME VISITOR OF AIR YOU
MAY PRESENT S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
ONE. MADAM CHAIR AND CENTERS I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE WHICH WOULD CREATE A
HEARSAY EXCEPTION IN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CASES FOR STATEMENTS
MADE FOR PURPOSES OF MEDICAL
DIAGNOSIS. VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ARE AMONG THE MOST
VULNERABLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND UNFORTUNATELY CRIMES
COMMITTED AGAINST THEM ARE AMONG
THE MOST DIFFICULT TO PROSECUTE.
THERE ARE FEW WITNESSES TO THIS
TYPE OF ABUSE WHICH OCCURS
ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS ENORMOUS PRESSURE IS OFTEN
BROUGHT UPON VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE FREQUENTLY FROM THEIR
ABUSERS OR FAMILIES TO DENY THE
ABUSE THEY ARE ENTERING. IN MANY
INSTANCES A MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL
MAY BE THE ONLY PERSON TO WHOM-THE VICTIM DISCLOSES THE EXTENT
OF THE ABUSE FOR INJURY OR LOSS
RIGHTLY SHIELD VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WHO REFUSED TO
TESTIFY FROM PENAL CONSEQUENCES
THEY CANNOT BE INCARCERATED FOR
REFUSING TO TESTIFY. REFUSING TO
TESTIFY IS NOT HOWEVER
INDICATIVE OF A DESIRE TO BE
LEFT UNPROTECTED AND SO WE
CONTINUE TO PROSECUTE OFFENDERS
WITHOUT FORCING VICTIMS TO THE
STAND WHERE THEY MIGHT PUT
THEMSELVES IN GREATER DANGER FOR
ABUSE OR ISOLATION. IN THESE
INSTANCES WHERE VICTIMS CANNOT
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE WOULD ALLOW VICTIMS
TRUTH TO BE HEARD. THIS BILL
WOULD CREATE A HEARSAY EXCEPTION
FOR STATEMENTS MADE BY A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIM TO A
MEDICAL CARE PROVIDER FOR
PURPOSES OF MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS OR
TREATMENT. AS WELL AS STATEMENTS
REASONABLY PERTINENT TO MEDICAL
DIAGNOSIS OR TREATMENT. THE
CHANGE WILL CONFORM CALIFORNIA'S
TREATMENT OF THE STATEMENTS. TO
FEDERAL LAW AND THAT OF OTHER
STATES SINCE FEDERAL RULES OF
EVIDENCE IN ITS RULE EIGHT OH
THREE SUBSECTION FOR PERMIT
STATEMENTS FOR PURPOSE OF
MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS IN ALL CASES
REGARDLESS OF THE DAY CLARENCE
AVAILABILITY AT TRIAL.
CALIFORNIA ALSO ALREADY OFFERS
THIS EXEMPTION IN CASES OF CHILD
ABUSE SB ELEVEN THIRTY SIX
EXCUSE ME SB ELEVEN TWENTY THREE
EXTENDS THE SAME PROTECTION. TO
ANOTHER VULNERABLE POPULATION.
MEDICAL HERE SAY WOULD BE A
CRITICAL AND EFFECTIVE TOOL TO
COUNTERACT AND ABUSERS
MANIPULATIONS AND THREATS THAT
PRE PREVENT VICTIM TESTIMONY
CONSISTENT AND EFFECTIVE
PROSECUTION OF DOMESTIC ABUSE
HAS A PROVEN TRACK RECORD OF
DECREASING THE INCIDENCE OF
DOMESTIC ABUSE. BUT EFFECTIVE
PROSECUTION REQUIRES COMPELLING
EVIDENCE THIS BILL ALLOWS
PROSECUTORS TO EFFECTIVELY
PROSECUTE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
THEREBY PROTECTING VICTIMS FROM
FURTHER ABUSE WHILE HONORING
VICTIMS CHOICE NOT TO TESTIFY.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT IS MIKE
MICHAEL FUHRMAN CHIEF ASSISTANT
DISTRICT ATTORNEY AT THE SAMBAR
DINO COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE. WELCOME MR BERMAN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO RECEIVE MORNING
THANK YOU THANK YOU ARE. MADAM
LOOK. MA'AM CENTER WHO SITTING
AS CHAIR SO THANK YOU FOR LIVE
ME TO SPEAK TO IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE IT IS HAS A
CENTER INDICATED A MODIFICATION
TO EVIDENCE CODE SECTION TWELVE
FIFTY THREE. PERMITTING
STATEMENTS MADE FOR THE PURPOSE
OF MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS BUT VERY
NARROWLY TAILORED UNLIKE THE
FEDERAL RULE EIGHT OH THREE FOUR
ONLY TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES-
THIS IS A- I HEAR TAKES ACTION
THAT HAS GREAT SIGNIFICANCE TO
ME I IT IS ON APRIL TWENTY
EIGHTH TWO THOUSAND IT WAS THE
DAY THAT BACKING MOURINHO'S HA
WAS BRUTALLY MURDERED IN BARSTOW
CALIFORNIA AND I HANDLED THE
PROSECUTION OF THAT CASE. SHE'S
BEATEN ARE A BILL WAS WRAPPED
AROUND HER NECK AND SHORT WAS
STUFFED UNDER HER THROAT ARE HER
TEETH WERE KNOCKED OUT WE CALL
THAT AN ABORTION SHE WAS THROWN
A TRASH CAN BE FOUND BY HER
FATHER. SHE WAS MURDERED BY THE
FATHER OF HER SON MURDERED AFTER
A DECADE OF ABUSE AFTER
INVOLVEMENTS- WITH THE POLICE
TRIPS TO THE HOSPITAL AND
DOCTORS AND ON NONE OF THOSE
STATEMENTS WERE ADMISSIBLE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT WOULD HAVE BEEN
OTHERWISE ADMISSIBLE IN AT LEAST
FIVE STATES AND CERTAINLY IN THE
FEDERAL JURISDICTION. I CAN'T
HELP BUT THINK SENATOR THE- MAN
WHO I SPENT TIME WITH SINCE TWO
THOUSAND. WHO IS EIGHT YEARS OLD
THE TIME. WHO STRUGGLED WITH
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND WITH-
REPEATED ARRESTS. THAT HE IF HE
HAD HIS MOTHER AROUND IF WE DID
WHAT WE SHOULD HAVE DONE BY
ADMITTING THAT. SO THAT SHE
WOULD BE HERE TODAY- I THINK HIS
LIFE WOULD HAVE BEEN DRASTICALLY
DIFFERENT. I REALIZE THAT MY
DEFENSE ATTORNEY- COLLEAGUES
HAVE ADVANCED CONCERNS. RELATED
TO- THIS MOMENT RIGHT TO
CONFRONTATION. ARE WE HAVE MADE
BY THE CENTER WILL MAKE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS- THAT WILL ADDRESSES
CONCERNS BUT I HAVE NO DOUBT
THAT IT WILL NOT. A REMOVED MY
DEFENSE ATTORNEY. FRIENDS
OPPOSITION- BECAUSE IT DEALS
WITH OUR RESPECTIVE VIEWS ON
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. WE SEEK TO
RESTORE THE VOICE OF VICTIMS ON
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS. VOICE IS
INTIMIDATED INTO SILENCE TO THE
VIOLENCE. CHILDREN OR- FORTY AND
EVEN LOVE. OUR CONCERNS ABOUT
THE INCREASING CYCLE OF VIOLENCE
THAT OCCURS ON INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE REPEATEDLY VICTIMIZED. AND
THEIR SILENCE OUR IS A PART OF
THAT THAT CYCLE OF VIOLENCE. AND
OUR CONCERN IS THAT WE PLACE
THEM IN GREATER DANGER. AS THE
PRECOURT NOTED- UNITED SUPREME
COURT THAT THIS PARTICULAR TYPE
OF CRIME IS SUSCEPTIBLE TO
INTIMIDATION OR COERCION OF THE
VICTIM. TO ENSURE THAT SHE DOES
NOT TESTIFY AT TRIAL. WE SEEK
THIS NARROW EXCEPTION TO ALLOW
STATEMENTS THAT ARE MADE ONLY IN
THE SERIES OF CASES. IN WHICH
THEY SEEK MEDICAL TREATMENT THAT
THEY BE ADMISSIBLE IN THE COURT
AND THE PROSECUTION. AND WE
REQUEST ARRIVAL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER FOR MAY. WE DO NOT
HAVE ANOTHER LEAD WITNESS BUT WE
WILL CONTINUE WILL MOVE ON TO
ANYONE WANTING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
ONE- WILL BEGIN HERE IN THIS
ROOM ONE TWELVE M. STONE STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS VERY
LIMITED NARROW THEY'LL. THANK
YOU DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. SIXTEEN NINE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WHAT. WOULD
YOU. SORRY. OSCAR SORIANA
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
OSCAR WILL NOW MOVE TO MOVE ON
TO THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
OR VERSUS- IT WILL TAKE TEN
MINUTES OF TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MATTER OUR MODERATOR-
SEE WE DO HAVE ONE LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION. ARE YOU ON THE A
PERSON PERFECT I AM THE PERSON.
MY NAME IS LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION WE OPPOSE
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE WHICH
CREATES A WAY TO AVOID THE RIGHT
TO CONFRONTATION ASSURED TO ALL
OF US BY THE CONSTITUTION I DO
TAKE ISSUE WITH THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S COMMENT SUGGESTING
THAT. THE DIFFERENCE OF OPINION
OVER THIS BILL RELATES TO OUR
POSITION ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
THE DEFENSE TAKES DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AS SERIOUSLY AS ANY
MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY OUR
DIFFERENCES OVER THE
CONFRONTATION CLAUSE SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE WOULD AMEND EVIDENCE
CODE SECTION TWELVE FIFTY THREE
BY ADDING A SUBDIVISION WHICH
WOULD CREATE A NEW HERE SAYING
GEN. IT WOULD ALLOW THE
INTRODUCTION IN COURT OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ALLEGED
VICTIMS DESCRIPTIONS OF ACCESS
OR ATTEMPTED ACTS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IF THE STATEMENT WAS
MADE FOR MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS OR
TREATMENT PURPOSES AND DESCRIBES
CURRENT OR PAST MEDICAL HISTORY
OR SYMPTOMS. INTRODUCED SHOULD
INTRODUCTION OF THESE STATEMENTS
WOULD THEN ALLOW THE PROSECUTOR
TO PROCEED TO PROSECUTE AN
INDIVIDUAL WITHOUT THE ALLEGED
VICTIM EVER COMING FORWARD IN
COURT IN FACT IN OUR- AND WE'VE
HAD SEVERAL DISCUSSIONS THE CDA
HAS ADMITTED THAT WITH THE
ASSISTANCE OF THIS EVIDENCE CODE
CARVE OUT THE PROSECUTION WISHES
TO PROCEED IN THE ABSENCE OF THE
ALLEGED VICTIM AVOIDING THE
REQUIREMENTS GUARDRAILS IF YOU
WILL OF THE CURRENT EVIDENCE
CODE. EVIDENCE CODE SECTION
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN EIGHT
ALREADY PROVIDES HEARSAY
EXCEPTION FOR STATEMENTS
CONCERNING THE INFLICTION OR
THREAT OF PHYSICAL INJURY THAT
ARE MADE TO MEDICAL FOR. OR LAW
ENFORCEMENT. SB ELEVEN ONE WOULD
GREATLY EXPAND CRIMINAL
PROSECUTIONS AND CONVICTIONS. IN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES
INCLUDING CASES WHERE THE VICTIM
CHOSE NOT TO PARTICIPATE WHICH
TO RECANT OR WAS AND COPPER
UNCOOPERATIVE FOR MYRIAD OF
REASONS. THIS BILL TAKES AWAY
THE VICTIM'S AGENCY PARTICULARLY
THE WOMEN WHO ARE ESSENTIALLY
INFANTA LEISING THEM BY
INCLUDING THEM WITH AN EVIDENCE
CODE SECTION DESIGNED TO PROTECT
YOUNG CHILDREN. THIS BILL MAKING
THE HEARSAY STATEMENTS
DELINEATED ADMISSIBLE WOULD
DEPRIVE PERSONS ACCUSED OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OF THEIR RIGHT
TO CONFRONT THEIR ACCUSERS. THE
CRAWFORD IN MALINDI IS CASE
MELENDEZ DIAZ CASES DO NOT SAVE
THIS FLOOD PROPOSED LEGISLATION
AND MELENDEZ DIAZ THE U. S.
SUPREME COURT SAID THE
CONFRONTATION CLAUSE MAY MAKE
THE PROSECUTION OF CRIMINALS
MORE BURDENSOME BUT THAT IS
EQUALLY TRUE OF THE RIGHT TO
TRIAL BY JURY. AND THE PRIVILEGE
AGAINST SELF INCRIMINATION. THE
CARD CAN CLOSE THE CONTINUED
LIKE OTHER CONSTITUTIONAL
PROVISIONS IS BINDING AND WE MAY
NOT DISREGARD IT AT OUR
CONVENIENCE THANK YOU. SO WE DO
HAVE A SECOND- LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS KATHY SURE FROM THE ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND I BELIEVE
SHE IS ONLINE. KATHY ARE YOU ON
THE LINE I AM PERFECT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PROCEED RIGHT I AM.
PERFECT WONDERFUL YES PROCEED-
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU SURE ON
BEHALF OF EIGHTEEN MILLION
CALIFORNIA ACTION. WE
RESPECTFULLY MATTHEW CODES SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE. THE
CONFRONTATION OF THE SIXTH
AMENDMENT STATES THAT IN ALL
CRAP CRIMINAL PROSECUTION THE
ACCUSED SHALL ENJOY THE RIGHT BE
CONFRONTED WITH THE WITNESSES
AGAINST. IT IS A SIMPLE BUT
POWERFUL CONCEPT SOMEONE FACING
THE POWER OF THE STATE TO
DEPRIVE THEM OF LIBERTY SHOULD
KNOW WHO IS PROVIDING TESTIMONY
AGAINST THEM. AND SHOULD HAVE
THE CHANCE TO CONTEST THAT WITH
THE TESTIMONY CARE ACT. THE CARD
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF A
CRIMINAL DEFENDANT BEING ABLE TO
TEST THE VERACITY OF THE
WITNESSES AGAINST BY CROP.
WITNESSES PRESENT IN COURT
ALLOWS THE TRIER OF FACT IS EVEN
WITNESS AND EVALUATE THE
WITNESS'S CREDIBILITY. THE GOLD
STANDARD FOR TESTING WITNESS
CREDIBILITY ACROSS EXAMINATION.
STATEMENTS PROVIDED FROM
UNDERSEA WITNESSES AND CANNOT BE
EXAMINED. WE DO NOT HAVE THE
SAME TESTED RELIABILITY. IT
FOLLOWS THAT EXCEPT WERE MADE TO
THE REQUIREMENT THAT A WITNESS
WITNESS TESTIFIED COURT THEY
MUST BE NARAL AND MUST
INCORPORATE SAFEGUARDS TO ENSURE
RELIABILITY AS MUCH AS IS
POSSIBLE WITHOUT THE POSSIBILITY
OF CROSS EXAMINATION. EXISTING
EVIDENCE CODE SECTION THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ALLOWED IN A STATEMENT
REGARDING THE INFLICTION OF
PHYSICAL INJURY UPON THE
DECLARATION AS SB ELEVEN THIRTY
ONE PROPOSES TO DO. BUT ONLY
WHERE THE DECLARATION IS
UNAVAILABLE AS A WITNESS
ACCORDING TO A STRICT STANDARD
WHERE THE STATEMENT WAS MADE AT
OR NEAR THE TIME OF THE INJURY.
AND WHEN THE STATEMENT WAS MADE
UNDER CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WOULD
INDICATE IT TRUSTWORTHINESS WITH
THE LIST OF FACTORS. TO ALLOW
THE COURT TO EVALUATE THAT
TRUSTWORTHY. MOREOVER THE
OPPOSING PARTY UNDER SECTION
THIRTEEN HYUNDAI MUST BE GIVEN
NOTICE OF THE STATEMENT. AND AN
OPPORTUNITY TO. NONE OF THESE
COULD OF PROVIDED IN THAT ELEVEN
ONE. WITHOUT THE TAKING
STRINGENT THAT ARE SEVENTY S.
ELEVEN SEVEN ONE WILL. DOWN THE
OF PROSECUTORS IT DID NOT AT
THAT THE FINAL EIGHT THERE RIGHT
TO CONFRONT THEIR QUEUE.
ASSEMBLY NOT NEEDED THE SECTION
THIRTEEN EIGHT ALL THERE ARE
THOSE ONE WITNESS IS TRUE. SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE I KNOW. AND
DAY EXPANSION HERE'S A- CREATED
AND PEOPLE COULD SECTION. THREE
WE RESPECT URGE NOTEBOOK. NOW TO
WITNESSES OPPOSITE. OVER THE
LONG. MODERATOR THANK YOU THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION- SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE TEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I DO HAVE ONE IN Q.
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THAT COMMENT.
YOU KNOW SOMEONE IN Q. I WILL
COOK YES WE ARE WANTING TO OVER
TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JEANETTE
AND I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
OPPOSITION TO SB. ELEVEN SEVENTY
ONE. Q. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU- OUR-
YOU CAN MANY OTHERS ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS IN REGARDS
TO THIS MEASURE. NO. SEARCHES ON
SOME OF THE EXAMPLES THAT WERE
GIVEN- IT'S IMAGES WITNESSES
WERE UNAVAILABLE SO I'M JUST
TRYING TO GET MY HEAD AROUND
LIKE ONE OF THE KINDS OF
SITUATIONS. THAT WOULD NOT BE
COVERED BY EXISTING HEARSAY
EXCEPTIONS. THAT WOULD BE
COVERED HERE- JUST BECAUSE
EXAMPLES I HEARD IT SEEMED TO ME
LIKE THOSE WILL PROBABLY ALREADY
BE COVERED BY THE EXISTING-
EXCEPTIONS NOT NECESSARILY UNDER
THIRTEEN SEVENTY THE WITNESS
WOULD HAVE TO BE UNAVAILABLE
SOMETIMES WE WOULD HAVE
WITNESSES THAT COULD BE
POTENTIALLY AVAILABLE THESE ARE.
STATEMENTS THAT ARE MADE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF BUCKLE DIAGNOSIS
WHICH DON'T CRAWL FALL UNDER THE
CRAWFORD STANDARD CRAWFORD DEALS
WITH BOTH TEST YEAH SPOKE WITH
RIGHT TO CONFRONTATION
SPECIFICALLY SPOKE TO
TESTIMONIAL STATEMENTS
STATEMENTS THAT WERE MADE FOR
EXAMPLE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
PROSECUTION. OUR STATEMENTS WERE
TRYING TO GO AFTER SO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO SEE COMMISSION
STATEMENTS THAT ARE INHERENTLY
RELIABLE BECAUSE YOU'RE TOO
AMERICAN POSITION FOR THE
PURPOSE OF TREATMENT BUT BUT
IT'S MERRILEES YOUR SIX OPTION
FOR. INFLICTION OF. INJURY RIGHT
WRONG ABOUT THAT. I THOUGHT AT
THAT THAT'S NOT OUR BELIEF IN
FRANKLY THIRTEEN SEVENTY WAS
PASSED IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX
MODIFIED IN TWO THOUSAND AND IT
WAS UTILIZING- AND IT WAS THE
BASIS FROM THE RESIDUAL
EXCEPTION TO THE HEARSAY RULE IN
THE FEDERAL RULES OF EVIDENCE.
THAT WAS PRE CRAWFORD IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FOUR THAT
PROTECTION THIS STILL DOES NOT
MEET THE CRAWFORD STANDARD
CRAWFORD STILL APPLIES TO
TESTIMONIAL STATEMENTS THE
STATEMENTS THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
THAT THE CENTERS TRYING TO
INTRODUCE OUR NON TESTIMONIAL IN
NATURE. THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT IN MICHIGAN VERSUS
BRYANT WITH RULE EIGHT OH THREE
EIGHT FOUR SAID THAT THAT IS NOT
CRAWFORD IMPLICATED INDEED WHAT
THE COURT SAID IN CRAWFORD WAS
THE CRAWFORD PLANS FOR SIX THE
MOMENT ANALYSIS. BECOMES
INAPPLICABLE IN SITUATIONS WHERE
STATEMENTS ARE NON TESTIMONIAL.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
SEEKING HERE. OKAY TRYING ANSWER
I THOUGHT I HAD A COPY IN OUR
WITH ME PARENTS NOT IN MY- CAN I
COPY. I THOUGHT. ONE MOMENT.
WHEN NOBODY'S MINE IT'S ALL
MARKED UP. A PUT UP HERE. JERRY.
OKAY I'M SORRY I WAS REFERRING
TO THIRTEEN SEVENTY I SYSTEM
HAVE A THE NUMBER AND YES YOU I
THINK YOU'RE REFERRING TO THE
STATEMENT MADE AT OR NEAR THE
TIME- EIGHT HOWEVER AGAIN THIS
WAS THIS THIS THIS DOES NOT
APPLY YOU CAN HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE YOU GO TO THE DOCTOR DAYS
WEEKS LATER WHERE YOU HAVE A OF
A BROKEN COLLARBONE AND THERE
WAS NO DISCUSSION ABOUT IT UNTIL
A LATER TIME THERE OKAY THERE
ARE A LOT OF INJURIES IN WHICH
ESPECIALLY IN A RECANTING A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIM
SITUATION. WHERE THEY MIGHT NOT
TREATMENT IMMEDIATELY SO IN
EXAMPLES YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
IF THE DRESS CERVANTES- WHO JUST
GOES STRAIGHT TO THE HOSPITAL.
AND IS TALKING TO THEIR ER
INTAKE NURSE OR DOCTOR. SAYING
YOU KNOW BY MY SPOUSE ON HIT ME
AND BROKE MY ARM- BACK TO BE
COVERED THIRTY SEVEN EVERY YEAR
SIGN IF THEY WANT TO THE
HOSPITAL. OR DOCTOR FOUR DAYS
LATER AND MIGHT NOT BE. THAT
THAT'S IT HAS TO BE AT OR NEAR
THE TIME DRIVING NEAR THE TIME
IF YOU IF YOU LIKE THAT THE POOR
YOU GET HIT YOUR ARMS PROGRAM.
AND THEN YOU GET A CARD DR THE
HOSPITAL AND TALK TO THE- TO THE
NURSE OF THE DOCTOR AND SAY THAT
STYLE WOULD STRIKE ME AS ODD OR
NEAR THE TIME. RIGHT YES BUT
WHEN I'M TRYING ABOUT ARE THEY
OFTEN TEACH. REAGAN INJURY
OCCURRED BUT- TREATMENT DOES NOT
OCCUR SOMETIME LATER. THAT OFTEN
HAPPENS IN THESE SITUATIONS
ESPECIALLY IN SITUATIONS WHERE
THE SITE I'M JONATHAN. I'M
DISTINGUISHING DIED OF THE TIME
WE GO STRAIGHT TO THE ER AFTER.
THE PERSON SALAS YOU. VERSES YOU
WAIT. THREE I'M NOT CRITICIZING
PERSON WAITING THREE DAYS AT
HOME THERE ARE MANY REASONS WHY
PEOPLE THE LIGHTS. BUT THREE
DAYS LATER YOU'RE SAYING WOULD
NOT. BE COVERED BY THIRTEEN
SEVENTY BECAUSE IT WAS NOT.
IMMEDIATELY AFTER. RIGHT OKAY-
AND IS THERE CASE LAW ON- AND I.
AS A FORMER TRIAL LAWYER- TRYING
TO DRAG MY MEMORY. IN TERMS OF-
HEREI DON'T KNOW THE TIME IS
OBVIOUSLY A- NOT A PRECISE-
TIMING ARE ARE THERE IS THERE A
WELL ESTABLISHED BODY OF. CASE
LAW ABOUT WHAT. I AS INTERESTED
WHAT QUALIFIES AS I DON'T GET
WHAT. QUALIFIES AS NEAR. WELL
I'M SANDERS YOU KNOW WASN'T AS A
FORMER. HUNDRED FORTY DESPITE
TECH A THE HEARSAY IRAQ. A
SITUATION WHERE YOU'RE UNDER THE
STRESS OF THE EXCITEMENT AT THE
TIME THE STATEMENTS MADE. A
STATEMENT COULD POTENTIALLY COME
IN DURING THAT TIME BUT WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO AND WHY WE'RE LIMITING IT
ONLY TO SITUATIONS WHERE THEY'RE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF MEDICAL
DIAGNOSIS OR TREATMENT IS
BECAUSE THAT'S WIDELY RECOGNIZED
AROUND OUR OUR COUNTRY THAT
THOSE ARE STATEMENTS THAT MAY
OCCUR OUTSIDE OF THE TIME FRAME
THAT ARE MEANT IT'S- DIRECTED
UNDER THIRTEEN SEVENTY. AND I
THE CASES ARE VERY CLEAR AS
SUPPLIES TO THOSE AND THAT LAW
IS IN A BROADER CONTEXT
PERMITTED IN MINNESOTA IN- NORTH
CAROLINA IN OREGON IN RHODE
ISLAND AND IN THE FEDERAL RULES
OF EVIDENCE UNDER EIGHT OH THREE
FOUR AND THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT IN MICHIGAN VERSUS
BRYANT FOUND THAT TO NOT BE
CRAWFORD IMPLICATED. WE'VE HAD
SIMILAR. WHERE ARE COURTS HAVE
MADE COMMENTS TO THAT IN A CASE
CALLED PEOPLE VERSUS CAGE AND
THAT WAS THE CASE IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN. THE COURT
CONSIDERED TO PARTICULAR
STATEMENTS OF A PARTICULAR
SITUATION A STATEMENT MADE TO A
DEPUTY SHERIFF. AS A RESULT OF A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASE IN A
STATEMENT THAT WAS MADE TO A
DOCTOR AT A LATER TIME. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF MEDICAL TREATMENT AND
THE HIGH COURT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SAID THOSE ARE VERY
DISTINGUISHABLE ONE IS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF PROSECUTION. WE CAN
AGREE WITH THAT THAT IS-
TESTIMONY NATURE. CONFRONTATION
MUST OCCUR IF THAT STATEMENTS
GOING TO COME IN. BUT THE CAGE
COURT ALSO RECOGNIZED IN
SITUATIONS WHERE WE'RE DEALING
WITH STATEMENTS MADE TO A
MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL FOR THE
PURPOSE OF. MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS
AND TREATMENT THAT IS NOT
TESTIMONIAL THEY SAID IT WAS NOT
TESTIMONY EVEN WHEN THE DOCTOR
WAS ASKING WHAT HAPPENED. FOR
THE SANDERS- EDUCATION IT'S
FORTY CALIFORNIA NINE SIX FIVE.
FOUR BUT IN THE END THIS
EXCEPTION TO YOUR POSTINGS ARE
CREATED. IF THE PERSON SOUGHT
TREATMENTS A YEAR LATER I WOULD
ALSO QUALIFY UNDER THE HEARSAY
RULE ON THE VEGAS EXCEPTION. IT
IT. IT TECHNICALLY COULD YES FOR
TWO YEARS LATER. IT ANYTIME
WITHIN THE STATURE LIMITATIONS
FOR. THE RECORD. OKAY ON IS YOU
KNOW THE STATE OF THAT EVIDENCE
IS GOING TO BE WEAKER THE LONGER
ONE WAITS RIGHT RIGHT IT WOULD
BE IMPEACHABLE IS WITHOUT
QUESTION. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I'M I'M SORRY I WAS LATE
TO THE PARTY SURE WERE WE ANY
MORE WITNESSES. WE'RE NOT.
ALWAYS BACK TO COMMITTEE OKAY
ANYMORE QUESTIONS ARE COMING
FROM- COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SENATOR
SKINNER. ALL AGES FOR MISSING
THE DISCUSSION SO FAR- BUT I AND
MAYBE THIS WAS ADDRESSED SO BUT
WHEN I READ THE ANALYSIS I SAW
THAT THERE IS. THERE ARE
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE A MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL CAN YOU ENTER THIS
HEARSAY EVIDENCE. AND IT'S NOT
COMPLETELY PROHIBITED BUT ALSO
SEE THAT WITH THE BILL'S TRYING
TO DO IS HELP THOSE SITUATIONS
WHERE THE VICTIM THEMSELVES IS
NOT WILLING TO COME FORWARD. AND
I DISCUSSED WHAT'S TRICKY FOR ME
AS- WE NEED TO SUPPORT VICTIMS
WE WANT THEM I DON'T MEAN
SUPPORT WE NEED TO. CREATE A
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE VICTIMS FEEL
COMFORTABLE AND SO THAT WE CAN
PROSECUTE THESE CRIMES AND SO
THAT WE CAN TRY TO STOP THE
CYCLE. HOWEVER WE ALSO KNOW THAT
- TEMP LIKE HEROES DON'T ALWAYS
WORK AND EVEN WHEN WE PROSECUTE
IF THE PERSON SAY IF IT'S A- YOU
KNOW THEY'RE NOT- J. OLDER
INCARCERATED THERE. THAT THE
RETALIATION TO VICTIMS IS REAL
AND- SOMETIMES THE VICTIM MADE.
B. WISER ABOUT THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCE AND SO I JUST I WAS
REALLY STRUGGLING WITH. WHETHER
THE REQUIREMENT WHEN IT'S IN
EFFECT NOT SOMETHING THAT THE
VICTIM WANTS TO HAVE PUT INTO
EVIDENCE. IS GOING TO BENEFIT
THE VICTIMS SAFETY AND THAT'S
WHAT I'VE BEEN STRUGGLING WITH.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF THAT WAS
EXPLICITLY ADDRESSED IN THE
PREVIOUS CONVERSATION. IF IT
WASN'T BUT I THINK PART OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT- IT'S HARD TO
GENERALIZE IF I COULD ON THIS
IT'S- YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
IT'S HARD TO GENERALIZE- I HAVE
SPOKEN TO VICTIMS WHO- WHO HAVE
MOVED OUT AND MOVED ON AND DON'T
WANT TO SHOW UP IN COURT- BUT
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN HIDING. AND
SO THEY DON'T WANT TO BE THERE-
AND- I. OBVIOUSLY HAVE DONE
BILLS. TO- BECAUSE VICTIMS HAVE
BEEN KILLED BECAUSE THEY THEY
WERE NOT ABLE TO GET A WHERE
THEY GOT AWAY AND- THE-
PERPETRATOR WAS ABLE TO HUNT
THEM DOWN AND SO. WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS TO CREATE AN
OPPORTUNITY AND I I'VE I OWE IT
TO THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY SPEAK
FOR THIS ISSUE THEMSELVES IS
SAID- MY PERCEPTION THAT THERE'S
IT'S A- IT'S A RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE DA'S OFFICE AND THE
VICTIMS AS TO EXACTLY HOW TO GET
THEM OUT OF THE SITUATION AND-
WHAT KIND OF TESTIMONY THEY CAN
USE IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO PROVE
THE CASE AGAINST. A PERPETRATOR
AND SO IT'S NOT CUT AND DRY IN
TERMS OF WHAT WHAT THEY WILL DO-
BUT IT'S A THERE'S A THERE'S A
DISCUSSION THAT HAPPENS AND
MAYBE MAYBE- I MEAN THIS. IN A
PERFECT WORLD THE DA WILL ALWAYS
BE LOOKING OUT FOR THE VICTIM
FIRST RIGHT AND WOULD CONSIDER
ALL THAT THE WINNER PERFECT
WORLD RIGHT. AND HOW. AND JUST
WORRIED ABOUT. HOW IT COULD END
UP USE BEING USED GIVEN THAT.
THE. THE PERSPECTIVE OF FURTHER
VIOLENCE IS SO COMMON IN THESE
CASES I THINK THE AND DEATH THE
I THINK THE EVIDENCE IS HAS
SHOWN THAT WHEN YOU PROSECUTE.
AND YOU CAN HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE THAT THE INCIDENTS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS REDUCED-
AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS BILL
IS TRYING TO GET TO IS THAT THE
MORE THAT WE CAN. PROSECUTE YEAH
I'M IF YOU END UP IN A GOING TO
A MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL IN AN
EMERGENCY ROOM THEN IT'S
SERIOUS- AND- THE ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY HOLD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE
BECOMES VERY IMPORTANT. AND
THAT'S THAT'S THE REASON FOR THE
BILL IS THAT IT ALLOWS- A
PROSECUTION. AND IT TO HOLD AND
AN INDIVIDUAL ACCOUNTABLE UNDER
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT ARE- THAT ARE
. PROTECT THE INTEREST OF THE
INDIVIDUAL RIGHT BECAUSE THE
PERPETRATOR HAS A RIGHT TO A
TRIAL. BUT IT ALSO PROVIDES THAT
THAT THE TOOLS TO BE ABLE TO USE
SOMETHING THAT WAS DONE AT OR
NEAR THE TIME OF THE- OF THE
INCIDENT- THAT THAT'S DONE
SPECIFIC FOR IT SPECIFICALLY FOR
THE PURPOSE OF MEDICAL ATTENTION. WE APPRECIATE WERE SOME TO A
VICTIM MIGHT BE POTENTIALLY MORE
COMFORTABLE IN THE MEDICAL
SENATE SETTING AND MORE WILLING
TO DISCLOSE HOWEVER AS I
UNDERSTAND IT CURRENT LAW ALLOWS
STATE IF THE VICTIM DOESN'T WANT
TO TEST FOR THEMSELVES BUT THEY
SAY YES PLEASE USE WHAT I SAID
USE WHAT I SAID TO THE DOCTORS
THAT THAT'S ALLOWABLE. NO OKAY
SO- THIRTY MIND IF I ASK THE
CONSOLE MAYBE I READ THE
ANALYSIS WRONG HERE. SORRY. THE. HAS TO BE UNAVAILABLE FOR IT
NOT JUST THAT THE WOULD GIVE
CONSENT. SO WITH THIS WITH THIS
RECORD SO IS THIS BILL REQUIRE
AT LEAST THEIR CONSENT. CAN WE
MODIFY IT TO AT LEAST ALLOW FOR
THEIR CONSENT EVEN IF THEY ARE
NOT WILLING TO TEST BY
THEMSELVES. OKAY OKAY. WELL IT'S
SOME LEVEL OF CONSENT WOULD. ONE
IF I COULD ON THAT ON THAT LAST
COMMENT ABOUT THIS THE SIXTH
AMENDMENT AS THE COURTS HAVE
HAVE- HAVE RULED AND APPOINTED
THAT DAY SAYS SIXTH AMENDMENT
DOES NOT APPLY TO SPECIFIC
SITUATIONS WHERE YOU'RE GOING IN
FOR A- IT IT AT EXCLUDES WHEN
THE ISSUE HAS. TO DO WITH.
MEDICAL GIVING INFORMATION FOR
WHICH YOU NEED A MEDICAL
DIAGNOSIS AND MEDICAL TREATMENT. ALL RIGHT ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS OR DEBATES ON THIS
ISSUE. SENATE KAMAR. THANK YOU
I'D- ALSO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
AND WANTED TO ECHO SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT- SENATOR- SKINNER
REYES I AM. I JUST AM TRYING TO
ALSO FIND THE BALANCE. BETWEEN
SAFETY AND JUSTICE AND
PROTECTION AND DUE PROCESS- I
DON'T WANT TO SPEAK IN GENERAL
TERMS BUT WE DO KNOW THAT- YOU
KNOW. D. A.'S- DO M. VICTIMS I
MEAN VICTIMS ARE PENNED BY A LOT
OF GROUPS TO KIND OF FURTHER A
PARTICULAR CASE. AND I'M ALSO
CONCERNED THAT IF THERE WAS THIS
EXEMPTION THAT WAS ALLOWED. THAT
DA'S COULD ALSO AND- PEOPLE ARE
VERY PEOPLE WHO KNOW THE LAW CAN
BE VERY PERSUASIVE FOR GOOD AND
FOR IN ALL. BUT I WOULD BE
CONCERNED THAT THIS EXEMPTION
WOULD ALLOW D. A.'S TO PERSUADE
FOLKS- TO ALSO. BE PUT IN THIS
CATEGORY THAT THEN WOULD ALLOW
D. A.'S TO USE HERE. RATHER THAN
HAVING FOLKS BE PRESENT TO SPEAK
ON ISSUES AND THERE ARE MULTIPLE
REASONS WHY. PEOPLE RE CAN'T AND
ARE UNCOOPERATIVE SOMETIMES IT'S
BECAUSE THEY DO FEAR FOR THEIR
SAFETY AND SOMETIMES IT'S
BECAUSE A WHOLE HOST OF OTHER
THINGS YOU KNOW LIKE IT WAS THAT
MOMENT IN TIME THAT PARTICULAR
SITUATION OR CIRCUMSTANCE AND
SOMETHING ELSE GOT RESOLVED
PEOPLE ARE NOT NECESSARILY THAT
INTERESTED IN HAVING SOMEONE
SWEPT UP BY THE CARCERAL SYSTEM.
YOU KNOW NEVER TO LIKE COME OUT
UNCHANGED AND- TO YOUR POINT THE
END ITS ROOM IT'S UNFAIR TO MAKE
GENERALIZATIONS BECAUSE EACH
CASE IS OFTEN IS UNIQUE AND HAS
ITS OWN SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES
WHICH MAKE THESE THINGS
OFTENTIMES REALLY COMPLICATED.
SO IM JUST WONDERING. IF THERE
ARE WAYS TO. IF THERE ARE WAYS
TO PROTECT. FOLKS WHO. REALLY
ARE SEEKING SOME PROTECTION-
WHILE ALSO MAINTAINING SOMETHING
THAT I THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT
WHICH IS DUE PROCESS AND HOW ARE
YOU CARVING SOMETHING OUT IN A
WAY. THAT STILL HOLDS ALL
PARTIES ACCOUNTABLE AND I WOULD
BE CONCERNED THAT YOU WOULD HAVE
PROSECUTORS THAT WOULD THEN SEE
THIS AS A LOOPHOLE. THE KIND OF
SWEET PEOPLE INTO A CATEGORY.
NOT HERE- AND I DON'T KNOW HOW
FAIR THAT IS AND SO- BUT I HEARD
FROM THE CONSULTANTS THAT IT'S-
IT'S KIND OF BINARY IN TERMS OF
WHAT THE BILL IT'S A IT'S EITHER
THIS OR THE ASSETS NOT. YOU KNOW
MAYBE UNDER PERJURY OR HAVING
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE NOTIFIED
NOTARIZED IT VERIFIED THAT THIS
IN FACT IS THAT. I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE ARE
WILLING TO CONSIDER. I MEAN.
IT'S SIMPLE I MEAN I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO BE ON
THE RECORD. IN SOME WAY WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT SOMEONE'S
LIFE EVERYONE'S LIFE. AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT BALANCES.
THAT SPEAKS TO THE INTENTION
BEHIND THE BILL AND THE PEOPLE
YOU'RE TRYING TO PROTECT.
CARRIERS LIKE TO RESPOND TO THAT
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELL IT-
THE SENATOR SKINNER ASKED IF-
IF- IF IT WOULD. THAT SHE
ACTUALLY DIDN'T ASK QUESTIONS
SHE SAID SHE'D BE MORE
COMFORTABLE IF IT REQUIRED THE
APPROVAL OF THE CONSENT IS A
BETTER WAY TO PUT IT THE CONSENT
OF THE VICTIM AND- AND I HAVE
SENT THOUGHTSPOT ABOUT THAT TO
SEE TO SEE WHAT. WHAT I THINK
RIGHT- AND I DON'T I THINK
THAT'S FINE I THINK THAT THE
WHOLE POINT OF IT IS THAT- IS
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS TO
SET UP ACCOUNTABILITY RIGHT. AND
AND EQUITY AND WAIT TO BE ABLE
TO UTILIZE THE INFORMATION THAT
WAS. PROVIDED TO A MEDICAL.
PROFESSIONAL SPECIFICALLY FOR
THE PURPOSES OF TREATMENT AND SO
TO- TO REQUIRE THAT THERE BE
CONSENT I DON'T THINK IS A
FENCE ANYTHING I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S APPROPRIATE AND- AND I
WOULD ACCEPT THAT AS AS AN
AMENDMENT THE OTHER AMENDMENT
THAT I WAS PREPARED TO TAKE IS
NOTICE BECAUSE THAT ONE OF THE
ISSUES RAISED. IN INDIA A POST
OPPOSITION LETTERS WAS THAT-
THERE WAS NO NOTICE REQUIREMENT.
OF THE INTENT TO USE THAT TYPE
OF TESTIMONY AND I DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THAT EITHER- SO
NOTICES WELL AS A CONSENT WOULD
ARE PART ARE AT LEAST TWO
PROTECTIONS THAT I THINK WOULD
BE APPROPRIATE. COUNTS ARE WE
CONSIDERING THOSE AMENDMENTS
HEARERS IT ONTO JUDICIARY THAT
YOU TAKE THOSE. WE CAN DO ONE
THEN I WOULD FOR SHE'S GONNA
TAKE FROM HERE. OKAY ALL RIGHT.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THE SIGN. THIS CAN YOU
RESTATE THE CONSENT AND NOTICE.
HOW HIGH THAT AMENDMENT WOULD
READ. WE SHOULD ACTUALLY DAMAGE
A DISH BECAUSE BILL MAGICIAN
NEXT WEEK OKAY- AND CAN YOU
RSTATE WHAT YOU'RE WILLING TO
TAKE- SENATOR CAFIERO YES THANK
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO-
REALLY THANK YOU FOR THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION- WHAT WHAT HAS BEEN
PROPOSED IS THAT- IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO UTILIZE- THE THAT
INFORMATION. PROVIDED TO MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS UP FOR THE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF- RECEIVING GIVING
INFORMATION TO THEM AND
RECEIVING TREATMENT THAT- THAT.
IN ORDER TO USE THAT INFORMATION
THE VET VICTIM WOULD HAVE TO
GIVE HER KICK HIM OR HER
CONSENT. AND AND IF THAT
INFORMATION IS GOING TO BE USED
AT THAT THERE WOULD BE A NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO THE- THAT THAT
INFORMATION IS GOING TO BE USED
. AND THE NOTICE REQUIREMENT
WOULD BE CONSISTENT WITH OTHER
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE HAVE- AND I
THINK THAT'S THIRTY DAYS BUT
WHATEVER DAYS ARE APPROPRIATE
THAT THAT WOULD BE FINE. I MEAN
HE'S. THIS IS AN ISSUE SO THEN
WOULD THIS TAKE CARE OF IT. I
DON'T THINK SO. CAN WE GET OUR
OPPOSITION WITNESS TO. ON RECORD
YES OR NO. ARE THEY NO LONGER
YOUR OWN CAR. WE DIDN'T
SPECIFICALLY TAKEN ISSUE WITH
NOTICE I BELIEVE MAYBE THE ACLU
DID BUT GIVING THE DEFENSE
NOTICE THAT THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
HAVE THE RIGHT TO. CONFRONTATION
IT REALLY DOESN'T SOLVE THE
PROBLEM IN OUR OPINION. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT ARM SPINNER
CABALLERO TOWARD CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS IN APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
TODAY PARENTS WERE LOOKING FOR A
MOTION ON THIS IN DUE PASSED TO
JUDICIARY. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR CHOI BOGUE. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY
ONE. SB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE
CABALLERO BRADFORD. A TROUBLED
SHOBO GUY COME LONGER KAMLAGER
NOT VOTING SKINNER. SKINNER I
WINNER WINNER ONLINE THREE TO
ZERO. IT MEASURES OUT GRADUALLY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR OUR VISIT
. MATHIS. THREE OKAY WE'RE GONNA
RECESSED UNTIL ONE THIRTY
ABILITY. YES ALL RIGHT SO THANK
YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE WILL
RETURN BACK TO ONE THIRTY YOUR
STUFF. YEAH.
LUNCH SO WE'RE BACK IN OUR FIRST
AUTHOR UP IS SENATOR MELENDEZ
WITH S. B. ELEVEN TEN AM I
CORRECT. WHEN YOU'RE READY YOU
MAY BEGIN THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE OF THE SENATE
BILL. ELEVEN TEN DEALS WITH THE
ISSUANCE AND RENEWAL OF WATER
CALLED SIX OH TWO LETTERS SIX A
TWO LETTER OR TRESPASS LITERATE
THE WORDY IS A FORMAL REQUEST BY
BUSINESS OR PROPERTY OWNER TO
PROSECUTE ANYONE WHO WAS
LOITERING OR ENGAGING IN
UNLAWFUL ACTIVITY ON THEIR
PROPERTY. THE LETTER GREATLY
IMPROVES THE CITY'S ENSURES
STABILITY TO ACT ON AGAINST
UNDESIRABLE TRUST PASSERS AND
FURTHER GRANTS LAW ENFORCEMENT
PERMISSION TO ENFORCE
TRESPASSING LAWS UPON IN WITHIN
PRIVATE PROPERTY WITH OR WITHOUT
A CALL FOR SERVICE. COMPLETION
OF A SIXTY TWO LETTER AUTHORIZES
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO REST AND OR
ISSUE CITATIONS TO TRUST PASSERS
FOR UP TO TWELVE MONTHS FROM THE
DATE THE LETTER WAS SIGNED
CURRENTLY THE SIXTY TWO LETTERS
MUST BE COMPLETED ANNUALLY
REQUIRING PROPERTY OWNERS TO
RENEW THESE TRESPASS LETTERS
YEAR AFTER YEAR. MY COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND
PROCESSESBETWEEN TALIBAN AND A
FIFTEEN HUNDRED OF THESE LETTERS
ANNUALLY. IN IN MY CITY ALONE
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT PROCESS
A TOTAL OF. THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
TWO LAYERS JUST THIS LAST YEAR.
THE OF THIS BILL IS TO ALLEVIATE
THE INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT STAFF TIME IN CITY
TIME DEVOTED TO PROCESSING THESE
LETTERS BY EXTENDING THE LIFE.
BY ONE YEAR STAFF TIME IT COULD
BE BETTER SERVED HELPING OUR
NEIGHBORS IN KEEPING OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE. BEFORE ENERGIES
MY WITNESSES HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL I WANTED TO
THANK THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION. FOR
WORKING WITH MY STAFF AND
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD ALLEVIATE
THEIR CONCERNS. AND SAID THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE ARE
AWARE I WILL BE AMENDING THE
BILL TO ADDRESS THE FOLLOWING
CONCERN SHOULD THE BILL PASS OUT
OF COMMITTEE TODAY. NUMBER ONE
REDUCING THE TIME IS SIX OH TWO
LETTER REMAINS IN EFFECT
CURRENTLY A FIVE YEARS DOWN TO
THREE YEARS. DURING A CHANGE IN
OWNERSHIP WHERE THE PROPERTY HAS
A SIX OH TWO LETTER ON FILE THE
NEW OWNER WILL BE REQUIRED TO
NOTIFY LAW ENFORCEMENT OF A
CHANGE IN OWNERSHIP. OTHERWISE
THE SIXTY TWO LETTER WILL EXPIRE
NUMBER THREE ALLOWING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO ACCEPT ELECTRONIC
SUBMISSIONS. ARE SIXTY TWO
LETTER APPLICATIONS TO ALLEVIATE
THE BURDEN OF HAVING PROPERTY
OWNERS HAVING TO PHYSICALLY COME
INTO THE OFFICE TO FILE THEIR
LETTERS. WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL A SURGEON
WHO WE ARE DELEON FROM RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT. AND
MAYOR BEN BEN RIGHT FROM. WELL
THE MARKET IS ON THE PHONE LINE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. WELL FOR BOTH
YOUR WITNESSES TWO MENTION
SUPPORT. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS
WILLIAM A SERGEANT WITH THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND ONLY HALF OF A
SHARE CHAD BIANCO WE ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS TODAY- OUR
DEPARTMENT OPERATES OUT OF
FOURTEEN INDIVIDUAL PATROL
STATIONS AND PROVIDES POLICE
SERVICES TO SIXTEEN CONTRACTS
CITIES WITHIN OUR COUNTY ONE OF
WHICH IS WELL THE MARK. OF THE
SECOND WITNESS IS IT THE MAYOR
WILDEN MARC WILL TOMORROW YOU
WILL HEAR FROM THEM SHORTLY.
MANY OF OUR LOCAL BUSINESS
OWNERS CONTACTED CENTER
MENENDEZ'S OFFICE AS WELL AS OUR
DEPARTMENT AND ASKED IF WE COULD
REVISE THE TRESPASS LETTER- LAW
TO MAKE IT MORE ACCOMMODATING
FOR BUSINESS OWNERS WITHIN OUR
JURISDICTION- FOR REFERENCE OUR
DEPARTMENT PROCESSES BETWEEN
TWELVE HUNDRED FIFTEEN HUNDRED
TRESPASSERS ANNUALLY. MORE
SPECIFICALLY ARE LARGE. AND
VALLEY STATION. PROCESS FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE
LETTERS LAST YEAR. EXCUSE ME.
AND LIKE I ALSO LEARN A PROCESS
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY TWO LETTERS
LAST YEAR. WE ESTIMATE THAT OUR
EMPLOYEES OVERSEEING THE LETTERS
AT EACH STATION GENERALLY A
COMMUNITY SERVICE OFFICER SPENDS
ROUGHLY 2025% OF HIS OR HER AT
TIME ANNUALLY PROCESSING. FILING
THESE LETTERS THE SERVER INTO
OUR PATROL STAFF. AND- AND
PURGING THESE LETTERS SO 252025%
OF THIS TIME- IS SPENT JUST ON
THESE LETTERS ALONE BY ONE
DEDICATED EMPLOYEE AT EACH OF
OUR STATIONS- WE ESTIMATE THAT
WE CAN REDUCE THIS BY 10% IF
THIS BILL PASSES- THAT WOULD
ALLOW OUR COMMUNITY SERVICE
OFFICERS TO BE OUTMORE IN THE
COMMUNITY AND BENEFITING THE
COMMUNITY BY. IMPROVING THE
QUALITY OF LIFE AND THAT IS OUR
JOB COMMUNITY SERVICE OFFICERS-
THE AMENDMENTS TO A SIX OH TWO.
I WILL RELIEVE BUSINESS OWNERS
AND THE REGIONS OF THE BURDENS
OF RENEWING. THE REQUEST
ANNUALLY- THEY REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF HOURS EMPLOYEES SPEND. AND IT
ALSO AFFORDS OR PREVENTS
FRAUDULENT REQUEST BY RECORD BY
REQUIRING THE REQUEST TO BE IN
WRITING AND ARREST. THIS BILL
DOES NOT ADD ANY SENTENCING
ENHANCEMENTS AND DOES NOT ADD
ANY CRIME- IT DOES NOT INCREASE
THE AUTHORITY OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO ENFORCE TRESPASS LAWS ON
PRIVATE PROPERTY. IT MERELY
EXTENDS THE TIME FOR RENEWAL
WHICH IN TURN REDUCES THE AMOUNT
OF HOURS SPENT. BY OUR PERSONNEL
TO PROCESS THESE LETTERS. I
UNDERSTAND OR SOME INITIAL
OPPOSITION'S OPPOSITION TO THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL- BY SEVERAL
ORGANIZATIONS BUT I BELIEVE THE
AMENDMENTS. THAT HAVE BEEN MADE-
CENSUS BILLS INTRODUCED MEDICAID
SO CONCERNS. AND PROVIDE A
STRAIGHTFORWARD RESPONSE- AND IS
BETTER FOR BOTH BUSINESSES
BUSINESS OWNERS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST RIVALS ON THIS BILL
PLEASE BURDEN TO BUSINESS OWNERS
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF TIME OUR
DEPARTMENT OR SPEND ANNUALLY.
SNRIS THIS PROCESS BY REQUIRING
THEM TO BE NOTARIZED IN WRITING
THANK YOU AND I'M AVAIL FOR ANY
TYPE OF QUESTIONS IF YOU WANT IF
YOU WISH. CAR MR WE HAVE
AMERICANS BEEN WHITE. HE SHOULD
BE ON THE PHONE LINE YEAH.
MODERATOR TO HAVE THE MAYOR. I
DON'T SEE THEM DIALED IN OKAY
WELL. YOU CAN GENERAL LETTERMAN-
LET'S NOW GO TO THE ROOM ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. OF S. B. ELEVEN TEN.
HEARING TO A NON MODERATE CAN WE
GO TO THE PHONE LINE TO SEE IF
THERE ARE ANYONE CALLING IN TO
SUPPORT OUR IN SUPPORT OF SB.
ELEVEN TEN. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I DO HAVE A
COUPLE COMMENTS THANK YOU IT'LL
JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR THE FIRST
COMMENT.
PETER THE MEROM PLEASE GO AHEAD. POSTED MAYOR BREAK YOU GUYS
EVERY. WE CAN HEAR YOU. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU SENATORS I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THIS
AFTERNOON I WAS ON EARLIER NOT
SURE HOW I WAS SUPPOSED TO GO BY
MYSELF AND I'M HERE NOW AND I
JUST WOULD LIKE TO- I THINK IN
THIS STORY A STORY THAT I COULD
HAVE BEEN MORE THAN A FEW TIMES
IN MY CITY WHERE SOMEONE HAS
CALLED BECAUSE I DO GET MY- ON
THE CITY WEBER RIGHT THE REGULAR
PHONE CALL FOR PRESIDENT THAT.
AREN'T REALLY ABOUT A PROPERTY
IS THERE NEAR IN SOME CASES
DIRECTLY AGAINST- IN A COUPLE
DIFFERENT SITUATIONS WHERE THE
PROPERTY LINE. WHAT'S THEIR
HOUSE WITHIN TEN FEET BUT THE
CONCERN- CALLING ABOUT IT
SOMEONE HAS MOVED INTO THE
PROPERTY AND IT'S TAKEN UP
RESIDENCE IN A START UP FIRE
RIGHT BEHIND THIS RESIDENTS IS
HOME- THIS MORE THAN ONCE BUT
IT'S ACTUALLY MULTIPLE TIMES
THROUGHOUT THE SIMILAR SITUATION
HAPPENED- CITY. CONTACT THE PROP
OWNER. FROM ONE OF THE SOMETIMES
EVEN OUR CITY. STATE WELL
COUNTRY. WE DON'T GET. CONTRA
WELL ACTUALLY JEWISH SIX SUCH
WATER YOU CAN NOW. WITH SOMEONE
OUTSIDE THE- HAS. WITH. THEN THE
A PROPERTY YOU MIGHT WE MIGHT OR
MOVED UP FIRST PERSON BUT WE GO
BACK AND AGAIN MAKE THAT THING
CON. OVER AND OVER ANY THIS ARE
TO CREATE WHAT ALLOW OUR YOU
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO MAKE THAT
FIRST TIME. OR YOU WOULD GIVE AT
LEAST COUPLE YEAR OR WE AFTER.
WATERS SO THAT THAT FAMILY
LIVING UP AGAIN THAT PROPERTY
WILL DOESN'T LIVE SOMEONE
EARNING. AND RAW. OR OTHERWISE.
JUST CAUSING AND USE DIRECTLY
BEHIND THE PROPERTY. YEAH I WAS
COULD SAY IS- ONLY HAVE ONCE OR
CITY BUT HOW RIGHT. WORK COME
UNDER. UNDER TAKE UP. AS THEY'RE
GOING. LIVES THERE IN THIS THAT
WE HUGE HUGE RELIEF TOWARD
DEPUTIES TO OUR RESIDENTS. YOUR
CONSTITUENTS CONFLICT BASED
THESE BATTLES RIGHT. WITHIN
FEET. JOINED. WHAT MADE ME HOW
MUCH CAN FEEL LIKE THEY CAN GO
IN EITHER BUT WHAT I'VE LEARNED
IS OVER AND OVER AGAIN POSTED
THE THAT. OR FIND A PROPERTY. A
BLACK BOOK. ONE OF THE THAT
THEIR HEARD FROM OTHER FRIENDS
ARE THERE'S THAT OWN THEN ON.
NOT TAKE A PRESIDENT ON THESE
PROPERTIES. I WOULD REALLY HOPE
YOUR EYES DAY I REALLY. YOUR
TIME. AND ALSO THE STATE OUR
ROADS WERE. THAT BECAUSE- WILL
BE LESS TIME WHERE THEY WOULD
HAVE TO STAND WAITING IN WAITING
THE HONOR OF THESE PROPERTIES TO
COME FORWARD. FINALLY FINANCING
I'M EXCITED THAT THE LETTER
AGAIN THE ONE THAT THAT ON FILE
RECENTLY EXPIRED. SO YOU NOTE
AFTER I VOTE THANK FOR YOUR.
TIME THANK YOU. NOW WILL BACK TO
THE PHONE. TOMORROW WE HAVE A
DO. WOULDN'T ARE WISHING TO
TESTIFY. TO OF A ELEVEN TEN. NOW
IS THE TIME. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR. PRE FOR. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHO SHALL MUCH
THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN CAN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU. NOW WILL GO TO OPPOSITION.
AND WE HAVE NO LEAD OPPOSITION
LISTED THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE
ROOM WAS WISHING TO TESTIFY IN.
OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN. TEN LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION I WANT TO SAY THAT
WE APPRECIATED THE AUTHOR
WORKING WITH US AND WE- AND WHEN
I SAY SPECIFICALLY THAT WE ARE
WITHDRAWING OUR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES HERE IN A ROOM.
MAROOCHYDORE PHONE LINES INTO
ACTORS ARE ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
ELEVEN TO. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO ASK BE
ALLOWED IN TURN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. TRYING TO
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU. BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE IS THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS CENTER
WINNER. THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. SENATOR
BILL MELENDEZ REJOICE CLOSE
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN- OUT OF
RESPECT FOR THE VERY LONG
MORNING IF YOU HAD A LONGER
AFTERNOON YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. BREVITY HERE- COUNCIL PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL IN THIS BILL
LOVINGTON. WE HAVE TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AS THE FOR THE
FOR AS AMENDED AS A AS AMENDED-
SB ELEVEN TEN MELENDEZ DO PASS
AS AMENDED BRADFORD. BRADFORD
AYE CHOI BOGUE TROUBLE GUY COME
LONGER. KAMLAGER AYE KINNER
SKINNER AYE WIENER WIENER AYE
FIVE TWO ZERO THE MEASURE HAS
FIVE VOTES IT'S OUT
CONGRADULATIONS NEXT UP IS SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT ALEXANDER IS A LOT SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY WHICH AIMS TO
REDUCE SPENT NO FATALITIES IN
HOLD DRUG DEALERS ACCOUNTABLE
LAST YEAR THE UNITED STATES
SEPARATE MORE FENTANYL RELATED
DEATHS AND GUN IN AUTO RELATED
DEATHS COMBINE. FENNEL IS
ESTIMATED TO BE UP TO FIFTY
TIMES MORE POWERFUL THAN HEROIN
AND AS HIGH AS ONE HUNDRED TIMES
MORE POWERFUL THAN MORPHINE.
THERE WAS A 4100% INCREASE IN
FEDERAL RELATED DEATHS BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN CALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCED THE HIGHEST NUMBER
OF DRUG FATALITIES IN THE NATION
WITH NEARLY- JUST OVER SIX
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS DYING FROM
DRUGS. ACCORDING TO THE DA SIM
SYNTHETIC OPIOIDS OVERDOSE
DEATHS PRIMARILY DRIVEN BY
FENTANYL INCREASED BY OVER 55%
JUST IN ONE YEAR'S TIME BETWEEN
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY IN JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. ONE OF MY
CONSTITUENTS ALEXANDER COUPLE
LEO DIED OUT I KNOWINGLY
CONSUMING FIVE TIMES THE FATAL
AMOUNT OF ILLICIT FENTANYL AND I
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH HER
FAMILY EVER SINCE FOR THE LAST
THREE YEARS TO CRAFT A
THOUGHTFUL PROPOSAL. I'M THIS
BILL DOES NOT PUT PEOPLE BEHIND
BARS IT IT DOES THE EXACT
OPPOSITE ANY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
WILL TELL YOU THAT THIS
ADVISEMENT THERE WE ARE ASKING
FOR IN THIS BILL IS PURELY
NOTIFICATION TO A PERPETUAL DRUG
DEALER THAT THEY COULD BUT NOT
NECESSARILY WILL BE CHARGED WITH
MURDER THIS IS MUCH LIKE THE
WATSON ADVISEMENT FOR DRUNK
DRIVING SB THREE FIFTY THIRTEEN
FIFTY EXCUSE ME APPLIES AN
ADVISEMENT FOR AN INDIVIDUAL
CONVICTED OF ILLEGALLY
MANUFACTURING OR DISTRIBUTING
FENTANYL TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
IF THEY CONTINUE WITH THESE
ACTIONS COULD RESULT IN THE
DEATH OF ANOTHER HUMAN BEING AND
LEAD TO A HOMICIDE CHARGE. THIS
BILL HELPS PROSECUTORS KEEP UP
WITH THE INCREASED AND DEADLY
DRUGS BEING SOLD ON KNOWING
CONSUMERS ESPECIALLY WHEN
THERE'S CONSUMERS ARE OUR
CHILDREN THIS POLICY IN HIS
ATTEMPT TO PREVENT FUTURE
FATALITIES BY GIVING DRUG
DEALERS A CHOICE A CHOICE THAT
COMES WITH CONSEQUENCES MAY SAID
EARLIER THIS BILL PROVIDES AN
ADVISEMENT IT DOES NOT PROVIDE
SERRATION. TWO GRAINS OF SALT
CAN BE ALL IT TAKES TO CAUSE A
FATALITY ONE WITH RESPECT TO
FEND OFF. IN LAFAYETTE NOISE
PEDDLED AS AN OXY AS A PERCOCET
AS EXAM AXE OR EVEN BABY ASPIRIN
THE RESULTS ARE DEADLY AND YES
BABY ASPIRIN A POLICE CHIEF IN
SPOKANE WASHINGTON INDICATED
THEY'RE BEGINNING TO NOW SEE
FENTANYL DISGUISED AS BABY
ASPIRIN TABLETS. ALEXANDER
COUPLE IT WAS POISON IN THIS
MANNER WHEN SHE PURCHASED WHAT
SHE THOUGHT WAS OXYCODONE BUT
WAS ACTUALLY FENTANYL. ALL OF
THESE THINGS COMBINE EASY ACCESS
THAT THAT HAVING THE BILL IS
BEING MADE TO LOOK LIKE A
LEGITIMATE PRESCRIPTION OR OVER
THE COUNTER PILL. THE MEDICINE
IN THE POST CFN BE A DEATH
SENTENCE IN THE ARAFAT NO EVEN
JUST HALF A PILL CAN TAKE A LIFE
REGARDLESS. OF WHETHER THE
PERSON KNOWINGLY CHOSE TO
CONSUME IT. NOW SADLY
ALEXANDER'S FAMILY IS NOT THE
ONLY ONE TO EXPERIENCE THE LOSS
OF A CHILD IN CALIFORNIA ALONE.
BUT NO DEATHS ROSE ONE HUNDRED
AND FORTY SIX PERCENT. FROM THE
YEAR TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TO
THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY. SENATOR
WIENER IN YOUR DISTRICT AND SAN
FRANCISCO FATALITIES DUE TO DRUG
POISONINGS OUTPACED KEVIN
NINETEEN FATALITIES IN TWENTY
TWENTY. WHEN I BEGAN WORKING ON
SB 35050% OF ALL DRUG POISONING
AND FATALITIES IN JORRIT LOS
ANGELES DISTRICT SENATOR COM
LONGER AND SENATOR BRADFORD THEY
WERE TREATED TO FENTANYL AS TO
STICK THAT HAS NOT WAVERED. LAST
YEAR AN ORANGE COUNTY FENNEL
ACCOUNTED FOR UP 264% OF DRUG
FATALITIES WE HAVE WAITED LONG
ENOUGH. TO GET A HANDLE ON THIS
EPIDEMIC THAT IS KILLING
CALIFORNIANS. WITH MEHERE TODAY
AGAIN IS MATT KAPPLER THE FATHER
OF ALEXANDER KHAPLU SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL WHOSE DAUGHTER WAS
KILLED BY FENNEL AND TOM WOLFE.
A FORMERLY HOMELESS FORMALLY
INCARCERATED RECOVERING DRUG
ADDICT AND THEY'RE BOTH HERE TO
SHARE THEIR EXPERIENCES AND WHAT
HAPPENED- WITH YOU AND WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
ABOUT. A I'M SORRY MR CHAIRMAN
IF I COULD JUST ADD THAT IF
THERE HAPPENED TO BE ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS RELATING TO
THIS BILL THAT I CANNOT ANSWER
I'M DISTRICT ATTORNEY MORGAN
GEYER FROM PLASTER COUNTY IS ON
THE PHONE LINE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU WILL GIVE YOUR TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH TO
BEGIN THAT. MAKE YOUR TESTIMONY-
pWILL FOR MR. HAVE A LOT OF.
pWILL FOR MR. HAVE A LOT OF.,
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH ALL OF YOU AGAIN. I
CAME HERE TODAY HOPING THAT THIS
WILL BE THE LAST TIME I COME
HERE TO ASK YOU TO NOT ONLY
CONSIDER CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY BUT TO MOVE
IT THROUGH. FOR A VOTE ON THE
FLOOR. ALEXANDER'S LAW AS YOU
KNOW IS NAMED AFTER MY DAUGHTER.
BUT THIS BILL IS ABOUT FAR MORE
THAN THE EMORY OF MY DAUGHTER
STRUCK DOWN INTERVIEWS BY THE
DRUG DEALER WHO TRADED HER LIFE
FOR PROFIT. IT'S ABOUT SAVING
THE LIVES OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS. I DON'T HAVE TO
TELL YOU HOW THE ROLE OF FAT AND
ALL THESE COUNTERFEIT PILLS ARE
WREAKING HAVOC UPON OUR
COMMUNITIES AND TODAY YOU HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PUT A
FORMIDABLE DEBT IN THOSE
TRANSACTIONS THAT ARE LITERALLY
A MATTER OF LIFE. AND DEATH. MY
HOPE TODAY IS THAT YOU WILL SEE
THE VALUE OF A BILL THAT MIRRORS
THAT OF WATSON'S LAW. A BILL
THAT HAS VERIFIABLE DATA SHOWING
SIGNIFICANT EFFECTIVENESS IN
REDUCING DRUNK DRIVING DEATHS.
WELL THE ISSUE OF FAT AND ALL
COMING INTO THIS COUNTRY FROM
MEXICO VIA CHINA ITS MAMMOTH. WE
IS CALIFORNIANS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE TO PERSUADE
DRUG DEALERS AT THE RISK OF
PEDDLING THESE DEATH TOLLS WILL
BE TOO COSTLY FOR THEM
PERSONALLY. OUR GOAL WITH THIS
BILL IS NOT TO THROW THESE GUYS
IN JAIL IT'S TO DISSUADE THEM
FROM TRADING THEIR OWN FUTURE TO
MAKE A PROFIT. OFF OF THE
POSSIBLE DEATHS OF OUR FRIENDS
NEIGHBORS AND LOVED ONES.
CALIFORNIANS VALUE SAFETY AND
THE RULE OF LAW THEY KNOW THE
DANGER IF AT ALL AND WHAT IT IS
DOING TO OUR COMMUNITIES AND
NEIGHBORHOODS. WE ARE CONFIDENT
THAT TAKING THIS STEP IS GOING
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE. AND I AM
BETTING THE MAJORITY OF STATE
REPRESENTATIVES WILL STAND UP
FOR THE REST OF US AND TAKE
ACTION TO SAVE LIVES IF GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITY. I IMPLORE YOU
PASS THIS THROUGH YOUR COMMITTEE
GIVE US ALL A LITTLE MORE FAITH
IN OUR GOVERNMENT AND LET ALL OF
OUR STATE REPRESENTATIVES MAKE A
DECISION ON THIS. IF NOT ANOTHER
YEAR WILL GO BY. THOUSANDS MORE
WILL DIE AND I'LL SEE YOU HERE
AGAIN NEXT YEAR. I WON'T GIVE UP
ON SAVING LIVES. AND NEITHER
SHOULD YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. NEXT UP IS MISTER WORF.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS THANK
YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME. MY NAME
IS THOMAS WOLFE TODAY I'M AN
ADVOCATE FOR RECOVERY BUT FOUR
YEARS AGO TODAY I WAS HOMELESS
ON THE STREETS OF SAN FRANCISCO
HOPELESSLY ADDICTED TO HEROIN
AND FENTANYL. I STAND BEFORE YOU
TODAY TO ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER
MOVING S. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR
FOR A FULL VOTE. THE DRUG
OVERDOSE CRISIS OF QUICKLY
SPIRALED OUT OF CONTROL IN
CALIFORNIA. OUR STATE HAS BEEN
FLOODED BY NEW SYNTHETIC DRUGS
SPECIFICALLY METHAMPHETAMINE AND
ILLICIT FENTANYL. THESE
SUBSTANCES HAVE NOT ONLY
CONTAMINATED THE STREET DRUG
SUPPLY BUT THEY'VE ALSO BECAUSE
THE THOUSANDS TO DIE OF OVERDOSE
AN UNINTENTIONAL POISONINGS I
PERSONALLY KNOW A LEVIN PEOPLE
THAT HAVE DIED BECAUSE OF
FENTANYL OVERDOSE. THIS
ADMONISHMENT IS THE FIRST STEP
IN ACKNOWLEDGING THE DRUG
DEALERS ARE WILLFULLY SELLING
THE SOME SUBSTANCES TO
UNSUSPECTING CONSUMERS. AND
WHILE I AGREE THAT FOR THE
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE THAT USE THE
SUBSTANCES IT IS A HEALTH
CRISIS. WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THERE SHOULD BE A CRIMINAL
JUSTICE ELEMENT INVOLVED FOR
THOSE SELLING IT. IMAGINE IF YOU
WENT TO A BAR AND THE BARTENDER
GAVE YOU A DRINK. THAT WAS
INTENTIONALLY LACED WITH ARSENIC
. THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT IS
HAPPENING HERE. INDIVIDUALS ARE
SELLING FINAL SOMETIMES LACED
INTO OTHER DRUGS WERE DISGUISED
AS A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT DRUG
ALTOGETHER. MOVING THIS BILL
FORWARD CREATES A DETERRENT FOR
DEALERS THAT SEEK TO MAKE A
QUICK PROFIT OFF OF THE MOST
DEADLY DRUG TO HIT OUR STREETS
IN HISTORY. IT CREATES
ACCOUNTABILITY AND GIVES YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IN LINE WITH THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO NATIONAL DRUG
CONTROL STRATEGY. RELEASED LAST
WEEK BY THE WHITE HOUSE THAT
STRUCK A BALANCE BETWEEN
SUPPORTING HARM REDUCTION IN
DRUG TREATMENT. WHILE COMMITTING
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
FIGHT DRUG TRAFFICKING. IT IS
MISLEADING TO CONFLATE DRUG
USERS WERE DRUG DEALERS THERE IS
A DIFFERENCE I KNOW. I USED TO
BE A MULE FOR A LARGE ORGANIZED
DRUG DEALING NETWORK IN SAN
FRANCISCO THE CONTROLS THE
MAJORITY OF THE DRUG MARKET IN
THAT CITY TODAY. THEY KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE DOING. THEY KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE SELLING. AND EVERY DAY
WE LET GO. BY WITHOUT TAKING
ACTION MORE INNOCENT PEOPLE DIE
FROM OVERDOSE. AND FENNEL
POISONING. IT'S TIME TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
MUST WORK TOGETHER. IN FACT IT
IS THE PATH FORWARD. THANK YOU.
WE'RE GONNA PASS FOR NO APPLAUSE
WE HAVE NO DEMONSTRATIONS IN THE
CHAMBER THANK YOU- NEXT REMOVE
UP TO MOVE TO OUR- WITNESSES
HERE PRESIDENT WHO WANTS. TO
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE JUST IN
YOUR NAME IN YOUR ORGANIZATION
THANK YOU. BUT ON THE ON THE
BEHALF OF CARE FOR THE OCTOBER
SECOND ASSURES PERMANENT SUPPORT
THANK YOU KNOW WOULDN'T. HELLO
MUSKER SORIANO FROM RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. MY NAME IS CHRIS
DID HERE I'M FROM ROCKLIN
CALIFORNIA AND THIS IS MY SON'S
ACTED HERE WHO DIED FROM
FENTANYL POISONING IN DECEMBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY. AND IT IS
WITHOUT SAYS YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION PROGRAMS WITHOUT
HESITATION AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE TO PASS THIS BILL SO
THAT EVERY ELECTED SENATOR HAS A
REACHED A CHANCE TO REPRESENT
THEIR CONSTITUENTS AND ENHANCE
PUBLIC SAFETY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THAT'S WHAT. HI MY NAME IS
SANDRA JENKINS. AND OUR SON
JUSTIN JENKINS THIRTY YEARS OLD
DIED ON PALM SUNDAY. AND IT WAS
MARCH TWENTY EIGHTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I HOPE WE
CAN ALL WORK TOGETHER TO PLEASE
THIS OFF THE STREET AND PLEASE
HELP US THIS WAS ME THANK YOU
THE CLIP. MY NAME IS DANA THIS
IS MY HUSBAND JERRY OGDEN THIS
IS OUR SON AUSTIN. WHO IS TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS OLD HE PASSED AWAY
TEN MONTHS AGO TWO DIFFERENT NOT
POISONING. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL PLEASE DO THE RIGHT
THING VOTE YES AND SAVE LIVES
THANK YOU EXODUS. HELLO MY NAME
IS SIMON THIS IS MY DAUGHTER
RUBY. HE WAS STRUGGLING WITH
ANXIETY ASKED ME TO TAKE HER TO
THE DOCTOR SEVEN MONTHS AGO.
COULDN'T GET AN APPOINTMENT SHE
WANTED CYNICS I DON'T KNOW WHY
DON'T YOU HEARD IT SOMEWHERE
SOMEHOW. SHE AGADA SNAPCHAT AND
THE MAN DELIVERED IT HE IS IN
JAIL. I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GONNA
HAPPEN IS NOT THE ANSWER THOUGH.
WE NEED A DETERRENT FOR THIS WE
NEED ACCOUNTABILITY WE NEED
SOMETHING BECAUSE IT'S THE
NUMBERS I WATCHING IT. I WOULD
BUILD THE OF NOT KNOWING THE
CLUE OF WHAT WAS GOING ON. IT IS
SCARY OUT THERE IT IS A CRISIS
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING TO DATE
SHE WAS IN THE PEOPLE MAGAZINE
YOU SAW IT MAYBE. IT IS
SOMETHING WE NEED TO ACT ON NOW
THANK YOU THANK YOU A THREE TEST
MARC NEXT WITNESS. HI I'M ERIC
ADAMS FROM CASSADEE CALIFORNIA
AND THIS IS MY SON DANIEL ADAMS
WHO WAS SIXTEEN YEARS OLD. WHO
PURCHASED APPEL ON SNAPCHAT. AND
IT COST HIM. IS LIVE. SO I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. HI I'M MICHELLE BOWMAN
. THIS IS MY ONLY SON I WILL
NEVER BE A GRANDMA HE WILL NEVER
BE A FATHER NOTHING WILL CHANGE
WHAT IT HAPPENED EXCEPT FOR YOU
GUYS PASSING THIS S. B. THIRTEEN
FIFTY LAW THANK YOU THANK YOU
THE CLIP. HELLO JOHNSON JENNIFER
AND MIKE FROM PLAYERS. WHEN JOHN
JOHNSTON OF. AS FOR TWENTY THREE
YEARS HOLDING HER HANDS AND I
HOLD HER IN MY HEAD. YOU REALLY
OF WHAT POSITION TODAY THERE'S
NO NEGATIVE RISK OR ANYTHING
THAT YOU CAN EXPLAIN TO ANY OF
US THAT WOULD JUSTIFY. A
BUILDINGS DOWN LAST. WE LIKE TO
DO TO DO THAT WE'LL BE BACK
EVERY YEAR AND THE NUMBERS ARE
GROWING UNFORTUNATELY. SO DIRECT
THANK YOU THE QUICKNESS. HELLO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY MY
NAME IS A LEASE YET AND I LOST
MY YOUNGEST BROTHER MY CAL AT
THE AGE OF TWENTY THREE. TO
VIETNAM NINE AND I AM IN.
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. WITH. HI
MY NAME'S LEADER ROLES I'M HERE
TO REPRESENT MY ONLY DAUGHTER.
WHO WAS PLEASE. JANUARY SECOND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE I SPEAK FOR
HER BECAUSE SHE NO LONGER HAS A
WOODS THANK YOU SUPPORT. THE
QUICKNESS. HELLO MY NAME IS
ASHLEY AND I LOST MY YOUNGER
BROTHER TOOK THAT WITH ME AND I
FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL. MY NAME
IS LISA IS L. AND THIS IS MY SON
CAMERON MARCH. HOUSE FROM
FENTANYL POISONING ON AUGUST
ELEVENTH OF TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE. AND I SIX STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ZACHARY MARCH AND I
FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS SIERRA AND MY
BROTHER DIED IT FROM- FAKE
PERCOCET PILL AND I STRONGLY
AGREE WITH THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I DIDN'T CRY. THIS IS MY
YOUNGEST SON MERRICK. WHO WAS.
AND SERVED BY THE COUNTY OF
SACRAMENTO AND HE DIED THE DAY
AFTER THANKSGIVING. FROM
CORPORATE AND ALL BENNELL- BASED
COMPANY I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW HOW
TO SPELL IT BUT THAT'S HOW WE
DIED AND- I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL BECAUSE IF HE COULD BE
INFLUENCED ANYONE COULD. HE HAD
THE MENTALITY OF ELEVEN YEAR OLD
TWELVE YEAR OLD BUT HE WAS
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD. AND I
STRONGLY. YOU GUYS PASSED
THROUGH THIS BILL BECAUSE IT'S
MUCH NEEDED THANK YOU THANK YOU
. ANY MORE WITNESSES HERE AND
ELEVEN TWELVE WHEN HE WON TWELVE
NO HEARING ON MODERNIZE COULD
PHONE LINES AND SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY
. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN FIFTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IT'LL BE JUST ONE
MOMENT FOR THE FIRST COMMENT.
TRYING TO FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TWO ONE FOUR. ONE
ONE NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS JEANETTE BELTS I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU RYAN TWO THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
GABRIELLE INGRAM AND I SUPPORT
TO TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH HI MY NAME IS MARY HOLDEN
I'M TIRED OF COUNTING AND I
SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN FIFTY. THANK
YOU RYAN SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS JULIE
GENERATION I'M A TWO DIVISION OF
THE STANDARD KAMLAGER MY NINETY
YEAR OLD SON DIED FROM FENCE AND
ALL THAT WAS SOLD BY A DEALER
WHO'S BEEN ARRESTED TEN TIMES
BEFORE. I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
ONE THREE FIVE YEAH. THANK YOU I
ONE THIRTY THREE PLEASE CALL HAD
. MY NAME IS. I'M SORRY- I
RECORDED THIS BILL MY SON YEAH
BOTH. YOU ARE HERE WHAT BE
THIRTY SIX I REMEMBER
GRANDCHILDREN. YEAH WALK OUT WE
ARE- THANK YOU YOU NEXT WOULD.
THANK YOU RYAN- TIME PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MERRIAM
APPEARANCE AGAINST AND SMALL I
LOST MY ONLY CHILD JEFF IN JUNE
OF LAST YEAR AS WELL AND I'M
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU I WON EIGHTY THREE
FOUR HAS. HELLO MY NAME IS
VIVIAN SELECT. ALONG WITH THE
BILL IN HONOR OF THE BEACH ONE.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JULIE MAY MOTHER OF JESSICA MAY
HOME I FOUND. ON YOUR BEDROOM
FLOOR. ON FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY OTHER COUNTERFEIT
THANKS HELLO I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT AWAY PLEASE CALL HAS. HI
MY NAME IS LISA MARKETS MOTHER
OF SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD BANANA
FEDERAL BANK. THIS BILL THIRTEEN
FIFTY. THANK YOU I'M TO NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWO ONE
NINE. NINE TWO TWENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CHRISTINE CAPITALISM AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF MY DAUGHTER
ALEXANDER CAPITAL AND ALL THE
OTHER VICTIMS- I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AND URGE TO CREATE
PASSED SB THIRTEEN FIFTY. THANK
YOU I'M TO TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JESSICA
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF MY
NEPHEWS WHO PASSED AWAY AT
SEVENTEEN FERNANDO ACTIONS AND I
AM PART SB THIRTEEN FIFTY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I WANT YOU TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
HOLLY CASH FOR THE BILL MY
BROTHER PASSED AWAY CHRISTMAS
EVE- AGE THIRTY FOUR AND WE'RE
LOOKING. TO SELL EVERYTHING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO EIGHTEEN
CRITICAL AT. MY NAME IS KIM
VANDER MEETING I'M CALLING IN
REGARDS TO MY ONLY CHILD AND SIX
OF HIS FRIENDS THAT ALONG THEIR
LIFE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. RIGHT ONE EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
FELICIA LUNAR HIGHLANDS MAY
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD SON- JACKER
TURNER AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
SB. THIRTEEN FIFTY. THANK YOU
I'M TWO THIRTY PLEASE CALL HAS.
MY NAME IS MONA LEE AND I AM
CALLING FROM YOUNG GIRL
CALIFORNIA MY SON MICHAEL DIED
ON FEBRUARY TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY
TWENTY AT THE AGE OF TWENTY
YEARS OLD AFTER HE WAS POISONED
BY A FAKE PRESCRIPTION
TELECENTRE NOW I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN FIFTY.
THANK YOU. THREE THREE THREE
FOUR HAVE. YES GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS HORRIBLE CHAU I LOVE MY
SON SERGIO BROACH ON MAY
FOURTEENTH TWENTY- POISONING BY
FENTANYL I FULLY SUPPORTERS BE
THIRTEEN FIFTY. THIS THIS BILL
IS LIKE TAKING BILL AND- HI
TRULY HOPE THAT THE YOUR
CONSCIENCE SPEAKS APPROVE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU BRING
TO THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS PAUL COLEMAN
FROM RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA- THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
TIME ON THIS TODAY AND- THE ONE
THING I GOTTA SAY IS THINGS
DON'T GET HOME UNTIL THEY GET
HOME AND I JUST PRAYED. IT'S ALL
. RIGHT NOW AND I KNOW OF YOU IT
AN SO SORRY FOR THAT IDEF IN
FAVOR OF THIS BILL GOING FOR
SOME HAVE TO CHANGE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN TWO OR FIVE AND
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I NEED HURDLE
MENDOZA AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL URGE YOU TO THOSE WHO
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW FOR DRUG
DEALERS. THINK ABOUT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING AND QUESTION
THERE'S A PIE BEFORE THE
CONTINUE POISONING OTHER- ARE
YOU NÂNG THANK THEM LIKE MY SON
DANIEL- I LOST LAST YEAR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I WON EIGHTY
EIGHT FOR HER. MENTAL HOTEL WITH
THIS BILL. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
TO THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS DEBORAH DORIAN
I FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL MY SON
ZACHARY LAWLER WITH ONLY
EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD. COLLEGE YEAH
. WELL THANK YOU FOR LISTENING
TO US ALL PLEASE TAKE OUR
CONCERNS CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN TO TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JODY I SUPPORT
THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF MATT AND
THE MANY FAMILIES THAT I SADLY
NOW WHO ARE GRIEVING- THIS IS A
PREVENTABLE GENOCIDE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH HI MY NAME IS
LISA WHICH SURELY I'M CALLING
BEHALF OF MY DAUGHTER LEAGUE
WHICH REALLY WHAT I THOUGHT NOT
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN JABER FOR
EVERY TWENTY YEARS OLD SO I OR-
FIFTY. THANK YOU ARE YOU TO
THIRTY TO PLEASE GO I HAVE. MY
NAME IS JENNIFER BRYANT I'M
CALLING FROM COMMUNITY
CALIFORNIA I LOST MY ONLY CHILD
MY BEAUTIFUL RIGHT BOY LANDON TO
SEND OFF QUICKLY HE PURCHASED
WHAT HE THOUGHT WAS XANAX WITH
PROFESSIONAL. I THANK. BILL
THANK YOU RIGHT TO TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CHARLENE VEHICLE IN MY VERY GOOD
FRIEND BARGAIN HUNTING WITH
PLACEMENT AND DIED AT TWENTY
SEVEN ACTUALLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
PLEASE RIGHT THANK. YOU'RE LYING
TO ALL FIVE THREE FOUR HAS. YES
MY NAME IS TINA BURKE MY SON
CHRISTIAN TAYLOR TWENTY ONE
YEARS OLD POISONED. JULY TWENTY
I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL WE NEED CHANGE TODAY I URGE
YOU TO PLEASE MAKE THE RIGHT
DECISION HERE. THANK YOU I WON
SIXTY FOUR PRESCHOOL AT. THANK
YOU FOR CALLING FROM POINT FROM
WHAT COULD BE A CALIFORNIA AND
IT IS AN HONOR OF A TREMENDOUSLY
MY FAMILY IS THERE TO CONFIRM.
THE COURT BILL SB THIRTEEN
CRITICAL. THING HAPPENS. THANK
YOU RIGHT TO THIRTY NINE CALL.
HI MY NAME IS ALAN UNDER
PRESIDENT OF THE INTERNATIONAL
COALITION ABOUT THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CONGRESS ORIGINALLY POLITY
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL AND
URGE OUR LEGISLATORS COULD TAKE
THE- LEAD AND ALL IS BECOMING A
LARGE. ONE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT ONE FIVE SEVEN. YES
MY BROTHER CRISTINA HELLO FACT
VER. EIGHTEEN THIRTY ONE
SIXTEEN TWENTY ONE NO I'M ASKING
IF YOU COULD PLEASE DO THE RIGHT
THING AND LET THE BILL PASS
RIGHT CURRENTLY WORKING. I THINK
HOW WE- PEOPLE. ROBERT RIVAS
THANK YOUNG. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
TO FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
HI MY NAME IS SHANTA MALTS I'M
CALLING FROM MEMPHIS TENNESSEE
MY DAUGHTER HALEY MALL- MARKED
HER LAST MAY THE FEDERAL
POLICEMEN UNEXPECTEDLY. I AM
CALLING AND TO STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE ALL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NINE PEOPLE HAVE. HELLO MY NAME
IS MOLLY ALDRIDGE AND I STRONGLY
STRONGLY SUPPORT ALEXANDER BLOCK
SB THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE JANUARY
SECOND TWENTY TWENTY ONE I LOST
MY NEPHEW AND THEN THREE DAYS
LATER JANUARY FIFTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE I LOST MY FIRSTBORN
SON GAVIN ADULT. DO THE RIGHT
THING THREE. WELL THANK YOU RYAN
TO THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME'S RENEE GALLIANO AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN
FIFTY IN HONOR OF ALL OF OUR
LOVED ONES THAT WE LOST. MIKE
MORRELL R. OUR SON OKAY- FOREVER
TWENTY NINE IN OTHER. OF FAMILY
AND FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES THAT
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY THIS I
STRONGLY STRONGLY. THAT WE MOVED
FORWARD AND STAND STRONG
TOGETHER. TAKE CARE OF THE-
DOCTOR STRANGE SO MANY LIVES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN TO
FORTY FOUR CRITICAL HAS. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WHO SHALL MUCH FOR ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN THE COURT OF SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT TO FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THINK THERE
ARE LOTS OF CLOSE FRIENDS ALSO
NEED TO FEDERAL AND I'D
APPRECIATE IT IF YOU IF YOU GUYS
MASS DRUG. CROSSING THE BORDER
WE STOP THAT YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AFTER HEARING
FROM ALL THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT NOW IT'S TIME FOR
OPPOSITION WE HAVE TO LEAVE-
OPPOSITION. WITNESSES ARE WE
HAVE. HELLO THE THROUGHOUT OUR
KATHY SHEARER AND GENET SANTA
PACKED PACKED PACKED IN I'M
SORRY AM I KNOW I'M MISSING THAT
UP BUT A CAT THIS YEAR. INTERNET. MODERATOR THERE GOOD AFTERNOON
OKAY CAN YOU HEAR ME YEAH WE GOT
TO. GREAT- GOOD AFTERNOON KATHY
SURE ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTIONS- WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB THIRTEEN
FIFTY- I WANT TO START BY
OFFERING MY SYMPATHY TO THE
CAPITAL AND THE OTHERS WHO HAVE
TALKED ABOUT THE LOSS OF THEIR
LOVED ONES- MY HEART GOES OUT TO
THEM NO ONE SHOULD HAVE. THAT
KIND OF LOS. WE ALSO SHARE THE
GOAL OF PREVENTING TRAGEDIES
LIKE ONE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT. ORIGINALLY SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY WON'T CHEAT AGAIN
. BE ADVISED NOT REQUIRED BY SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SERVES ONE
PURPOSE AND ONE PURPOSE ONLY
SETTING UP TO SEND AND IN
CURRENT DRUG CASES FOR
PROSECUTION FOR MURDER AT A
LATER. THE PERSON CAN BE
PROSECUTED FOR AND CONVICTED OF
SECOND DEGREE MURDER NOT ONLY
WHEN THEY DID NOT INTENDED THAT.
BUT EVEN IF THEY DID NOT KNOW
THAT THE DRUGS. WERE ADULTERATED
. THIS IS NOT GOING TO DO
ANYTHING TO STOP THE DRUG TRADE
OR TO STOP PEOPLE FROM SELLING
ADULTERATED DRUG. WE KNOW THAT
THE PROSPECT OF HARSHER
PUNISHMENT EVEN THE PROSPECT OF
A PRISON SENTENCE FOR SECOND
DEGREE MURDER. DOES NOTHING TO
STOP PEOPLE FROM ENGAGING IN
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY. MORE SECOND
DEGREE MURDER PROSECUTIONS OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE FURNISHED DRUGS
WILL SIMPLY SEND MORE PEOPLE TO
PRESENT FOR LONG PERIODS OF
TIME. WITHOUT DOING ANYTHING TO
STOP THE DRUG USE THE CALORIES
BUT WE ALL SO MUCH FOR ALL. WE
DO KNOW WE NEED TO DO TO COMBAT
DRUG MISUSE AND- ALITY THAT
RECALL. INCREASE ACCESS TO
TREATMENT TO HEALTH SERVICES AND
HARM REDUCTION SERVICES. WE
AREN'T DOING ENOUGH OF THOSE
THINGS AND PEOPLE ARE DYING
AFTER THE CALL. STOP THE DEATH
PROVIDE. WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR LOCAL. Q. NEXT WITNESS PUSH. I'M GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JANET TWENTY
THIRTEEN AND I HAD TO CALIFORNIA
STATE DIRECTOR FOR DEBT ALL OF
THE ALLIANCE I'M ALSO HERE TO
TESTIFY AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO SB FIFTY I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THANK- THE
WITNESSES FOR COMING FORWARD
AND- MY YEAH OUR COMMITTEES
AFTER WE GO OUT TO ALL THE
FAMILY AND AN INDIVIDUAL BOX
FRIENDS AND LOVED ONES BUT AGAIN
I'M RESPECTFULLY MATTER BECAUSE-
NOW- BPA INTERNATIONAL
ORGANIZATION PROVIDING GOOD
QUALITY. FOUNDED AND FINANCED
PASS AND HEALTH AND HUMAN RIGHT
LEGISLATOR COMPONENTS A HARSHER
PENALTY BOX AND CLEAN ACCORDING
ACCORDING TO PRISON FOR DECADES
CURRICULA GETTING HOMICIDE WHAT
KIND OF MESSAGE TO DETER DRUG
FELONY DRUG USE AND DRUG RELATED
FATALITIES FIFTY YEARS OF THE
DRUG WAR HAS SHOWN AT. THANK AND
CREATURE AT. IS THERE ANY
CRIMINAL. FOR DRUG LAW. BUT A
LOT YOUR DOG IN LACK YEAR OR-
WHAT WE KNOW EXACTLY THAT. THANK
THAT HAVE YOU KNOW DETERMINE
BACK IN. THE RACIAL. AND ALLOW.
CORRECTIVE AND DRIVE MORE.
FURTHER AWAY FROM ACT. LANCRY.
THE EXPANSION OF VOLUNTARY.
WATER TREATMENT AND HARM
REDUCTION BETTER. RATHER THAN
PURSUING EXPENSIVE AND
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE POLICIES THAT
ARE NOT SUPPORTED BY RESEARCH
I'M ONE OF THE MOST COMPANY
LEADERS PEOPLE OF FAITH ARE NOT
CALLING NINE ONE ONE IN THE
EVENT OF AN OVERDOSE HERE AT
COOLEY AND BOB MAY BE UNINTENDED
BACK HERE IS THAT WOULD
INDIVIDUAL COUNTRIES FATAL
OVERDOSE. MAYBE TO TACKLE
CALLING NINE ONE ONE FORTUNATELY
CALIFORNIA ALONG THIRTY NINE
OTHER STATE HI NINE ONE ONE
COULD SAMARITAN LAWS WHICH
PROVIDE LIMITED IMMUNITY FROM
PROSECUTION FOR THOSE PEOPLE
MEDICAL FACILITY. THANK THEM.
PUBLIC HEALTH TO GUIDE YOU
INCLUDING UNDER MY- BY
ENFORCEMENT OF DRAGON COMA THANK
ACTUALLY. STILL WILL RESULT IN
CRITICAL EVALUATION OF A THE L.
A. COUNTY ORGANIZED POPULATION
AND LIFE LIKELY EXACT. ATTY WHAT
WE TO GET A LETTER EIGHT STREET
. SCALE UP THROUGH THE INTERNET.
HE DIRECTLY ENGAGE PEOPLE ARE
INCLUDING. LIVE OVER TO
PREVENTION SURVEY THANK HARM.
AND SYRINGE SERVICE PROVIDERS.
ON MY TRACKING IS THAT CONTRACT
CONNECT PEOPLE COULD HEAR AN
INTERNET. INCLUDING IF YOU COULD
SORT TREATMENT WE MUST INCREASE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR KIND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THAT WAS OUR SECOND- LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION S.
B. THIRTEEN FIFTY HERE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. THANK YOU DEREK
MORGAN WITH THE L. BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS YOU MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TODAY.
THANK YOU. LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ARE VERSUS WILL
TAKE TEN MINUTES OF TESTIMONY
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
POINT THE INDIVIDUAL WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPTION OF THIRTEEN
FIFTY WE WILL BEGIN. IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF THE
S. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE OF THEM ZERO. LINE TWO
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE TO FORTY SIX. MY TO FORTY
SIX DROPPED OFF IT'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT FOR OTHERS. THANK YOU
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN NINE
TO FORTY SIX. YES MY NAME IS I
REMEMBER HELLO AND MY FUND- WITH
PLAYED BY FANS AT ALL WE WERE IN
THE OTHER LINE IN IT THAT. I
NEVER CALLED IT SO THEY GAVE IT
THE NUMBER HERE- HE- HAD BOTTOM
CONTAINER OFF BECAUSE MEN HAVE
BASKETBALL AND IT MEANT THAT
THAT HE HAD A FOUR MONTH OLD
BABY I'M SORRY TO INTERRUPT BUT
IS TIME IF YOU JUST STATE YOUR
NAME. AND YOUR POSITION ANYWHERE
FROM. WE APPRECIATE THAT I'M SO
SORRY. OKAY FROM UP OF FROM
ANGELES. THE ONLY WAY WE COULD
BLOW DOWN DRUG DEALERS IS BY
MAKING. BEEN HERE THE PENALTY WE
SUPPORT THIRTEEN FIFTY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I APOLOGIZE.
MY NINE NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN ONE NINETY SEVEN. YES
THIS IS MARIA ORTEGA AND- ON
BEHALF OF MY SON AGE AND THEY
HAVE FOOD AND CALL THE VICTIM. I
DO SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN FIFTY. IT
ALSO HAPPENED NEWS OR NOT IT'S
ALWAYS A GOOD AMOUNT OF OVER
GOALS LIKE THEY WERE CALLING
THEM OUT THESE ARE POISONING
NUMBER I APOLOGIZE BUT AT THIS.
WE'RE TAKING THAT ARE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION WE'RE GOING TO
ALLOW IT TO. EXPRESS EUROPAS ARE
YOUR SUPPORT BUT IF YOU COULD
JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME- WHO YOUR
PRESENT AND YOUR- SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION INTO THE BILL. RIGHT
TO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
TO TWENTY SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS-
I ALSO WOULD NOT. ON THE OTHER
LINE I LAST NIGHT THANK BAKRI.
TWENTY THE HELLO AND I- SB
THIRTEEN THANK YOU. RIGHT FORTY
NINE YOUR LIGHT IS OPEN. NINE TO
FORTY NINE. MY NUMBER TWO FORTY
NINE HAVE YOU MUTED YOURSELF WE
CAN I HEAR YOU. NO ANSWER FROM
NINE TO FORTY NINE AT THIS POINT
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL NOW BRING ONE THING GIRL
OURS WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION- TO THIS BILL WILL
NOT BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
OUR MEMBERS AND WE HAVE SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU MADAM VICE
CHAIR- FIRST OF ALL I AM EVEN
THOUGH WE HAVE SOME
DISAGREEMENTS CENTER I DO WANT
TO. APPRECIATE YOUR ON. YOUR
STICK TO IT IS MASSIVE I KNOW
IT'S NOT A WORD NATION WITH THIS
BILL BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH WE MAY
HAVE DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES ON
THIS BILL STEMS FROM THIS JUST
UNBELIEVABLE SOCIETAL TRAGEDY ON
DISASTER THAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING
AND- I HAVE NOT LOST A FAMILY
MEMBER TO DRUGS SO I WILL I DO
NOT I CANNOT. GET UP HERE AND
SAY THAT I UNDERSTAND WHAT THESE
FAMILIES HAVE DEALT WITH- I'VE
LOST A FAMILY MEMBER OF THE ****
DRUGS AND SO I AM FROM THE
BOTTOM OF MY HEART- I AM SO.
SORRY FOR YOUR HORRIFIC TRAGEDY
FROM THIS POISON AND IS POISON I
AGREE THAT IS POISON- I HAVE
HOWEVER AS MR WALLS- AND COULD I
REPRESENT A CITY THAT HAS BEEN
DEEPLY. MONTEL I FOUND ALL THE
OTHER DRUGS AS WELL I COME FROM
A COMMUNITY SPECIFICALLY. HAS
BEEN COMPLETELY HORRIBLY
IMPACTED BY MATH LONG BEFORE
ANYONE KNEW WHAT SENTINEL WAS
AND MANY OF US HAVE BEEN WORKING
FOR MANY MANY YEARS. TO TRY TO
REDUCE USE- AND TO TRY TO. YOUR
IMPLEMENTED INTERVENTIONS SO
THAT PEOPLE CAN STAY HEALTHY AND
TO THE PEOPLE SURVIVE- AND I
KNOW PEOPLE WHO HAVE OVERDOSED I
KNOW PEOPLE WHO HAVE BECOME
HOMELESS- BECAUSE OF DRUG USE I
KNOW PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
HORRIBLY PEOPLE WHO BECOME HIV
POSITIVE IN CONNECTION WITH A
DRUG USE- PEOPLE WHO- HAVE IT TO
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON THIS IS
A REFLECT SOCIETAL PROBLEM AND
IT'S GETTING WORSE- THERE ARE
NOW DRUG MARKETS IN THE US THERE
ARE. MARKETS FOR ILLICIT DRUGS
IN THE US RIGHT NOW WHERE YOU
CANNOT PURCHASE HER WIN ANYMORE
. WHERE WHERE THE SYNTHETICS
HAVE COMPLETELY READ SUPPLANTED
HER ONE BECAUSE THEY'RE CHEAPER.
AND SUCH AS FENTANYL AND
CARFENTANIL AND ALL THE OTHER
ONES BECAUSE THEY ARE CHEAPER
AND THEY'VE SUPPLANTED IT. AND
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO SUPPLANT-
AS LONG AS THE MARKET EXISTS.
BECAUSE IF THERE'S ONE THING
WE'VE LEARNED FROM THE FIFTY
YEAR WAR ON DRUGS IS THAT. WE
CAN MAKE THE PENALTIES HARSHER
AND HARSHER AND HARSHER IT
DOESN'T REDUCE DRUG USE IT
DOESN'T REDUCE DRUG DEALING IT
DOESN'T REDUCE OVERDOSES IT
DOESN'T REDUCE. POISONINGS IT
DOESN'T REDUCE DEATH. IT NEVER
HAS AND IT'S NOT GOING TO- AND I
ALSO JUST WANNA I WANNA MAKE
SURE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
SAME BILL. ON IT WAS YOU KNOW A
LOT OF THE TESTIMONY TODAY FOCUS
ON THE POISON THAT IS FUNCTIONAL
. THE WAY I READ THIS BILL AND
SENATOR AGAIN I APPRECIATE YOUR
DEDICATION IS BUT I WANT TO MAKE
I WANT TO. JUST STATE MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE SCOPE OF
THIS BILL AND I ASK YOU TO
PLEASE TELL ME ANYTHING I GET
WRONG ABOUT YOUR BILL YOUR BILL
YOU KNOW BETTER THAN ANYONE.
OKAY ON MY UNDERSTANDING OF THIS
BILL IS THIS IS NOT. LIMITED TO
ADULTERATED DRUGS WERE
MISREPRESENTED DRUGS THIS IS
DESTROYED THIS IS NOT. JUST
ABOUT DRUGS WERE THAT HAVE BEEN
LACED WITH SOMETHING. ELSE THIS
IS WHY TO DRUGS OR SIMPLY WHAT
THE- PERSON PURCHASED A DRUG
INTENDING. TO TAKE A DRUG AS
WELL. ON THE BILL DOES NOT JUST
APPLY IT TO FANS AND ALL. IT
APPLIES TO CODY SORRY CODEINE.
BUDGET IN COCAINE
METHAMPHETAMINES IRWIN POD
PSYCHEDELICS. I'M MORE. DRUGS
THAT DON'T HAVE TO BE
ADULTERATED APPLIES TO A LONG
LIST OF DRUGS NACHO'S SYNTHETIC
OPIOIDS NONSENSE FRONTAL. AND
THEY DON'T HAVE TO BE
ADULTERATED OR MISREPRESENTED.
AND THERE IS NO REQUIREMENTS IF
IT IS ADULTERATED WITH THE
PERSON ACTUALLY KNOWS KNOWS THAT
IT'S ADULTERATED TO SOMETHING
WRONG. WITH THE DRUGS. SO THE IF
YOU WERE SOMEONE WHO WERE
SELLING A DIME BAG OF COCAINE TO
SOMEONE OR A SMALL AMOUNT OF
MATH UNADULTERATED. NO LATE NOT
LEAST OF ANYTHING SIDE DIME BAG
OF COKE OR A SMALL AMOUNT OF
MATH AND YOU GET ARRESTED AND
PROSECUTED CONVICTED OF DRUG
THANKS. YOU WILL GET THIS
ADVISEMENT. WHAT. FIVE IT IS AND
IT'S A REVISED INTO GETS PUT
ONTO YOUR CONVICTION OF INTO THE
- AND THEN IF YOU SO YOU SELL
THE DIME BAG OF COKE IN YOUR
INFECTED AND THEN A YEAR LATER.
YOU SELL ANOTHER DIME BAG OF
COCONUT LACED WITH ANYTHING AND
YOU'RE CONVICTED. THAT VICE MAN
COMES AND- I CAN BE A PREDICATE
FOR MURDER CONVICTION EVEN
THOUGH FRONTAL HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH THAT. IT WAS SOMEONE
SELLING COCAINE TO SOMEONE WHO
WAS INTENDING TO BUY COCAINE
THAT'S HOW I READ- THIS BILL.
AND SO. CAN WE ASK FOR SOME
ORDER IN IN THE CHAMBER PLEASE
THANK YOU- DO YOU WANT TO GO
THROUGH I THINK YOU MIGHT HAVE A
FEW QUESTIONS- THAT IS MY THAT
IS MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE BILL
AND I PLEASE ASK YOU TO TELL ME
IF I'M WRONG. OR MAYBE THERE'S
YOU INTENDED SOMETHING BUT IT'S
NOT WRITTEN THAT WAY I JUST
WANNA. YEAH I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE AND
SO- WELL FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THE MODERATOR HAS
MORGAN DIAL ON THE PHONE LINE
HE'S GOING TO ASSIST. ME WITH-
SOME OF THE TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
BUT IT. IN OUR MADAM MODERATOR
NOW I GUESS- DO YOU HAVE MR
GUILE ON THE LINE. ONE MOMENT
AND I'M DOUBLE CHECKING OKAY
WONDERFUL THANK YOU SO WHILE
WE'RE WAITING FOR THAT MANY
ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE SUGGESTING
THAT- IF SOMEONE IS- CONVICTED
IN COURT AND THE ADMONISHMENT IS
READ TO THEM AND THEN THEY DO IT
AGAIN AND THEY COME BACK THAT
THEY WOULD BE CHARGED WITH
MURDER- THAT'S- INCORRECT ON THE
- ON A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT
LEVELS IN THAT. NUMBER ONE IT
WOULD HAVE TO BE A CASE WHERE
SOMEBODY ACTUALLY DIED AS A
RESULT OF THE DRUGS OR SELLING.
RIGHT AND I WANNA I SEE THAT I
HAVE A CELL APART TO. AS YOU
SAID THERE'S ONLY ONE QUESTION
THAT. I FOR SOMEONE WHEN IT'S
JUST IN TERMS OF WHAT THE SCOPE
OF THE BILL AS RIGHT IN TERMS
OF- IF I GOT ANYTHING WRONG THAT
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE A
ADULTERATED OR MISREPRESENTED
IT'S NOT JUST FUNCTIONAL ALL
THESE OTHER DRUGS AS WELL MAGIC
MUSHROOMS CODY INVITED AND-
MATHIS CETERA. AND THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT THAT YOU KNOW THAT
THERE WAS ANYTHING WRONG WITH
THE DRUGS NO YOU I MEAN THIS IS
YOU ARE SELLING A DRUG THAT HAS
SPENT UNTIL THAT KNOWING THAT
YOU YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S TAKING
PLACE AND YOU CONTINUE TO SELL
BUT WE'RE IN THE BILL DOES IT
WORK FIRST OF ALL DOES NOT
LIMITED DEFENSE AT ALL AND IT'S
NOT LIMITED TO. ADULTERATION MY
READING OF THIS BILL IS THAT
AGAIN HE'S YOURSELF A CLASSIC
SOMEONE SAYS I WANT A DIME BAG
OF COCAINE AND GOES AND BUYS A
DIME BAG OF COCAINE FROM SOMEONE
WITH NO FENTANYL AND IT'S A
STRAIGHT UP COCAINE. AND THEN
THE PERSON GETS ARRESTED. FOR
SELLING COCAINE. CONVICTED FOR
SELLING COCAINE ON ADULT. THEY
WILL GET ADVICE ON. THAT'S HOW I
READ THE BILL AND I I'VE IF I'M
WRONG PLEASE TELL ME- OKAY. YES
STEVE THE- MISTER BENNETT
MODERATOR. DO YOU HAVE MISTER
MORGAN GEYER ON THE LINE DIAL
DIAL I'M SORRY I APOLOGIZE. I
DID NOT SEE HIS LINE CONNECTED
AT THIS POINT. AMONG THE PUBLIC
LINE. MISTER MORGAN DIAL IF YOU
ARE ONLINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. HE'S COURTING MY STAFF
HE'S ON THE LINE I THINK YOU
MIGHT BE ON THE PUBLIC LINE.
FILE CAN YOU HEAR ME. I THINK WE
HAVE ELEVATORS A MOMENT PLEASE.
I'M SORRY HE WAS- IDA IF THERE.
CHECK OUT OF YOUR MIND PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. NO I'M
SORRY HE IS NOT CONNECTED TO THE
CONFERENCE. AND SO IS THE
SENATOR- GOING FORWARD YOU KNOW
I MEAN HE'S ON THE LINE SO I
DON'T KNOW WHY BUT HE COMES ON
HE CAN- AND SO THAT THAT THAT'S
MY READING OF THE BILL IT'S A
VERY SIMPLE BILL- IT'S. NO WELL
I. IF THE READER OF THE FIGURE
OUT WHY YOU. I'M NOT SURE IN THE
MEETING I'M I'M CHAIRING THE
MEETINGS SO WOULD YOU MIND JUST
HOLDING OFF JUST ONE MOMENT.
HE'S TALKING TO THE MODERATOR
RIGHT NOW APPARENTLY SELL.
MODERN TECHNOLOGY. I'M SORRY
THIS IS THE AT&T MODERATOR DID
YOU SAY HE'S WITH SOMEBODY- NO
MY STAND NOT WITH EACH. OKAY.
OKAY I'M GETTING A MESSAGE FROM
A DIFFERENT OPERATOR THAT HE IS
WITH THEM SO HE SHOULD BE
JOINING US SHORTLY I WILL LET
YOU KNOW SOME OF THE VINE IS
OPEN OKAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
MISTER DIAL YOUR LINE IS OPEN
CAN YOU HEAR US.
WE SHOULD HAVE. AND THE LATEST
UPDATE AS HE DOES CONNECTED
AMAZON BACKEND SO I WILL LET YOU
KNOW WHEN HE IS BACK ON AND IS
WIDE OPEN I APOLOGIZE FOR THE
INCONVENIENCE. OKAY BUDGET. YEAH
BOB SO MODE WHERE HE WHEN HE
GETS ON HE CAN CORRECT ME IF I'M
IF I'M WRONG BUT I THIS IS A
VERY SIMPLE BUT WITH A COUPLE
PARAGRAPHS LONG- AND IT CROSS
REFERENCES THE SECTIONS OF THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE THAT
CRIMINALIZE AGAIN A LAUNDRY
LIST. OF DRUGS. IN FACT IN FACT
THE- THE ADVISEMENT SPECIFICALLY
EVEN SAYS CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES
EITHER REAL OR COUNTERFEIT. SO
THIS THIS IS A DRAMATICALLY
BROADER BILL THEM. NONE THE
POISONING BY FENTANYL- AND THEN
THE BEEN THE VERY REAL ISSUE OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE THINKING OF
BUYING. A PERCOCET WRITTEN IN
THERE BUYING. MATH OR WHATEVER
THEY THINK THEY'RE BUYING IT HAS
COUNCIL AND DISCOS DRAMATICALLY
BEYOND THAT- AND THERE'S AND IF
IT IS ADULTERATED THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT IN THE BILL. THAT
YOU KNOW THAT IT WAS
ADULTERATED. ON IT IT. AT THE
BEGINNING THIS NOT ABOUT OF
COURSE. BUT RATHER ABOUT NOTICE
ON- I AM WHILE I AGREE WITH YOU
AT THE BILL ITSELF DOES NOT
IMPOSE A NEW SENTENCE OR CREATE
A NEW CRIMES. WHAT IT DOES DO IS
IT AND I THINK IT'S I THINK IT'S
VERY MUCH INTENDED TO CREATE A
BASIS THAT. IF A PERSON DIES IN
A SECOND DRUG- TRANSACTION DRUG
CELL- THEN THERE WOULD BE A
BASIS AND MALICE BECAUSE OF
HAVING RECEIVED ADVICE- FOR
MANSLAUGHTER OR MURDER IN FACT
THAT SPECIFICALLY PUT IN THE
ADVISER YOU CAN BE CHARGED WITH
VOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER. OR
MURDER CITING THE PURPOSE OF
THIS BILL THIS IS JUST MY TAKE
ON IT IS TO- SO THESE PEOPLE
WILL BE CHARGED- WITH MURDER OR
SOMETHING AKIN TO A SUBSET IF.
THEY SELL AGAIN AND SOMEONE
DIES- WHETHER OR NOT- THE NEW
WELL WHETHER OR NOT IT WAS
ADULTERATED AND WHETHER OR NOT I
HAD ANYTHING TO. OF OFFENSE AND
ALL AND THE LAST TIME YOU
BROUGHT THIS BILL LAST YEAR THE
YEAR BEFORE I BELIEVE THE
COMMITTEE OFFERED YOU AN
AMENDMENTS. OF THE BILL I THINK
WHAT A PASSED OUT OF COMMITTEE.
KEEP THE BILL ON TIME. BUT
PROVIDE THAT THE- IT WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO COMMENCE AVIDIN. AND
SUBSEQUENT- CRIMINAL PROSECUTION
YOU TO NOT TAKE THAT AMOUNT
WHICH WAS YOUR PROG A- AND I
BELIEVE IT WAS PROBABLY BECAUSE-
IT WOULD UNDERMINE THE ABILITY.
TO CHARGE MURDER OR VOLUNTARY
MANSLAUGHTER AND THAT SUCKS.
RESCUES AND I SAY ALL THESE
THINGS- WITH ENORMOUS RESPECT
UNITED HAVE A DESPITE ARE
SIGNIFICANT POLITICAL
DISAGREEMENTS I THINK A VERY
GOOD POSITIVE. COLLEGIAL
RELATIONSHIP- AND I SUPPORT YOUR
BILLS WHEN YOU BRING THE BILL'S
EXPERTS MY BILLS- BY ON THIS ONE
I THINK THAT THIS IS A BILL.
THAT IS BEING PORTRAYED AS VERY
NARROW ABOUT ABOUT FENTANYL
POISONING AND NO AND GIVING
NOTICE TO PEOPLE WHEN THIS WILL.
ABSOLUTELY EXPLODE TRUCKS DRUG
SENTENCING FOR AN ENORMOUS ARRAY
OF DRUGS AND SITUATIONS HAVING
NOTHING TO DO. WITH FENTANYL OR
CARFENTANIL POISONING AND THAT
IS VERY CONCERNING- AND THAT IS
ONE HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
FOUND I'LL SPECIFICALLY- ABOUT
IT. BOB EVANS. BOTH AND I IN THE
SUB- NOT TO. AGAIN APPETITE NOT
THE BEFORE US TODAY. OKAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND I YOU
KNOW CERTAINLY ANTICIPATED THAT
WEWOULD NOT SEE EYE TO EYE ON
THIS BUT I DO WANT TO ADDRESS
JUST TAKE A COUPLE OF THINGS YOU
SAID RATHER THAN. LUMP IT ALL
INTO MY CLOTHES- SO YOU KNOW
LET'S REMEMBER THAT I MEAN
FENNEL CERTAINLY IS MUCH
DIFFERENT THAN THAN COCAINE OR
MATH OR MATH EVEN. IN ITS- YEAH
- EIGHT IT'S UNLIKELY THAT
SOMEONE IS GOING TO COME FORWARD
BEFORE JUDGING BE CHARGED WITH
MURDER BECAUSE SOMEBODY INGESTED
COCAINE THEY MAY VERY WELL COME
BEFORE THE JUDGE AND BE CHARGED
HER BECAUSE THEY INGESTED
COCAINE THAT ALSO HAD FENTANYL
IN IT THAT THAT'S THE FOCUS HERE
BUT YOU ARE CORRECT IT DOESN'T
SPECIFICALLY SAY AND SNOW IN
HERE BUT THE FOCUS ON IT THE
DEATH THAT RESULTS FROM THE
DRUGS THAT ARE INGESTED AND STOP
BY THE PER WHO NOT THOSE WHO HAS
BEEN. THANK YOU HAS WARNED IN
THE BLOOD THAT. TAIPEI BEHAVIOR
IS DANGEROUS THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
GOING AFTER SO IN THAT RESPECT I
DO FEEL. IT'S NARROW IN MY MIND
CERTAINLY NOT IN YOURS- BUT- YOU
KNOW THE GOAL IS TO HAVE FEWER
PEOPLE SELLING THIS DEADLY DRUG
WHICH AS YOU POINTED OUT NOW WE
HAVE CARFENTANIL AND WHICH IS
EVEN STRONGER THAN REGULAR
FENNEL AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
UNFORTUNATELY CONTINUE. CHASING
THE NEXT NEW DRUGS AND- HEROIN
NOW IT'S- IT IN A LARGE PART
IT'S NOT JUST THE BIGGER MARKETS
IT'S A SMALLER MARKETS TO YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO FIND IT BECAUSE
THEY REPLACED IT WITH BENHAM
BECAUSE IT'S CHEAPER AND IT'S
EASIER TO MAKE IN THESE LABS
AND- I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE NEXT
THING IS GOING TO BE BY. IT AND
DEADLIER. I UNDERSTAND THERE IS
THE ARGUMENT THAT YOU KNOW
THERE'S FOR EVERY DRUG DEALER
THAT YOU TAKE OFF THE STREET
ANOTHER ONE WILL TAKE HIS OR HER
PLACE. AND THAT'S PROBABLY TRUE
HELPER. WHEN THEY GET OUT OF
PRISON THEY DON'T SPEND THAT
MUCH TIME IN PRISON LET'S BE
HONEST RIGHT NOW THAT SAME DRUG
DEALER IS OUT. BUT SOMEBODY
REPLACED HIM WHILE HE WAS
INCARCERATED NOW YOU'VE GOT TO
ON THE CORNER WE'RE INCREASING
THE NUMBERS THE GOAL IS TO KEEP
. HEARINGS HEARINGS LIKE THIS
FROM HAVING TO TAKE PLACE AGAIN
FROM HAVING ALL THESE PARENTS
CAN FOR FROM LISTENING TO
TESTIMONY SAYING I LOST MY ONLY
CHILD I LOST MY GRANDSON I MEAN.
I DON'T THINK. CARCERI OUR WAY
OUT OF THIS THAT'S NOT MICHAEL
IT JUST ISN'T. BUT I THINK WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO AT
LEAST TRY. TO PERSUADE. SOME OF
THESE FOLKS TO RETHINK THEIR
LINE OF WORK TO RETHINK WHAT
THEY'RE DOING- I MEAN WHAT ELSE
ARE WE GOING TO DO ARE WE GOING
TO LEGALIZE EVERY DRUG IN JUST
SAY WELL IF YOU MAKE IT A LEGAL
THEN. THAT'S NOT THE ANSWER
EITHER- I HOPE THAT AT LEAST
THAT TOUCHES ON THE YOU KNOW THE
POINTS HE MADE LEAST FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE- I BELIEVE HE IS
CURRENTLY ON THE LINE OKAY
MISTER GUILE ARE YOU ON THE ON
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE. HE I AM
ON THE LINE CAN YOU HEAR ME.
PERFECT I CAN HEAR YOU CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES SIR WE CAN- WOULD
YOU LIKE TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT SENATOR WIENER
HAD FOR YOU. SURE AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTY- AND ALL OF GET RIGHT
TO IT CENTER WE KNOW YOU BROUGHT
UP YOU BROUGHT UP A GOOD POINT.
THE ABILITY OF THE ADVISEMENT TO
BE USED IN A FUTURE HOMICIDE
PROSECUTION IS ONE FACTOR THAT
GOES INTO A DECISION THAT A
PROSECUTOR WOULD HAVE TO MAKE
THE LAW OF IMPLIED MALICE HAS
BEEN AROUND FOR A LONG TIME WE
HAVEN'T USED IT IN. THE
SITUATION THAT YOU PRESENTED
EARLIER WHERE THERE'S A SMALL
AMOUNT OF COCAINE SOMEONE SELL
THAT- AND SOMEONE DIED THIS IS
DIFFERENT FINAL IS CHANGED THE
LANDSCAPE AND WHAT IT IS US
REQUIRING. SOMEONE TO HAVE
SUBJECTIVE KNOWLEDGE OF THE
DANGER OF WHAT THEY'RE DOING WE
HAVE TO PROVE THAT IN ORDER TO
CONVICT SOMEONE OF MURDER WITHIN
ADVISEMENT WITHOUT AN ARGUMENT
BUT WHAT THIS DOES IS IT SAYS.
IF YOU SELL DRUGS. YOU'RE ON
NOTICE NOW THAT THE LANDSCAPE
HAS CHANGED BUT IF YOU KILL
SOMEONE AGAIN IF YOU DO THIS AND
SOMEONE DIES AS A RESULT. THE
STAKES ARE NOW RAISED AND NOW
YOU COULD FACE A HOMICIDE CHARGE
BE THAT SOME SORT OF. CATEGORY
MANSLAUGHTER OR MURDER SO IN
THAT SITUATION WHERE SOMEONE
SELLS DRUGS THERE THEN WHEN THEY
ARE CONVICTED EITHER AT PLAY OR
SOMETHING THEY ARE THEN GIVEN
THE ADVISEMENT THAT SAYS. YEAH
NOW NO YOU DIDN'T KNOW BEFORE
BUT NOW YOU DO YOU KNOW WHAT IS
POSSIBLE IF YOU DO THIS AGAIN.
AND IF THAT PERSON DOES IT AGAIN
AND THAT PERSON DIED. NOW THOSE
STEAKS ARE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PROSECUTE FOR SOME
SORT OF HOMICIDE BE A MURDER. OR
MANSLAUGHTER SO IT DOESN'T MAKE
IT ANY EASIER IT DOESN'T MAKE IT
PRESUMPTIVE IT DOESN'T CHANGE A
DRUG LAW WHAT IT DOES IT SAYS.
IS WE CAN NOW USE THE FACT THAT
YOU KNEW AS ONE OF THE PIECES OF
EVIDENCE FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
SAY YOU KNEW HOW DANGEROUS IT
WAS. YOU CAN DISREGARD THAT
DANGER AND YOU DID IT ANYWAY
BECAUSE THE ESSENCE OF THE
HOMICIDE IS SORT OF A DEADLY.
APATHY IT'S A I KNOW IT. THERE
AM I GONNA DO A ANYWAY. AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS SEEKS TO DO AND
FEDERAL HAS CHANGED THE
LANDSCAPE WE DIDN'T NEED TO DO
IT BEFORE IN THOSE OTHER TYPES
OF CASES THAT. THAT YOU WOULD
REFERENCE EARLIER BUT THIS IS
SORT OF THAT ABSENCE OF. AHA I
KNOW HOW DANGEROUS IT IS NOW
YOU'VE TOLD ME. AND I DID IT
ANYWAY I HOPE THAT HELPS CLARIFY
SOME OF THAT OBVIOUSLY. WE ARE A
NUMBER OF OTHER COUNTY TO ARE
DOING THIS ALREADY IN SOME FORM
BUT THIS IS A MUCH NEEDED TO ON
A STATEWIDE LEVEL. TO MAKE IT
CONSISTENT I'M HAPPY TO HAPPY
TO. ANSWER ANY MORE QUESTIONS OR
OR GO THROUGH ANY OF THAT. NO
THANK YOU I. MINIMIZER THE THANK
YOU- YOU CLARIFY THE PURPOSE OF
THAT SIDE I KNOW NONE OF MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE BILL WAS
WHAT WAS ACCURATE AND OBVIOUSLY
WITH A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE ON
THAT- SISTERS. THIS IS A COUPLE
THINGS THE FINAL THINGS. COCAINE
DOES KILL PEOPLE I KNOW SOMEONE
WHO DIED OF A HEART ATTACK FROM
COOKING. ON MATH SKILLS PEOPLE-
YOU KNOW EVEN THOUGH IN SAN
FRANCISCO. WITHOUT A LOT OF
DENTAL DOES WE'VE GOT PLENTY OF.
OVERDOSE DATHS FROM. ON LATEST
MAPS. AND UNLEASHED HER WHEN- SO
IT'S- DOES NOT DRUGS KILLING P.
I AM AGAINST SUCH AS- A BROAD
ARRAY- BUT I. THE DIALOGUE AND
WE'LL JUST HAVE TO. AGREE TO
DISAGREE ON THIS ONE. THANK YOU
SENATOR WIENER- JUST A CRAZY- I
KNOW IT WAS THE QUESTIONS
ADDRESSED- DID YOU HAVE
SOMETHING ADDITIONAL. OR JUST
PERSONAL FURTHER COMMENT AT IF
I'M ALLOWED TO I'M- SORRY
ANSWERS QUESTIONS. I BELIEVE IT
WAS YOUR ANSWER QUESTION WAS
YOUR QUESTION ANSWERED BY THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY MR GUILE. YES
I'M ALREADY HERE I HAVE NO
PROBLEM- GETTING FURTHER ANSWER-
BUT I MEAN I. BUT YEAH. YEAH IF
YOU COULD JUST- PERHAPS LET THEM
ADD TO BRIEFLY THAT WOULD BE
GREAT SO PLEASE GO AHEAD WILL
GIVE ME ABOUT A MINUTE IF THAT'S
OKAY I UNDERSTAND IN IS. THE
REASON FOR THE BROAD AMOUNTED OF
DRUGS BEING PUT UNDER THIS BILL
IS THAT FENTANYL IS NOW BEING
FOUND IN EVERYTHING. FOR
THINKING THEY'RE BUYING COCAINE
PEOPLE ARE THINKING THEY'RE
GETTING A MARIJUANA EDIBLE. THIS
BILL SIMPLY ADVISES THAT DEALER
OF THAT AND WARNS THEM OF THAT I
WANT TO POINT OUT IS ONLY IF
SOMEBODY DIES AS A RESULT OF
THOSE DEADLY DRUGS. THAT THEY
WILL BE POTENTIALLY PROSECUTED
AND THAT IS AFTER THEY HAVE BEEN
WARNED. I WOULD I WILL TURN THE
QUESTION AND ASK WHAT IS AND
REASONABLE ABOUT SIMPLY WARNING
A PERSON TO STOP SELLING DRUGS
BECAUSE THEY COULD POTENTIALLY
KILL SOMEBODY. AND IF ONLY IF
THEY DISREGARD THAT MORNING AND
CONTINUE TO SELL ON SOMEBODY
DIES IT'S ONLY THEN. IS THERE
THE POTENTIAL FOR THEM TO BE
CHARGED WITH MANSLAUGHTER OR
MURDER. I WOULD LOVE AN ANSWER
TO THAT- THIS TIME IS TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY NOT TO ASK QUESTIONS
OF THE OF THE MEMBERS BUT I
THINK YOU. MIGHT WELL I WILL BE
YOU SIT HERE AND YOU SAY YOU SAY
YOU'RE SORRY AND YOU CARE FOR US
ALL THEN DO THE RIGHT THING AND
PASS THIS BILL THANK YOU SENATE
FOR THEIR INPUT. THANK YOU SIR.
IN ORDER IN THE COURT IN. IN THE
CHAMBER PLEASE THANK YOU- DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- SENATOR SKINNER. THIS
IS A DIFFICULT. POLICY TO
DISCUSS BECAUSE THE LEGITIMATE
THE VERY LEGITIMATE. HI RUSSIAN
AN EMOTION THAT ANYONE WHO LOST
A LOVED ONE TO FEDERAL. OR TO
ANY OF THE DRUGS FOR THAT MATTER
FEELS LEGITIMATELY. FOR US AS
POLICY MAKERS WE ALWAYS HAVE TO
WEIGH. THOSE LEGITIMATE
EXPERIENCES AND FEELINGS AND
THEN WHAT WE ARE PUTTING INTO
LAW. AND THE DIFFICULTY I THINK
THE THING THAT VARIOUS OF THE
MEMBERS WHO ARE STRUGGLING WITH
. IS THAT THE WHAT'S BEING PUT
BEFORE US. PERHAPS THE LANGUAGE
STATED. THAT THE DRUG DEATH
MINUTES IN OTHER WORDS HE
ADVISEMENT WAS SPECIFIC THAT IT
WAS A FENTANYL RELATED. I CAN'T
SPEAK FOR EVERYONE ELSE BUT
THERE MIGHT BE MORE WILLINGNESS
. HOWEVER IT DOES NOT YES IT YES
IT IS TRUE THAT MOST OF THE
DRUGS LISTED COULD BE. BUT IT
DOESN'T MAKE THAT. SPECIFIC IT
DOESN'T MAKE IT THAT IT MUST BE
. AND SO YOU HAVE AND NOT LOOK
AT NO WAIT WOOD SHOULD ANY DRUG
DEATH BE ANY WORSE BETTER OR-
BUT THERE CAN BE CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE ANOTHER DRUG ON THAT LIST
. LEAD TO SOMEONE'S DEATH HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH FEDERAL WAS
NOT ADULTERATED BUT IT WAS A
PARTICULAR CIRCUMSTANCE OF THAT
PERSON FOR EXAMPLE. AND THOSE
THAT'S WHAT OUR COURT SETTINGS
ARE TRYING TO DEAL WITH THIS
WHOLE CONTEXT OF ANY. OF ANY
CRIME THE CHARGES THAT ARE
BROUGHT. AND IN OUR ENACTING OF
LAWS WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL NOT
TO. OVER PRESCRIBE SOMETHING
WHEN WE DON'T HAVE ALL THOSE
CONTACTS AND SO. IF THIS. BILL
WERE TO BE A WARNING VERSUS
SOMETHING THAT COULD BE ALLOWED
A GUARANTEED EVIDENCE WHEN WE
CAN PROTECT THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF
THE NEXT CHARGE. SUCH A WARNING
AS A WAY TO HELP. PUBLIC SAFETY
AND PROTECT LIVES I COULD
SUPPORT. FOR POTENTIALLY IF IT
WERE MODIFIED SWEET REALLY WAS
SPECIFIC TO FENTANYL OR
CARFENTANIL. BUT IN ITS
BROADNESS. IT IS VERY HARD.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER.
AMERICAN WATER. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I JUST HAD A QUESTION
EITHER FOR THE AUTHOR OR FOR THE
G. A. R. SO CURRENTLY. AND THERE
HAVE BEEN SOME- EXAMPLES OF THIS
THAT HAVE BEEN IN THE NEWS BUT
CURRENTLY THERE ARE INDIVIDUALS
EITHER DEALERS WHO HAVE BEEN
SELLING OR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
SHARING DRUGS THAT HAVE BEEN
CHARGED WITH MURDER AND OR
VOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER WHICH I'M
ASSUMING IS. AND INTENT OF THE
BILL TO CHARGE PEOPLE AT SOME
POINT WITH- MURDER AND IN THE
INSTANCES WHERE THIS HAS
HAPPENED PEOPLE HAVE DIED. FROM
TAKING A DRUG THAT WAS LACED
WITH FENTANYL SO THAT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW. SO MY
QUESTION IS. IF THAT'S ALREADY
AVAILABLE TO D. A.'S AND IF IT'S
ALREADY A TOOL THAT'S BEING USED
BY D. A.'S. HOW DOES THIS DIFFER
OR HOW DOES THIS ADD BECAUSE IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT DA'S ARE
ACTUALLY. LOOKING AT THE TOOLS
THAT ARE IN THEIR TOOLBOX V. OF
THE PENAL CODE AND ARE FIGURING
OUT WAYS TO CHARGE. DEALERS IN
THANKS WITH THESE KINDS OF
CHARGES NOW. SO I DON'T KNOW IF
. THIS COVERS SOME OPENING THAT
ISN'T ALREADY AVAILABLE OR IF
THIS IS AN ADDITIVE IN SO I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT TO ADD
AND THEN IF MAYBE- YOUR WITNESS
CAN ALSO SHARE BUT YOU KNOW I'M
ASKING BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE IF
THE DA WANTS TO CHARGE SOMEONE
THEY CAN. ALREADY RIGHT THANK
YOU- CENTER COMMONER FOR THE
QUESTION I WILL HOPEFULLY THE
MODERATOR STILL HAS DIEGO WHILE
ON THE LINE. IS YOUR FINEST-
GREAT LINE IS STILL OPEN OKAY
AND SO- YOU CAN HEAR ME YES
MORGAN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE AND
I HAVE TO RESPOND BETTER WE CAN
DO IT NOW IT'S INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT THESE CHARGES REQUIRED
IF WE WANT TO SEE A MURDER
CHARGE ON SOMEONE FOR. FOR
SELLING. THAT ALTERNATELY KILLED
SOMEONE WE HAVE TO PROVE THEY
KNEW HOW DANGEROUS IT WAS. AND
WE CAN DO THAT THROUGH THE
EVIDENCE OF THE CASE BUT IT
DOESN'T EXIST IN A LOT OF THESE
CASES BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY A
NUMBER OF THE THAT RESULT IN
CORNERS CASES AND THEY DON'T
START I'M A SITE INVESTIGATION.
WE TO BUILD. AND WHETHER.
SOMEONE WHO CAN'T PROVE BECAUSE
THE EVIDENCE ISN'T THERE WE
DON'T HONESTLY THINK THEY DIDN'T
KNOW HOW DANGEROUS THEIR
BEHAVIOR WHILE WE DON'T HAVE A
CASE WHAT THIS DOES IS PUT
SOMEONE WHO ALREADY. BEEN FOUND
RISK. I NOTICED THAT IT IS
DANGEROUS BUT IF YOU SELL MATT
IF YOU SELL COCAINE IF YOU TAKE
BILL IF USED ANY. IT LIKELY AND
VERY DANGEROUS AND YOU COULD
KILL SOMEONE AND IF YOU DO THAT
AGAIN THEN WE CAN PROVE IT YOU
KNOW WHAT BECAUSE YOU DID YOU
ABILITY TO DO IT IT'S JUST VERY
DIFFICULT AND SO MANY OF THE
PEOPLE I CAN TELL BY TODAY THEIR
CASES HAVE. HAVEN'T COME TO
FRUITION THERE HAVEN'T BEEN ANY
ONE HUNDRED WILL BE GOOD
ASSEMBLY THERE DURING. OR THIS
YOUR PARTNER AND SAID NOW YOU
KNOW THE POINT AS AS CENTER MY
POINT GOAL IS TO PREVENT THAT IF
THE SAY YOU KNOW WHAT DANGEROUS
DON'T DO IT AGAIN IF YOU DO AND
SOMEONE THAT THE RESULT. ALL YOU
. AT THAT THAT DEADLY APATHY
THAT WE ARE SEEKING TO PROSECUTE
NOT ANYONE WHO JUST SELL DRUGS
BUT SOMEONE WHO KNOWS THAT IT'S
DANGEROUS. THIS ALL OF YOUR THAT
DANGER AND OTHER AND THAT'S TRUE
IF YOU ARE DEALING WITH GUNS IF
YOU'RE DRUNK BEHIND THE WHEEL
AND NOW SELLING DROP BECAUSE
THAT MAKES IT VERY LIKELY BE
OKAY THAT YOU'RE BUYING OR THE
PILL THAT YOU'RE BUYING IS GOING
TO BE SPENT ON THAT. TO BE FAIR
. IT IT. YEAH THOSE CASES WHERE
HAVE EVER IT US PROVE THAT NOW
OR IF WE DON'T HAVE WE HAVE HOPE
THAT SHOWS A LITTLE BIT OF LIGHT
ON ON HOW THAT ADVISEMENT WORK
IT DOES BUT IT ALSO IT IT M. HAS
REVEALED ANOTHER QUESTION IF I
MAY WHICH IS THAT YOU SAID IT
ADVISEMENT PROVES THAT THEY KNOW
BUT IT. LET DO SO ADVISORY STAY
BE PROVIDED THE DEFENDANT
WRITING YOU'RE A PLEA FORM OR
AFTER SENTENCING. SO A THAT
WOULD SUGGEST TO ME. THAT I'M-
THE FIRST STEP IS NOT JUST
GETTING AN ADVISEMENT THE FIRST
STEP IS ACTUALLY A CHARGE- AND
THOSE AND SORE AND IF YOU WORK
THAT THROUGH YOU'RE EITHER
EXCEPT IT PLAYED. THE- OR YOU'VE
BEEN CHOI. YOU SAY THE VIOLENCE
WOULD PROVE THAT THEY KNOW- IN I
WOULD LIKE AN EXPLANATION TO
THAT BECAUSE HOW I READ IT YOU
WOULD GET AN INVITE AND
ADVISEMENT. AFTER THE FACT. SO
IS THE ENVIRONMENT VOLUNTARY. I
MEAN BECAUSE YOU COULD HAVE.
WHICH DOESN'T MEAN YOU KNOW PLEA
MEANS ACCEPT THE PLEA RIGHT AND
I CHARGE MEANS YOU'VE BEEN
CONVICTED- OR SENTENCING MEANS
THAT THIS PROCESS HAS HAPPENED
WITH THE COURTS SO CAN YOU OPT
TO NOT HAVE THE SIZE PUT IN YOUR
BECAUSE YOU SO ATTACHED ARE YOU
. I DON'T KNOW EVERYONE WHO'S
NOTING. IS TO MILLIMETER ANSWER
WHATEVER EXACTLY WHAT IS IN IT
SO IS THE BISON BOND HERE YOU
CAN YOU TO NOT HAVE. BECAUSE YOU
DON'T NOW OR DOES IT I'M WITH
YOU IT DOES IT IN THE NEAR FILE
REGARDLESS. SO THERE ARE THERE
ARE THERE ARE. CASES WHERE THIS
IS IT IS RELEVANT TO ON ON
SOMEONE'S CONVICTION FOR SALE
THAT DOES NOT INVOLVE THE DEATH
OF SOMEONE. SOMEONE IS CONVICTED
FELON BURKE UP THEY EITHER
PLEASE THE DAUGHTER THEY WERE
CONVICTED BY A JURY. ULTIMATELY
AT THE CONCLUSION THAT CASE OF
ARE FOUND RESPONSIBLE ONE OF
THOSE TWO IT. WILL BE GIVEN BY.
BY THAT YOUR CON. THIS CASE WHAT
YOU DID BY SELLING OUR PRODUCTS
YOUR NOW GO OF WHAT YOU ARE
DOING IS DANGEROUS AND IT COULD
GO SOMEBODY AND IF YOU DO IT.
COULD BE ON THE HOT LAW AND THAT
IS THE ADVISEMENT THAT WOULD
ONLY COME INTO PLAY SHE- DO THE
AGAIN. YOU AND I WANT TO THE
RESULT THEN BY. FROM PRIOR.
YEARS NOW. ELEVEN ARCADE WE PAY
. WE KNOW THAT YOU KNOW HOW
DANGEROUS IT WAS BECAUSE YOU
WERE TOLD. RIGHT CLARIFY THAT.
IT DOES I'M ONE OF THE ONLY TIME
WE WOULD USE THAT IN THE FUTURE
RIGHT I APPRECIATE M. THE
RESPONSE I'M JUST TRYING TO-
THINK. ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS WITH
PRACTITIONERS IN THIS FIGHT. YES
BUT JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE ADVISED
DOESN'T MEAN YOU WILL BE CHARGED
WITH MURDER IT DEPENDS ON EVERY
CASE IT DEPENDS ON THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT HAPPENED ON
THE EVIDENCE EVERY PROJECT EIGHT
AND THERE ARE THOSE WHO BOB WE
WILL CAN'T WAIT OR DON'T WANT TO
. THE AND GIVEN THE CERTAIN THE
CASE IT MAY BE APPROPRIATE IF
JUST ONE ADDITIONAL TO HELP ONE
GET THE MESSAGE TO THE
PARTICULAR DEFENDANT AND REYES.
THE QUESTION IN THE FUTURE IF
SOMEONE DIED AS A RESULT OF
THEIR CONTINUED CONTACT. OKAY
YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT THANK YOU
. IMAGINE THE OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. I HAVE A JUST TWO
QUESTIONS AND THIS THE FIRST
QUESTION IS FOR THE SUPPORTER-
ACTUALLY MISTER GUY WHO FOR THE
DESCRIPTION HERE- I KNOW THAT
SOME PROSECUTORS A STARE TRYING
TO USE THIS FENTANYL ADVISEMENT
IN COURT. HOW IS THIS ADVICE
BEEN BEING RISK IT BY JUDGES AND
DEFENDANTS IN THE COURTROOM AND
HOW CAN SB THIRTEEN FIFTY BE
HELPFUL TO THE D. A.'S. AND DOWN
THE IN PURSUING THE SENTINEL
CASE. BUT GOOD QUESTION SO
THEY'RE ABOUT SEVENTEEN COUNTIES
IN COUNTING WHO ARE PROVIDING
THIS ADVISEMENT THROUGH SOME
FORM EITHER AT THE TIME OF THE
PLEA AT THE TIME OF THE CERTAIN
SOME B. ICER IN METHOD BY
MANAGER WHEN SOMEONE IS CHARGED
NUMBER HOW MANY OF THE- SOMEWHAT
MIXED. SOME JUDGES. SOME ARE
HESITANT TO DO IT I'M DOWN TO GO
SHOOTING WHETHER NOT THAT SHOULD
BE DONE OR COULD BE DONE SO THE
END RESULT IS IT'S WORKING IN
SOME COUNTIES BUT WE'RE GETTING
SOMEWHAT INCONSISTENT SO AS
THIRTY THREE ONE IT. EIGHT
MESSAGE WHEN SOMEONE ALL HELD
FOR THE SELLING OF NARCOTICS
THAT ADVISE MINUTES BUT WE ALL
HOPE AND PRAY THAT THE LAST BY
THERE WERE NEEDED FOR YOU
KNAPPER'S CASE PERCENT YEAH BUT
IT WOULD MAKE IT AN EFFORT ON
THE PART. ALL MONEY LETTER THAT. PERFORMS COUNTY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR AND I DO HAVE A
QUESTION FOR MR WELL ARE YOU
STILL IN THE- THANK YOU SIR.
MISTER WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT-
DECRIMINALIZATION AND NOT
PROSECUTING DRUG DEALERS HAS
REDUCE THE AVAILABILITY
AVAILABILITY OF DRUGS IN THE
OPEN MARKET. SO AND THERE'S A
STATISTICS ACTUALLY BACKED UP
RIGHT NOW SAN FRANCISCO WERE
PULLING ONE POINT ONE KILOS ON
AVERAGE PER WEEK JUST FROM THE
TENDERLOIN OF JUST ILLICIT
FENTANYL OFF THREE. WELL PASSED
YEAR WE ARE THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHT DRUG DEALERS. ALMOST A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY OF THEM WERE
REPEAT OFFENDERS. SO CLEARLY
WHAT WE'RE DOING IN OUR CITY IN
SAN FRANCISCO IS NOT WORKING AND
IT'S REFLECTED IN THE OVERDOSE
DEATHS LAST YEAR WE HAD SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY OVERDOSE
DEATHS THE BOTTOM LINE. FROM THE
HEALTH INSPECTOR. YOU KNOW
JUSTICE PER. WE ARE APPROACHING
THIS CRISIS AS IF WE WERE STILL
DEALING WITH LOW GRADE STREET
LEVEL HEROIN. BUT WE ARE NOT.
NOW DEALING WITH A DRUG THAT IS
FIFTY TO ONE HUNDRED TIMES
STRONGER THAN MORPHINE. WHICH IS
WAY STRONGER THAN BLACK TAR
HEROIN WAS ON THE STREET SO WE
MUST. STOP AND STEP BACK AND
COULDN'T RECONSIDER OUR APPROACH
FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH PERSPECTIVE
AND A CRIMINAL JUSTICE
PERSPECTIVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR. OUR NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
WERE COLLEGE THE NEW MELINDA'S
WHICH I CLOSE I WOULD THINK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN- FIRST LET ME
SAY THANK YOU TO- THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS THOUGH CLEAR. NOT A
LINE- I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
QUESTIONS AND SEEKING CLARITY ON
THE BILL AND I ALSO WANT TO
THANK- ALL THE WAY WHO ARE TO A
- ALL THE WITNESSES WHO CALLED
AND IT IS- YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
THING THAT THEY- LIVE WITH. A.
I HAVE DONE THIS BILL I DON'T
SLEEP THE NIGHT BEFORE MY
STOMACH IS IN KNOTS I CAN'T
IMAGINE WHAT THESE PARENTS FEEL
LIKE SO I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
. OKAY I TESTIFIED. SOME.
NATIONALLY THE DEATH RATE FROM
THESE DRUGS HAS INCREASED AND
YOU'VE HEARD THE STATISTICS BUT
IT IS INCREASED BY ABOUT OVER A
1000% BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN AND TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND OVERDOSE DEATHS
HAVE IT AT SKEWS ME OVERDOSE
DEATHS HAVE INCREASED IN EVERY
MAJOR DEMOGRAPHIC GROUP BUT THE
NOTE BROUGH SEEN BIGGER INCREASE
IN DEATHSTHAN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY. AS MORE. SB THIRTEEN
FIFTY DOES NOT CREATE A DRUG
INDUCED HOMICIDE CHARGE AS IT
WAS EXPLAINED BY THE DA AND
MYSELF THIS IS AN ADMONISHMENT
IN COURT. SO THAT WE CAN HOLD
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE IT DOES NOT
MEAN THAT THEY WILL BE CHARGED
WITH MURDER MEANS THE
POSSIBILITY IS THERE BUT MOST
IMPORTANT. IS THAT WE GIVE THE
ADMONISHMENT AND THAT THEY KNOW
THAT NO ONE IN FUTURE CAN SAY I
HAD NO IDEA. THAT FENTANYL THE
SIZE OF TWO GRAINS OF SALT COULD
KILL ANOTHER HUMAN BEING. THEY
CAN'T SAY THAT ANYMORE. THE GOAL
IS INCREASING. EDUCATION IF YOU
WILL IT IS NOT ABOUT
INCARCERATION. THESE DRUGS ARE
UNFAIRLY TARGETING IMPOVERISHED
COMMUNITIES ACCORDING TO THE L.
A. TIMES DRUG OVERDOSES WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR JUST UNDER 30%
OF THE ALL THE DEATHS OF
HOMELESS IN TWENTY TWENTY THAT
WAS THE LEADING CAUSE. THIS BILL
WILL FORCE DRUG DEALERS TO MAKE
HARD CHOICES AND TO BE AWARE OF
THE CONSEQUENCES OR BENEFIT TO
GO ALONG WITH THAT CHOICE LIKE
ANY OTHER RESPONSIBLE ADULT BUT
THE UNWILLINGNESS. TO ADDRESS
THE FINAL EPIDEMIC ON THE CHANCE
THAT IT WOULD INCREASE
INCARCERATION LEVELS IGNORES THE
FACT THAT SO MANY PEOPLE ARE
DYING FROM IT IF YOU CAN'T SAY
IT'S GOING TO INCREASE. THE
NUMBER OF BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
WHO ARE INCARCERATED WITHOUT
ALSO. THANK NUMBER BLACK BROWN
PEOPLE WERE DYING FROM THIS DRUG
ARE INCREASING AS WELL MORE SO
THAN THOSE- BEING INCARCERATED
FOR SELLING THESE DRUGS. THIS IS
NOT A RACIAL ISSUE- I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE-
ARGUMENTS THAT THE OPPOSITION-
MADE THOUGH I'VE SPOKEN TO SOME
OF THOSE ALREADY BUT I WILL SAY
THAT- LET'S SEE THEY SAID. THE
STATE SHOULD NOT CONTINUE TO
SPEND FUNDING ON INCREASING
INCARCERATION LEVELS THAT WE
SHOULD FOCUS ON EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES OKAY WELL IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY BEFORE WE ENACTED
STRICTER DRUNK DRIVING LAWS WE
HAD ABOUT TWENTY FIVE.
CALIFORNIA IN THAT YEAR WHO WERE
KILLED IN DRUNK DRIVING FAST
FORWARD TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AFTER WE PUT THE ADMONISHMENT IN
PLACE FOR D. WISE THAT NUMBER
WAS CUT IN HALF. SB THIRTEEN
FIFTIES A WARNING FROM THE COURT
ENSURING THAT A CONVICTED
INDIVIDUALS EDUCATE ON THE
DANGERS OF DEALING LESS HOT
FENNEL SAME AS WE DID FOR DRUNK
DRIVING. THE OPPOSITION ALSO
SAID THAT A CONVICTED DEALER
FACE MURDER CHARGERS CHARGES CAN
ARGUE THAT INDIVIDUAL CHOSE TO
CONSUME. TOO MUCH HEROIN OR
WHATEVER THE DRUG WAS- IT IS
UNLIKELY THAT SOMEONE THE VERY
FIRST TIME THE USE HEROIN. IS
GOING TO DIE FROM IT IT IS. VERY
LIKELY THAT SOMEONE WHO TAKES
SPENT NO FROM THE FIRST TIME IN
THE WRONG AMOUNT WILL DIE FROM
IT THAT'S GUARANTEE AND FIT IN
MY OPINION THAT'S VICTIM BLAMING
. YOU CAN STEP YOU CAN TAKE A
LIST OF DRUGS I AGREE. IT'S
DANGEROUS AND YOU JUST YOU
SHOULDN'T BE DOING IT BUT WE
DON'T BLAME THE VICTIM. I MEAN
IT'S SIMILAR TO WHAT I THINK
THOMAS SAID EARLIER WHERE IF-
YOU KNOW IF OUR KIDS WERE
DRINKING UNDER AGE WHICH- A LOT
OF KIDS DO AND A LOT OF. MEMBERS
OF THIS LEGISLATURE PROBABLY DID
. OR DIE BECAUSE HE WAS BEING
SOMETHING LETHAL. IN ALCOHOL
WOULD BE OUTRAGED. SO WHY ISN'T
ANY DIFFERENT WITH THIS I AGREE
PROBABLY SHOULDN'T BE BUYING.
PERCOCET OR IS AND WHATEVER ELSE
IT IS FROM SO CLOSE THAT OUT BUT
PEOPLE ARE DOING IT DOESN'T MEAN
THEY DESERVE TO DIE IT. AND HE
GOES UNDER RAY ABOUT THIS. ABOUT
WHAT WE DON'T WANT INCARCERATE
MORE PEOPLE WELL THAT'S NOT THE
ANSWER WELL THERE'S ANOTHER DRUG
DEALER WHO WILL STEP INTO THEIR
PLACE OKAY SO THEN WHAT. WHAT
WHAT DO WE DO NOTHING DO WE JUST
SAY YOU GOT US THERE'S NOTHING
WE CAN DO I MEAN IS THERE EVER A
PROBLEM THAT COMES. THIS BODY
THAT IS A WEEK SOLVENT OF COURSE
NOT. WE DELIVERY UNDER THIS TIME
THINGS THAT. BUT WE CAN'T SOLVE
FOR DECADES. WE SURE AS HECK TRY
. DON'T WORRY FROM CLIMATE
CHANGE TO PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUES
YOU NAME IT WE TACKLE IT. BUT
CHECK YOUR ISSUE WE JUST CAN'T
SOLVE THERE'S JUST NOTHING WE
CAN DO I'M JUST. I DON'T THINK
THAT THAT'S TRUE AND I HONESTLY
I UNDERSTAND. YOUR POSITION THAT
YOU DON'T WANT TO PUT MORE
PEOPLE BEHIND BARS I DO BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT I DON'T WANT TO SEE
MORE PEOPLE PUT IN THE CAVE I
THINK THAT TRUMP'S PUTTING
PEOPLE BEHIND BARS. WHAT IASK
WE HAVE NO DISPLACING NEITHER
POSITIVE OR NEGATIVE HERE PLEASE
NO CLAPPING. OVER YOUR TURN I
DON'T WANT TO PROLONG THIS
DISCUSSION BUT I THINK IT'S A
UNFAIR CHARACTERISTIC TO
INDICATE THAT THERE'S NO
WILLINGNESS TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE AND SETTING. THIS IF WE
WERE BEING ASKED TO MAKE AN
ADVISEMENT THAT WAS RELATED
SPECIFICALLY TO FEDERAL AND TO
THE TO THAT AND AS YOU POINTED
OUT THE- TRAVIS. SOMETHING THE
QUIBBLING OF TWO GRAINS OF SALT
CAN KILL YOU AND THAT IT IS IT
IS. RAMPANT IN ALL THE DIFFERENT
DRUGS THAT PEOPLE THINK ARE
PERHAPS JUST. KNOCKS ECONOMY FOR
JUST. OR JUST A HYDROCODONE BUT
THAT'S NOT WHAT IS BEFORE US AND
SO I JUST THINK IT'S FAIR TO PUT
ON THE RECORD AS MUCH AS YOU PUT
YOUR FOOT ON THE CLOTHES. PUT
THE RIGHT. D. AS POLICY ME.
COMMITTEE ARE REALLY BEING ASKED
TO VOTE FOR. AND IF I WERE BEING
GIVEN SOME ALTERNATIVES I COULD
SUPPORT. SIR CHAIRMAN BRADFORD
ST STE. THE DISCUSSION AGAIN I'D
LIKE TO JUST ADD SOMETHING THAT
THE FIRST TIME THIS BILL CAME
THROUGH- S. ME CHANGES. TO J.
YES. FIFTY TWO THIS. THEY'RE
WILLING TO MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD IF WE NARROW IT DOWN TO
JUST FENNEL THEN TELL ME THAT
NOW AND WE CAN ALL WORK TOGETHER
AND MOVED OVER WITH THAT'S THE
STATE POINT YES- WINNER. YEAH ON
IT YOUR INITIAL COMMENT.
SENATORS DINNER YOU YOU'VE
TOUCHED ON IT TWICE NOW IS. IS
THAT THE COMMITTEE'S POSITION
THAT YOU WANT IT NARROWED TO J.
BECAUSE A THE.
THERE ARE ALWAYS HAPPY TO WORK
WITH ANYONE AND I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO HAVE FURTHER CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THAT OPINION THAT WAS PUT
FORWARD LAST YEAR OR THE YEAR
BEFORE. HERE'S A THE OTHER DAYS-
NOT BE ADMISSIBLE SIR AND THE
SUBSEQUENT PROSECUTION SO THAT
IT WOULD BE ABOUT EDUCATION AND
TELLING PEOPLE- AND YOU TO STEP
BACK AND THAT WAS YOUR PROGRESS-
YOU HAVE- KNOWING WAS IN THE
DRUG OR WHAT THE DRUG. THERE ARE
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF A
DIFFERENT I'M GONNA HAVE TO SIT
DOWN WITH YOU AND TALK
FENTANYL'S IMPACTING ALL OF OUR
TO REFER WHAT KIND OF HAPPY TO
CONTRA. WAS NOT THAT WAS A ONLY.
ISSUE SURE SEEKING A MOTION ON
THOSE MEASURE TO PASTURE
CORPORATIONS IS THERE A MOTION.
HE'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
TROUBLES. HI THIS IS MEGAN. I'M
COUNCIL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
. SB THIRTEEN FIFTY MELINDA'S TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD
. BRADFORD NOT VOTING AT
SHOWBOAT I FOR BOCA. IF YOU CAN
SHOW BOTH HI CHAU BOOK I'D COME
LONGER. CAMARGO NOT VOTING
SKINNER INTERNAL VOTING WIENER
WIENER NO VOTES ONE TO ONE ARE
WE WILL REMOVE YOU FROM THE
CHAMBER WITH THOSE DISPLAY OKAY
THANK YOU BYE THANK YOU. WATER.
THE EVERY THERE WAY.
WE'RE WE'RE NOT GONNA TAKE THAT
KIND OF LANGUAGE IN HERE OKAY SO
YOU CAN YEAH YOU KNOW. YEAH ALL
RIGHT. YEAH OKAY ALL RIGHT.
HERTZBERG YOU READY CAN YOU
FOLLOW THAT. YOU KNOW YEAH.
WE'RE WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA
CALL A RECESS WE'RE GOING TO BE
A RECESS.
WHEN ASKED TO WAIT ONE MORE
MINUTE CENTER HERTZBERG BUT
YOU'LL BE PRESENTED AS THIRTEEN
TWENTY. ONE BURKE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. IT'S HARD WORK THANK
YOU. THIS BILL IS ABOUT GUN
VIOLENCE GUN VIOLENCE. GUN
VIOLENCE HAS EXPLODED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES OF THE LAST FEW
YEARS MUCH. THE INCREASE
VIOLENCE IS FROM THE USE OF
ILLEGAL WEAPONS WEAPONS THAT THE
REVERDY BRUCE LAW PUT IN PLACE
AND I THINK IT WAS EIGHTY NINE
AND THEN PRODIGY TO GHOSTS AND
NINE I BELIEVE. THE FARM'S USE
JUST THE OTHER WEEK THIS MASS
SHOOTING IN SACRAMENTO. STOLEN
AND CONVERTED TO BE USED AS
FULLY AUTOMATIC WEAPONS. SO
CALLED GHOST GUNS ARE TO BLAME.
THESE WEAPONS ARE EITHER MADE OF
POLYMER PARTS CREATED BY THREE
D. PRINTERS OR OR A GUN OR
LITERALLY YOUR FILING OFF THE
SERIAL NUMBER. ON GHOST GUNS ARE
RELATIVELY INEXPENSIVE AND-
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT MADE BY
LICENSE MANUFACTURES THEY LACKED
THE SERIAL NUMBER OR AS I
SUGGESTED THE SERIAL NUMBER'S
BEEN REVIEW REMOVED MAKING THEM
IMPOSSIBLE TO TRACE. HERE'S
WHAT'S IMPORTANT BUT BUT I COME
FROM IN LOS ANGELES R. LOS
ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT
RECENTLY DECLARED A GHOST GUN
EPIDEMIC. CONNECT TO OVER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE LOS ANGELES POLICE
COMMISSION REPORT FOUND THAT THE
NUMBER OF GHOST GUNS CAUGHT.
APARTMENT JUMP 4100% SINCE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. IN THE FIRST
ELEVEN MONTHS OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE OUR POLICE DEPARTMENT LOS
ANGELES ON EVEN LARGER RISE
COMPARED TO THE PREVIOUS YEAR
SKYROCKETING UP TO ONE THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED AND EIGHTY UP
BEING CONFISCATED TWO COMPARED
TO ONLY EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTEEN
AND TWENTY TWENTY IN OAKLAND.
BETTER BUDGET CHAIR OF THE
ROUGHLY TWELVE HUNDRED FIREARMS
SEIZED BY POLICE OFFICERS THAT
YEAR. GOT A TWELVE HUNDRED WERE
GHOST GUNS ACCORDING TO THE
LOCAL POLICE DEPARTMENT LAST
YEAR IN SAN FRANCISCO. MISTER
WINNER. A POLICE. FOR SUCH GUNS
AS A DECEMBER SEVENTH ACCOUNTING
420% OF ALL GUNS SEIZED BY THE
DEPARTMENT. THAT NUMBER HAS
RISEN FAST IN RECENT YEARS JUST
SIX SUCH GUNS WERE SEIZED BY
SAMPRAS OF FISCAL POLICE IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN. AND SO NO SUCH
GUNS WERE RECOVERED IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN. SIGNIFICANT CHANGE OF
CIRCUMSTANCES WITHOUT QUESTION
CALIFORNIA LEADS THE NATION IT
ACTING ROBUST GUN LAWS TO
PROTECT. OUR CALIFORNIANS.
GOVERNOR NEWSOM. IS A FIERCE AND
ROBUST LEADER AND ADVOCATE FOR
COMMONSENSE GUN REFORM. HE
SIGNED MULTIPLE GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION MEASURES INTO LAW
SINCE HE WAS SWORN INTO OFFICE.
AND YET THE DISTURBING NUMBERS
REPORTED OUT OF POLICE
DEPARTMENTS A JUST SUGGESTED
DEMONSTRATED THERE'S STILL MUCH
MORE TO BE DONE AND WE NEED TO
GET CREATIVE. UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP AT THE DIRECTION OF
THE NEWSMEN MINISTRATION THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
THIS MEASURE SB THIRTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN PROVIDES A SET OF NEW
TOOLS IF YOU WILL AN INCENTIVE
TO GET THESE DANGEROUS WEAPONS
OFF OUR STREETS A PRIVATE
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM
SPECIFICALLY MEMBERS. THIS BILL
CREATES A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION ALLOWS ALMOST ANYONE TO
BRING A LAWSUIT AGAINST THOSE
p. IMPORT HELLO LEGAL WEAPONS
WHAT IS THAT FIFTY CALIBER
MACHINE GUNS. S. ILLEGAL GHOST
GUNS AS I JUST SUGGESTED GOES
KIND KIDS STOP WEAPONS. IN OTHER
WORDS S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN GIVES PRIVATE LESSONS
PRIVATE COMMUNITY MEMBERS. WORK
CONCERNED ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
THESE DANGEROUS WEAPONS A TOOL
TO KEEP THESE WEAPONS OFF THE
STREET. THIS BILL HARNESSES THE
POWER OF A COMMUNITY. I
DETERRENCE ABOUT IT WE DO IT IN
MANY OTHER. WE DO IT WOULD PUT
THE PICTURE UP IN THE POST
OFFICE WE DO IT IN SO MANY OTHER
WAYS WE LOOK. THE COMMITTEE. THE
SACRAMENTO WHEN THEY'RE RELEASED
TALKED ABOUT. THE PHOTOGRAPHS
AND OTHER THINGS WHERE THE
COMMUNITY WAS VERY INSTRUMENTAL.
IN HELPING DEALING WITH CRIME.
NOW A PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
MEMBERS OF THE SHORT HERE. HE'S
CERTAINLY NOT SOMETHING NEW IN
CALIFORNIA. THE END WAS CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT CIVIL CODE SECTION
FIFTY ONE. PERSON MOTIONS OF THE
CIVIL RIGHTS DISORDERS ALSO
PRIVATE RIGHTS OF ACTIONS IN
VARIOUS CONSUMER PROTECTION LAWS
AND THE LIKE. NOW HE NUMBER
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE TEXAS
STATE LEGISLATURE AT BASICALLY
CREATED THIS PRIVATE ENFORCEMENT
SCHEME ENACTED PRODUCE A SEVERE
AND RESTRICTIVE ABORTION LAWS
WHICH IS OWNING TECH SUCCESS BA
WHICH ALLOWED ANYONE TO SUE.
PROVIDERS AND OTHERS EIGHT IT AT
TRAINING WORKSHOP. IF TEXAS CAN
USE THE MACINNES TO TAKE A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE. ANY
DANGER LIVES CALIFORNIA IS THE
GOVERNOR HAS SAID CAN USE THE
SAME MECHANISM TO BAND THAT THE
WEAPONS OF WAR AND SAVE LIVES
FURTHER THE SHIP'S COURT HAS
ALLOWED SB EIGHT TO REMAIN IN
PLACE. IF THIS PRESIDENT IS TO
STAND THEN WE SHOULD USE IT TO
GET AN ASSAULT WEAPON AND GHOST
GUNS OFF THE STREET WE LOOK AT
THIS IT'S VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
DISCIPLINE COURT. AMIGAS BRIEFS-
THE BY AN ORGANIZATION CALLED
THE FIREARMS POLICY COALITION
FILED THE BRIEF IT SAYS IF YOU
JUST WITH THE PORTIONS THEY'RE
GONNA COME ALONG WITH GUNS DO
EXACTLY THIS THING. WE USED IN
AND THE COURT HAD THIS POSITION
FOR THEM WHEN THEY WERE
CONSIDERING THIS AND SAID WISH
HE- WAS. THE COST TO. OF THIS
PER RIGHT OF ACTION WAY WE DID.
IT IS NOT. THAT THE SUPREME
COURT HAD THIS VERY ISSUE IN
GREAT DETAIL BEFORE THEM. THIS
BELT BILL MAY NOT BE THE PERFECT
SOLUTION BUT IT OFFERS A
CREATIVE TOOL NEVER USED OR
TESTED BEFORE. IN MY JUDGMENT.
WE HAVE A NUMBER. WHEN YOU. THAT
ARE THAT HAVE CERTAINLY. REDUCE
GUN VIOLENCE BY OVER 50% IN THE
LAST NUMBER OF YEARS EVERYTHING
THAT WE COULD POSSIBLY USE EVERY
TOOL WE CAN FIND IN THE TOOLBOX.
TO ME IS ANOTHER TOOL THAT WE
SHOULD TRY TO EMPLOY TO PREVENT
GUN VIOLENCE I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE FROM
DEMAND ACTION FOR GUN SENSE OF
CRYPTO LOPILATO I BELIEVE ON THE
LINE SHE'S HERE IN THE ROOM OR
NOT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO
VOTE. YOU ARE YOU MISS LOPILATO
MISSED. HAVE YOU HERE IN PERSON
SO ARE YOU SURE YOU'RE ONLY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT SO WILL FOR
YOU FOUR MINUTES IF YOU KNEW
THAT. THANK YOU. CRISTALLO
BLOTTO AND I'M A MOM LIVING IN
THE BAY AREA I'M A VOLUNTEER
LEADER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF MOMS DEMAND ACTION
FOR GUN SENSE. IN THAT ROLE I
CONNECT WITH GUN VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS PARENTS STUDENTS
COMMUNITY PARNERS AND PEOPLE
ALL AROUND THE STATE WHO WANT TO
SEE CALIFORNIA LEAVE. A GUN
VIOLENCE PREVENTION. I
PERSONALLY STARTED VOLUNTEERING
WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION BECAUSE
I WAS SICK OF FEELING HELPLESS
EVERY TIME MY SON IS IN THE
SCHOOL SHOOTING OR MASS
SHOOTING. AND EVERY TIME I
TALKED TO GRIEVING FRIENDS OR
FAMILIES WHOSE LOVED ONES HAVE
BEEN TAKEN BY GUN VIOLENCE.
THIRTY NO SITTING ON THE-
HUNDRED AND TEN PEOPLE ARE
KILLED BY GUNS AND TWICE AS MANY
ARE WOUNDED OF COURSE THOSE
NUMBERS DON'T EVEN BEGIN TO
CAPTURE THE ON GOING TRAUMA
EXPERIENCE I FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES IMPACTED GUN
VIOLENCE. WE KNOW AFFECTING SO
MANY WAYS I KNOW YOU'VE ALL SEEN
OR EXPERIENCED THE IMPACT OF GUN
VIOLENCE IN YOUR DISTRICTS ARE
RIGHT HERE FOR YOU BURKE AND
FELT THAT SINKING FEELING.
ANSWERS WE- AND BRING A NEW TOOL
IN THIS THE ABILITY OF
INDIVIDUALS TO BRING CIVIL SUITS
TO READ OUR COMMUNITIES OF A
GHOST ALL WEAPONS AND GHOST GUNS
GUN VIOLENCE IDENTITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA IN THE RIVER. THOMAS
WIDE AS WE- FAMILIES TORN. HERE
WE CAN'T SIT BACK AND HOPE THAT
THE PEOPLE BRINGING THESE
WEAPONS OF WAR INTO OUR STATE
WILL SUDDENLY CHOOSE TO STOP.
THIS BILL OPENS UP ANOTHER LANE
TO PROACTIVELY ENFORCE
PROHIBITIONS ON A LEGAL ASSAULT
WEAPONS AND GHOST GUNS BEFORE
THEY CAUSE INJURY DEATH OR
TRAUMA IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
FOCUSES ON GUN MANUFACTURERS
BROADER IMPACT AND DOES NOT
CREATE A PRIVATE CAUSE OF ACTION
AGAINST INDIVIDUALS MAY BE
PURCHASING OR ATTEMPTING TO
PURCHASE THESE WEAPONS.
FOURNETTE ALREADY DISTRIBUTE OR
IMPORT ASSAULT WEAPONS WE ALSO
ALREADY HAVE A LAW REGULATING
THE SALE OF FIREARMS PRECURSOR
PARTS THAT CAN GO INTO EFFECT IN
JULY IN THIS VERY COMMITTEE HAS
PASSED MANY SMART COMMONSENSE
POP PIECES OF GUN LEGISLATION
MANY OF WHICH RIGHTFULLY
RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR A
HOLISTIC APPROACH TO GUN
VIOLENCE PREVENTION. BUT EVEN
THOUGH WE HAVE A STRONG AS WE
NEED BOLDER ACTION AND NEW
APPROACHES TO TRULY AND THE
PROLIFERATION OF THESE WEAPONS
THIS BILL GIVES US ANOTHER WAY
TO BE SURE THAT THE INDIVIDUALS
IS WHO YOU TO BYE ARE BY BRING
THESE WEAPONS INTO OUR STE.
COUNTY I SB THIRTY SEVEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU NOW WE'LL SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER WITNESSES HERE
AND ROOM ONE TWELVE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN.
SEEN KNOWN RUSHING TO THE
MICROPHONE. ALL WE DO OKAY GOTTA
BE QUICK HERE. SLASH YOU GIVE
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION. EACH
POSITION ALEX NAVARRO MOMS
DEMAND ACTION FOR GUN SENSE IN
AMERICA AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL. I'M BACKING GREEN I LIVE IN
MARIN COUNTY AND I'M A VOLUNTEER
WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION AND I
ALSO SUPPORT. MARY LOU RECITAL
COMING FROM YOLO COUNTY I'M A
FORMER POLICE OFFICER. AND A GUN
OWNER AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
YOU SEEN NO ONE ELSE APPROACHING
THE MICROPHONE WILL GO TO OUR
MODERATOR NOW AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE TUITION
JUST. SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIRTY
TWENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE TWO SIX THREE THREE
PLEASE CALL HAVE. OH I'M SORRY I
THINK I'M PROBABLY. I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU. AFTER
HEARING FROM LONG WHEN THIS IN
SUPPORT NOW IT'S TIME FOR
OPPOSITION WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES LISTED. GRIFFITH
JUNIOR AND DANIEL REID I SOONER
NOT IN THE ROOM ARE THEY ON THE
PHONE LINE MODERATOR. I WONDER
OPEN. WE'LL GIVE YOU TWO MINUTES
EACH TO TESTICULAR IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR RICHARD
SHERMAN'S VOTERS FOR THE REGULAR
GROUP OF LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA LIFE WILL ALSO
PROTRUSION I'LL BE OUT OF OUR
MEMBERS TRUCK. CALIFORNIA TRONG
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN. THIRTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN SO BROADLY IT COULD
LITERALLY ANY PERSON BRING SO
ACTUALLY THE ARM INDUSTRY. ON
THE LAWFUL COMMERCE OF FARM GEN
THE BILL BILLING FARMS THERE'S
ANOTHER MISGUIDED BILL THAT
SEEKS TO SQUASH INDISCRIMINATE
AGAINST THE LIVES OF THOSE.
QUALCOMM.
THE OPERATORS FROM SOMETIMES IN
THE SAY GOODBYE ACCIDENT OR
MALICIOUS CRIMINAL INTENT YOU
MUST FOCUS OUR TIME AND
RESOURCES ON THOSE WHO CHOOSE
YEARS FARM COMMERCIAL CRIMES.
WILL OFFER HIM PROHIBITS FARMING
ARE SHOULD BE. PROTECT LAWS WILL
COME ACT MENU FOR NINETY FROM.
THE PHARMACY TO CLIMB. BACK WITH
BUT YOU SENATE CALLED FIVE-
LOCKER VICTIMS. PERSON IS USING
A FIRE WELL AND- DAMAGE ORANGE.
ORDERLY LOST PAGE RULING STATE.
HI BUILDING COMPOSED A LOT OF IN
HER INDUSTRY THE HARM BECAUSE BY
OTHERS HERE'S A LITTLE. IN A ROW
PUBLIC ON NATIONAL LOS THREATENS
DILUTE. ALL RIGHT TO LIBERTY IN
THIS AND STABLE OF OTHER.
ECONOMIC SUBSECTORS LAW GROUP
THE- ENTERPRISE UNITED STATES.
IN A CONSTITUTIONAL REASONABLE
BURDEN INTERSTATE AND FOREIGN
MINISTRY A LOT GOING TO MACHINES
OF THE THAT THE WILLING A FIVE
IS VERY SB THIRTEEN TWENTY SO
CLEAR DIRECT CONFLICT WITH
FEDERAL LAW THERE'S BEEN TRIED
AND- THE CLEARLY. THE OF. POSTED
SHALL OR THE LAW SHALL ABRIDGE
THE PRIVILEGES OR IMMUNITIES OF
CITIZENS UNITED STATES.
PASSWORDS IN UNFORTUNATE AND
WASTED TAX ALL IT WILL BE SHALL
IT WILL BE WERE. FARMS OR TOOL
YOU CANNOT HOLD ABOUT LARA. TO
YOU. WHAT NEXT FILING LOS
AGAINST FOR THE GENERAL MOTORS
WHEN IT IS DOES NOT THE WHEEL
AND TALKS INSTRUCTIONAL. OR
PURSUING SIMPLE RUN YOUR- ON THE
SIDE DIED THE SHALLOW AND
CLEARLY INDICATED NO THE IN A LA
OF. YOUR OPEN PANDA BOX. ARE
WITH WILL BOG AN ALREADY TAX
COURT IN WE- THAT THE SLUGGISH.
CURRENT GATHERING THERE TRYING
GENERAL WILLIAMS LAWS TO HE
HARDENED CRIMINALS OFF OUR
STREETS. THANK YOU FOR THE TOP.
OUR MANUFACTURERS RETAILERS AND
RANGES. AND THEY JUST WANTED. TO
DISCUSS MUCH OF THE TALK TODAY
FOR PROPONENTS STATES BASED ON
FALSEHOODS AND HOW HATCHER'S
USING THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
AND THAT HAVE TO SCORE POLITICAL
POINTS FOR GOVERNOR. ON A
PERSONAL CRUSADE FOR NATIONAL
PUBLIC. GUN CONTROL RIGHT.
MEDICATION AND FROM ELECTED WHO
ARE MISLEADING THE PUBLIC. WHAT
ATTENTION FROM THEIR FAILURE TO
EFFECTIVELY ENFORCE OUR NATION'S
GUN LAWS DEFINITIONS MATTER
KNOWS THOSE DEFINITIONS ARE
VAGUE AND POORLY RITTEN FAST
QUICK LIABILITY TOWARD ACTION
AGAINST MANUFACTURERS HAVE
UNIFORMLY INCORRECTLY BEEN
REJECTED BY THE COURTS FIREARMS
ARE LAWFUL PRODUCTS. MEANWHILE
FOR LATER MISS SUCH. IS ABSURD
MY WHOLE HOME BUYING.
INCENTIVIZING HOW ISSUED
NEIGHBORS UNDER THIS LOGIC YOU
MIGHT AS WELL OUT KRIS JENNER
ISSUE I NIGHT MANUFACTURE SO
THIS MANSON MURDERS IS THAT
SOMETHING MISTER. AS ONE
MENTIONED FEDERAL. IT'S VERY
CLEAR ON THAT AND THIS WITH BE
IN CONFLICT WITH IT HE'LL BE A
WAS PASSED WITH WIDE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE.
WHAT WAS PASSED IN RESPONSE TO A
WAVE OF LAWSUITS ATTEMPTING TO
HOLD FIREARM COMPANIES LIABLE
FOR CRIMINAL MISUSE OF FIREARMS
BY REMOTE THIRD PARTIES THE
LAWSUITS WERE REALLY AIMED AT
PUTTING THE COMPANY THAT IS
BASED ON CIRCUMSTANCES BEYOND
THEIR CONTROL. LAWYERS THE BOY
OF THEM MAY ON THE END FOR
CRIMINAL MISUSE OF LEGAL
FIREARMS THAT ARE AWFULLY SOLD
HOW DID WE GET HERE LAWSUITS FOR
PILING UP IN THE LATE NINETIES
AND EARLY TWO THOUSAND. IN
RESPONSE TO THAT WHO WAS THIRTY
THREE STATE. WHAT ABOUT LATER
LAW IN PLACE ADDITIONALLY ON.
ONWARDS CRASH BACCA AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL IT WAS A LOPSIDED
APPROACH IT PASSED THE HOUSE
200-832-1404 THE SAME HAPPEN
YOUR SENATE WHICH PASSED MEASURE
BUT KEEP UP ONE. DON'T YOU KNOW
WHO SENATE. IS SENATOR BILL
NELSON OR STANDARD HINGED NAY
YOU THEY ALL VOTED IN FAVOR OF
BLACK AT TIME. THIS TWERK ISN'T
UNIQUE TO THE FIRE INJURY MANY
MEDI DEVICE THE AIRLINE INDUSTRY
AND EVEN ONLINE AND CONTENT
PROVIDERS. FROM FOR THOSE
LAWSUITS WHEN PLANNING FOR IN
FOR. POSTED ON THEIR SITE BY
OTHERS COMES UP IRONICALLY
ADDITION MANY MEMBERS AS MANY
HAVE ARGUED FOR IN THE PAST.
ADDITIONALLY I'M GONNA GO OFF MY
HUSBAND IN LITTLE BIT THE
PREVIOUS BILL THAT CAME OUT I
WONDER THE MAN HE- YEAH. AS TO
MANAGING THE KEY TO ON YOU CAN
CALL. AND OPEN ON THIS ONE. YES
SHERMAN I'M ALL THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR APPLE THREE FINAL
WAS THE LAW BECAUSE YOU ANTI GUN
. FOR USING COURTS OF THE ANGER
. WAITED CIRCUMVENT THE LAW MAY
PROCESS. ARNIE WAS WHY OFFICIALS
AND AN NOW BACK A ENGINEERING IT
LOCKED THEIR CIRCUMVENT ALLEGE
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT AND WHAT
EXTRA CIVIL LIABILITY AND THERE
. COME BY THE TEAM FRAMERS COST
YOU. SOMETHING THIS BILL THE TEN
YOU WITH THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- GERMAN THANK YOU COMMITTEE
WE STRONGLY AGAINST THIS BILL
THANK YOU. NOW WE'RE COMING BACK
TO THE ROOM ONE TWELVE IS THERE
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION- S. B. THIRTY TWENTY.
HELLO I'M OSCAR SORIA AND AS A
REAL LIVE I JUST OPPOSE THIS
BILL IT'S A CRIMINAL PROBLEM NOT
A GUN LAW THANK YOU ANY OTHER
HELPS ANYONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM
WISHING TO SPEAK OUT AGAINST IT
HEARING TÍNH NINE NOW WE GO TO
OUR MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
CALLERS WISHING TO TESTIFY.
SEVEN THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
SPEAK OPPOSITION SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE TWO
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS GABRIELLE IS EMBEDDED
IT MIGHT OPEN THEIR ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THEIR THEM I OPPOSE ITSELF.
THANK YOU NINE ONE NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD HI MY NAME IS
JANET FELT AND I OPPOSED THIS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BILL. THANK YOU
RYAN TO NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ I APOLOGIZE I MISSED
THE SUPPORT I'M WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M TWO FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MY NAME IS CARLENE ELLIS AND I
AM A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION AND
I'M A COMPETITIVE SHOOTER AND A
MEMBER OF MANY OTHER GUN RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M TO SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DARREN BUT
WELL I AM A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND- NRA MEMBER-
TAKING TIME OUT OF MY BUSY WORK
DAY TO VOICE MY STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY. OKAY THANK YOU TO
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MY NAME IS MIKE ALIAS I AM A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
PISTOL ASSOCIATION AND THE
VENTURA COUNTY GUN OWNERS GROUP
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB ONE
THREE TWO SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU TWO EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HUME SENATORS RESIDENT
FATHER TO AND FROM NINE YEARS
AYE OPPOSED THIS BILL SB TWENTY
THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU
. YOU'RE GOING TO SIXTY THIRD
PLEASE CALL OUT- MY NAME IS RON
LANDER RETIRED MILITARY RETIRED
LA COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
AND CHAIRMAN- IS A CHAPTER OF
THE RPA ON BEHALF OF MY CHAPTER
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU
NINE ONE NINETY THREE FOR HER.
RESEARCHERS ESTIMATE GRANT ON
THE CHAIR OF THE- SOUTH ACROSS
AFTER THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
PISTOL SOCIALIZATION AND IN
ORDER MEMBER AND I'VE BEEN
WAITING ALMOST SEVEN HOURS TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN TO EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE TWO EIGHT
FIVE I'M SORRY I MISUNDERSTOOD
THE NUMBER MY NAME IS PAUL KATZ
I'M A RESIDENT OF VENTURA
COUNTY- FATHER OF THREE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M TO SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S
MELANIE HEAD BAND THE MOM OF
THREE A LIFETIME MEMBER OF THE
NRA MEMBERS C. R. PA AND AI AND
MACHINE INSTRUCTOR FOR FOUR
EIGHT AND BOY SCOUT THE CATCH
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
. YOU'RE GOING TO EIGHTY EIGHT
PRECOR HER. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
KATHY GRAHAM I'M ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION I
HAVE SEVENTEEN GRANDCHILDREN I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU RANGERS FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS PAT
HURDEN I AM A LIFE MEMBER OF THE
NRA MY LIFE MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION. I'M CHAIRMAN OF THE
TAMA COUNTY CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND RETIRED SURGEON
OPEN HOWEVER TROLL I AM CALLING
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO S. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
FOR LISTENING. THANK YOU I'M TWO
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS WHICH OPTIONS AND A ONE
OF OUR STRONG OPINION TO THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M TO
SEVENTY NINE PEOPLE HAVE. HI
THIS IS ERIN THRASH A MEMBER OF
THE RPA AND I'M STRONGLY AGAINST
THE BILL. THANK YOU RYAN TO
EIGHTY THREE CRITICAL HAS. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS DAVE TRONG- A
RETIRED MILITARY AND I AM
STRONGLY AGAINST SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN AND A NUMBER OF THE
RGA. THANK YOU RIGHT TO SIXTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS TERRY AND COBIA I AM A
RESPONSIBLE MEMBER OF THE NRA
INNING TAKING AND KERN ST
RESPONSIBLE CHILDREN I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL ONE THREE TWO
SEVEN. YOU'RE RIGHT TO NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JOHN HICKMAN I AM A AND R. A
LIFE MEMBER C. R. P. A LIFE
MEMBER AND THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
NEVADA COUNTY GUN OWNERS. ON
BEHALF OF MY CHAPTER AND THE
GOVERNING CITIZENS OF NEVADA
COUNTY WE STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL
THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU
. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS TERRY HUME- AND I
REMEMBER AS A MEMBER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN TO SEVENTY
SEVEN PRESCHOOL I HAD. HI MY
NAME IS MIKE CURRICULUM A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER IN IRVINE-
OPPOSED TO FEDERAL THIRTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN WE SHOULD BE
ENACTING LAWS SOLELY FOR THE
PURPOSE OF MAKING POLITICAL
STATEMENTS. THIS BILL WILL DO
NOTHING TO REDUCE FILE ACTED
IT'LL BE CHALLENGE OR A
SIGNIFICANT COST TO THE STATE.
THANK YOU. YOU'RE GOING TO
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
THINK THIS NOW THE HOMELAND AND
I OPPOSE SB. THIRTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU. YOU
AFTER HEARING FROM BOTH SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION WE NOW BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE SENATOR
WIENER. BY SENATOR WIENER ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND TODAY.
ZERO CHOI BOOK. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK M. I
HAD A QUESTION REGARDING THE USE
OUTLINED IN. THANK YOU IN THIS
COMMITTEE WE HAVE HAD MANY
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HOW ADDITIONAL
CIVIL PENALTIES DO NOT DETER
CRIME. I'M WONDERING. I AM
WONDERING HOW THIS BILL IS ANY
DIFFERENT TO THE VARIOUS OTHER
BILLS WE HAVE HEARD ADVOCATING
FOR ADDITIONAL PENALTIES. I
THINK THAT THE QUESTION A THOUGH
I HAVEN'T BEEN- IN THIS
COMMITTEE ON A DAILY BASIS OF
THE OIL AND HISTORY HERE THE
PENALTIES THAT WE TALK ABOUT OUR
GOVERNMENT PENALTIES IMPOSED
UPON. PEOPLE AND WHETHER OR NOT
THAT THOSE FEES AND FINES MAKES
SENSE THIS IS DIFFERENT. THIS IS
CIVIL PENALTY WHERE THE PERSON
IS WHO'S GOING AFTER THE
INDIVIDUAL AND CIVIL COURT CAN
GET A RECOVERY- BOTH ATTORNEYS
FEES AND TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER AND THAT WAS IT. THE PURPOSE
OF THIS MEASURE. OUR FORTY NINE
STATES DECIDES WITH
CONSTITUTIONAL YOU KNOW. THEY
DECIDE WHAT YOU'VE SEEN SO MANY
CASES IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS ACT
AND VARIOUS OTHER THINGS AND
WHAT THE SUPREME COURT SAYS
FINAL COSTS MAIN COURT. THE
SUPREME COURT MADE THE
DETERMINATION THAT THIS TYPE OF
PROCESS FOR CIVIL FOR PRIVATE
RIGHTS OF ACTION ARE
CONSTITUTIONAL. AND SO. IS IT.
TO SEE IF THIS OF THE CURRENT
WITH ALL THE LAWS THAT WE HAVE
IN CALIFORNIA IS A SUGGESTED WE
HAVE REDUCE GUN VIOLENCE BY 50%
IT'S STILL NOT ENOUGH SO EVERY
TOOL THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE IS
DETERMINED TO BE CONSTITUTIONAL
AND THIS MEANS THAT IF YOU'RE
GONNA TAKE MONEY OF THE BANK
ACCOUNT OF THE PERSON MAKING THE
ILLEGAL OUTDOOR CAESAR
AUTOMOBILE AT THEIR HOME MAYBE
LACKED IS DETERRENT IN THIS
PROCESS I DON'T KNOW BUT- SOME.
THIS BECAUSE EVERYTHING. FINE
AFFECTION STILL NOT ENOUGH.
THANK YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG- AND
ONE LAST QUESTION HOW LIKELY IS
A CRIMINAL WHO IMPORTS ILLEGAL
ASSAULT WEAPONS TO BE DETERRED
BY ADDITIONAL CIVIL PENALTIES
WHEN THEY AREN'T EVEN DETERRED
BY THE RISK OF GOING TO STATE
PRISON WELL THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION TO THE QUESTION IS WILL
THEY WANT TO WE DON'T KNOW THE
BOTTOM LINE IS TO NEUTRAL THE
TRUCK IT'S ONE THING TO THINK
ABOUT WELL I'M GONNA GO TO
PRISON ARE GOING TO PRESENT.
RELIGION YOUR CAR YOU HAVING TO
GO TO COURT YOU COULD THEY HAVE
A WHOLE HOST OF THINGS I DON'T
KNOW BUT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT YOU
KNOW WHAT I SHOWED YOU THAT
FIRST OF ALL ANDREAS THE
OPPOSITE DISTRICT ARE. PROVIDE
PEOPLE OF YOU KNOW THE FOLKS IN
THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL.
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO AN
ILLEGAL WEAPON. FOR THIS BILL
ONLY DEALS WITH ILLEGAL WEAPONS
POINT ONE. POINT TWO WE KNOW
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT 65%
OF ALL OF THESE A GHOST GUNS
FROM THE- TOBACCO FIREARMS
FOLKS. ARE HERE CALIFORNIA WE
KNOW OF THE BABBITT EPIDEMIC A
CHILDREN OAKLAND SAN FRANCISCO
AND LOS ANGELES. FOR THESE
PARTICULAR TYPES OF WEAPONS OR
IN FACT IS A CAUSAL CONNECTION
BETWEEN THEM AND CRIME. SO IF
YOU CAN TRY ANY NEW TOOL IN THE
SUPREME COURT TO ITS
INTERPRETATION OF THE LAW IN
THIS. DO THAT SHOULDN'T WE HAVE
A RESPONSIBILITY ASSIST ANYWAY
WE HAVE SUCH EXTRAORDINARY.
LET'S TRY EVERY HUNDRED SUN. AT
HIS BACK WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
IS IF SOMEBODY'S QUINCES LAW
PASSED THIS AND I HOPE IT DOES
IN THE GOVERNOR SIGNS IT.
CERTAINLY IT'S CLEAN HE. HIS
IDEA CAN STILL HIS IDEA JUST OF
. BUT THE POINT IS THAT. MAY IT
WORKS ARE. THERE'S GONNA BE
SOMEBODY'S GONNA TRY IT I
GUARANTEE IS GOING TO GET A LOT
OF ATTENTION AND WE'LL SEE WHAT
KIND OF CHILLING EFFECT IT HAS
ON FOLKS WHO ENGAGE IN USING
THESE WEAPONS. THE SENATOR
HERTZBERG BUSH COURSE OF COURSE
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION.
SKINNER THANKS SO MUCH AS CENTER
HERTZBERG I REALLY WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING US THIS BILL-
WE HAVE A LOT OF DIFFICULT
DISCUSSIONS IN THIS COMMITTEE
WHERE WE ARE VERY COMMONLY
TRYING TO. WE END UP.
CRIMINALIZING IN EFFECT THE- NOT
THE SOURCE SO WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT. IT'S JUST A LOT OF ISSUES
THAT WE KNOW FOR EXAMPLE IF WE
TAKE- OPIOID EPIDEMIC WE CAN
TURN TO PURDUE- THE PURDUE-
FIRST A COMPANY. AND THE VERY
AGGRESSIVE THE BOTH THE CREATION
OF A VERY STROKES AND VERY
AGGRESSIVE MRKETING OF THOSE
WHICH RESULTED IN MANY PEOPLE
BECOMING ADDICTED AND THEN WHEN
THEY COULDN'T GET THEIR
PRESCRIPTIONS PURSUING. TO HELP
FALLING INTO THESE- THESE
HORRIBLE TRAPS IN WITH GUN
VIOLENCE WE FIND A SIMILAR THING
WHERE WE FIND THIS AGGRESSIVE
MARKETING. BY NOT ONLY
MANUFACTURES ASSOCIATION OF THE
GUN MANUFACTURERS IN EFFECT
FINANCE. AND YET THEY'RE RARELY
EVER HOLD HELD RESPONSIBLE
THEMSELVES AND SO I APPRECIATE
THIS BILL BECAUSE REDUCE
BEGINNING TO HOLD THE VERY
SOURCE OF THE PROBLEM
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE PROBLEM. AND
AGAIN SUPPORTED APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR. SEEN NO
FURTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
HERTZBERG TALKED CLOSE I THINK I
ADDED THE ISSUES THAT I WANTED
TO ABOUT THE LAWFUL USE OF
WEAPONS AND THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING IS THAT THERE'S NO
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT. TO HAVE AN
EAGLE ILLEGAL WEAPON THIS IS
BEEN ILLEGAL IN CALIFORNIA SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE THERE'S NO
FOCUS ON GOING AFTER FOLKS
LAWFUL USE OF A WEAPON IT'S A
FIFTY CALIBER MACHINE GUN WHICH
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE GONNA
DO TO GO DEER HUNTING FACT. IS
THE SHOP THAT'S CLOSE ISRAEL
HEROES AND SUBSEQUENT AND BUY
BEER GOES AND- BERADA AND IT IS
A GHOST GUN THAT WE KNOW IS
THERE'S AN EPIDEMIC ABOUT SO
IT'S A VERY NARROW. SAID
APPLICATION IT DOESN'T DEAL WITH
PEOPLE'S CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS
BECAUSE THERE'S NO
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT FOR WHAT.
THAT. I THINK IT'S A THE IT IS A
- YOU OF THIS LAW AND I DO GIVE
GOVERNOR A DEAL OF. FOR HE WHAT
HE'S DONE AND YOU KNOW I SUSPECT
THAT WILL BE CHALLENGED AND THAT
GIVEN THE SUPREME COURT WEWENT.
WITH WITH THE LAWYERS FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND MY OFFICE-
WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME THINKING
THROUGH THIS IN A GREAT DETAIL
TO MAKE SURE. THAT IT WAS WITHIN
THE FRAMEWORK THAT WAS SET FORTH
BY THAT STATE'S SUPREME COURT IF
THEY WANNA DETERMINE.
CONSTITUTIONAL BUT RIGHT NOW
THIS IS THE LAW AND WE FEEL LIKE
WE'RE ON PRETTY SOLID GROUND AND
WE THINK THAT GIVEN THE
CHALLENGES WITH GUN VIOLENCE IT
IS A CRITICALLY IMPORTANT NEW
TOOL THAT THE GOVERNOR THINKS
AND I THINK WE SHOULD ADD TO OUR
LAWS IN CALIFORNIA THE STAFF AT
LEAST HAVE SOME DETRIMENT. TO
GUN VIOLENCE. AS FOR RIVAL
MISTREATMENT THANK YOU. SENATOR
A WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
WIENER WE HAVE A DO PASS.
COUNCIL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN. THE
PAST APPROPRIATIONS AND FOR OF
SENATE PROBE CIRCA EXCEL LINK.
THE WAIT MAYBE THIS. ELIZABETH
IT'S A TO APPROACH YEAH THE PAST
APPROPRIATIONS APPROPRIATIONS
AND THAT WAS MY FORMER STAFFERS
KNOW YOUR STAFF FOR. SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN BRADFORD. BRADFORD
I'D SHOW VOGUE NO JO'BURG NO COM
LONGER. SKINNER SKINNER AYE
WIENER WIENER I'D THAT MEASURE
HAS TO VOTE TO LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU SENATOR THANK YOU SENATOR
NOW WE HAVE SENATOR GLAZERS BEEN
WAITING PATIENTLY. HE'S PLANNING
SB FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU AT YOUR BRADFORD GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS- FOURTEEN SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL THAT WOULD REDUCE
BARRIERS TO RE ENTRY FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE RELEASED SAN
. WE CONVICTED. THE BILL ONLY
APPLIES TO THOSE WHO WERE FOUND
BY THE STATE TO BE INNOCENT OF
THE CRIMES FOR WHICH THEY WERE
IMPRISONED. WOULD ENTITLE THEM
TO A CERTIFICATE OF INNOCENCE
DOCUMENTING THERE IS THE
FINDINGS OF THEIR INNOCENCE.
WRONGFULLY CONVICTED INDIVIDUALS
FACE MANY BARRIERS REBUILDING
THEIR LIVES FOLLOWING A FINDING
OF FACTUAL INNOCENCE. FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN THEY APPLY FOR A
JOB OR HOUSING PROSPECTIVE
EMPLOYERS AND LANDLORDS. I CAN
LEARN ABOUT THEIR CONVICTION AND
INCARCERATION BY REVIEWING
COMMERCIAL BACKGROUND CHECKS.
ONLINE RESEARCHER EVEN
EMPLOYMENT OR RENTAL HISTORIES.
BUT THOSE SOURCES TYPICALLY DO
NOT LATER AND DAUGHTER
REDUCTIONS. OR FINANCED BY THE
STATE OF FACTUAL INNOCENCE AS A
RESULT EMPLOYERS OR LANDLORDS
HAVE NO REASON TO BELIEVE THAT
THE APPLICANTS WERE EXONERATED
AND FOUND INNOCENT. AND
INDIVIDUALS HAVE NO SIMPLE WAY
TO PROVE OTHERWISE. SB FOURTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT WOULD PROVIDE
INDIVIDUALS FOUND TO HAVE BEEN
FACTUALLY INNOCENT A CERTIFICATE
OF INNOCENCE. THAT THEY CAN
PROVIDE TO THEIR EMPLOYERS OR
LANDLORDS THAT INDICATE ONE THE
DATE OF THE CONVICTION AND ITS
REVERSAL. TO THE DURATION OF THE
INCARCERATION AND POST RELEASE
RESTRICTIONS RELATING TO THE
WRONGFUL CONVICTIONS AND THREE A
STATEMENT THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS FOUND- FAT IN. OF
THAT CRIME. REMOVING THESE
ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES WILL HELP
THESE INDIVIDUALS. SIDE WITH
MORE THE BILL HELP LOWER
RECIDIVISM LEVELS AND CREATE A
PATH FOR THOSE WHO WERE FOUND
INNOCENT TO RE ENTER INTO
SOCIETY I'D LIKE INTRODUCED A
JOHN HELD IN. IN THE FROM AFTER
IN. SATISFIED OF THE BUILDING
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
I'VE OF. ARE YOU SEE WALDRON-
HERE SHOW WILL GIVE YOU FOUR
MINUTES OF YOUR THE SOUL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'M JOHN ALLEN
FOUNDER OF AFTER IN A SENSE- CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL ALONG WITH
CALIFORNIA SAYS- WE ARE IN
OAKLAND BASED NONPROFIT THAT
PROVIDES. ASSISTANCE A- WE'RE
BACK IN. AND IMPRISONED FOR
CRIMES THEY DID NOT COMMIT WE'VE
REACHED MORE THAN SEVENTY
EXONERATION CALIFORNIA AND
GROWING AND MORE THAN EIGHT
HUNDRED NATIONALLY WITH SKILL
HELP WITH INCREASING ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE SOCIAL SERVICES AND
LEGAL SERVICES. WE WANT TO THANK
CENTER GLAZER- FOR CHAMPIONING
THIS CAUSE AND PREVIOUS CAUSES
AND CURRENT CAUSES FOR
EXONERATION CALIFORNIA AND
KEEPING CALIFORNIA- AHEAD OF THE
PACK OF OTHER STATES AND HOW WE-
FACE UP TO THE CONSEQUENCES OF.
WRONGFUL CONVICTION- IT DAILY
CONVERSATIONS EXONERATES I HEAR
ABOUT MANY OF THE BARRIERS THEY
FACE IN REBUILDING THEIR LIVES
AND- WHEN WE WORK WITH US ON OUR
TIME WE SPEAK ABOUT POST RELEASE
ASSISTANCE WE'RE TALKING MANY
MANY. STAFF RELEASE WE JUST WITH
THE TYPICAL REENTRY FOR WORK.
I'M TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE WHO'VE
BEEN OUT FOR TEN FIFTEEN YEARS
AND THEY TOLD. ABOUT OF CURTIS
THE DEEP. OF BEING SEEN AS TOLD
WERE WRONGFULLY CONVICTED AND
THIS BILL AGAIN WOULD FOCUS ONLY
P. OR OR FROM VICTIMS COMP IS
PART. AND IT WOULD PROVIDE THEM
THE CERTIFICATE OF INNOCENCE
THAT SUMMER GLAZER MENTIONED AND
IT WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THAT THE
RAPSHEETS BE ANNOTATED. TO
SIMPLY REFLECT THE ULTIMATE
DISPOSITION OF THE CASE THAT
THEY WERE FOUND INNOCENT I
CURRENTLY THAT DOES NOT HAPPEN
AND SO IN ADDITION TO THE DEBT
THE DIFFICULTY IN TELLING THEIR
STORY- THAT WOULD BE IN SOME
PART REMEDY BOX AND- ONE. SERVED
IT AND BY THE WAY WALKING IN
WITH AN ORDER FROM THE VICTIM'S
COMPENSATION BORDER ACCORD OF
MANY PAGES THIS IS NOT THE SAME-
THIS WOULD REALLY BE- GREAT STEP
FORWARD. BUT IN ADDITION TO
THAT- THE RAPSHEETS AT THE DOJ
LEVEL. I WILL BECAUSE THEY DRAW
FROM THE STATE RAPSHEETS I WILL
BE ANNOTATED TO- AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE REFLECT WHAT ACTUALLY
OCCURRED. SO AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR. CONSIDERING THIS BILL AND
I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY.
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY HELP. OKAY ARE DO WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES HERE IN A ROOM-
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF THIS MEASURE STAGE NAME YOUR
MUSIC. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
SENATORS MY NAME IS ANTHONY
DIMARTINO ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AFTERNOON
MATTHEW GALLAGHER CAL VOICES
PROUD CO SPONSOR VIRGIN I BOTH
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHTS SENATOR
SKINNER. AT THE COLON AND PHONE
LINES AND ALSO WHETHER THERE'S
OPPOSITION BUT I HAVE TO RUN
OVER PERCENT ANOTHER BILL AND I
JUST WANTED- THE SENATE. BRING
IN THIS BILL THANK AFTER
INNOCENCE FOR THEIR GOOD WORK.
AND I WILL BE PRESENTING A BILL
LATER THAT WILL HELP OUR X.
HONOREES. GET THE APPROPRIATE
FINANCIAL COMPENSATION FROM THE
VICTIM'S COMPENSATION FOR IT SO
I THINK THESE EFFORTS ALONG WITH
OTHER EFFORTS THAT. SUPPORTED
ADVOCACY GROUPS HAVE BEEN
ENGAGED IN WILL REALLY HELP TO
PUT RIGHT. THIS SITUATION OF
PEOPLE BEING- RESPOND SOMEONE IS
WRONGFULLY CONVICTED SO I
SUPPORT THE BILL ARCHITECT OUT
ON. A NEED TO RUN TO COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU. I WILL GO TO OUR
PHONE LINES INTO YOUR THURSDAY
INDIVIDUALS INTERESTED IN SIR-
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT MODERATOR PLEASE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU. WILL MOVE NOW TO
OPPOSITION. WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION ON FILE IS OR ANYONE
PRESENT HERE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITIN.
OF FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT. SHE
KNOWN HER INTO THE MICROPHONE
WE'LL GO TO OUR PHONE LINES.
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE IN Q.
DESIRES OF SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION OF FOURTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE BEN BIRO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU.
BREYER ARE RIGHT WILL BRING YOU
TO THIS ROOM IS THERE ANYONE
HERE PRESIDENT ON ONE TWELVE NO
WE ARE DONE WITH. YOU MAY NOW IS
THERE ANY QUESTIONS. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR WIENER ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS QUESTIONS
HEARING CHAIN NINE SENATOR WENT-
GLAZER WHICH I'D LIKE TO CLOSE.
IRAN'S HUMAN. FEDERATION
RESPECTFULLY ASTRONAUT. YOU WE
HAVE A TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COUNCIL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
SB FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT. SB
FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE CHOI BOGUE I SHOBO
GUY COME LONGER SKINNER WIENER.
WHEN I ARRIVED MEASURE HAS THREE
VOTES WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU. CENTER
WINNER. THINK YOU'RE UP BACKED.
WITH OVER TWELVE OF TWENTY. FOR
TWENTY EIGHT. OKAY SO THAT
REFLECT. WE'RE GONNA BE DOING SB
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT THANKS IN A
WINNER THANK YOU ARE JIM
BRADFORD- ONE THING YOU'RE GOING
THIS- ARE TODAY I AM PRESENTING
SENATE BILL TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT
ARE WHICH WILL PROTECT OUR TERMS
AND THEIR PRIVACY BY
PROHIBITING. D. A. PROFILES FROM
BEING USED FOR ANY PURPOSE OTHER
THAN IT BEING AN INVESTIGATION
ACROSS THE CENTER OF THE ANSWER
AND WHICH RESULTED. I CURRENTLY
- SEARCH ASSAULT SURVIVOR- YOU
CAN IF THEY CHOOSE- SUBMIT A
SEXUAL ASSAULT EXAMINATION- IN
ORDER TO COLLECT AS EVIDENCE
INCLUDING DNA EVIDENCE I MAY
HELP IDENTIFY. THE PERPETRATOR
THIS IS AN EX VERY EXTREMELY
INVASIVE EXAMINATION- IF YOU
IMAGINE A SEXUAL ASSAULT
SURVIVOR I JUST HAVING UNDERGONE
ONE OF THE MOST DRAMATIC
EXPERIENCES AMASSED LOS ANGELES
ALL. HAVE YOU THE KERR FORWARD.
AND THEN GO COMING BY ACTUALLY
GOING TO THE HOSPITAL AND
UNDERGOING AN INTENSELY INVADE.
OUR OUR NATION TO COLLECT DNA-
IT'S NOT SURPRISING THAT MANY
SURVIVORS DO NOT COME FORWARD
BECAUSE OF THE BARRIERS INVOLVED
AND MANY DO COME FORWARD I DO
NOT A CEMEX. IMITATION BECAUSE
FOR SOME PEOPLE IT CAN BE RE
TRAUMATIZING- FEDERAL LAW WHEN A
VICTIM PROVIDES DNA THE FEDERAL
DATABASE- DOES NOT ALLOW FOR THE
IDEA NAY IN THE FUTURE BE USED
FOR OTHER PURPOSES DNA'S USED TO
HELP IDENTIFY- THE ATTACK- IT
WILL NOT BE USED FOR OTHER
PURPOSES. UNFORTUNATELY WE
EARLIER THIS- THAT- THE SAN
FRANCISCO POLICE DEPARTMENT HAD
A LOCAL DATABASE CONTAINING DNA
FROM SEXUAL ASSAULT SURVIVORS-
AND OTHER VICTIMS. AND WE'RE YOU
. JANET TO IDENTIFY PERPETRATORS
IN FUTURE CRIMES SO IN OTHER
WORDS SOMEONE SEXUALLY ASSAULTED
GOES TO THE HOSPITAL TO PROVIDE
A DNA SAM- AND IT GOES INTO A
DATABASE HOLDING ON TO THAT
DATABASE. AND THEN THAT DNA BE
USED TO IMPLICATE THE SEXUAL
ASSAULT SURVIVOR FOR A FUTURE ON
RELATED OFFENSE AND IF YOU'RE-
WHEN THAT HAPPENED WE ALL SAID
WHAT I CAN'T POSSIBLY. BE LEGAL
BECAUSE THE LAST THING WE WOULD
WANT TO DO IS CONVEYED A SEXUAL
ASSAULT SURVIVORS BUT IF YOU
HAVE THE COURAGE TO COME FORWARD
AND TO GO TO THE HOSPITAL AND
PROVIDE A DNA SAMPLE- THE LAST
THING WE WANT TO CONVEY TO THEM
IS THAT DOING THAT MIGHT GET YOU
IN. WELL IN THE FUTURE. YOUR
FUTURE. PROBLEM WE TOOK LOOK AT
STATE LAW WE REALIZED THAT IT
WAS- ALTHOUGH I THINK THAT IT
IS. LIKELY THAT A GOOD ARGUMENT
THAT IT'S UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND
TO THE RIGHT TO PRIVACY- THERE
WAS NOTHING IN STATE CO. OP
PROHIBITING IT. AND SO AS A
RESULT WE INTRODUCE THIS BILL-
WORKING WITH OUR DISTRICT
ATTORNEY FROM WHO ARE YOU WILL
HERE SHORTLY AND WITH ADVOCATES
- TO MAKE IT ILLEGAL AND WHAT
THE BILL PROVIDES IT'S QUITE
SIMPLE. ON THE IF YOU A CAN
PROVIDE. A SAMPLE ON BAG DNA
CANNOT BE RETAINED AND THEN USED
FOR PURPOSES UNRELATED TO
IDENTIFYING- YOUR ATTACKER. OUR
THIS IS. OUR LEGISLATURE THAT
HONESTLY SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN THE
CODE FOREVER- BUT WE DID NOT
REALIZE THAT THIS WAS AN ISSUE
NOW THAT WE DO.
IT SAYS TESTIFYING IN PERSON IS
SAN FRANCISCO DISTRICT ATTORNEY
TO SUBMIT IN WHOSE OFFICE-
DISCOVERED THIS PROBLEM AND MADE
PUBLIC AND I WANT TO THANK FOR
DOING THAT- AND THEN IN
ADDITION- ELSE- CONNECTS- THE-
POLICY AND ADVOCACY AT THE
JOYFUL HEART. FOUNDATION THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
CHAIR BRADFORD AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION TO THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER
FOR INVITING ME TODAY THANK YOU
SIR WE AND ASSEMBLY. FOR SERVING
AUTHOR AND CO AUTHOR OF THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. I'M HONORED TO
SPEAK COSPONSORED SB TWELVE
TWENTY EIGHT TO PROTECT AND
SUPPORT. SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL. SB
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT STEMS FROM
MY OFFICES DISCOVERY THAT THE
SAN FRANCISCO POLICE DEPARTMENT
CRIME LAB WAS SYSTEMATICALLY
RETAINING DNA COLLECTED FROM
SEXUAL ASSAULT SURVIVORS IN ITS
QUALITY ASSURANCE DATABASE AND
LATER SEARCHING THE DATABASE-
INCRIMINATE. I AM. SINCE CAN
THAT INCLUDES COLLECTED FROM
CHILD VICTIMS. THIS PRACTICE IS
UNETHICAL AND VIOLATES SURVIVORS
PRIVACY RIGHTS IT ALSO THREATENS
PUBLIC SAFETY BY TREATING
VICTIMS LIKE CRIMINALS IT
DISSUADE SURVIVORS COMING
FORWARD TO REPORT SEXUAL
ASSAULTS WHICH ARE ALREADY
SIGNIFICANTLY UNDER REPORTED
THAT MAKES ALL OF US LESS SAFE.
I EXPOSE THIS THIS AND CALLED
FOR AT LEAST. SB TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT DOES THAT IT WOULD
PROHIBIT THE RETENTION OF DNA
PROFILES OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
SURVIVORS IN ANY DATABASE THAT
COULD BE SEARCHED FOR REASONS
UNRELATED TO THE SPECIALIST.
BUILDERS NOT LIMIT THE DNA TO
INVESTIGATE SEXUAL ASSAULT
CRIMES SB TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT
ALLOWS DNA EVIDENCE TO BE USED
IN THE INVESTIGATION OF THE
UNDERLYING SEXUAL ASSAULT CASE-
NOT RESTRICT THE USE OF THE
SUSPECTED PERPETRATORS DNA. SO
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENTS CAN STILL
CONNECT DIFFERENT SEXUAL ASSAULT
CASES. SB TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT
WILL PROTECT THE PRIVACY AND
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS OF
SURVIVORS AND WILL PROMOTE
PUBLIC SAFETY BY ENCOURAGING
SURVIVORS TO REPORT SEXUAL
VIOLENCE. THE MISUSE OF
SURVIVORS DNA UNDERMINES PUBLIC
TRUST VIOLATES VICTIM PRIVACY
AND THE TERMS OF SURVIVORS FROM
COMING FORWARD MY OFFICE STAND
WITH HER AND WILL CONTINUE TO
FIGHT TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS IN
EVERY WAY WE CAN. BEST TWO DATE
IS CRITICAL PUBLIC SAFETY AND
THE SUPPORTING ACTUAL ASSAULT
SURVIVORS. FOR THESE REASONS. I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT AND I'M PROUD
TO CO SPONSOR TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT I ORDER I VOTE TO PROTECT
SURVIVORS RIGHTS THANK YOU. JUST
ASK THAT YOU STATE YOUR NAME MY
WE KNOW YOUR BUT I DON'T BELIEVE
YOU GAVE IN YOUR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU CHAIR BRADFORD J.
SABINE SAN FRANCISCO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY CO SPONSOR OF TWELVE
TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU X. WITH
THIS. OUR OTHER MEMBERS. HELLO
EVERYBODY HEAR ME. YES HELLO YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU I HAVE GONE OUT
MONIES MATTEO CELLO- THE- POLICY
INVITATION ASSOCIATES DR
AUGMENTATION I'LL BE TESTIFYING
PLACE OF ALSO CONNECT- POLICY
DIRECTOR- TRIPLE PATIENT STANDS
STRONG SUPPORTER SENATE ONE TWO
TWO EIGHT DID YOU KNOW PRIVACY
FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT VICTIMS WE
WANT TO AN EARLIER HAND IT. I
TOOK A HEART WE BEEN WORKING
REALLY TO DECADE TO AND THEN IT
BACK AND CREATE A MORE SURVIVE
CENTER. AND FROM IMPORTANT JUST
SYSTEM BY DOING THIS WE LOOK TO
ENSURE THAT SOME FEEL SAFER. AND
WORKING WITH BHANSALI'S AND
PROSECUTORS THE CASE. FOR MANY
REASONS MOST VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
VIOLENCE TO NOT REPORT THEIR
ASSAULTS A LOT. ADD TO THIS VERY
FEW RATE ASSESSMENT DAY IN
PRISON. I WAS OF THE THEIR OWN
PATH AFTER. WITH A WHETHER THEY
WANTED TO LONG. OR NOT BUT
MAKING HARD FOR THOSE WHO SHOULD
REPORTING HAS. PUBLIC SAFETY
BROWN'S. IF I WOULD THAT MAKE IT
DID TO SEE UNDER AN INVASIVE AND
MANY TIMES WE TRAUMATIZED SEXUAL
ASSAULT EXAMINATION SHOULD NOT
BE TREATED AS CRIMINALS WE
SHOULD ENCOURAGE THE SURVIVORS
TO COME FORWARD AND NOT CREATE
BARRIERS TO REPORTING CRIMES
MUST MAKE SURE. RIGHT TO PRIVACY
IS RESPECTED. THE CARD REACHED
OUT TO ORGANIZATION AND TOLD
THAT THE CASE THAT OCCURRED HERE
IN SAN FRANCISCO IT MADE THEM
ANGRY AND WORRIED. OUR COUNTY
CLOTHES CENTER WIENER FIRST
SWIFTLY INTRODUCED. SOLUTION
THAT SIGNALS ABOUT HELP. THAT
THEY MATTER AND WHAT HAPPENED TO
THEM MATTERS DIGITAL HOPE WE GET
TO I WAS TRUST ANIMALS THE
BARRIER REPORTING SPECIAL SAUCE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU NOW WILL MOVE TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE A WITH THIS IS IN SUPPORT
PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION. ENTITLEMENTS ARE
THE PROSECUTORS OF LINES OF
CALIFORNIA PROUD SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ANTHONY
DIMARTINO ON BEHALF OF CRIME
SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE
IS STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ELEVEN GOING BACK AS
FOR ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. SEE NO OTHER WITNESSES
STANDING IN LINE WE WILL NOW GO
TO OUR MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE. WISHIN IS
SPEAKING REPORT OF SB TWELVE
TWENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. OVER
TWENTY TWO NINETY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BE SURE FOR ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU CAN
NOW WILL MOVED OPPOSITION
THERE'S NO FORMAL OPPOSITION
LISTED ON THIS BILL IS OR ANYONE
HERE IN ROOM TWO ONE TWELVE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
OF TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT. HEARING
SEEN NONE WE'LL GO NOW TO OUR
PHONE LINES MODERATE OR DO WE
HAVE ANYONE IN Q. WHICH- IN
OPPOSITION TO TWELVE TWENTY A-
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO ASK B. TWELVE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. WE'LL BRING YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
OR CONCERNS AS RELATES TO THIS
ISSUE. ROOSTING. NINE SENATOR
WINNER WHICH ARE CLOSE RESPECT
LAST FOREVER DO WE HAVE A MOTION
. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR COM
LONGER WE HAVE A DEEP PASSER.
ALSO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
INDUSTRY TWELVE TWENTY. SB
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT BRADFORD R.
REDFORD I'D SHOW BOTH. ROBO GUY
COME LONGER I'M A MUGGER AYE
SKINNER WIENER. WIENER I'M-
THREE VOTES IT'S OUT WILL BE THE
ROLO ON. OF F. FOR BOTH HOW
MEASURE HAS FOUR VOTES WILL BE
THE ROLE OPEN I'M ONE OF YOU
MISTER COUNTY. AND NOW WE HAVE
YOUR NEXT BILL- EIGHT THREE FOUR
YES I THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN- THE
SENATE BILL EIGHT THIRTY FOUR IS
THE KNOW EXEMPTION FOR
INSURRECTION ACTS. SB THIRTY
FOUR WILL CLARIFY AND CONFIRM
THE FRANCHISE TAX. THREE VOTE
TWENTY SIX M. STATUS OF A NOT.
ORGANIZATION IF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL DETERMINES OF THE
NONPROFIT IS ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN
OR INSIDE AT THE COMMISSION OF
VARIOUS SERIOUS CRIMES
SPECIFICALLY- INSURRECTION
AGAINST THE GOVERNMENT I TREAT
RESULT FIRST. CONSPIRACY WE WILL
BE- AMENDING THE BILL- RIGHT THE
CLASS. WITH A FRACTURED TAX
BOARD IT'S VERY GENERAL ARE WE
BELIEVE IN THE CAUSE LAW HAVE IS
ALREADY- BUT WE BELIEVE THAT
IT'S AN- TO MAKE A VERY EXPLICIT
AND SO- COLOR ARE. CALIFORNIA I
GRAN TAXES. I TO NUMBER OF SIR A
PUBLIC- UNFORTUNATELY TRAGICALLY
WE SAW WITH JANUARY'S AND ON
JANUARY SIX OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE- AN EFFORT TO OVERTHROW THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT IN
ACTION. I AM NOT THAT'S THAT
WERE INVOLVED. IN EITHER
DIRECTLY OR INCITING- THAT
INSTRUCTION- AND THESE
NONPROFITS AND NONPROFITS
INVOLVED IN SIMILAR- BEHAVIOR.
I'M. READ THERE IS A THING CAL-
THERE FOR DONATIONS OF ARE SIX-
THAT IS ON X. AND IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR CAL CALIFORNIA TO BE CLEAR-
THAT OF A WILL NOT RISK-
EXEMPTIONS. VERY VERY CLOSE.
WITH TO THE FOREMOST. REGIONAL
EXPERTS IN THE COUNTRY PRESS
SOLARI TRIBE- AT HARVARD LAW
SCHOOL. AND DEAN ERWIN
CHEMERINSKY- BERKELEY COLLEGE OF
LAW- TO MAKE THE BILL VERY
FOCUSED AND NARROW AND TARGETED
AND CONSTITUTIONAL. THE LETTERS
- TO THE CONSTITUTIONALITY OF
THE BILL TIME WILL CONTINUE TO
OF COURSE WORK WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL- FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TO
MAKE SURE CAN BE WHAT. I
IMPLEMENTED OUR COLLEAGUES OUR
DEMOCRACY THE- IS AT RISK WHAT
HAPPENED ON JANUARY SECOND
ALTHOUGH I WISH. WE COULD SAY
WHICH IS A COMPLETELY UNIQUE A
SEPARATE SITUATION AS THE CHOICE
NINE OF A VERY VERY TOLD. FOR TO
OVERTURN. OUR DEMOCRACY I AND-
THERE I AM SERIOUS CONCERNED AS
OUR MEN. THAT IT COULD HAPPEN
AGAIN- AND WE SHOULDN'T ANTI
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS SHOULD NOT.
BE SUBSIDIZING ORGANIZATIONS-
THAT ENGAGE IN OUR INSIGHT-
INSURRECTION AGAINST OUR
GOVERNMENT STOCKWELL'S FOR AN
AYE VOTE- WITH ME- TODAY
TESTIFIED I BELIEVE BOTH BY
PHONE A LOT ABOUT. HOW
CALIFORNIA AND THE BAY. STRONG
IMATION MAKE. REFER FIVE. PRIME
BUSINESSES TO MANAGE SHOW
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY YOU MAY BE
. HELLO THIS IS A LARGE BASKET I
THANK THE SENATOR WIENER FOR THE
CHANCE TO TESTIFY I'M HERE THE
OF. CALIFORNIA STRONG.
COLLISIONAL EASY ELECT LOCAL
INTO THE GROUPS OVER EIGHTY
THOUSAND ARE TOLD INCOME ARE
INDIVISIBLE GROUPS FORMED ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AFTER THE TWENTY
FIFTEEN TO OPPOSE THE RADICAL
TRUMPETED VERSION WITH BEST
PRACTICE DANGEROUS APPROACH TO
ORDERING SYSTEM. RIGHT DON'T
FIRST. BOTH AND PRO DEMOCRACY
POLICY. I SUPPORT OVER THE ARE
ALREADY ILLEGAL BUT ALSO IT IS
OF COURSE THE OPPOSITE OF TERROR
SACRAMENTO THAT- BASED THE ABOUT
THE NUMBER OF RESULT TWENTY A
LOT ALTHOUGH SB THIRTY FOUR DOES
IS REINFORCE JUSTIFIED. TO GEN.
I CONCORD WILL BE A MOCKERY OF
OUR AND A LOT GENERAL LAWS ARE
NOT SELDOM IT TAKES ACTUAL
LIVING PEOPLE OF ALL THEM AND
THE CASE AT HAND WITH A THIRTY
FOUR CAL TRAINING TRACK OR OKAY
. THIS IS YOUR STEP. JANUARY
THIRD. RIGHT YOUR ANGER FROM THE
IS FOR THE ANSWER WOULD MEAN OF
HIS WITH THE POTENTIALLY
UPPERCUT BUT HIS WHAT
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA'S STRONG
THEM I HOPE ON SB. EIGHT THIRTY
FOUR. NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU
CHAIR BRADFORD GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IT CAN OF COURSE I AND I AM
THE DIRECTOR QUALITY FOR ADL'S
WESTERN DIVISION I THANK SENATOR
WE ARE AND A COMMITTEE FOR AND
BY NOW BY OR S. B. PEOPLE. IN
NINETEEN VERY OKAY. INDIA RIGHT
RIGHT EIGHT. STOPPING THAT OF
THE JEWISH PEOPLE ENCOURAGE
EMPIRICAL FOR ALL KEEPING WITH
OUR MISSION EIGHT HAS PART AND
CONTRACT AND EXTREMELY THREAT
ACROSS THE SPECTRUM IN THE WAKE
OF JANUARY. I MEAN YOU.
CHARITABLE NONPROFIT MEDIA OF
USING THEIR TAX EXEMPT STATUS
COULD FURTHER EITHER VIOLENT OR
HATEFUL JEFF. HERE OR UNDER
TOPIC AND ALSO WROTE A LETTER TO
THE IRS EXPRESS ARGUED AND
INDICATED NO REPORT AFTER
CURSORY INVESTIGATION WE
UNCOVERED EVIDENCE THAT ARE. HE
IN ORDER TO ACT THAT'S YEAH IN
THE FIRST AND ENGAGING IN SELF
DEALING BY. SALARY AND OR A
BURNING PUNCH A RICH AND FAMILY
MEMBER THEY THE TAXI DOWN ENTITY
WELL. YES THAT IS ALLOW TO RAISE
MONEY OR FIND. WHILE AVOIDING
STATE AND BETTER INCOME AND
UNEMPLOYMENT HAVE. THANK YOU FOR
THE ORGANIZATION CAN FIGHT
PROPERTY TAX. THE INCOME. FAILED
AND EMPLOYMENT AFTER WELL BUT
PER MOST IMPORTANTLY
CONTRIBUTION THE FIVE POINT
ORGAN GEN OUR ALWAYS HAPPY I GOT
THE BALL FROM DONORS ME BUTTE.
AND ARE MADE IN. TWENTY THREE.
AND YEAH BE DONE TO ENSURE NEXT
GROUP YOU KNOW ABUSE I THINK
THAT STATIC HELP OR ANY ELSE
SENATOR WE SB EIGHT THIRTY IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN THE DIRECTION
IF AND THE MESSAGE OR THANK YOU
. OUR DEMOCRACY SHOULD NOT BE
PERMITTED OPERATE HOW. WE'RE PER
. WE ARE YOU FOR SB THIRTY FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY NOW WILL MOVE
BACK TO ROOM ONE TWELVES OR
ANYONE HERE WHICH IS TESTIFIED
IN SUPPORT. OF IT B. EIGHT THREE
FOUR. NINETY NINE MODERATOR WILL
BOTH GO TO THE PHONE LINES DOWN
. AND SEE IF THERE'S ONE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT THREE FOUR PLEASE
CALL ONE EIGHT ZERO AT THIS TIME. I DO HAVE ONE IN Q. I DO HAVE
A COUPLE IN HERE LET'S SEE ONE
MOMENT HERE. ONE FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FIVE SIX.
NINE THREE HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO HI MY NAME WHICH IS
ME AND WE URGE STRONG SUPPORT
FOR SB EIGHT THIRTY FOUR THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU
SENATOR WIENER FOR BRINGING THIS
TO OUR ATTENTION THANK YOU FOR
THIS. YOU'RE RIGHT THREE ALL
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
REBECCA ELLIOT CALLING FOR
INDIVISIBLE SAN JOSE AND WE'RE
PART OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
STRONG COALITION AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I TWO HUNDRED PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
DEBORAH GARVIE A PHD IN SAN JOSE
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OFSB
THIRTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT NOW WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO OFFICIAL
OPPOSITION LISTEN ON THESE
MEASURES OR ANYONE HERE IN THE-
ROOM ONE TWELVE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION S. B. IT
FOR. ALL RIGHT HEARING THE SCENE
DON'T WANNA WILL GO NOW TO OUR
PHONE LINES MODERATOR. DO WE
HAVE ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION A. S. B. EIGHT
THREE FOUR. THANK YOU EVERYONE
SHOULD SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
ASK THE EIGHT THREE FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT A TIME.
WELL TRY WHY FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHY ONE NINETY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JEFF
PHELPS SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU SIX WITNESS THANK YOU I HAVE
ONE MORE THANK YOU GOING TO
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT NOW THE HOLDEN AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY
THREE OH SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE ZERO SIX. NINE THREE OH
TWO SO I HAD. I I'M FOUNDER YEAH
SACRAMENTO COUNTY FROM. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU. GREAT THANK YOU WERE
BACK COMMITTEE NOW ARE THERE ANY
COMMENTS QUESTIONS ON FOR DINNER
WINNER GARCES MEASURE. SENATOR
JOE VOTE SO I RESTARTED TRY IT
WAS TRYING TO FIND SOME EXAMPLES
OF THE NONPROFIT STATE YOU THE
REFERENCE HERE AFFECTING DO YOU
HAVE ANY IN PARTICULAR IN MIND.
WE ARE. WITH MY- I THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION I YOU KNOW I EVEN
THOUGH THERE ARE CERTAINLY
NONPROFITS ISSUE DOESN'T TAKE.
EATING OF PRESS REPORTS THE
NUMBER THEY ARE I'M NOT TO ME
IT'S NOT ABOUT WERE TARGETING TO
SURVIVE NON NONPROFIT- DERA
THERE ARE NONPROFITS THAT- WERE
QUITE INVOLVED IN THE JANUARY
SIX- INSURRECTION- WE BELIEVE.
PROFITS WHO WERE PREPARING FOR
THE NEXT INSTRUCTION AND THEY'RE
RAISING MONEY FROM OUR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS- OR THEY
THEY CAN RAISE MONEY FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS- TWO
SEPARATE- THAT WOULD BE TAX
DEDUCTIBLE AND I DON'T THINK
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
SO WERE YOU REFERENCE JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION PURPOSES WERE YOU
REFERENCING- ARE YOU CONCERNED
THAT THERE'S A PROBLEM IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE NONPROFIT OR
ARE YOU REFERRING MORE TO
NATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS NONPROFIT
. CAP TWO CATEGORIES. OF
NONPROFITS THAT WOULD BE
IMPACTED BY THIS BILL ONE AS-
NONPROFIT CENTER INCORPORATED
REGISTERED AS NONPROFITS IN
CALIFORNIA AND RECEIVE THEIR TAX
EXEMPTION FROM THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD. THEY IF. THEY WOULD LOSE
OUT TOPICS SO THAT- IF THEY
LOSE- IF THEY LOSE THEIR STATUS-
THAN THEN CONTACT TO THEM BE
NONTAX. I'M THE SAME AS A NUMBER
OF LOST THEIR THEIR TAX EXEMPT
STATUS FOR NON CALIFORNIA-
NONPROFITS REGISTERED IN ANOTHER
STATE IN CALIFORNIA ARE CURRENT
LAW IS THAT FOR NON CALIFORNIA
NONPROFIT TO RAISE MONEY HERE
THEY HAVE TO REGISTER. YOUR TURN
HELLO I PUT. PROCESS SO. WE KNOW
BE ABLE TO- THERE WITHOUT BE
ABLE TO HERE TO MONEY- IF A- IF
THEY WERE INDIGENOUS RUSSIAN AND
SO IF YOU ARE A CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT MAKE YOUR CONTRIBUTIONS
WITHOUT NUMBER BUT THAT'S NOT
ELIGIBLE TO RAISE MONEY HERE YOU
CAN'T ADOPTED UNDER HEALTH.
RIGHT BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE ANY
SPECIFIC. REFER IN CALIFORNIA
PERCENT I MEAN I CERTAINLY HAVE
MY OWN KNOWLEDGE OF NONPROFITS
THAT IT SEEMS PRETTY CLEAR WERE
ENGAGE IN EITHER ENGAGING IN OR
INCITING INSURRECTION ON JANUARY
SEX AND NONPROFITS- I THINK ARE
GOING TO DO IT AGAIN. I'M NOT
HERE TO SECURE THE NONPROFIT- AT
ISSUE BECAUSE THERE ARE
NONPROFIT SO WE PROBABLY DON'T
EVEN KNOW ABOUT. AND WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN
THE FUTURE BUT REGARDLESS OF
THAT THIS IS ABOUT JUST ME
MAKING THE GROUND RULES REALLY
CLEAR. THAT IF YOU IF YOU ARE
NONPROFIT AND YOU EITHER
YOURSELF OR INSIDE SOMEONE ELSE.
TO TRY TO OVERTHROW THE
GOVERNMENT. THAT THEN YOU'RE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR TAX EXEMPTION.
THANK YOU CENTER. YOU HEARING NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION BASED ON THIS
ITEM SIR WHEN WAS LIKE CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL WE'RE
SEEKING A MOTION- DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WE HAVE A MOTION
IS RIDER. CAN I MAKE A MOTION.
I THINK CENTER aMERCE
DEAL COURTESY OF SHOULD NOT BE
HAPPY TO DO A COURTESY- MOTION
ON THE BILL THANK YOU SENATOR.
OKAY OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION BY
CENTER- CHAU BOTH AND IOS THE
COUNCIL TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON S. EIGHT THREE FOUR. HI
BRADFORD DIETRO BOTH NOT VOTING
SO BURKE NOT VOTING COM LONGER
SKINNER WIENER AYE WIENER AYE.
TO GO THROUGH THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTER
WINNER NON NEXT EPICENTER
STARTED. AND HE HAS SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY TWO. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN. TODAY I AM PRESENTING
TO YOU ALL SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
TWO. OTHERWISE KNOWN AS RYAN'S
LAW. WE'LL TELL RYAN'S STORY- IN
A MINUTE HIS MOM IS HERE TO DO
THAT PART BUT- I JUST WANT TO
START OUT THE PRESENTATION JUST
BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE. THIS
MEASURE. UP CRAFTED- AND MAKE US
A STRONGER BILL- THAT DOESN'T
CREATE A NEW CRIME BUT REALLY
INFORMS. THE DEFINITION OF GROSS
NEGLIGENCE AND SO TO THAT EFFECT
I WANT TO NOTE THAT WILL BE
ACCEPTED MEN THE TYPICALLY
REMOVE THE REFERENCE TO PERSONS
GOING DOUBLE THE SPEED LIMIT
UNDER THE QUICK DEFINITION OF
NEGLIGENCE. JUST SEE ON PAGE
SEVEN UNDER SECTION THREE AND-
STRIKING SECTIONS THAT REQUIRE
THESE COURT MANDATED AT. THINGS
THAT WERE CURRENT. BUT THIS THIS
IS INTENDED TO MAKE OUR STREETS
SAFER FOR PEDESTRIANS FOR
BICYCLISTS FOR DRIVERS- WE'RE
LOSING LIVES AT AN ALARMING
RATE- BY. IT JULES WHO ARE OFTEN
A REPEAT OFFENDERS OF EXTREME
SPEEDING- AND OTHER INCIDENTS
THE BILL- WILL NOT BRING BACK
THE LIFE OF ANY OF THESE VICTIMS
LOS TO FACING DREAM SPEAKING TO-
IMPACTS WE'VE SEEN FROM INSIDE
SHOWS HAPPENING IN IN THE
COMMUNITY- COPING- OR CAROLINE
RYAN- THEY'RE NOT WITH US BUT I
THINK AS A LEGISLATURE WE CAN
ACT AND IN A SURGERY- AND INTEL
WAY USE. SCOPE TO PROSECUTE
CRIMES WITHIN ATTENTION TOWARDS
WHAT IS TRULY GROSSLY NEGLIGENT-
THE FACTORS MAY INCLUDE NOW
UNDER THIS BILL PARTICIPATION
INSIDE SHOWS OR ACCEPT AN
EXHIBITIONIST EXCESSIVE SPEED.
BUT NOT THIS NOTION OF A DOUBLE
THE LEGAL LIMIT ON COUNTY
HIGHWAYS STREETS- BUT THE DMV
DOES REPORT THAT OVER FIFTEEN
HUNDRED MORE RECKLESS DRIVING
CITATIONS STATEWIDE IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WE'RE- THAN THE YEAR
BEFORE. AN L. A. ALONE WE'VE
SEEN TWO HUNDRED NINETY FOUR AND
IF IT WAS KILLED WITHIN THAT 24%
INCREASE FROM THE PRIOR YEAR. I
LAST. 5% AND SERIOUS INJURIES TO
BICYCLISTS WERE UP BY 34% FROM
TWENTY TWENTY. C. H. P. REPORTS
THE STREET RACING SIDESHOWS OF
CROSSOVERS TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
FOUR CRASHES STATEWIDE THE PAST
FIVE YEARS THIRTY OF WHICH HAVE
BEEN FATAL. TWENTY FOUR OF TO
RESULT IN SERIES IN. THIS ON TOP
OF THE TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
CALLS THAT THEY RECEIVE FROM
ILLEGAL STREET RACING- AND
EXCESSIVE SPEEDING. IN GENERAL
HAS BECOME AN EPIDEMIC ON OUR
ROADS THE FACT IS MEMBERS THAT
PEOPLE USE CARS. AS THEY WERE
GOING. OR IS THERE SOME VEHICLE
FOR THEIR SOCIAL MEDIA PROWESS.
AT THEY ARE REALIZING THE FATAL
AFFECT THAT. IS KIND OF
NEGLIGENCE HAS ON FAMILIES. I'M
A STICK TO THE CALIFORNIA
VEHICLE CODE AND THE PENAL CODE
ISSUES BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE AND
LET MY LEAD WITNESS- TALK ABOUT
THE PERSONAL SIDE OF THIS BUT-
ESSENTIALLY THIS GROSS
NEGLIGENCE STANDARD. SERIES OF
MAY FACTORS OF THESE ARE THESE
ARE MANDATORY FACTORS BUT IT MAY
INCLUDE FOR PROSECUTION PURPOSES
SOME OF THESE FACTORS BUT THE
GROSS NEGLIGENCE DEFINITION IN
LAW STILL HOLES- YOU STILL HAVE
TO- EXHIBIT. THIS IN A CONSCIOUS
DISREGARD FOR LIFE- AND IF YOU
CHAU FACTS SHOWING MALICE- YOU
CAN BE GUILTY OF MURDER UNDER
EXISTING LAW. THIS IS SOBRE EVER
WORK- AND I APPRECIATE THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS NOT LOOKING TO
INCREASE RATES OF CARBURETION-
BUT I THINK THIS BILL WILL SEE
TO IT THAT THOSE OUT THERE
PARTICIPATING THIS RECKLESS
ACTIVITY REALIZE THAT IT'S NOT A
GAME. AND FOR THE VERY TIGHTLY
ORGANIZED NETWORKS OF STREET
RACERS AND EXTREME SPEEDERS-
GERMAN DRIVING A LAMBORGHINI WHO
JUST KILLED SOMEONE AND CENTER
COM LOGGERS DISTRICT THE OTHER
WEEK- DRIVING HIS DAD'S
LAMBORGHINI IN FACING VERY
LITTLE CONSEQUENCE FOR THAT ACT
BECAUSE IT WASN'T EVEN IN HIS
NAME UNDER THE TITLE. STAND SO
HOPE BUT JUSTICE HERE TODAY AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL AND I'M
HONORED HERE TO HAVE THE KOTEL
FAMILY WITH ME- AND I THINK
KAREN IS HERE TO DELIVER THE
LEAD TESTIMONY. ONE OR TWO
WITNESSES SUGGEST JUST ONE ART
WILL FORTY FOUR MINUTES. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN BRADFORD AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS KAREN COMPEL AND I AM THE
FOUNDER OF THE RHINE CAPELL
FOUNDATION AND THE GRIEVING
MOTHER OF. I'M HERE WITH JEFF MY
HUSBAND AND RYAN'S FATHER. I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF ALL
PARENTS WHO'VE LOST A CHILD IN
AN AVOIDABLE TRAGEDY AND FOR
THOSE GRIEVING FAMILIES OF LOVED
LOVED ONES LOST. DUE TO HIGH
SPEED THING AND OTHER RECKLESS
DRIVING. THESE INCLUDE MONIQUE
MOON YO'S THIRTY TWO KILL
PARALYMPIC BOULEVARD IN OVERLAND
AVENUE IN WEST LA THE LAST.
PLACE AND HE DRIVERS. IS
FATHER'S DAY. THANK YOUNG EVER
PREVIOUS CITED TWICE FOR DRIVING
ALEX SPEEDS AND ADVANCED
RECEIVED. AND.
TROLL STRIKING A WALL AND A TREE
CAUSING THE TEEN'S DEATH IN
MAJOR INJURIES TO AN ADULT
PASSENGER. OUR SON RYAN WAS
TRAGICALLY KILLED ON AUGUST
SIXTH TWENTY TWENTY AT THE AGE
OF SIXTEEN IN A COLLISION WITH A
SPEEDING DRIVER WHO'S GOING
APPLE THE SPEED LIMIT ON THE
STREET I NUYS. THANK FOR DRY
OVER NINETY AN HOUR JUST EIGHT
MONTHS BEFORE THE ACCIDENT DUE
TO CURRENT LAW THE DRIVER WAS
CHARGED WITH A MISDEMEANOR
KILLER MANSLAUGHTER AND RECEIVED
ONE YEAR PROBATION SIX MONTHS.
THE LABOR RIGHT WAS AN
INCREDIBLE SIGN HE WAS A TWIN
BROTHER HE WAS THE YOUNGER
BROTHER HE WAS A GRANDFATHER HAS
IN AN EFFORT AND A FRIEND I AM
WITH THE COPS KID EVER BOB WAS
BUT FRIEND IF YOU EVERYONE. HE
CAUGHT WITH. SMALL ATHLETIC
LOYAL RESPECTED IN VERY CAUTIOUS
HE WAS A TALENTED FILMMAKER AND
PLAN TO GO TO COLLEGE TO STUDY
FILM. I COULD GO ON AND ON ABOUT
WHAT A WONDERFUL HUMAN BEING HE
WISE BUT I WOULD NEED WAY MORE
TIME THAN FOUR MINUTES HE WAS
THE BEST OF ALL OF US AND TAKEN
WAY TOO SOON. THE TRAGEDY THAT
SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN HIS TWIN
SISTERS SHOULD BE GRADUATING
SCHOOL WITH THEM THIS YEAR AND
EXPERIENCING ALL THE LIFE
MOMENTS TOGETHER THAT THEY HAVE
. HIS BROTHER AND HE JUST
GETTING CLOSER OVER COATED AND
WILL NEVER HAVE THE CHANCE. TO
FIND THEIR TRUE FRIENDSHIP. JEFF
AND I WILL NEVER GET TO SEE HIM
GROW UP GO TO COLLEGE GET
MARRIED HAVE KIDS ALL THE THINGS
HE WAS EXCITED ABOUT. HIS FUTURE
. I TRULY BELIEVE THE
TRADITIONAL ENFORCEMENT PUBLIC
AWARENESS AND UNDERSTANDING
ONE'S OWN PERSONAL POSSIBILITY
WHILE DRIVING. SB ONE FOUR SEVEN
TWO WILL SAVE LIVES. SB ONE FOUR
SEVEN TO PROVIDE A REASONABLE
SOLUTION IN LAW THAT MAY PREVENT
THE NEXT TRAGEDY FROM EVER
HAPPENING TO WHICH- I LOVE WHAT
. I DON'T ANY OTHER PARENTS TO
HAVE TO GO THROUGH WHAT WE HAVE
IN TOWARD THE LAST TWENTY ONE
MONTHS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND YOUR SUPPORT S.
ONE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE HERE AND IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE WISHING TO
TESTIFY. ON THIS MEASURE SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO NINETEEN
NINE MODERATOR NOW OVER TO OUR
PHONE LINES INTO IF THERE'S
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. BORDERLINE THREE OH NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHARE MEMBERS
ANDREW ANSLEY- WHICH ARE YOUR
HANDS WE USE THOSE AND LYING ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS OR. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT- NOW GO TO OPPOSITION. WE
HAVE. OUR LEAVES ARE WOULD LEAD
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. YOU MAY
BEGIN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
BRADFORD AND TO THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON
AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION MY HEART GOES OUT TO
RYAN'S FAMILY AND ALL OF THE
FAMILIES THAT HAVE SUFFERED THIS
KIND OF TRAGEDY. HOWEVER WHILE
SEEKING TO STOP TRAFFIC DEATHS
IS A LAUDABLE GOAL SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY TWO WAS FLOOD AND
THEREFORE NOT THE ANSWER TO OUR
PROBLEM WITH RECKLESS AND
DANGEROUS DRIVING OR VEHICULAR
MANSLAUGHTER. SB. FORTY SEVEN
TWO WOULD CONSTRUCTIVELY REMOVE
THE CURRENT FELONY REQUIREMENT
OF GROSS NEGLIGENCE AND ADD THE
INCLUSION OF ANY SITUATION WHERE
THE DRIVER HAS PRIVATE PRIOR
CONVICTIONS OF SPEEDING OR
RECKLESS DRIVING. IF THE CURRENT
OFFENSE INVOLVED SPEEDING OR
RECKLESS DRIVING. GROSS
NEGLIGENCE BY NH. THE TIME OF
THE ACCIDENT THAT LED TO THE
DEATH THERE CANNOT BE A PER SE
INDICATION OF GROSS NEGLIGENCE A
SIDE SHOW OR AN EXHIBITION OF
SPEED MAY BE INDICATIVE OF GROSS
NEGLIGENCE BUT NOT NECESSARILY
UNDER ALL CIRCUMSTANCES USING
PRIOR CONVICTIONS OF RECKLESS
DRIVING IS AS BY THE BILL SAID
NOTHING ABOUT THE DROPPING AT
THE TIME. FOR DOES. THE ROAST.
OR- MEN'S RAHA SUCH AS IMPLIED
MALICE THE PROPOSED ADMONITION
IS- IS OVERBROAD AND SERVES NO
BASIS EXCEPT TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR PROSECUTORS TO CHARGE AND
CONVICT INDIVIDUALS UNDER THE
ALREADY FLOOD SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY TWO IN MY EXPERIENCE AS
A PUBLIC DEFENDER FOR NEARLY
FORTY YEARS AND DOESN'T A
DEFENSE ATTORNEY LATER THEIR THE
LOCATOR OF AN INDIGENT DEFENSE
TEAM I CAN TELL YOU THE HONEST
MY ALREADY GIVEN IN FOR INSTANCE
DO YOU AYE CASES DO WELL. YOU
REALLY DO ANYTHING I THAN IS THE
PROSECUTORS BURDEN WHY DO I SAY
THIS OUR CLIENTS CAN BARELY TAKE
IN ALL THE INFORMATION THAT SAVE
WHERE INFRACTIONS ARE HEARD AND
JUDGES OVERSEE HUNDREDS OF
INFRACTIONS IN THE DAY THESE
COURTS MOVE AT LIGHTNING SPEED
AN ADMONISHMENT REGARDING FUTURE
BEHAVIOR IS VIRTUALLY THE LAST
THING A DEFENDANT TAKES INTO
MIND. IN THESE SITUATIONS PEOPLE
WHO CAUSE THE DEATH WILL DRIVING
BASED ON CONDUCT NOT AMOUNTING
TO A FEW. AND WITHOUT ROSE
NEGLIGENCE NOT LONG IN OUR
OVERFLOWING PRISONS AND JAILS
MISDEMEANOR SERRATION CAN
PROVIDE ADEQUATE PUNISHMENT AND
DETERRENCE CHANGING THE RULES OF
THE LAW THAT IS STOOD WELL IN
THE INTEREST OF JUSTICE FOR
DECADES. SIMPLY NOT JUSTIFIED
HERE THESE RESULTS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MARK COUNTY
CAN TO THE ISSUE THAT ARE WAS
JUST REYES AND- DOES OUR
AMENDMENT TO DRESS UP. A THERE
WERE AMENDMENT YEP I HAD NON
SMOKING THEM COUNCIL. HE YES SO
THERE THE ADMONISHMENTS SECTIONS
ARE OUT OKAY I UPON AND THEN AND
HE'S TAKING OUT THE AT THE END
OF THE GROUP TECHNICIANS
DEFINITION ITHER BEING
CONVICTED OF A SPEEDING ACCESS
TO DOUBLE. I STILL FEEL THAT YOU
WE CAN'T HAVE A PER SE
DEFINITION OF GROSS NEGLIGENCE
IT IS THE TOTALITY OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES SO OUR POSITION
WOULD REMAIN ALTHOUGH WE DO
APPRECIATE REMOVAL OF THE ADMIN
. ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. NOT LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR USER
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF. SB ONE TWELVE.
FROM THIS IS KATHY SURE FROM THE
ACLU I THOUGHT THAT I WAS- AND
UP TO BE A LEAD OPPOSITION WHAT
ON. THEY SHOULD HAVE A NAMELESS
ESERVER READY YET CORRECT. OKAY
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT-
GOOD AFTERNOON- KATHY SURE ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION- WE- ACTUALLY NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE WORKING SEVENTY
TWO- AND I ALSO WANT TO OFFER MY
SYMPATHY TO THOSE COMPELLED.
OKAY NO ONE SHOULD SHOULD HAVE
SUCH A LAW- I THINK WE ALL WANT
TO STOP TRAFFIC TRAFFIC
FATALITIES BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE
APPROACH TAKEN IN THE STILL
WON'T DO THAT- PEOPLE WHO. CAN
RECKLESS DRIVING OR THANK ABOUT
. ACTION AND THERE'S CERTAIN NOT
BEING ABOUT. WHETHER IF IT IF
THEY DOES CIRCUMSTANCE THEY'RE
NOT CONTEMPLATING SOMEONE DYING
AS A RESULT OF THEIR RECKLESS
DRIVING WHETHER THEY BE PUNISHED
ON THEM. FELONY LEVEL. STING ONE
MAKES NO DISTINCTION AS TO HOW A
PERSON SHOULD BE PUNISHED ON.
WHAT. IN THE CAR. AT.
AT THE BUT- IF NOT- REGARDLESS
OF WHAT THEIR PAST RECORD MAY
HAVE BEEN- AND THEY WERE NOT
DRIVING IT CHRIS NEGLIGENT IN
THE CURRENT CASE AND- THEY STATE
PARKWAY. I YEAH YOU OTHERWISE AS
THE DON'T- WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR LOCAL. THANK YOU ANYONE
HERE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. ANY
ADDITIONAL STRAIN ON WILL GO TO
OUR PHONE LINES IN OUR CONTINUE
WITH. OPPOSITION FROM PARENTS.
MODERATOR THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL BRING YOU BACK
TO THE COMMITTEES DURING
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS SENATOR
WINNER I THANK YOU FOR SAW- I
WANT TO. EXPRESS I'M- SUDDENNESS
SECOND ALSO IS FOR YOUR LOSS-
APPARENTLY AS A CHILD. PART OF
PARADISE AND NEVER COMES BACK
AND IT'S JUST I CAN'T EVEN
FATHOM. WHAT THAT MEANS BUT I'M
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE U. TURN
THE HORRIFIC TRAGEDY AND TO.
ADVOCACY TO TRY- AVOID DISASTERS
LIKE THIS- IN THE FUTURE THANK
YOU. AND I WANT TO THANK HER FOR
THE COMMITTEE AND- TO REALLY.
TRY TO GET IT. TRY TO GO WHICH I
THINK REVISED. ABSOLUTELY
WITHOUT PAYING THE CONSEQUENCES
AND SO HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
AND I'LL MAKE A MOTION TO ANSWER
. ADDITIONAL COMMENTS QUESTIONS
BY COMMITTEE. SENATOR CALM WATER
YES I APOLOGIZE FOR HAVING TO
STEP OUT FOR A SECOND I JUST
WANTED- TO KNOW BECAUSE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS WITH- THE
KILLER MANSLAUGHTER. YOU COULD
GET SENTENCED- YOU KNOW AS YOU
COULD BE ONE YEAR IN COUNTY JAIL
COULD BE SIX YEARS IN STATE
PRISON SO I WAS JUST TRYING. TO
GET A SENSE OF. IN AND WHAT TO
DO THAT IS NOT AVAILABLE. USING
CURRENT CODE. AND YES. YES AND I
WOULD ALSO I WOULD AYE WE NEED
WE DO HAVE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
HERE FROM ALISON TREES WILL TO
IT WHAT'S TO COMMENT ON THAT
NUMBER AB WHAT MAKING HER WAY TO
THE MY LOAN- G. HELLO. BRIAN'S
CASE I FEEL. FROM FROM MY
STANDPOINT FROM THE R. AND IS TO
ADD FACTORS THAT CAN BE
CONSIDERED BUT NOT TO TIE A
PROSECUTOR'S HANDS TO BE FORCED
INTO THAT SO THAT THE LANGUAGE
IN THE BILL MAY. INCLUDE BUT ARE
NOT LIMITED TO HE SORT OF.
PARTICIPATION IS SIDESHOW
DRIVING OVER A HUNDRED MILES AN
HOUR- YOU KNOW THESE RECKLESS
DRIVING INCIDENTS SO IN OTHER
WORDS- THE GROSS NEGLIGENCE
STANDARD YOUR SETTING HASN'T
CHANGED AND IT DOESN'T ACTUALLY
CHANGE LENGTH OF SENTENCE. DOES
AND- YOUR SHOW. ALICE CAN YOU
KNOW DO YOU HAVE OF MURDER- AND
SO IN ANY CIRCUMSTANCES THE
IDEAS THAT BY FILLING OUT SOME
OF THESE FACTORS FOR THE
PROSECUTION TO AT LEAST BE ABLE
TO TURN TO. IN THAT HELP TO MAKE
THE CASE BETTER IF THE TOTALITY
OF CIRCUMSTANCES STILL- MOUNT TO
WHAT WHAT WOULD AMOUNT TO
VOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER BUT- IT'S
NOT TYING THEIR TO THAT. THAT'S
THAT'S HOW WE DON'T WANT TO BE
HEAVY HANDED AND I DON'T KNOW
THAT THAT WOULD BE PER A GROUP
AND SEE IF. AFTER THE TEST GROSS
NEGLIGENCE IS MINOR. THANK YOU
MY NAME IS ALLISON TREES ALL AND
SENATORS FURNACE RIGHT AND
USUALLY CRIMINAL DEFENSE
ATTORNEY- I'VE DONE SO FOR THE
LAST TWENTY FIVE THEY'VE ALSO
VICTIM ADVOCACY. THIS IS A
UNIQUE CONFIRM. HELLO FAMILY FOR
MANY YEARS AND THE SUN THAT THEY
LOST WAS A VERY. DEAR FRIEND OF
MY SON'S. SOMETHING HAS TO BE
DONE HERE AS A DEFENSE ATTORNEY
I WATCHED ON. THE WAYS IN WHICH
THE VAGUENESS OF THIS LAW.
BENEFITS DEFENDANTS ALL THE TIME
. IN THIS CASE I SAT AND WATCHED
AS THE PROSECUTORS STRUGGLED
DISABLED HOW DID HOW DID THESE
FAX FIFTY GREATER PUNISHMENT HOW
DO WE DO SOMETHING THE PERSON IN
THIS CASE WAS GIVEN ONE YEAR OF
PROBATION. AND IN THAT ONE YEAR
OF PROBATION THERE ISN'T EVEN
ENOUGH TIME. TO PAY BACK THE
EXPENSES THAT THEY HAD FOR THEIR
SON'S FUNERAL. PROSECUTORS NEED
GUIDANCE AND IF YOU DIRECT THEM
TO THINGS LIKE DRIVING OVER A
HUNDRED MILES AN HOUR RECKLESS
DRIVING. THOSE THINGS ASSIST THE
SYSTEM. IN REALLY TARGETING
THESE THESE ARE JUST MINOR
VIOLATORS THESE ARE PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY IN THEIR CASE THIS IS
A CASE WHERE NINE MONTHS BEFORE
THIS AND WAS DROPPED ON NINETY
UP SURFACED. SURFACE STREET
MIDDLE OF THE DAY. SO I
UNDERSTAND WHY THE. WHERE THERE
IS AN OBVIOUS SPEED LIMIT THAT'S
AGAINST THE LAW. IT IS IT IS BUT
FOR SENATE AND- BUT I DO THINK
IF YOU CAN DIRECT. A
PROSECUTOR'S ATTENTION OR A
JUDGE'S ATTENTION TO CERTAIN
WORDS IN ACCORD BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW IT'S JUST TOO BIG. AND IT
WILL HELP THE ENTIRE SYSTEM
PROSECUTE THOSE WHO REALLY NEED
TO BE MORE SERIOUSLY PROSECUTED
THEN JUST A YEAR OF PROBATION
ESTIMATE THERE NO DETAILED I'M
SOME COMMUNITY SERVICE. I YOUR-
SO I'M GONNA STOP TALKING I'M A
YEAH BECAUSE I DO I HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING AND I'M TRYING TO
DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN WHAT
HAPPENED IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE
AND WHAT LAW BECAUSE LAWS NOT
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE IT'S ABOUT ON A
GO BOARD AND HOW YOU'RE
IMPACTING A SYSTEM AND SO THE
QUESTION WAS. IT SEEMS TO ME.
THERE ARE ALREADY TOOLS IN THE
PENAL CODE TOOL KIT TO ALLOW
FOR. AT INSTANCES WHERE THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF CIRCUMSTANCES-
THAT. PROBABLY CONTRIBUTED TO
SOMEONE'S DEATH- THAT THERE ARE
TOOLS IN THE TOOL KIT THAT CAN
BE USED AND I DON'T KNOW ALL THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT HAPPENED WITH
THIS PARTICULAR CASE I CAN'T.
WHY THE PERSON DO WE GET
PATIENTS BERMAN HERE. I'M EITHER
NO WAY YOU CAN. I IN A PLAN
CLEAN TIME AND THE DEATH OF
SOMEONE WHO WILL NEVER COME BACK
I MEAN WE EVEN WE EVEN WANT TO
DO THAT A LOT IT RIGHT- SO I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT. OFTENTIMES
WHEN THEY'RE BILLS IT'S ABOUT
TRYING TO FIX SOMETHING THAT
ISN'T WORKING FOR. YOU KNOW THE
COMMON DENOMINATOR FOR THE
GREATER GOOD AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS IF YOU ARE
INVOLVED IN SOMETHING WHERE
YOU'RE DRIVING OVER THE SPEED
LIMIT. IF YOU. KILL SOMEONE. IF
YOU HAVE A REGISTRATION THAT IS
EXPIRED IF IT'S IN A CAR THAT
ISN'T YOUR LIKE ALL OF THOSE
THINGS YOU WOULD ADD INTO THE
CHARGES THAT ARE PLACED ON A
PARTICULAR DEFENDANT TO MAKE THE
CASE. AM I HEY THIS IS JAZZ
FINDING THE TOOLS IN THAT TO
GET. AND MAKING IT MORE CLEAR TO
THOSE WHO ACTUALLY DO THIS ON A
DAILY BASIS. THAT YES YOU CAN
CHARGE FIFTY MANSLAUGHTER. IN
THESE SPECIFIC CASES BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW IT TODAY AND I DO THIS
EVERY DAY IN COURT EVERY DAY AND
I SEE THAT IT IS NOT BEING
CHARGED NEARLY IT. HALF IN KEY
IS WHERE. I THINK THIS LIMITED
EDITION TO ONE NINETY TWO WILL
MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ISSUE. NOW ALL
RIGHT I TOO WAS STRUGGLING WITH
THIS AS I STATED- WITH AGAIN THE
DUPLICITY INCIDENT WAYS OF-
WHAT'S ALREADY ON THE BOOKS AND
TRYING TO HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT WE'RE
CAPTURING HEREIN ARE. WE ARE.
FROM BOTH THE FAMILY AND- THE TO
THE ATTORNEY HERE BUT MISSION. I
TO SEE IF YOU CAN ADDRESS SOME
OF THOSE QUESTIONS IN YOUR
CLOTHES MISTER. BUT IF YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU FOR
THE ENGAGEMENT I THINK YOU
YOU'RE ASKING THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS AS A COMMITTEE AS AS
MEMBERS- ADDED TODAY. M. INTENT
ON WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION
HERE ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THE MOBILE
OF THE ATTESTATION AND THIS
QUESTION OF ARE WE GOING TO
MAKE. THIS PER SE GROSS
NEGLIGENCE QUESTION RIGHT. WE
STILL WANT TO AFFORD
PROSECUTORIAL DISCRETION IN
THESE CASES YOU STILL NEED TO
CONSIDER THE TOTALITY
CIRCUMSTANCE WE DON'T WANT TO
CUT EXISTING THAT WERE. WE JUST
ADDING THESE MAY CONSIDERS. TO
THE CODE WILL FOCUS AND ACQUIRE
SOME KIND OF SURGICAL NATURE TO
THIS PROSECUTION SO THAT WHEN
FOLKS TO COME IN AND HE'S AGREE
JUST CASES- THAT THEY'LL HAVE
SOMETHING TO LOOK TO IN THE
CODE. AND THAT. THEY CANCER PLAY
THE DATE AIMS- THAT GETS. THE
WELL HEELED PEOPLE WHO CAN
AFFORD A VERY EXPENSIVE CRIMINAL
DEFENSE LAWYER LIKE MYSTERY SO-
TO GET THEM OFF WHAT. AND THE
FACT IS THAT YOU KNOW IF YOU
DON'T HAVE THAT KIND OF DEFENSE
IF YOU'RERELYING SOLELY ON
PUBLIC DEFENSE- AND THE CASE IS
MOVING QUICKLY. THINGS GO VERY
FAST- AND SO I THINK THERE'S AN
INEQUITY IN CURRENT LAW. THAT
AFFORDS- THE PRIVILEGED A LOT
MORE ABILITY YOU KNOW THE KID
DRIVING THE DAD'S LAMBORGHINI
WITHOUT ANY SENSE OF
CONSEQUENCE. I THINK YOUNG
PEOPLE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THESE CARS ARE DEADLY AND SIDE
SHOWS OR NOT A GAME STREAM
SPEEDING IS NOT A GAME. THIS
ISN'T A WAY TO IMPRESS YOUR
FRIENDS THIS TAKES LIVES SO
HOPING WITH THESE. THESE THESE
LIGHT COMES ON THE SCALE A
LITTLE MORE ATTENTION FOR
PROSECUTORS WITHOUT LIMITING
THAT DISCRETION AND WITHOUT
BURDENING ANY. STATION THE
EXISTING CODE THAT WE CAN. SIX
MONTHS SO I APPRECIATE MISTER
CHAIR YOUR WORK AND ESPECIALLY
THE COMMITTEES WORKING HELPING
MAKE THIS BILL- AT THIS BILL
JUST. AND WITH THAT ESPECIALLY
AFTER I VOTE. IN ORDER WIENER WE
HAVE A FEW PASS RECOMMENDATION
TO APPROPRIATIONS ABS AMENDED.
AND I WOULD JUST ASK FOR THE
AUTHORS COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE
TO WORK TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN EXPRESSED BY
BOTH THE COMMITTEE AND THE
OPPOSITION- THIS MEASURES TO
MOVE FORWARD CHAU. THANK ALSO AT
LEAST CALL THE ROLL ON. S. B.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO. SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO BRADFORD
BRADFORD I'D SHOW BOTH TRUBACI
CAMARGO- KAMLAGER NOT VOTING
SKINNER WIENER WIENER EIN.
REDRESS THREE VOTES WILL LIBERAL
OPENED FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU FIGURE MUCH. YOURS OR SHE
COULD DO SENATOR WILL EXPEL. THE
PRESENTATION ANALYST AT.
SACRAMENTO. MAKE IT. RIGHT I.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN FIRST
I WRITE TODAY TO PRESENT SB TEN
EIGHTY NINE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
WILK BEFORE I PRESENT THIS BILL
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
CHAIR AND STAFF FOR THEIR HARD
WORK THIS LEGISLATION THIS IS
TRUE FOR A BILL THAT WILL ENSURE
THE CALIFORNIA'S MEDICAL
BENEFITS CHERRIES ARE ABLE TO
RECEIVE THE HIGHEST QUALITY
EYEGLASSES AVAILABLE. CURRENT
LAW REQUIRES THE ADDRESS AND
OTHER PROVIDERS TO OBTAIN I GO
OUT. FROM THE CALIFORNIA PRISON
INDUSTRY AUTHORITY.
UNFORTUNATELY THE SYSTEM IS
PLAGUED WITH PROBLEMS AS THE
EYEGLASSES OFTEN TAKE MONTHS TO
DELIVER TO PATIENTS AND ARE OF
SUCH POOR QUALITY THAT THEY
CAUSE IRRITATION AND BREAK MUCH
MORE EASILY THAN AYE GLASSES
MANUFACTURED ELSEWHERE. THIS
BILL ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY
ALLOWING PROVIDERS TO GO OUTSIDE
OF THE PA TO OBTAIN EYEGLASSES
FOR MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES. THE
LEGISLATURE UNANIMOUSLY PASSED
THE LEGISLATION LAST YEAR WITH
AB FIVE SEVENTY NINE LARA THAT
ALLOWED CAL FIRE TO GO OUTSIDE
OF THE P. EIGHTY. PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT FOR QUALITY
PURPOSES. WITH ME TODAY TO
PROVIDE EXPERT TESTIMONY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TOM OF.
OPTOMETRIC. THE DOCTOR.
ASSOCIATION IS TERRY MAKE IT
BACK OUT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN TERRY MCKAY OVER
THERE AND READ AN ASSOCIATES IN
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
OPTOMETRIC ASSOCIATION- THIS
LEGISLATION DID PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY FROM THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE TWO WEEKS AGO. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBER VINCE MIXED
ORDINARY VICTORIES WITHIN THE
PRISON SYSTEM LATELY PERHAPS
MOST EXTRAORDINARY. SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND PRISONERS REMOVED FROM
THE STATE INCARCERATIONS SYSTEM
NEVER SLOWING DOWN AND STOPPING
THESE YEARS OF MASS
INCARCERATION. THERE ARE HOWEVER
SOME CONSEQUENCES WE KNOW FROM
THE FIREFIGHTERS THAT THREE
YEARS AGO WE HAD A HUNDRED
NINETY EIGHT INMATE CRUZ LAST
YEAR WE HAD FORTY TWO. WE KNOW
THAT WE'RE LOSING THOSE
PRISONERS THAT WE WOULD BE
USING- FOR THE- FOR THE CAMPS
AND WE ALSO LOSING THOSE WHO
WE'D BE USING- FOR- THE TRAINING
. FOR PRODUCTION. LESS VISIBLE
ARE THE PROBLEMS THAT REACH
OPTOMETRY. W DID A SURVEY OF
OUR MEMBERS WE FOUND OUT THAT
FROM THE PRISON AUTHORITY 38%
SAY IT TAKES AT LEAST ONE TO TWO
MONTHS. 50% SAID IT TAKES AT
LEAST TWO MONTHS. AND I REMIND
YOU THAT THE PEOPLE WHO RECEIVE
THESE GLASSES ARE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE. 50% OF THE CHILDREN
WHO LIVE IN CALIFORNIA UNDER
MEDICARE I'LL- THERE THE ONES
WHO GET THE GLASSES SO MUCH
LATER THAN KIDS WHO ARE NOT. THE
GLASSES THEMSELVES ARE NOT IN
THE CONDITION THAT THEY SHOULD
BE. IT SHOULD BE NOTED ALSO THAT
WHAT WE'RE ASKING TO DO IS WHAT.
IN MANY RESPECTS THE PIAA IS
ALREADY DOING LKS. THE CLOSER
WE LOOKED INTO THIS WE FOUND OUT
THAT OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS THE PIAA. HAS CONTRACTED
OUT THE WORK GIVEN TO THEM. LAST
YEAR OVER FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
CASES OF GOING OUT AND HAVING
EYE GLASSES DONE. LEADING OF
COURSE ALSO TO THE LACK OF
SUPERVISION. AND TO THE ALACRITY
TO WHICH THEY ARE RETURNED. WE
ARE NOT GOING AFTER THE PIAA
PERSONALLY THOSE WHO HAVE A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE PIAA CAN
CONTINUE TO USE THEM. I WOULD
SUGGEST IS THE PRISONERS ARE
ABSENT IN OUR PRISONS THAT THERE
IS MORE SPACE FOR INDIVIDUALS TO
BE A PART OF THE PIAA. THERE ARE
SEVEN THOUSAND PRISONERS
INVOLVED IN THIS PROGRAM. THEY
WORK FOR IN FOURTEEN HUNDRED
DIFFERENT AREAS OF PROVIDING
GOODS AND SERVICES AND FOR THE
MOST PART THEY DO AN
EXTRAORDINARILY GOOD JOB. 68% OF
WHAT THEY SELL ABOVE FROM 64%
TWO YEARS AGO IS PURCHASED BY
CDC ARE. SO WE CAN ALLOW THE
OPTOMETRIST TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR MOST VULNERABLE GET THE
GLASSES THAT THEY NEED WITHOUT
DOING DAMAGE TO THE SYSTEM
ITSELF. WE'RE ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SORRY CAN YOU WERE
HEARING- NOW LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES HERE. WHO ARE PRESENT
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. TEN EIGHTY NINE. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK
AND SUPPORT. THEN LET'S GO TO
OUR PHONE LINES MODERATORS OR
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN EIGHTY NINE.
HE WAS SINCERE IN SUPPORT OF SB
TEN EIGHTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M
DOCTOR DOUGLAS MAJOR I'M A
CERTIFIED CORRECTIONAL HEALTH
PROVIDER I'M PART OF THE STATE
WIDE CHILDREN'S NOW CHILDREN
VISION NOW COALITION WHICH
INCLUDES MEMBERS FROM HARVARD
BERKELEY. LA STANFORD ONE EIGHTY
NINE IS THE FIRST STEP TO
IMPROVE OPTIONS AND CHOICES
LIVING HERE FIVE MILLION
CHILDREN OF COLOR IN OUR STATE
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE
SERVICES COVERAGE THESE CHILDREN
DESERVE EQUAL AND EASY ACCESS TO
AYE WHERE. PLEASE ON THE TOOLS
ACADEMIC SUCCESS IN IMMIGRATION
TO OUR HIGH TECH SOCIETY WITH
THE OUTCOME OF BETTER PUBLIC
SAFETY AND MAYBE. LET HER WITH A
CONVERTIBLE ROBBERIES. YOU KNOW
PERSONALLY I AM PROVIDED SCHOOL
BASED VISION SCREENS FOR
THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN EACH YEAR
FOR THE LAST THIRTY SIX YEARS.
AS A RESEARCHER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH AUTHORITY. AS A
CURRENT MEMBER. ADRIN THANK JAIL
I SEE A DIRECT LINK BETWEEN FOR
VISION ACADEMIC OPTIONS BANKRUPT
ALREADY. HELLO THESE MIGHT SEEM
LIKE HUGE NUMBERS TO ME THEIR
FACES. ALL BROWN PLAQUE. WHO
DESERVES TO HAVE THE WORLD'S TO
BE SUCCESSFUL IN SCHOOL SO
PLEASE. PLEASE. WALDRON SIX
THANK YOU. YOUR LINE THREE
TWELVE TRICKLE HAS. HI KELLY
HERNIA CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M THREE NINETEEN. I DAMIEN
FERAL NATIONAL DIRECTOR OF
VISION TO LEARN BUSINESS LEARN
IS SUPPORTING THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT NOW
WILL GO TO OPPOSITION IS THERE
ANY LEAD WITNESSES HERE. WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION I SEE NOT
ONLY WITNESSED IN OPPOSITION
LISTED. HERE ANYONE HERE PRESENT
IN MARIN ONE TWELVE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION- SB TEN
EIGHTY NINE. SCENE NINE.
MODERATOR CAN WE GO TO THE PHONE
LINES NOW FOR OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TEN EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU. BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE SENATOR COM HONOR.
HERE I EIGHT- SORRY TO DO THIS I
HAVE A QUESTION I AM. BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T SPECIFY SO I DON'T KNOW
IS THIS FOR. ALL OF CDC ARE FOR
ADULTS OR IS IT JUST FOR. THE
BEAUTIFUL BLACK AND BROWN
CHILDREN. IN CAMPS. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT MEDICARE THAT
ORIGINALLY MEDICARE COVERED
VISION JUST. POOR CHILDREN NOW
IT COVERS FOR ADULTS ALSO AND SO
MEDICARE LICENSE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS MEDICARE PEOPLE
WHO DO CLASSES THROUGH MEDICARE
GET THEM THROUGH PIAA AT
CORRECTIONS RIGHT SO THIS
DOESN'T SPECIFY IT'S- I GET THIS
IS ABOUT OFFERING EIGHT OPTION
FOR HOW TO OBTAIN AYE WHERE
BECAUSE COPYRIGHT. WE CAN GET
INTO A WHOLE DISCUSSION. BUT
SILENCE ON. AGE OR EVEN FOR
FACILITY UNDER CDC ARE SO I'M
JUST TRYING TO GET US IT'S ALL
OKAY. IT'S ALL ABOUT THE
MEDICARE MEDICAL OPINIONS SO
IT'S PEOPLE OUTSIDE. CORRECTIONS
WHO GO TO A MEDIC CAL PROVIDER
FOR OPTOMETRIC SERVICES THOSE
PEOPLE SEND THE GLASSES TO PI A
TO GET THE PRESCRIPTION FILLED.
AND SO P. I. A. FILLS THE
PRESCRIPTIONS FOR MEDICAL PEOPLE
NOT IN KERR STREET MEDICAL OKAY
BECAUSE THE WITNESS CONFUSE ME
IT'S FOR ADULTS TO. NOW IT APPLY
IT ISN'T THERE WAS ARE ALL
MEDICAID IT'S MADAM. SENATORS
FOR ALL MEDICARE OKAY. OKAY THAT
HELPS. THIS WAS. IT SHOULD BE
SIMPLE BUT IT'S NOT BUT- SO IT'S
REALLY REALLY GOOD THAT WE HAVE
RESTORED. THE OPTOMETRIC
SERVICES A MEDIC CAL THAT'S
ESSENTIAL AND NOW THAT WE HAVE
THEN EVERYONE WHO IS ON MEDICAL
THE NEW NEEDS GLASSES NEEDS
DESERVES QUALITY GLASSES AND IF
OUR P. I. E. SYSTEM IS NOT
PRODUCING THAT WE HAVE TO FIX
IT. AND WE HAVE. WHAT I DON'T
LIKE ABOUT THE BILL IS PULLING
IS PROVIDING CONTRACTS TO- YOU
KNOW. PRIVATE SECTOR COMPANIES
WHEN WE WERE TRYING TO PROVIDE A
SERVICE THAT WAS A JOB TRAINING
PROGRAM FOR. HOWEVER I HAVE A
LOT OF PROBLEMS WITH THE JOB
TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT ARE PA
RUNS. AND I DON'T THINK WE
COMPENSATE OUR INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS ADEQUATELY AND I
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY OR WHO MIGHT
HAVE BEEN IN THIS PROGRAM EVER
GOT A JOB WITH ANY TYPE OF UP TO
CURRENT COMPANY- NOW I'M TAKING
IT SOMEWHAT FACE VALUE. THAT THE
QUALITY IS LOW AND PERHAPS IT IS
NOT. AND I DON'T I DON'T KNOW
IF- I CAN'T REMEMBER WHEN I READ
THE ANALYSIS IF THERE WAS ANY-
DOCUMENTING TO WHETHER TO BALLOT
. HELLO EIGHT THIS IN FOR THAT
THE QUALITY OF THE GLASS IS
BEING PRODUCED BY IN THE PA
SYSTEM OR IS LOW. WE ARE TO KNOW
THAT OKAY SO- SO THEY'RE KIND OF
SEPARATE ISSUES. AND- I'M
PERSONALLY WHERE THERE'S OTHER
PROBLEMS WHETHER THIS QUALITY
ISSUES THEY ARE NOT BUT THERE
ARE A LOT OF PROBLEMS WITH THE
SYSTEM AND I CERTAINLY DON'T
WANT TO HAVE. THE SB A SITUATION
WERE USING OUR MEDIC CAL DOLLARS
TO PROVIDE. YOU KNOW LOWER
QUALITY PRODUCTS SO IT'S I'M IN
A CONUNDRUM ON. THE COMPETITION
IS GOOD AND I CERTAINLY SEE THE
PIAA AS A MONOPOLY OF SORTS AND
I HAVE HEARD NOT ABOUT. I WHERE
BUT FOR THINGS LIKE YOU KNOW
WOMEN'S UNDERWEAR AND BRAS THE
QUALITY IS REALLY POOR- YOU CAN
WEAR THEM ONE OR TWO TIMES AND
THEN THERE'S NO A LASTING AGAIN
IT IT TAKES A LONG TIME IF YOU
ASK FOR ANOTHER PAIR. I'M FOR IT
TO COME- THAT'S RIGHT FOLKS-
IT'S CLEAR THAT ARE INCARCERATED
AND I GET THAT THIS IS NOT. SO I
MEAN AND YOU KNOW THERE MAY ALSO
BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO AN AUDIT
ON PA BECAUSE I CERTAINLY THINK
THAT IF YOU HAVE A- CLIENTELE.
THAT ISN'T VALUED THEN YOU MAY
FEEL INCLINED TO PRODUCE
PRODUCTS OF LESSER QUALITY. AND
MAYBE I HAVE A BIAS FOR EYEWEAR
BECAUSE I CAN'T SEE- SO THEN
THERE'S THAT TOO. THE OTHER COME
TO QUESTIONS. WELL I'D Q. I'M
TORN BETWEEN THIS BECAUSE- I GET
WE'RE TRYING TO GO AND IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE HAVE QUALITY
PRODUCTS THAT ARE MADE I TOO WAS
LONG CENTER SKINNER WANNA KNOW
HOW MANY JOBS. ARE YOU KNOW
AFTER BEING RELEASED ARMY
INDIVIDUALS FOUND JOBS IN. AN OP
TO METRICS- BUT I GUESS I'M
MOSTLY TROUBLED BY THE FACT
THAT. YOU GUYS- MAKE GLASSES
WERE OF POOR WHITE KIDS IT'S
ONLY FOR BLACK AND BROWN KIDS TO
GET GLASSES. RIPPED THROUGH ME
FOR A LOOP BECAUSE THE LAST TIME
I CHECKED NOT ALL BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE POOR. AND ON ALL
POOR PEOPLE BLACK AND BROWN
CHAU- ARE YOU DISCRIMINATING
AGAINST POOR WHITE FOLKS AND THE
ONLY PRISON GLASSES. HE STILL ON. SO THAT'S KINDA BUT TO ME FOR
A LOOP COLUSA. IN THE AREA HOPE
SELL ANNA BECAUSE AGAIN ARE YOU
DISCRIMINATING AS TO THE FACT
THAT ONLY BLACK AND BROWN KIDS
GET THEIR GLASSES MADE BY THE
PRISON INDUSTRIAL. YOU KNOW.
SYSTEM AYE AYE AYE I FOUND THAT
VERY STRANGE SO ANYWAY. I'M NOT
LEAVE MY COMMENTS THERE. WHEN
CENTER SKINNER- I WANT TO JUST
MAKE SURE AGAIN I'M READING THIS
RIGHT INDEPENDENT OF BY OTHER
CAR COMMENTS THIS DOES NOT
ELIMINATE. D. I. A. FROM
SUPPLYING GLASSES IT JUST ALLOWS
FOR A NEW OKAY. WITH THAT I'M
WILLING TO SUPPORT THE BILL. AND
BUT I DO THINK THAT WE- SHOULD
AT SOME POINT AND I'M NOT GONNA
TELL HIM HEALTH BEING THE BUDGET
HERE BUT WE REALLY NEED TO HAVE
A HEARING ON THE P. I. IT. AND
ON THE MOUNTAIN. YOU KNOW OUR
PEOPLE REALLY BEING WELL TRAINED
ARE THEY BEING PAID ADEQUATELY
ARE THE PRODUCTS WORTH IT AND-
POINT I WOULD HAPPY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THAT AND
SUPPORTED ALL THE WAY BUT IN THE
MEAN TIME I THINK IT'S OKAY. TO
PROVIDE SOME- AT LEAST- SOME
PROVIDER ABILITY TO CHOOSE. I
THINK THE OTHER THING IS GOING
TO THE POINTS OF- SENATOR
SKINNER IN THE CHAIR. THERE'S A
LIST OF- JOBS THAT FOLKS ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE TO APPLY FOR BECAUSE
THEY HAVE BEEN INCARCERATED AND
HAVE A RECORD IT WOULD BE
INTERESTING TO FIND OUT WHAT
KINDS OF SKILLS ARE NEEDED TO
PRODUCE ALL OF THE THINGS THAT
ARE IN THE INVENTORY OF PA AND
THEN WHAT OF THOSE CORPS. WITH
RESTRICTIONS ON PEOPLE BEING
ABLE TO FIND EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE FOR YOU TO
BE ABLE TO WORK TO LEARN HOW TO
DO THAT AND THEN WHEN YOU COME
OUT NOT AND SO WHAT OTHER-
SKILLS AND WHAT OTHER JOBS UNDER
THAT CAT. SO THAT.
THE ALTERNATIVE VENDORS AND I'M
GOING TO KEEP GOING DOWN THIS
ROAD THEY WILL BE PROVIDING
GLASSES FOR. THESE BLACK AND
BROWN KIDS AS WELL OR IF OTHER
KIDS TO. THE BRANCH THAT. AND
THAT'S NOT OK IN ORDER TO ABOVE
WOULD YOU OKAY I. SIN CENTER
HOPEFULLY I DID NOT KNOW THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS ON THE PHONE
SO I UNDERSTAND THE FACETIOUS
MISS OF YOUR QUESTION RIGHT YES
EVERYBODY GETS TREATED EQUALLY
IN THE SITUATION SO APOLOGIZE
FOR. AS FARRAKHAN MARKERS AS-
NOT ONLY BE AN INSENSITIVE BUT
FAILING TO RECOGNIZE THE
AUDIENCE. I WOULD HOPEFULLY
AUSSIE WOULD STILL GIVE US AN
AYE VOTE AND THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO. THANK YOU MR CHAOS
. GEORGE BOTH. A THROUGH PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS- OUR MOTION ON
THIS MOVE. BEEN MOVED BY SEN.
MARTYR CANCEL PLEASE CALL ROLL
ON AS RETAIN EIGHTY NINE. SB TEN
EIGHTY NINE BRADFORD. BRED FOR
NOT VOTING CHOI BOGUE HI BROUGH
GUY COME LONGER COME LONGER AYE
SKINNER. SKINNER I WINNER WINNER
I. FOUR ZERO. I JUST CHECKED
OKAY ALL RIGHT CENTER SKINNER
EUROPE. YEAH. HI. VERY PLEASED
TO SERVE TO PRESENT TO YOU SB
NINE NINE THREE. CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN WAS ONE OF THE FIRST STATES
TO RECOGNIZE THAT. VICTIMS OF
CRIME DESERVE SUPPORT AND THAT
WHEN YOU SUPPORT PEOPLE THAT
HAVE BEEN HAVE HAD A CRIMINAL
ACT AGAINST THEM YOU CAN IMPROVE
PUBLIC SAFETY IT'S NOT ONLY BE
ETHICALLY MORALLY SMART THING TO
DO. IT CREATES SAID TRUST IN-
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHEN YOU FEEL
THAT YOU- THAT REPORTING A CRIME
THAT COOPERATION AND ALL IS
GOING TO YOU KNOW TO CAN'T
ALWAYS RESULT IN EITHER GETTING
YOUR PERPETRATOR OR GETTING A
CONVICTION BUT AT LEAST YOU CAN
FEEL SUPPORTED. AND SO WE
ESTABLISHED MANY YEARS AGO. THE
WHOLE PROGRAM FOR AT THIS BY THE
VICTIMS. BOARD WHERE WE PROVIDE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT WE COVER- THE
COST OF MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
WE HAVE TRAUMA RECOVERY CENTERS
WE HAVE A WHOLE VARIETY OF
THINGS. NOW WHAT'S INTERESTING
THIS AS HAPPY. TIMES IS THAT WE
HAVE NOT TREATED ALL VICTIMS
EQUALLY AND WE HAVE A PATTERN OF
THIS IN A VARIETY OF OUR
DIFFERENT- I'M I'M GOING TO GIVE
AN ANALOGY OF SO YOU KNOW I
THINK MOST OF US HAVE BEEN ON
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE FOR
A LONG TIME AND WE KNOW THAT FOR
YEARS. WE HAVE TO. YEAH TO BE
TAKEN SERIOUSLY. AND WE HAD
YEARS WHERE RAPE EVIDENCE WAS
STUCK ON SHELVES AND NEVER DEALT
WITH AND BECAUSE WE REALIZED
THAT. FOR WHATEVER REASON LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERHAPS SAW SOME OF
THE PEOPLE WHO REPORTED RATE AS
BEING SOMEHOW THAT THEY INVITED
THAT. ATTACK THE WARNER WERE THE
VICTIM. WELL WE HAVE A SIMILAR
SITUATION AMONGST OTHER. PEOPLE
THAT WERE SUBJECT TO COURT. YOU
TO. BRITISH PROVISION
SUPERVISION WELL THEN YOU'RE NOT
TREATED AS YOU AND YET YOU ARE
STILL SORE SUBJECT TO CRIMINAL
ACT WHY IS IT ANY DIFFERENT YOU
YOURSELF WAS INVOLVED IN IT YOU
SHOULD HAVE JUST AS MUCH RIGHT
TO THAT SUM. IF VICTIM THE WE
ARE GOING TO IN SAFETY BECAUSE
WE'RE GOING TO IMPROVE THE
COMMUNITY'S FEELINGS TOWARDS LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THEIR
RESPONSIVENESS SO WHAT MY BILL
DOES IS IGNORE IS THAT LESS THAN
ONE IN FIVE CALIFORNIA CRIME
SURVIVORS RECEIVE FINANCIAL HELP
OR COUNSELING OR MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE PART OF THAT IS
BECAUSE OF THINGS THAT WE'VE
BUILT INTO THE PROGRAM THAT WE
NEED TO GET RID OF AND PART OF
IT IS BECAUSE WE DON'T FUND IT
ADEQUATELY SO BILL WOULD IMPROVE
THE ACCESS TO SUPPORT SERVICES
FOR BOTH BUYERS CRIME ANY.
INCREASE IN THE ACTUAL SUPPORT
AVAILABLE AND PROVIDES SOME GUY
INCREASE THE TRAUMA RECOVERY
CENTER STREAMLINED PROCESS FOR
THOSE BITS AND REMOVE SOME OF
THE BARRIERS THAT CREATE IT
HOLDEN SEPARATION DISPARITIES
AND I ALSO HAVE SOME COMPONENTS
FOR X. USED HEARD YOU'RE A BILL
THAT WOULD BAR EXAM. NOW WE ALSO
PUT EGGS RESTORED THE EVEN THE.
WE'VE BEEN TO HAVE BEEN
WRONGFULLY CAN. FOR THEM TO GET
THEIR SUPPORT WE PUT THE THROUGH
A LONG PROCESS IN MY ALSO
ADDRESSES THAT IN WITHOUT I
WOULD LIKE MY EXCELLENT. FIVE
KEY WITNESSES SUPPORT NEEDS
HOLLAND WHO'S THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CRIME SURVIVORS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE TO SPEAK AND
THEN I HAVE A EXONERATED
INDIVIDUAL JOE DIAZ WHO WILL
CALL IN. THANK YOU CORRECT.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER THANK
YOU TO THE CHAIR GOOD EVENING TO
ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
. YOU FOR MAKING THE TIME TO
HEAR ME. I'M STANDING HERE THE
BEGINNING OF NATIONAL CRIME
VICTIMS RIGHTS WEEK IS THE
KICKOFF FOR AN ANNUAL EVENT THAT
CEASES J. ALSO HOLES ALL
SURVIVORS SPEAK ARE WE HAVE OVER
THIRTEEN THOUSAND CRIME
SURVIVORS IN OUR MEMBERSHIP HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
MAKES THIS ONE OF THE LARGEST-
CRIME SURVIVOR ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS HERE IN THE STATE
AND WE CAME HERE TODAY
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE STATE
ACCOUNT IT MORE. IN X. OUR
SEARCH. IN THE NEEDS FOR
SURVIVORS ACROSS THE STATE. SB
NINE THREE THREE DOES THAT IN
MULTIPLE WAYS IN WHICH CENTER
SKITTERED CENTER SKINNER JUST
MENTION. AND WHAT WE HOPE IS
THAT THE STATE BEGINS TO SEE
ACCESS TO SUPPORT FOR VICTIMS
SERVICES TRAUMA RECOVERY CENTERS
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AS A KEY
PART OF THE SAFETY INSPECTION.
BEING THAT WHEN SURVIVORS GET
THIS TYPE OF SUPPORT RIGHT AWAY
WE'RE LESS LIKELY TO SEE REPEAT
INCIDENTS OF VIOLENCE AND CRIME
IN THE COMMUNITIES WE ARE LESS
LIKELY TO SEE PEOPLE WALKING
AROUND WITH AN ADDRESS TRAUMA
WHICH AFFECTS AND IMPACTS IN ALL
KINDS OF WAYS WE KNOW THAT WE
WILL SEE FOLKS HOUSING
PROTECTED. THEIR EMPLOYMENT
PROTECTED AND THAT IS THE SPIRIT
BEHIND BILL HE CREATES SAFE
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE IT ADDRESSES
ALL THE BASIC NEEDS OF. THE
VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS HAVE AFTER
EXPERIENCING A CRIME. I KNOW
THIS FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE.
WEARING L. LOS MEMBERS OF MY
IMMEDIATE FAMILY TO COME IS NOT
AN EASY STORY TO TELL THE
HARDEST ALREADY TELL IS THE
IMPACT OF THOSE CRIMES YEAR
AFTER YEAR ON MULTIPLE MEMBERS
OF MY FAMILY HOW THE SANCTIONS
THAT WERE CONNECTED TO MY
BROTHERS WHO WERE INVOLVED IN
THE CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM BEFORE
AT THE TIME OF THEIR DEATH
WITHIN HANDED DOWN TO THEIR
MOTHER SAYS THE SIBLINGS AND THE
REST OF OUR FAMILY HERE TOO MANY
INDIVIDUALS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT EXPERIENCE THIS
AND DISPROPORTIONATELY IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
SPECIFICALLY BLACK BROWN. AND
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY AND SO C. S.
B. NINETY THREE B. AS AN
OPPORTUNITY WE KNOW THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY
VICTIMS COMPENSATION IN MANY
WAYS HAS BEEN A MODEL AT WORK
AND IT. MORE IN WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE SERVICES ARE
ACCESSIBLE AT THE COMMUNITY
LEVEL BECAUSE WE KNOW. THAT WHEN
SURVIVORS GET HELP RIGHT AWAY
WHEN THE BARRIERS ARE REMOVED
AND WHEN THEY'RE GETTING SUPPORT
FROM PEOPLE THEY KNOW AND HAVE
ONGOING ACCESS TO. TO SENATOR
SKINNER'S POINT THEY ARE MORE
LIKELY TO COOPERATE THEY ARE
MORE LIKELY. TO GET THE JUSTICE
THAT MANY DESERVE AND THAT THEY
HAVE OPTIONS- FOR WITH THE
JUSTICE AND COUNTABLY LOOKS LIKE
THEM BECAUSE THERE'S HEALING
INVOLVED. AND SO WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THIS BILL
TO CONTINUE MOVING ITS WAY
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE WE HOPE
THAT YOU HEAR THE VOICES OF
THOUSAND CRIMES BARBERS WHO HAVE
BEEN CALLING FOR THE STATE. TO
SHIFT ITS ATTENTION PRIOR TO
HEALING MENTION AS PART OF
PUBLIC SAFETY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION. YES
MY NAME IS JOE DO YOU KNOW THE
ONE ONLINE OKAY WHAT WILL. THE
NEXT ONE ONLINE I'M SORRY.
FOLLOWING THE SHIP TWO MINUTE.
YES HI MY NAME IS JOE DEALS
HELLO HEARD YOU TO PASS SENATE
BILL NINE NINE THREE WHICH MAKES
IMPORTANT PRUDENT TO KNOW WHERE
STATE TREATS PEOPLE WHO PROVED
THAT THEY WERE IN PRISON FOR A
CRIME HE DID NOT COMMIT I KNOW A
LOT ABOUT THAT WHY BECAUSE IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR I WAS TRIED
AND CONVICTED OF A SEXUAL
ASSAULT SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
WHICH I HAD ABSOLUTELY NOTHING
TO DO WITH MY APPEALS TO THE
STATE AND FEDERAL COURTS WILL
REJECT AFTER NINE YEARS IN
PRISON I WAS COLD THEN PLACED ON
THE SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY. NEVER
STOP FIGHTING TO PROVE MY
INNOCENCE I HIRED ATTORNEYS TO
ASSIST ME IN PAID FOR DNA
TESTING AND PREVENTIVE MEASURES. TO INVESTIGATE MY CASE. BY IT
TWENTY TWELVE TWENTY. AFTER I
WAS ONE WEEK. THE CAME TO LIGHT
OF COURSE. FROM THE SAN THERE DO
ATTORNEY CONVICTION CHECK. MIKE
WAS OVER. IN THE CHARGER AGAINST
ME WITH. THE FOLLOWING YEAR I
WHICH CLEARED FACTUALLY INNOCENT
IN COMPENSATION TO THE VICTIM
COMPENSATION FOR. MY
COMPENSATION MONEY INCLUDED ONLY
THE TIME I SPENT IN PRISON NOT
THE TIME SPENT ON SCHOOL. HELLO
COME. ABOUT THIRD OF THE
MONARCHY SHE HAD ALREADY BEEN
SPENT ON LEGAL FEES TO GET MY
CASE OVERTURNED INCLUDE MY
INNOCENCE THIS BILL WILL MAKE
THINGS BETTER FOR CALIFORNIA.
THIS CALL JOHN EVERY TIME
INVOLVED TO BE SPENT ON PAROLE
THIS BILL WILL REIMBURSE FUTURE
GALLERIES FOR THE REASONABLE
ATTORNEY FEES AND EXPENSES
GETTING CONVICTIONS OVERTURNED.
IN GETTING COMPENSATION THIS
BILL WILL ENSURE THAT THE AMOUNT
OF COMPENSATION MONEY PROVIDED
TO A LOT OF REASONS INCREASED
ANNUALLY. TO KEEP PACE WITH
INFLATION. NOTHING THE STATE
DOES MAY UP WHAT WE GONNA REJECT
MY- THAT. I COULD DO BETTER THIS
BILL IS IMPORT STEP IN THAT TO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW WILL GO
TO OUR WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE SIXTY NAME YOUR MUSICIAN
POLICE THAT HASHEM INSPIRE
PROSECUTORS ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA IN SMART DRESSES
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
ANDY GENTEEL WITH CRIME
SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF SB NINE NINE
THREE AND IN STRONG SUPPORT. WE
AS THE CALLER WITH CRIME
SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE
AND STRONG SUPPORT. A LITTLE
WITH CRIME SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY
AND JUSTICE PROUD CO SPONSOR AND
STRONG SUPPORT. LESTICUS HERE
WITH CANCER IS RECEDING JUSTICE
INSTRUCTS APART THANK YOU. AB
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE IS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. CRYSTAL OF A
LOT OF VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS
DEMAND ACTION FROM ALAMEDA
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. NOT FROM
MARIN COUNTY A VOLUNTEER WITH
MOMS DEMAND ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. JOHN ELDON EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF AFTER IN A SENSE A
CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL IN
STRONG SUPPORT. WHEN BACK A CELL
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. YOU KNOW
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
NOW WILL MOVE THE WITNESSES OP
IN OPPOSITION. DO WE HAVE A
PRIMARY WITNESS LISTED IN
OPPOSITION. NO NO NO WE DON'T
SELL OUR- ALL RIGHT IS THERE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE NINE
THREE. THREE NINE LET'S GO TO
OUR MODERATOR MODERATOR DO YOU
HAVE ANYONE WISHING TO QUEUE UP
IN OPPOSITION NINE NINE THREE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SHIFT BEGAN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE NINE THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. BY THREE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY APOLOGIES
CARE MEMBERS NICOLE KING OUT OF
ON BEHALF OF EVERY SECOND AB I
AM IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINE
THREE. WE DO. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU.
LET'S MAKE SURE DID I CALL OF
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
PONE LINE I WANT TO MAKE SURE
FOR I DIDN'T GIVE OPPORTUNITY TO
. YOU Q. AND. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINE
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME WE DON'T WANT YOU HERE
JUST A MOMENT.
ONE MOMENT FOR THAT LINE.
OVERLYING. THREE TWENTY FOUR
NINE THREE TWO FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN- HI WE CAN COMMENT ON
BEHALF OF AT THE DATA AND JOHN
PORT. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU. YOU
CAN ALSO GO BACK ONE MORE TIME
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IS OR
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY ON VIA
PHONE IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB
NINE NINE THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE ONE
COMMENT IN Q. ONE MOMENT HERE.
OVER TO LINE THREE FIFTEEN.
THREE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD BY
THREE FIFTEEN. YES I'M VERY
WORRIED THAT- YELLOW COUNTY AND
I KNOW I MISSED MY CHANCE OKAY
CAUSATIVE- I CAN IMPORTANT THIS
I'M FROM MOMS DEMAND ACTION YOLO
COUNTY THANK YOU. I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THINK YOU AREN'T
GOING TO BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEES OR ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS IN REGARDS TO THIS
MEASURE. IN NINETEEN NINE DO E
HAVE A MOTION FOR THIS. CENTER
CALM WATER IS THAT A MOTION.
SENATOR SKINNER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. A MISTER CHAIR- I
APPRECIATE THE WITNESSES WHO FOR
US SPOKEN AND GIVEN THEIR- SOME
OF THEIR EXPERIENCES I JUST
WANTED VERY QUICKLY IN MY
CLOTHES RELATE I WAS ON THE
BOARD OF A GROUP CALLED YOU TO
LIVE IN THE TWO YEARS BETWEEN
WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY IN
THE SENATE IN YOU TO LIVE IS A
GUN VIOLENCE INTERVENTION
ORGANIZATION IN S. IS. UTILIZED
THOSE DIRECTLY TO THE HOSPITAL
SO IN MY AREA IT GOES TO
HIGHLAND HOSPITAL WHICH IS OUR
MAIN TRAUMA CENTER SO GUNSHOT
VICTIMS ARE BROUGHT THERE AND
UTILIZING COUNSELORS ARE RIGHT
THERE WHEN A GUNSHOT VICTIM
ARRIVES AND WONDER IF WE RIGHTS
TO. TO SUPPORT THE FAMILY TO
HELP MINIMIZE AMENDED YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU FEEL OFTEN IN THOSE
KIND OF ANGRY MOMENTS THERE
COULD BE A FAMILY MEMBER WHO
WANTS TO TAKE JUSTICE INTO THEIR
OWN HANDS SO ONE OF THE BEST GUN
VIOLENCE INTERVENTIONS IS HELP
BRING CALMNESS BRING SUPPORT
SENATE. NOW VERY OFTEN NO
CIRCUMSTANCES THE GUNSHOT VICTIM
IS TRAUMATIZED THERE IN A
HOSPITAL ROOM AND NOT ALWAYS
THAT RESPONSIVE TO LINE WORK AND
OF COURSE MEANT WILL COME TO THE
RIGHT OF PAID LEGITIMATELY BUT
OFTEN THAT FOR COUNTER THEN GET
. AS IF THERE NOT. REDIFF AND
MAYBE LATER BABY AFTER THE THEY
ARE BUT THE POINT IS THAT IF
IT'S ALREADY IN THERE THE END
THE DOCUMENTATION AROUND THE
CRIME THAT THERE WAS NON
COOPERATION IT CAN AFFECT THEIR
ABILITY TO GIVE VICTIM SERVICES
NOW WE KNOW THAT PUBLIC SAFETY
IS MOST SERVED. SO WE CAN. GET
CRIMINALS. WHEN WE DON'T HAVE
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO ACHIEVE WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVING PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND WHILE. WHY
DESCRIPTION OF THAT IS MAYBE AN
INARTICULATE WAY TO SAY HOW
IMPORTANT THIS KIND OF VICTIM
SUPPORT IS BUT THIS KIND OF
VICTIM SUPPORT IS NOT ONLY
ESSENTIAL TO THOSE VICTIMS JUST
TO HELP THEIR TRAUMA. IT WILL BE
GREATLY IMPROVED PUBLIC SAFETY
WHICH IS I THINK WHAT ALL OF US
ARE ABOUT AND SO WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR I. PHONE. THANK YOU.
CANCEL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
S. B. NINE NINE THREE WE HAVE TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. SB NINE
NINE THREE SKINNER BRADFORD
BRADFORD I'D CHOI BOGUE JOBO GUY
COME LONGER COMMA- I SKINNER HI
SKINNER AYE WIENER. WIENER AYE
FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO THAT
MEASURES OUT CONGRADULATIONS NOW
. YOUR GOES PAINFUL PART. ALL
RIGHT. YOU GO. THANK YOU SENATOR. THANK YOU SIR BRADFORD YOU MAY
PRESENT SB TEN EIGHTY EIGHT ALL
RIGHT I'M DOING AS WE TEN EIGHTY
EIGHT WHICH IS WILL AMEND THE
PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICERS
PROCEDURAL BILL OF RIGHTS BETTER
KNOWN AS POLL BARK TO PROVIDE
THAT THE VIOLATIONOF THE ACT
SHALL NOT BE THE BASIS FOR
REVERSE OR MODIFY DISCIPLINE. IF
A PERSON VIOLATIONS DEEP TO BE
WITHOUT A SUBSTANTIVE THE FACT
THIS HARMLESS ERROR RULE
COMPARABLE TO WHAT IS APPLIED TO
ISSUE PROCEEDINGS WOULD BE
DETERMINED BY THE MINUTE OF
HEARING OFFICER FOR BORDER.
ARBITRATOR THE PILOT INCLUDE
PROCEDURAL ERRORS INCLUDING
MISSION ART OF EVIDENCE. UNLESS
THE ERROR ADVERSELY AFFECTS A
SUBSTANTIAL RIGHTS OF THE
OFFICER TO AN EXTENT THAT
CONSTITUTES FUNDAMENTAL
UNFAIRNESS. HARMLESS ERRORS
INCLUDING TECHNICAL ERRORS THAT
ARE NOT SO DAMAGING AND
PREJUDICIAL ASK TO CHANGE THE
OUTCOME OF AN INVESTIGATION OR
DECISION AND WOOD CONSIDERATION
OF THE TOTALITY OF THE DISPUTE
WITH EVIDENCE OF MISCONDUCT IS
SIGNIFICANT. ENOUGH TO OUTWEIGH
THE CLAIM THAT AN ERROR WAS
SUBSTANTIALLY ENOUGH SUBSTANTIAL
ENOUGH. TO JUSTIFY CHANGING
DISCIPLINE. SB TEN EIGHTY EIGHT
APPLIES A COMMON LEGAL STANDARD
USED IN VIRTUALLY ALL LEGAL
PROCEEDINGS BOTH CIVIL AND
CRIMINAL. TO PAUL WALKER.
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT HAS
ALREADY APPLIED THE HARMLESS
ERROR PRINCIPLES TO PROBAR IN
REVERSING LOWER COURT RULINGS
THIS BILL CLARIFIES THAT THE
COURT'S APPLICATION OF THE
HARMLESS ERROR RUSES NOT
APPLICABLE MERELY UP. TO THE
FACTS OF THAT CASE BUT TO ALL
POLICE DISCIPLINE CASES IN THE
STATE THAT FALL UNDER POOL BAR
POOL BAR PROVIDES LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WITH AN
EXTENSIVE LIST OF RIGHTS WHICH
HAS THE FACT OF INSULATING
OFFICERS FROM ACCOUNTABILITY.
WHEN THEY- HAVE COMMITMENT
COURSE BE FOLLOW TECHNICAL
VIOLATIONS THAT DO NOT IMPAIR
THE RIGHTS OF OFFICER OFTEN
PRECLUDE AGENCIES FROM
ADDRESSING SERIOUS MISCONDUCT.
THE BILL DOES NOT INTEND TO
ENCOURAGE EMPLOYEES TO ENGAGE IN
PROCEDURAL VIOLATIONS INVITING
PROCEDURAL ERRORS RUNS THE RISK
OF LOSING THE CASE AND COULD
MAKE THEM SUBJECT TO SUBSTANTIAL
CIVIL PENALTIES NOR DOES THIS
BILL AIMS TO TAKE AWAY RIGHTS
AFFORDED TO OFFICERS. TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT TODAY IS VERY WANT TO
GRAB PAST PRESIDENT AND NATIONAL
ACADEMY ARBITRATORS AND LECTURE
AT BERKELEY LAW SCHOOL AND
RONALD YANK A RETIRED
ENFORCEMENT UNION TURNING BURKE
REPLACED THE PAST RECORD CAL HR
UNDER GOVERNOR BROWN. THERE
THERE ARE ALSO AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHTS. EXPECT
THE BEEN HERE DAY. OKAY RUN
ISSUE OR I'M VERY WINOGRAD ARE
ME HAVE BEEN BY THE CHAIR. I
WANT TO SAY PRELIMINARILY EIGHT
AND A HALF HOURS PLUS WE'VE BEEN
HERE I'VE RUN A DOZEN MARATHONS
IN MY LIFE I'VE PRESIDED OVER
HUNDREDS OF HEARINGS SITTING ALL
DAY IN HEARINGS I TIP MY IF I
WAS WEARING A HAT I TIP IT. YOU
DESERVE IT AND I WISH THE PUMP.
THE DEPTH AND SCOPE OF YOUR
PROBING OF ISSUES OF PUBLIC
SAFETY WITH THAT SAID- I AM A
MEMBER OF THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
REFORM STUDY GROUP ALONG WITH
RON. THAT'S A SMALL GROUP SIX OF
US. WE HAVE I THINK CUMULATIVELY
OVER FOUR HUNDRED YEARS OF LIFE
LIVING EXPERIENCE WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE OUR LATE SEVENTIES AND
WE'RE ON THE YOUNGER END OF THAT
GROUP. RIGHT IT INCLUDES JOE
GRODINOF FORMER JUSTICE OF THE
SUPREME COURT AND A LABOR LAWYER
AND PROFESSOR EMERITUS AT HAYES
A STINGS INCLUDES FELTON
HENDERSON RETIRED U. S. DISTRICT
COURT JUDGE- THE NORTHERN
DISTRICT OF CALIFORNIA- WHO
PREVIOUSLY WAS IN THE CIVIL
RIGHTS DIVISION OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT. IT INCLUDES
CATHERINE FIST A PROFESSOR OF
LAW BERKELEY. IT INCLUDES JOHN
TRUE A FORMER LABOR LAWYER. AND
FORMER SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY INCLUDES NAY AND
INCLUDES RUN. AMONG US WE HAVE
PROBABLY ABOUT TWO HUNDRED YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE IN LABOR RELATIONS
AFTER GEORGE FLOYD WAS KILLED-
WE DECIDE WELL WHAT COULD WE DO.
GOT WE GOT TOGETHER TO OUR WHEEL
HOUSE IS LABOR RELATIONS WHAT.
IN FOREIGN AND I FOUR OF US YOU
ARE HAVE BEEN UNION LAWYERS IN
OUR LIFE- WE DID NOT WANT TO
ABOLISH COLLECTIVE BARGAINING WE
DID NOT WANT TO GIVE ALL POWER
TO POLICE CHIEFS. WE ARE NOT AT
THAT END OF THE POLITICAL
SPECTRUM WE DECIDED WE COULD
COME UP WITH SOME PRETTY DECENT
REFORMS AND WE PUT TOGETHER A
PACKAGE. AND WE THANKED US
SENATE BRADFORD. FOR GIVING
CONSIDERATION TO ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT PIECES IN THIS PACKAGE
THIS WHAT WE'LL CALL THIS
HARMLESS ERROR BILL. IT FILLS A
GAP IN THE OPPO BAR- WHICH NOW
ONLY HAS A HE'S A VERY SPECIFIC
PROVISION AS TO ENFORCEMENT AND
IT ALLOWS FOR WIN THIS.
LEGISLATION THIS ACT IS
INCORPORATED IN COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS WHICH IS
UP AND DOWN THIS. ARBITRATE AS
THE TIME FOR ME WELL THERE WAS
THIS TECHNICAL PROCEDURAL
VIOLATION REACTIVE FOR THIS
PARTICULAR POLICE OFFICER SHOULD
NOT BE FOUND TO ENGAGE IN
WRONGDOING WHAT THAT GAP THIS IS
IMPORTANT FOR POLICE TO CAD
COUNT ABILITY IT ENDS RELIANCE
ON TECHNICAL PROCEDURAL
VIOLATIONS- THAT WILL EXCUSE
MISCONDUCT THAT IS OTHERWISE
PROVEN WHERE THERE'S NO
PREJUDICE THERE'S NO LOSS OF
THIS IS OF A SUBSTANTIAL RIGHT
IMPORTANT FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
BECAUSE- I. WENT UP A- CREATES A
BAR REINSTATEMENT OF SERIOUS
WRONGDOING WHEN THERE'S NO
PREJUDICE IN TERMS OF
SUBSTANTIAL RIGHTS ON THE
MERITS. IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
TRANSPARENCY IT ALLOWS THE
PUBLIC TO SEE WHAT IS GOING ON
WITHOUT BURYING WRONG DOING
BEHIND SOME TECHNICALITIES IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR YOU. I AM ACTUALLY
QUITE. IS THAT. THERE ARE SO
MANY UNIONS WHO'VE EXPRESSED-
CUT UNIFORM OPPOSITION- WHEN I
AM I AM TOLD AND PRIVATE THERE
ARE UNIQUE BLUES WHO THINK THIS
IS GREAT. ON HAVE TO BE
REPRESENTING SOME OF THE- V. P.
WRONGDOERS TO CLOG UP THEIR OWN
CALENDAR DETENTION. AND BY THE
WAY NO PROSECUTION A GROUP
THAT'S IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL SO THAT'S IN INTERESTING. I
TOLD HEALTH. IS THE IMPORTANT TO
THAT THERE ARE OTHER REMEDIES
AVAILABLE. AND AND I THINK THAT
REALLY SUMS UP WHAT I HAVE TO
SAY ABOUT THIS- THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION WE THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR ATTENTION AND SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT SO WHERE A- POLICE
OFFICER DEPUTY SHERIFF GETS OFF
ON A LOCAL A TECHNICALITY A POOL
BAR VIOLATION- IT LOOKS HORRIBLE
TO THE PUBLIC AFTER GEORGE AND
VARIOUS OTHER ATROCIOUS IT
INCIDENTS THAT WERE VISIBLE TO
US ALL ON ON TELEVISION. OF
THERE WAS A BACKLASH AGAINST
ARBITRATION- IN GENERAL. NOW
THAT'S NOT SO TERRIBLE FOR A
WINNING UNION SIDE BECAUSE THEY
CAN SAY LOOK THE ARBITRATORS
LIKE A JUDGE HE SHE HEARD IT ON
THE MERITS WE HAD A BETTER CASE
WE WON. BUT WHEN THE OFFICER
GETS OFF ON A TECHNICALITY IT
LOOKS LIKE HOLY HECK- TO THE
GENERAL PUBLIC THINK ABOUT HOW
OF WHAT WOULD HELP BILL COSBY
IT'S RELEASED FROM FROM PRISON
AND THE HORROR OF THE PUBLIC- TO
THAT. WHEN THE PUBLIC THINKS
THAT THERE ARE DIRTY COPS. IN
OUR DEPARTMENTS- THERE IS A HUGE
BACKLASH BY THE WAY LET ME JUST
GIVE A QUICK EXAMPLE OF A
TECHNICAL VIOLATION- THAT- WOULD
NOT ALLOW A REVERSAL IN OUR
SITUATION SO THERE'S A TWELVE
MONTH REQUIREMENT BUT APARTMENT
LARGE OF A PROBLEM THEY STARTED
INVESTIGATION THEY GOT A YEAR TO
GO AHEAD AND BRING CHARGES. BUT
BECAUSE OF POLICE DEPARTMENTS
BEING UNDERSTAFFED THEY SEND
EVERY COPY OF GOD ADAM STREET
THE PAPERWORK IS LATE IT COMES
IN IN THIRTEEN MONTHS HOWEVER IN
THIS CASE THE OFFICER KNEW LIKE
IN MONTH ONE WHO ALL THE
WITNESSES AGAINST HIM OR HER
WE'RE GOING TO BE SO BECAUSE THE
CHARGES WERE BROUGHT IN THIRTEEN
MONTHS INSTEAD OF UNDER TWELVE
THE OFFICERS SUFFERED NO
PREJUDICE AT ALL AND THAT CASE
SHOULD NOT BE THROWN OUT AND YOU
ARE. COMPARE I'M SUCH KIDS AN
ANY EVENT TO THE PA BACKLASH- ON
THE PERCEPTION AND OTHER THAN
THE REALITY OF DIRTY COPS FROM
YELLOW TO GEORGE FLOYD INCIDENT
TO THE BLACK JOGGER IN AND AWAY
INTO A SUBURB IT CETERA. THIS IS
ALL OVER THE MEDIA. WORD OF
MOUTH OBVIOUSLY POLICE OFFICERS
ARE INNOCENT ONES THE VAST VAST
MAJORITY ARE NOT ANYWHERE NEAR
THE KIND OF VICTIMS- OF THOSE
WHO SUFFERED FROM POLICEMAN'S
MISCONDUCT OR OR THEIR FAMILIES
AND LOVED ONES NONETHELESS
MORALE HAS JUST DROPPED LIKE
LIKE A STONE. WHAT YOU HAVE IS
AN INCREDIBLE NUMBER OF
RETIREMENTS RESIGNATIONS YOU'VE
GOT A- MUCH LESS INTERESTED IN-
YOUNG BRIGHT COOKIES THAT WE
WANT TO BE- IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
JOINING- AND APPLYING FOR POLICE
ACADEMIES WHAT DOES THIS MEAN.
THIS MEANS UNDERSTAFFED POLICE
DEPARTMENTS LESS PROFESSIONAL
POLICE DEPARTMENTS AND OBVIOUSLY
LESS TRUST BETWEEN THE PUBLIC ON
THE ONE HAND AND- THESE OFFICERS
ON THE OTHER. IN A WAY AND AS
BERRIES SAID. GETTING DIRTY COPS
OUT OF DEPARTMENTS CAN EASILY BE
SEEN AS A BENEFIT TO UNIONS THEY
DON'T HAVE TO SPEND THEIR LEGAL
DEFENSE MONEY DEFENDING SUCH
OFFICERS HAD CETERA I'M GONNA
COOK CLOSE WITH. THIS BILL.
AUTHORED BY SENATOR BRADFORD
DOES NO PREJUDICE TO ONE OFFICER
IF THERE'S A POOL BAR VIOLATION-
BECAUSE HE SHE- AGAIN IN MY
THIRTEEN MONTH VERSUS TWELVE
MONTH OF THE OFFICER KNEW THE
WITNESSES ALL THE WAY SUFFERED
NO PREJUDICE BY VIRTUE OF THE
DELAY SPEAKING ABOUT HOLD HALF
BOWLS BURYING ME WE'D BE HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS FROM ANY
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE THROUGH
THE- THIS. YOU SO MUCH SIR- I'M
WOULD YOU MIND STATING YOUR NAME
AND YOUR- AND WE'RE FROM FOR THE
RECORD PLEASE ALL RIGHT SO MY
NAME IS RON YANK- I WAS A-
UNIONS ARE. A TURN FOR LIKE
THIRTY YEARS I RETIRE FOR COUPLE
YEARS JERRY BROWN GETS SELECTED
JERRY BROWN ASKED ME TO SWITCH
SIDES OF THE TABLE AND REPRESENT
THIS STATE. AND HIM AND
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGAINST
THE UNIONS THAT REFUSED TO CLOSE
AN AMMO YOU- WITH ARNOLD
SCHWARZENEGGER. OF SO- I TOLD
THE GOVERNOR I COULD DO IT ONLY
FOR A YEAR BECAUSE MY FAIR. MOST
IMPORTANT. IN THE BAY AREA. AND
THEN THREE YEARS LATER I TAKE A
JOB WITH FELTON HENDERSON TRYING
TO CLOSE THE CONSENT DECREE- OF
THE OAKLAND POLICE DEPARTMENT.
SO I'M AYE THERE WAS ANOTHER JOB
I HELD I'M ON MY THIRD
RETIREMENT THAT BUT THE TWINS
GOING TO STICK. YEAH BUT I THINK
RUN ONLY HAD TO PENSIONS. IN IN
. RECOGNITION OF RUN HE DID NOT
SAY THAT THE UNIONS HE
REPRESENTED FOR THIRTY PLUS
YEARS FOR PUBLIC SAFETY POLICE
AND FIRE AT THE STATE LEVEL AND
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL ALL OVER THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THERE
WERE FEW IF ANY. WHO A FEW HAVE
ANY. THE KIDS. WHO HAD A
DEPRESSIVE PRACTICE AND THE
TRUST IN PRACTICE THAT RUN HAD.
SO I'LL JUST ADD THAT IN
DEFERENCE TO- MY CALLING. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ADD TO BOTH OF YOU
FOR BEING HERE AND TESTIFYING
NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE- IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
EIGHTY EIGHT. LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU. DO
WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TEN EIGHTY
EIGHT CENA WILL MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ARE VERSUS AND-
WE WILL TAKE TEN MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THE ROW AT THIS TIME. I
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM IF YOU DON'T MIND
CHECKING THE LINE ONE MORE TIME
JUST READ TO ASSURE OURSELVES
THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORT WITNESSES. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB TEN EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM MODERATOR HAVING HEARD
FROM ALL SUPPORTERS WILL NOT
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE
FROM THE OPPOSITION WE DO HAVE
TO LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES- WE
HAVE DAVID- MUSTARD. MUSTARD
GARNI JUNIOR AND I APOLOGIZE IF
I MISPRONOUNCE YOUR NAME I
BELIEVE MAYBE IN PERSON- I AM
OVER THE LINE. DAVID ARE YOU ON
THE LINE. YES I AM CAN YOU HEAR
ME ABSOLUTELY PLEASE PROCEED SIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND GOOD
EVENING I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF PORAC. I'M A LABOR
ATTORNEY IN FACT I STUDY LABOR
LAW UNDER PROFESSOR WINOGRAD AT
BERKELEY. AND I UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROCEDURAL
REPRESENTATION RIGHT. WHICH IS
WHY WE ARE SO IMPORTANT. MY
CLIENTS AND I HAVE WORKED WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND LEADERSHIP TO
ADDRESS MANY OF THE CONCERNS
UNDERLYING THE STILL. INCLUDING
MODERNIZING FOR STANDARDS
INCREASING TRANSPARENCY AND
CENTER BRADFORD TO DELL. WHICH
SET UP PROCEDURE FOR
DECERTIFYING OFFICERS WHO COMMIT
. THERE IS MISCONDUCT. I'D FIRST
LIKE TO CLARIFY WHAT WILL BE OUR
DOES AND DOESN'T THOUGH. YOU'LL
BE ARE PRIMARILY PROVIDES
PROCEDURAL RIGHTS DURING AN
INVESTIGATION THAT LARGELY
MIRRORED THE RIGHTS THAT UNIONS
HAVE. IT'S NOT ABOUT GETTING OFF
ON A TECHNICALITY IT'S ABOUT
THINGS LIKE BEFORE AN OFFICER IS
QUESTIONED OR INTERROGATED THEY
RECEIVED NOTICE THE RIGHT TO GET
A REPRESENTATIVE THE RIGHT TO
RECORD THE INTERVIEW THE RIGHT
TO USE THE RESTROOM. IT'S ALSO
ABOUT DUE PROCESS. THAT OFFICERS
RECEIVE THE RIGHT TO ACCESS
THEIR PERSONNEL FILE REVIEW
ADVERSE COMMENTS RIGHT REBUTTALS
OBTAIN EXCULPATORY MATERIAL THAT
ARE WITHHELD FROM AN INTERNAL
AFFAIRS INVESTIGATION. THESE
REMEDIES ARE REALLY MODERATE. I
MERRILY DEAL WITH THE
ADMISSIBILITY OF THE ACCESS TO
EVIDENCE. THE FIRST REMEDY THAT
YOU USUALLY SEE IS SUPPRESSION
IS MODELED AFTER THE
EXCLUSIONARY RULE IN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE. UNLAWFULLY OBTAINED
STATEMENTS OR EVIDENCE MAY BE
EXCLUDED WERE APPROPRIATE SECURE
A VIOLATION AND TO THIS
INCENTIVIZE AGENCIES FROM
CONTINUING TO HAVE FURTHER
VIOLATIONS SECONDLY IT ALSO FOR.
AIMED AT IMPROPERLY WITHHELD
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT AS
ADMINISTRATIVE APPEALS OFTEN
PROCEDURES AND ACCESS TO THAT
INFORMATION I'VE SUCCESSFULLY
ENFORCED POV ARE RIGHT ON
SEVERAL OCCASIONS OVER MY CAREER
AND I CAN TELL YEAH IN NONE OF
THOSE CASES IN A PROCEDURAL
VIOLATION RESULT IN A DISCIPLINE
BEING OVERTURNED. MOST OF THE
CASES I'VE HANDLED INVOLVED THE
SUPPRESSION OF OFFICERS
STATEMENT WHERE THEY WERE
UNLAWFULLY INTERROGATED WITHOUT
A UNION RAP. IN THOSE CASES
WITHOUT EXCEPTION THE COURT
EXPRESSLY ALLOW THE AGENCY TO
CONTINUE TO PURSUE THE
DISCIPLINARY CASE BUT SIMPLY
PROHIBITED THE AGENCY FROM USING
THE ILL GOTTEN STATEMENT. IN
FACT IN ALL OF THOSE CASES. THE
CIRCUMSTANCES WERE AN OFFICER
WAS INTERROGATING CARYATID
WITHOUT A RAPID WITHOUT NOTICE
ON THE SPOT THEY WERE
SUBSEQUENTLY SENT TO INTERNAL
AFFAIRS AND THE RIGHTS WERE
AFFORDED TWO ONE AND THE
SUBSEQUENT STATEMENT IN INFERNAL
AFFAIRS IS IT AND WAS ADMISSIBLE
IN THE COURT ALLOWS THE CASE TO
GO FORWARD JUST LIKE IN A
CRIMINAL CASE WHERE. EVIDENCE IS
IMPROPERLY OBTAINED. THE OTHER
TYPE OF CASES THAT I'VE DEALT
WITH INVOLVED ACCESS TO MATERIAL
MIGHT IN FACT ARE YOU ONE OF THE
SEMINAL IS. THE SACRAMENTO
POLICE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
VERSES AND I GUESS THAT
PUBLISHED THIRD DISTRICT COURT
OF APPEAL DECISION. THAT
ESTABLISHED THAT PEACE OFFICERS
HAVE A RIGHT TO ACT THAT ADVERSE
COMMENTS CONTAINED IN THEIR
INTERNAL AFFAIRS FILES THAT ARE
USED TO HINDER. THEIR CAREER
PATH MISTER MAGOO. MR MYSTIC
JUST TO LET YOU KNOW THAT-
YOU'RE JUST ABOUT TWO MINUTES
AND IT'S GOING INTO THE SECOND
WITNESSES TIME FRAME- HELLO
ALPALA. AB THE SECOND LEAD
OPPOSITION WITH WITNESS MISTER
RYAN SHERMAN IS GIVING UP HIS
TIME OR A LOT OF TIME THAT YOU
MAY NEED IN ORDER TO TESTIFY SO.
PLEASE PROCEED. I APPRECIATE
THAT- AND THANK YOU RYAN. THIS
BILL IS ALSO AN UNNECESSARY
BECAUSE THE SUPREME COURT RULED
A LONG TIME AGO IN NINETEEN.
EIGHTY EIGHT. THAT SB IT'S AN
ABUSE OF DISCRETION. TO OVERTURN
DISCIPLINE OR EVEN THERE'S A
PRESS THE STATEMENT CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES OVER MINOR
VIOLATIONS. THE GREEN COURT
PRESIDENT IS BINDING ON EVERY
CORNER IN CALIFORNIA INCLUDING
ON THE MINISTRY OF BODIES THE
COURT IN THAT CASE LAY DOWN
ABOUT FOUR ANALYSIS WHEN
CONSIDERING A VIOLATION AND SAID
THAT REINSTATEMENT IS NOT
PROPER. WHERE THE EMPLOYER WOULD
HAVE REACHED THE SAME CONCLUSION
WITHOUT THE KHOBAR VIOLATION NOT
VERY CONSISTENT WITH ALL OF MY
EXPERIENCES THE COURT EVEN IN
THAT CASE THAT THIS IMPRESSION
WAS THAT ARE IT WHEN THEY.
TEACHER IT TURNS IT BACK IN THE
COURT SAID ALSO THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS APPROPRIATE IN SOME
CASES. WHERE IT'S AN EFFECTIVE
DETERRENT. THIS BILL WOULD
PREVENT THE TRIER OF FACT FROM
HAVING THE DISCRETION TO FASHION
A REMEDY FOR POPE ARE VIOLATIONS
WHENEVER THE EVIDENCE OF
MISCONDUCT IS THE NAME AGAIN AND
NOT. WAITING TO THE BILL
OUTWEIGH THE SIGNIFICANT OF THE
VIOLATION. IT WOULD CREATE A
PERVERSE ENDS JUSTIFY THE MEANS
INCENTIVE FOR INVESTIGATORS THAT
WOULD BE UNACCEPTABLE IN ANY
OTHER CONTEXT. NO ONE WOULD
SUPPORT ALLOWING POLICE
INVESTIGATORS THE VIOLATE
MARANDA OR FOURTH AMENDMENT
RIGHTS JUST BECAUSE THE
INVESTIGATORS BELIEVE THE
SUSPECT. COMMITTED A SERIOUS
CRIME THE SAME APPLIES HERE.
RIGHT THE CONVERSE IS REALLY
TRUE THE MORE SERIOUS THE MATTER
THE MORE IMPORTANT IT IS FOR
INVESTIGATORS TO FOLLOW THE
RULES AND FOR PEOPLE THE RIGHT.
THIS BILL GOES TOO FAR BY
ELIMINATING THE TRIER OF FACT
ABILITY TO EXCLUDE IMPROPER
EVIDENCE AND INCENTIVIZING
INTERROGATION VIOLATIONS BY
ELIMINATING AGENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY WE SHOULD NOT BE
ENCOURAGING ANY LAW ENFORCEMENT
INVESTIGATOR TO CUT CORNERS.
ORDER I ONLY WRITE IN ANY
CONTEXT WE NEED A CULTURE THAT
FOSTERS OFFICERS AFFORDING
RIGHT. AND MISTER CHAIRMAN YOUR
BILL SB TWO ALSO OBVIATES THE
NEED FOR THIS BILL. BECAUSE
THAT'S THE TO PROVIDE. PROCEDURE
YOU SORT OFFICERS. WHO ENGAGED
IN SERIOUS MISCONDUCT.
SIGNIFICANTLY YOU'LL BE ALRIGHT
DO NOT APPLY AT ALL IN THE SB
TWO DECERTIFICATION PROCESS OR
PROCEDURES. THAT IT'S
UNNECESSARY CLUTTER PEEL BR WITH
A BALANCING TEST BETWEEN THE
VIOLATION. AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE
A LAST MINUTE ON THAT TO CLOSE-
THE YOU'VE BEEN GIVEN- MR TIME
MISTER SHERMAN'S TIME AS WELL
JUST ABOUT TWO AND A HALF
MINUTES. I THAT WAS ACTUALLY MY
LAST I'M JUST GONNA CLOSE WITH
SB TWO ALREADY DEFINED THREES
MISCONDUCT AND THAT PROCESS
OPERATE COMPLETELY INDEPENDENTLY
APPEAL B. R. AND THE DISCIPLINE
PROCESS RIGHT I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND I APOLOGIZE FOR
GOING OVER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME YOU WILL NOT. THIS
IS HERE. TWELVE NUMIS GERMANS
FRENCH GERMAN- WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
ALSO- IN OPPOSITION- JOINED BY
THE POLICE OFFICER ASSOCIATIONS
OF CLAREMONT CORONA POMONA
PALACE VERDES NEWPORT BEACH PLUS
CANADA BE SURE ASSOCIATION
UPLAND PO A SAM AND APPEAL WAY.
IT WAYS OF. BURBANK ARCADIA
RIVERSIDE VALLEY SCHOOL PLEASE
FOR TEN P. LA AND CULVER CITY
PEEL AWAY ALL OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH DO YOU
HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SEE NON WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE OR
RESIST WILL TAKE TEN MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE FROM THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF SB TEN EIGHTY EIGHT WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB HAD
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. FIND
THREE ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE MANAGER AND MEMBERS NOT USE
AYE RULING ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION A LOT THAT LOOKED AT
EACH YEAR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MACINNES LEAVE EVERYTHING
IN CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU RYAN THREE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE
MEMBERS SHANE WILL BE IN ABOUT
CALIFORNIA'S STATEWIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION RETURN
ORDER POLICE CALIFORNIA LODGE IN
THE SHERIFF'S EMPLOYEES BENEFIT
ASSOCIATION OF SAMBAR DINO
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I HAVE NOT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IF YOU WOULD MIND
CHECKING THE- PHONE LINES ONE
MORE TIME AT A MODERATOR TO
ASSURE HERSELF THAT WE HAVE
HEARD FROM ALL OF OUR WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB TEN EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE SEVEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
HAVE NO COMMENT THANKYOU THANK
YOU MADAM MODERATOR AND WE WANT
TO THANK ALL OUR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL NOT
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR
MEMBERS. HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. PERFECT SENATOR
BROTHER WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. IF
YOU WANT TO THANK MY WITNESSES
BOTH MR. WINOGRAD AND MR YANG
FOR YOUR EXPERT TESTIMONY ALSO
WON APPRECIATE- THE COMMENTS BY
THE OPPOSITION BUT- THE
OPPOSITION'S. IN A POSITION IS
NOT NEW IT HAS BEEN LIKE THAT
SINCE ALMOST THE BEGINNING OF
TIME WHEN IT COMES TO TRYING TO
REFORM IN. ASKED LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO BE HELD TO THE SAME STANDARDS
AS THE GENERAL PUBLIC AS EVERY
DAY AND THAT THIS IS ALL TAT
THIS MATTER DOES IT DOESN'T
STRIP AWAY. ANY OF THE POLICE
OFFICERS BILL OF RIGHTS IS JUST
ALLOWS US IN FAR TOO MANY GEORGE
FLOYD TO RODNEY KING DRAWN
SETTLESTO SANDRA BLAND'S-
OFFICERS WHO HAVE BLATANTLY
VIOLATED. THEIR JOBS- OF THEIR-
THE BADGE IN MANY WAYS IS WALL
AND GO ONCE GAVE THEM THIS
JESSICA HOW HOLDING OFFICERS
ACCOUNTABLE JUST LIKE YOU HOLD
THE GENERAL PUBLIC SO THIS IS
ALL WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS- TREAT
EVERYBODY FAIRLY AND- LAW
ENFORCEMENT SHOULD BE ABOVE THE
LAW AGAIN THIS IS NOT ABOUT
SUCH. A STRIPPING AWAY ANY
RIGHTS AND IF ANYTHING I THINK
THOSE 99% OF THE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO PUT THAT UNIFORM ON EVERY
DAY AND IT HERE TO THOSE
GUIDELINES WOULD APPRECIATE A-
KIND OF. ON THE LINE TO BEGIN IT
- I WON'T SEE EASIER BY A FOR
WAY OF WHOLE- WHO VICE THE RULE
OF LAW AND ACCOUNT AND THIS IS
ALL THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH
THIS RANGE AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD JUST LIKE TO COMMENT
THAT IT WAS ACTUALLY PRETTY- AS
A FORMER TEACHER THOUGHT IT WAS
PRETTY- THREE- NEED TO HAVE A
PROFESSOR IN THE STUDENT I HEAR
TESTIFYING AT THE SAME TIME AND
OUT OF. IN THIS CASE A WRITTEN
THIS A PIECE OF LEGISLATION ON
OPPOSING SIDES BUT I THINK IT'S
REALLY NEAT TO SEE. A PROFESSOR
AND HIS STUDENT- GOING BACK AND
FORTH IT'S PRETTY A I THINK IT
SAYS A LOT ON- IT'S- ON YOUR
PART AS A PROFESSOR. SEPT GOOD
AS AN ADVOCACY. SO DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. THANK YOU YOUR MOTION BY
SENATOR COM LOCKERS THE MOTION
IS. DO PASSED BUT FIRST WE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE AND
APPROPRIATIONS. M. CANCEL PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON S. B. TEN
EIGHTY EIGHT SB TEN EIGHTY EIGHT
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE INTRO
BOGUE. TRUCKLOAD NOT VOTING COM
LONGER COME UNDER AYE SKINNER
WIENER. WE WILL LEAVE THAT- BILL
OPEN FOR OUR ABSENT MEMBERS.
SENATE BRADFORD YOU HAVE A
SECOND BILL SB TWELVE SIXTY TWO
. YES WE HAVE TWELVE SIXTY TWO
WHICH WILL RETURN PUBLIC COURT
RECORD ACCESS TO THE STATUS QUO
BY ALLOWING THE SEARCH AND
FILTER RESULTS OF INDIVIDUALS
EIGHT- BIRTH AND DRIVER'S
LICENSE NUMBER ON THE MAY. TWO
THOUSAND AND ONE. I MEAN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ALL OF US OR NONE
VERSUS HAMBURG WAS DECIDED BY
THE CALIFORNIA FOURTH DISTRICT
COURT OF APPEALS. IN THAT RULING
THE COURT CALLED FOR THE REMOVAL
OF TWO IDENTIFIERS DATE OF BIRTH
AND DRIVER'S LICENSE AND- NUMBER
FROM PUBLIC RECORDS MANY COURTS
HAVE SINCE REMOVED THE ABILITY
TO SEARCH AND FILTER RECORDS
BASED ON DATE OF BIRTH AND A
DRIVER'S LICENSE NUMBERS AS A
RESULT OF INDIVIDUALS. WHO NEED
TO UNDERGO A BACKGROUND CHECK
PROCESS TO SECURE OR WORKER
HOUSING OR WHO HAVE- PROVIDED
THERE ARE I'D I'D IDENTIFIERS
FOR THIS PROCESS ARE BEING
STALLED OR STOPPED COMPLETELY IN
THE BACKGROUND CHECK PROCESS
THIS TOO LATE.
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
INDIVIDUALS WITH COMMON NAMES
AND PREVENTS THESE INDIVIDUALS
FROM BEING ABLE TO SECURE WORKER
HOUSING ON A TIMELY BASIS. IT IS
A- IN THOSE ARE REQUIRE TO PUT
BACKGROUND CHECKS ON APPLICANTS
CAN NO LONGER USE THESE
IDENTIFIERS WHEN CONDUCTING
RECORD CHECK THEY WILL BE LEFT
WITH. NOTHING BUT NAMES AND
LITTLE OR NO WAY TO ASSOCIATE
THE COURT RECORD WITH A SPECIFIC
INDIVIDUAL. THE ALL OR NOTHING
ALL OF US- NINE VERSUS HAMBURG
DECISION DID NOT. NOW SAID IT
AGAIN DID NOT PROHIBIT THE USE
OF BACKGROUND CHECKS ENTIRELY
NOR DID IT PROHIBITS BEING ABLE
TO SEARCH THE COURT INDEXES
COMPANIES NONPROFITS APARTMENT
OWNERS AND OTHERS WILL CONTINUE
TO PERFORM. BACKGROUND CHECKS ON
APPLICANTS REGARDLESS OF THE
OUTCOME OF THIS BILL WHETHER IT
BE FOR LIABILITY OR INSURANCE
PURPOSES OR ORGANIZATIONS
WANTING TO MAINTAIN IS SAFE IS
ENVIRONMENT THE HAMMER DECISION
NOT CHANGED PROP. ARE IN. USE OF
THESE DENTAL FIRE. WHEN
SEARCHING WE ARE ALONG THE DELAY
IN THE PERSON'S BACKGROUND CHECK
BY BEING CALM PLEADED. AND THE
THEIR APPLICATION. ACCEPTED EVEN
IF THE APPLICANT PROVIDES THOSE
IDENTIFIERS WILLINGLY FOR THE
PURPOSE OF A BACKGROUND CHECK. I
AM CAN YOU COMMITTED TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH OPPOSITION TO FIND
AN EFFECTIVE WAY TO REMEDY THIS
ISSUE. OF THESE BACKGROUND
CHECKS NOT BEING COMPLETED IN A
TIMELY MATTER BUT ENSURING THAT
INDIVIDUALS WITH CRIMINAL
RECORDS CONTINUE TO HAVE
MEANINGFUL ACCESS TO HOUSING AND
EMPLOYMENT. TESTIFYING TODAY IN
SUPPORT IT'S COVERED ALL OVER X.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF. CHECKER
.ORG IN OSCAR SCHELLER-
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF MORONGO
GAMING AGENCY. WE ALL HAVE ERIC
ELLMAN SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF
CONSUMER DATA. INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AVAILABLE AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS AND I RESPECT LESS
RELIABLE. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD- BELIEVE WE HAVE MR KEN
OLIVER IN PERSON. HI MY NAME IS
KEN OLIVER I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT CHECKER DOT ORG HOW
GREAT TO SEE SOME FAMILIAR FACES
A HERE IN THIS HEARING TODAY- I
LIKE TO START OUT JUST BY GIVING
A LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT ABOUT MY
OWN BACKGROUND- I AM JUSTICE
IMPACTED- FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO.
DON'T KNOW- I SPENT TWENTY FOUR
YEARS AND CAL PUBLIC BINS AND
UPON MY RELEASE TO THE BAY AREA
WENT TO WORK FOR A PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW FIRM AS A POLICY
DIRECTOR- SOME OF THE FOLKS WHO
HAVE UP TESTIFIED FOR AND WITH-
IN THE WORK AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WAS IMPORTANT TO ME-
I'M ALSO. BANDBOX WHAT HAD A OP
. TO WORK WITH A LOT OF
DIFFERENT COMPANIES UP AND DOWN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
EDUCATING THEM AND DOING
ADVOCACY. FAIR CHANCE
EMPLOYMENT- SINCE I'VE BEEN
HOME. I'VE ALWAYS LOOK FOR
MEANINGFUL WAYS TO IMPACT THE
JUSTICE IMPACTED COMMUNITY IN A
POSITIVE WAY- AFTER MY STINT AS
A POLICY DIRECTOR I WENT ON TO
LEAD. A WORKFORCE DEVELOPING
ORGANIZATION BY THE NAME OF CROP
WHERE I WAS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND PARTNER WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD TO BUILD OUT THE- REST OF
THE DENTURE. THREE TEXANA
PROGRAM- IN ENTRY- SINCE MY WORK
THERE I NOW WENT ON TO WORK IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR CHECKER DOT
ORG- SOME COMPANY MISSION. IS
FAIR CHANCE EMPLOYMENT IN FACT
CHECKER IS A TECH COMPANY IN
CALIFORNIA. BOY MORE PER. IMPACT
WHO'VE COME. AS IN ANY OTHER
COMPANY IN CALIFORNIA TECH
COMPANY THAT IS. CHECKER IS A
BACKGROUND CHECK COMPANY. BUT
THE MISSION AS I MENTIONED IS
FAIR CHANCE EMPLOYMENT AND
EMPLOYEE OVER SEVENTY- JUSTICE
IMPACTED PEOPLE AND THEY'RE
FUNDAMENTALLY RETHINKING
BACKGROUND CHECKS BASED WHEN I
LOOK AT THE WORK IN THE THAT I
DO EVERY DAY TO GET PEOPLE TO
LEVEL. ACCESS AND I'M A BIT. THE
THIS IS AN EXTENSION OF THE FAIR
CHANCE ACT BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS ACCESS TO
LIVABLE WAGE JOBS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA- I SUPPORT SB
TWELVE SIXTY TWO BECAUSE IT
WOULD RESOLVE A LOT OF THE
DELAYS THAT DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECT. BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA FROM ACCESSING
WORK. I MEAN AT THE END OF THE
DAY THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT HELPING PEOPLE ACCESS WORK
THE QUICKEST IN THE FASTEST. AND
THAT'S ESPECIALLY TRUE WHEN
INDIVIDUALS HAVE GIVEN CONSENT.
FOR BACKGROUND CHECKS IN ORDER
TO ACCESS EMPLOYMENT- FOR MYSELF
I WOULD DO A BACKGROUND CHECK
EVEN THOUGH I DID TWENTY FOUR
YEARS IN A CALIFORNIA PRISON AT
CHECKER AND OTHER COMPANIES THAT
I WORK FOR- AND THAT WAS AN
IMPORTANT STEP. IN ORDER FOR ME
TO GET TO THE H. R. PROCESS TALK
ABOUT. SOME OF THE MISTAKES THAT
I'VE MADE IN MY LIFE AND MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT TO DECORATE- A THAT
LEVEL WEIGHT AND I'VE BEEN ABLE
TO ACCESS- I WOULD EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT THERE I ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT. SOME OP POSITION THE COURT
BACKGROUND CHECK- I WOULD JUST
SAY AS MUCH AS I LOVE I'M A PROP
REVOLVES ARE NONE. DO LEGALS.
AND I THINK THAT THE APPROACH
ABOUT PRIVACY GOOD ONE- BUT I
ALSO THINK THAT ONCE THOSE OF US
WHO'VE BEEN IMPACTED GIVE THAT
PERMISSION TO COMPANIES TO
ACCESS OUR OWN PERSONAL
INFORMATION WHICH IS YOU KNOW
IT'S A PUBLIC RECORD AT THAT
POINT- THAT WE SHOULD BUT ALLOW
YOU TO ACCESS OUR INFORMATION AN
EXPEDIENT MANNER SO THAT WAY
DOESN'T DELAY THE HIRING PROCESS
SOMETIMES CAN TAKE TWO THREE
FOUR FIVE MONTHS DEPEND ON THE
COURT L. A. COUNTY IT'S GOTTEN A
LOT BETTER BUT THERE'S ON THE
COUNTER A LOT SLOWER- AND SO IT
ACTUALLY DOES HAMPER US FROM
BEING ABLE TO ACCESSIBLE IMAGE-
THAT'S MY TESTIMONY TODAY AND
THAT'S WHY SUPPORT TWELVE SIXTY
TWO WOULD APPRECIATE AND- BE
MORE THAN GLAD TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IF THERE ARE ANY.
THANK YOU MISTER OLIVER. WE HAVE
A SECOND- WITNESS IN SUPPORT
OSCAR. SCHULLER AND I BELIEVE
YOU ARE ON THE LINE. HE HEARS
OSCAR. MADAME MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ON THIS ROSTER SCHULER ON
THE LINE. I DO NOT SEE HAVE
LINED OUT AT. OKAY WHILE WE WAIT
FOR OUR SECOND LEAD WITNESS%
LET'S CONTINUE WITH ANY
WITNESSES AND ROOM ONE TWELVE DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
HI SB TWELVE SIXTY TWO HERE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. HELLO MISTER
MEMBERS AS DOUBLE CHECK- WITH
THE LOS ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT. CONTINUE
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS BERNIE
OROZCO WITH CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS RYAN ELAINE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
I'M HERE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
WILL IT- WISHING TO- SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. AT TWELVE SIXTY
TWO. SCENE NINE LET'S MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS WILL TAKE
TEN MINUTES OF TESTIMONY MADAME
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
BUY IN SB TWELVE SIXTY TWO WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE SIXTY TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE
THREE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING ASHLEY
HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE THREE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
ALSO PART THANK YOUNG. THANK YOU
LINE THREE SEVENTEEN PLEASE FOR
HER SHE- ALLEN PRESIDENT OF THE
INTERNATIONAL COALITION OF ALL
OF THE CONSERVATION QUALITY AND
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. NINE THREE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING AND LIDELL ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION
LEAGUE IN SUPPORT. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE SIXTY
TWO PLEASE PRESS WHY. ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR YOU WOULD MIND
PLEASE CHECK POINTS ONE MORE
TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE HEARD FROM ALL OUR SUPPORT
WITNESSES. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
SIXTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR- WE GIVE ONE LAST
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR XIN SAY LAST
. WE'LL GIVE ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY
FOR US FOR SURE. I DO NOT SEE A
BLIND ALBUM OKAY PERFECT THANK
YOU MADAM MODERATOR I WILL NOW
PROCEED WITH OUR LEAD OPPOSITION
WE DO HAVE TWO WITNESSES ON
RECORD IF JOSHUA KIM NATIONAL
DIRECTOR OF LITIGATION FOR
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY. ROOT AND
REBOUND I BELIEVE YOU ARE ON THE
LINE JOSH RIGHT CAN YOU HEAR US. I DO NOT SEE THE LINE FOR
JOSHUA ARE DIALED IN. HE DOES.
JOSHUA. NOT A MODERATOR WE
BELIEVE HE IS ON THE LINE. MAYBE
CALL THE ONE MOMENT.
I DO NOT SEE FIND OUT AND. HE'S
CURRENTLY COMMUNICATING WITH-
STAFF HERE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE SO
HE'S HE BELIEVES HE IS ON THE
LINE. FOR GOSH I WONDER IF YOU
ARE ON THE LINE PLEASE PRESS
STAR ZERO SO I CAN OPEN YOUR
LINE. SURE HE HANG UP AND CALL
BACK AGAIN ARE YOU GONNA. THERE
ARE THREE WIDE OPEN. THANK YOU I
APOLOGIZE ON MY LINE WAS
CONNECTED AT. CHESHIRE CAMPAIGN
THE NATIONAL DIRECTOR OF
LITIGATION AT ROOT AND REBOUND A
WE PROVIDE SERVICES FOR PEOPLE
WITH CRIMINAL RECORDS. CLEAN
SLATE AND LICENSING I'M ALSO THE
LEAD COUNSEL IN ALL OF US AREN'T
NINE VERSUS HENRY WHICH IS WHAT
SHE- DESCRIBED IN THE- COURT
AGREED RESPECTFULLY. ASK YOU. P.
R. WELL- HOW ARE DID SHE TO FAST
AND EASY CHECK HARM NEEDED COLOR
. RESTORE INTENDED THE- CALLS.
PERSON IS HIS. AT TWELVE FIFTY
TWO AND IS HEADQUARTERED.
CRIMINALIST SHOULD BE EASY
OBTAIN. WORRIED THAT EMPLOYERS
MIGHT BE USED TO HIRE OF COLOR
TAKING PRECLUDE BURKE IT HAVE NO
RECORD. UPDATE IT OKAY FIFTY
NINE WOMEN QUICKLY IF HE'S NOT.
HURRICANE DOES NOT OF EMPLOY WHO
HOME REQUIRED TO A BACKGROUND
CHECK AND ACCESS TO IT YOU AS A
BACKGROUND CHECKS WORK. AND
REFUSED. YOU'RE NOT THE ONE YOU
POSSIBLE RISK CAN. IN FACT IT'S
SUCH A- WOULD. THEIR CHANCE. AND
WE HAVE YET TO SEE ANY EMPLOYER
IN FACT TAKING THAT ROLE IN REAL
LIFE. BUT WE HAVE SEEN PLAYERS
MAKING A PROBATIONARY HIGHER
PENDING THE RESULT OF A
BACKGROUND CHECK. AND WE HOPE
AND YOU TIME ORDERS WOULD BE
ENCOURAGED TO WORK BILL
BACKGROUND CHECKS ALL TOGETHER
MAKING THEIR HIRING DECISIONS
BASED ON. MORE RELIABLE EVER.
ERICA IS STILL. IS THAT. FINALLY
BILL VIOLATES THE CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO PRIVACY. CONCERNS BY
THE COURT EIGHTY FIVE FURTHER
THE ASIAN RESPECT THE COURAGE TO
GO AGAINST THAT THE BILL AS IT
IS WRITTEN TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- JOSH- WE
HAVE A SECOND WITNESS ONLINE
FIDELL CHOCOLATE. CAN YOU HEAR
US. IF HEARING YES FIDEL PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD EVENING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS FIDEL SUGA I'M A GRADUATE
STUDENT IN THE SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
REDLANDS AND ORGANIZER WILL
RIVERSIDE ALL THE SONORA WHERE
LOCAL CHAPTER OF ALL OF US IN
THE NATIONAL ORGANIZATION LED BY
FORMALLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE TO
FIGHT FOR THE RIGHTS OF
CURRENTLY AND FORMERLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE WE ARE HERE
TODAY AS- I HAVEN'T USED WHICH
IS BILL SEEKS TO UNDERMINE. THE
SUB COMMITTEE OPPOSES BILL WILL
BRING BACK THE HARMFUL PRACTICE. SHE AND- BACKGROUND CHECKS ONE
BACK CHECKS BE CAN FOR ANY
REASON ANY IN OUR FORMALLY.
PEOPLE AND PREVENTS FROM FINE
PLAN AND HEALTH NEEDED JUST A-
REIMBURSES. AND A FORMER
INCARCERATED PERSON MY
EXPERIENCE WILL BACKGROUND
CHECKS HAVE BEEN DETRIMENTAL TO
MY HEALTH AND WELL BEING. I WORK
FOR A COMPANY WHEN I FIRST
RETURNED HOME AFTER A CERTAIN
AGE AND YOUR SENSE AND- AFTER
WORKING WITH THIS COMPANY FOR
TWO YEARS I WAS PROMOTED TO A
MANAGER POSITION. AND EXPERIENCE
NAVIGTIONAL. LET PATIENTS. I'M
NOT BE HAVE CONTROL YEARS
EXPERIENCES LIKE THIS PEOPLE ME
WHO HAVE BEEN JUST AS A BACK
FROM OF CHANGE SENATE WILL
FINANCE MOBILITY TO FOR MYSELF
AND MY STORY NOT YOUR FOR MANY
CARS TO PEOPLE R. COSTA ON A
AFTER THIS TRYING INCLUDING
THROUGH THE USE OF HONEST BACK
CHECKS CONDUCTED THE POTENTIAL.
FOR YEAH SB TWELVE TWO WHAT.
THEY'RE HAVING BLOWING WHICH PUT
IMPORTANT PROTECTION IN PLACE
PREVENT THE USE OF A NEXUS.
DISCRIMINATORY BACK CHECKS WE
STRONGLY URGE THE SUBCOMMITTEE
TO OPPOSE SB TWELVE SIXTY TWO
THANK YOU- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FIDEL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY
WILL MOVE ON TO ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWELVE SIXTY
TWO. NO WITNESSES. I'M IN
OPPOSITION OKAY WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
OR VERSUS WILL TAKE TEN MINUTES
OF TESTIMONY. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
S. B. TWELVE FIFTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THE ROLE AT THIS
TIME. WHY THREE FORTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FIVE ANALYSTS WOULD
LEGAL SERVICES CENTER CHILDREN
COMMENTS JOHN APPLICATION. SB
TWELVE FIFTY TWO THANK YOU. ZERO
NINE THREE THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ADRIANA
MOLECULAR CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE SERVICES TO PRISONERS AND
CHILDREN ALL IN IN OPPOSITION TO
SB TWELVE FIFTY TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M THREE FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME S DENY IT WITH
COMMUNITY LEGAL SERVICES HOW
ALSO AND WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
SB TWELVE SIXTY TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M THREE FORTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BY THREE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I AGREE
WITH ALL OF US BUT NONE ARE WE
RESPECT WE HAVE TO OPPOSE BASED
ON THE FACT THAT ARE UP POINTS
WERE NOT CONSIDERED IN THIS BILL
AND IT VIOLATE- HELLO ARE-
HOUSING RIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT FORTY. GO AHEAD.
NINE THREE FOUR ZERO. HELLO
HELLO YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
LOVE FOUNDING OF ALL OF US IN ON
AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN AND I ABSOLUTELY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AND THEN AGAINST
EVERYTHING WE GET AROUND-
BANDBOX. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND CHECKING THE LINES
ONE MORE TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM ALL.
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO ASK B. TWELVE
SIXTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I DO HAVE ONE MORE
COMMENT IN HUMAN HISTORY ONE
MOMENT.
NINE THREE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
ROBINSON AND I'M WITH TRYING
DEAD AND MUNITY DOLLARS AND-
WITH ALL OF THE NINE SACRAMENTO
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. PLEASE
NOTE THAT ALL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR AND THANK YOU TO OUR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WHEN I BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO OUR MEMBERS TO ANY MEMBERS
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY CNN SENATOR BROUGHT FOR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. ARE YES
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY I WANT TO THANK
THOSE WHO CALLED IN IN
OPPOSITION BECAUSE I HEAR YOUR
CONCERNS LOUD AND CLEAR BUT I
THINK. THIS PROVIDES AN
ADDITIONAL SAFEGUARD THAT IS
NOW- BEEN A- SOMEONE IN INCOME
PARENTS TOO AGAIN FINDING
EMPLOYMENT BY CONFUSING
INDIVIDUALS WITH SIMILAR. NAMES
AND JUST IMAGINE THE NUMBER OF
BURNING OROZCO'S THAT MIGHT BE
OUT THERE THAT YOU CONFUSED- SO
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE RIGHT PERSON'S
DATA AND I. JUST INDIVIDUALS
WITH SIMILAR LAST NAME SIMILAR
FIRST NAMES IN WHICH DELAYS THIS
PROCESS AND I OF ALL PEOPLE
INDIVIDUALS AND VERY MUCH.
CONCERNED WITH NOT. YOU KNOW I
NECESSARILY LOOKING INTO
PEOPLE'S BACKGROUND I DID THE
FIRST BACKGROUND BAN THE BOX IN
TWO THOUSAND AND TEN- WHEN I WAS
IN THE ASSEMBLY SHOW I. TOTALLY
SUPPORT BUT EVEN WITH A BAND THE
BOX IT DOESN'T PROHIBIT SOMEONE
FROMDOING A BACKGROUND CHECK
AND THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE FAIL TO
UNDERSTAND EVEN WOULD BAN THE
BOX YOU CAN STILL DO A
BACKGROUND CHECK. ON SOMEONE-
BECAUSE WITH THE INTERNET.
NOTHING PRIVATE. SO ALL DOES IT
STREAMLINES THAT BACK SURGERY
BACKGROUND CHECKS. IN NARROWS IT
DOWN TO A BIRTHDAY AND A
DRIVER'S LICENSE SO WE KNOW
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE RIGHT. JANE
DELL VERSUS FIFTY OTHER ONES OUT
THERE THAT. MIGHT WIND UP. AND
NOT BEING EMPLOYED ARE.
CONFUSING THEM WITH SOMEONE ELSE
AND IN PREVENTING YOU FROM-
WHATEVER HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES SO WE
WILL CONTINUE TO. ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS- THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPRESSED BUT I THINK IN THE END
OF THE DAY I HATE IT I THINK
IT'S GOING TO GREATER AND
GREATER SAFEGUARDS CANNOT FIND
THE RIGHT INDIVIDUAL WHEN WE
DOING BACKGROUND CHECKS SO- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SENATOR BRADFORD WE HAVE A
MOTION. THANK YOU SENATOR COME
LONGER THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE AND APPROPRIATIONS.
CANCEL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
SB TWELVE SIXTY TWO PLEASE. SB
TWELVE SIXTY TWO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I INTRO BOGUE I ABOAGYE
COM LONGER. COME I SKINNER
WIENER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
KEEP THE ADS WILL OPEN FOR OUR
ABSENT MEMBERS. SENATOR BRADFORD
YOU HAVE ANOTHER BILL SB TWELVE
SEVENTY THREE. WHEN YOU'RE READY
BOB SENATOR- THAT'S- TWELVE
SEVENTY THIRTY FOUR THIRTY THREE
OTHERS TO TWENTY THIRTY OCTOBER
TWENTY THIRD- THIS BILL WILL
ELIMINATE THE MANDATORY
REQUIREMENTS THAT SCHOOLS NOTIFY
LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR A WIDE RANGE
OF STUDENT BEHAVIOR SUCH AS
POSSESSION OF CANNABIS OR
ALCOHOL OR ANY ASSAULT ON A
SCHOOL EMPLOYEE DECADES RESEARCH
AND ANECDOTAL GO- STUDENTS AND
PARENTS LONG TERM HARM TO YOUNG
PEOPLE OF EVEN MINIMAL CONTACT
WITH JUVENILE OR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. BLACK STUDENTS
TO ATTEND STUDENTS STUDENTS OF
COLOR AND STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY REFERRED TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT CITED AND
ARRESTED HOWEVER EXISTING LAW
OFTEN FORCES SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS AND STAFF TO
NOTIFY LAW ENFORCEMENT EVEN WHEN
THEY KNOW THIS WILL BE HARMFUL
TO STUDENTS REBELS OF THE
PARTICULAR CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE
INCIDENT OR THE INDIVIDUALS-
STUDENTS SITUATION AND SOMETIMES
CASES THESE WALLS EVEN AUTHORIZE
EDUCATORS TO BE FINE FOR FAILING
TO REPORT SUCH INCIDENTS AND
ESPYS TWELVE SEVENTY THREE WILL
REDUCE LONG FOR BERMAN
INVOLVEMENT IN SCHOOLS AND GIVE
TEACHERS AND ADMINISTRATORS WHO
ARE OFTEN BEST. TO THE TERM
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE THE
FLEXIBILITY AND THE POWER NEEDED
TO SUPPORT WHY HELLO STATE MAN
FIRST CODE LAW ENFORCEMENT
INCREASING AT YOUR DESCRIPTION
TERMINATE WHEN THE FIRE ALARM.
FORCED TO LIMIT AB. TWO SHIPS
GROUP. ALL TO REPORT INCIDENTS
AND ELIMINATING THE CODE FOR
DOES. OF PUBLIC SCHOOL AND
PUBLIC SCHOOL ME HOWEVER I'M A
MANY THE BILL TO RE AND THE
CRIMINAL PENALTY FOR WILLFUL
DISTURBANCE TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
RAISED BY SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AND WILL STILL- WHILE
STILL PROTECTING STUDENTS FROM
UNDERSERVED CONTACT WITH THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
SPECIFICALLY. THIS SECTION SHALL
NOT APPLY TO ANY PERSON WHO IS A
PUPIL CURRENTLY ENROLLED IN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT. THIS CHANGE
WILL ENSURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
MEET OUR IN KENT A PROTECTING
STUDENTS WHILE HOLDING
ACCOUNTABLE INDIVIDUALS WHO
DISTURB SCHOOL MEETINGS AND
ALARMING TREND WHICH THAT WE'VE
SEEN GROW ACROSS THIS COUNTRY
DURING THIS PANDEMIC TESTIFYING
TODAY. ARE YOU SELLING DOING-
WITH ACLU- CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
BELEN DELGADO WITH THE LORD
SUPPORTERS FOUNDATION
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS SENATOR
PROPER WE WILL NOW CONTINUE WITH
THEIR WITNESSES WANTING TO
TESTIFY WE HAVE SALLY CHIANG ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. YES OF EXCEL
YES WE CAN PLEASE PROCEED. HI
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS HI
CHIANG AND I'M A LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE AT THE ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTIONS WITH THE PRODUCT COULD
CONSERVE SB TWELVE SEVENTY THREE
ELIMINATE STATUTORY MANDATES
THAT FORCE EDUCATORS TO CALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT EVEN WHEN THEY KNOW
THAT IT IS NOT THE RIGHT
RESPONSE TO AN INCIDENT. ARE
ONLY A PART. OF THE CALIFORNIA
REPRESENT STUDENTS IMPACTED BY
THESE OVERREACHING AND IT TODAY
I WILL SHARE SOME OF THEIR STORY
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE ASK
ME A LOT AND THE EIGHTH GRADER
WAS RECOMMENDED FOR EXPULSION
THE ALLEGED SCALE KANDERSTEG
HAPPENS AT THE REQUIRED UNDER
HEAD COACH FORTY NINE OH TO SEE
WHICH MANDATE THAT. OF ONE
FOURTH FOR ANY AND A STUDENT
CONDUCT A CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE
LOS ANGELES SCHOOL OAKLEAF
CONTACT. ONE THING WITH ASKING
BETA HERMAN'S THE MATTER SHOULD
BE HEARD BY THE IN THIS CASE
EVEN THE POLICE STATION.
INTERGENDER TWENTY TWENTY LI
LONNIE IN LATIN FRESHMAN THE TAX
BY ANOTHER STUDENT. THE ONE HE
HAD NO INTENTION OF FIGHTING
ONLY STRUGGLE TO GET AWAY.
DURING THE ATTACK OF SEPTEMBER
PHYSICALLY INTERVENED AND LONG
TURNING BACK AROUND LEE LANI
UNINTENTIONALLY MADE CONTACT
WITH HIM. SHE IMMEDIATELY
APOLOGIZED AND COMPLY WITH ALL
OF HIS INSTRUCTION. THEY ONLY
HAD NO FORMER BEHAVIORAL ISSUES
AND HAD NEVER BEEN IN. THE
QUALIFICATION. WE WANT INJURIES
INCLUDED SCRATCHES. BRUISES AND
- IN THERE ARE NO CURRENT MARKS
ON THE- BODY. ONLY ONE HOPE WAS
TAKEN WILL BE OFF OF. ALTHOUGH
THE OFF STATED HE AND THE
TEACHING. ANY CONTACT WITH ACTED
AND THAT THE STUDENTS STATEMENT
MATCH THE TEACHERS HE HAD ABOUT
ACCORDING ISSUED CITATIONS. AS A
RESULT WE LONG BATTERY AND
ASSAULT CHARGES. WE WANT BRIDGE
PACK A DURING SCHOOL. AT THE
JUVENILE COURT. THE COURT
ALLUDED TO THE FACT SCHOOL
OVERREACTED. UPON COMPLETION OF
COUNSELING AND COMMUNITY SERVICE
THE CASE WILL LIKELY BE. WE WANT
SHOULD NEVER BEEN TAKEN TO THE
CORPORATE OFFICE LET ALONE
SUBJECT TO A CITATION I THINK
TALK TO ME VERY WILL ENSURE THAT
SCHOOLS AND EDUCATORS HAVE THE
DISCRETION THEY NEED TO DECIDE
ON THE BEST RESPONSE TO EACH
CASE. AND WILL CONTACT THEIR
ALARM ANTHONY LEILANI AND MANY
OTHERS NUMBER ONE LAW
ENFORCEMENT BROUGHT IN. FACT I
DON'T THINK. THREE THANK YOU.
OPEN ALL RIGHT. THIS IS THE
FIRST- MELENDEZ RATHER ARE YOU
IN THE ON THE LINE. YES PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU- GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATOR GRASSLEY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE MY NAME AVAILABLE
ALTHOUGH MY CONDO SHE HER NAME
HERE IN SUPPORT OF S. T. W.
THREE I HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR
STUDENT SAFETY IN SCHOOLS IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN FIRST OF A HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT AND NOW AS THE
EDUCATION PROGRAM ASSOCIATE A
LOT OF RECOMMENDATION DURING MY
TIME WITH DEMOCRATS DISTRICT I
WAS WITNESS TO HARSH OF THE
FIELD AND CRIMINALIZATION. OF
STUDENT FOR MINOR OFFENSES. WHY
WAS THAT THE LARGER INTO TWENTY
ENTER OCCURRED CAMPUS WHICH IS
A- WHAT RESULTED IN TEN COULD
CARS. OUT OF OUR- OPPOSITION
BOTH. ACTUALLY COLUSA PARTNER
CLASSICAL THE FOG WERE CALLED
UPON YOU TO AN ALTERCATION
INVOLVING STUDENT BY. DURING
UNDERCLASSMEN MUCH AFTER THEY
STEPPED FOOT ON CAMPUS ALONG
WITH CAMPUS SECURITY- THE ONLY
AGGRAVATED THE SITUATION BY
PULLING PUSHING AND PEPPERS
SPRING STUDENT. EVEN THOUGH NOT
INVOLVED IN THE FIGHT. FOR HER
BY THEIR NEGLIGENCE. I'M CALLING
FROM BACKING. CRYING AND SCARED
NOT KNOWING THAT A LOT WOULD
HAPPEN. I'M NOT ONLY MY- LIVES
YEAR BUT MINOR WELL AS A STUDENT
BEING TRAUMATIZED BY THE COLD
THAT MANY BUT HAVING ONE. ON
SCHOOL PROPERTY I'M NOT NIGHT OF
LAUGHTER DOMINO YOU HAVE BLACK
AND BROWN I PASSION ABOUT THIS
ISSUE BECAUSE WE HAVE NEVER BEEN
A WALKING A FOR OUR COMMUNITY.
WHAT WE NEED TO BE A BANKER AND
I'M BOTH MENTORS THERAPISTS AND
MENTAL HEALTH OF BURKE AND OUR
SCHOOLS THE COMPANY LEVERAGING
BAYRAVAND WESTERNERS DON'T
RECALL GAUGE IN A MANNER THAT IS
HEALTHY TO THEM. WE SHOULD NOT
EIGHT AND THAT INCOME ARE YOU
ONE OF THE PHONES THAT YOU'RE
GOING WHAT THEY WANT AND HOW
THE- AND NEEDS. TO HAVE A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL STUDENTS.
CLEVELAND OF THE- WILL BE.
SCHOOL POLICE AND GETTING BOND
WAS. FROM TO BE ELOQUENT HANDLES
. HANDLE STUDENT. ONE CALL TO
HAND DISCIPLINE ISSUES. IN THE
MONTH OF YOUR- AS- WITH. BY
CAMPUS. TO SHOW THAT ACTS STILL
NEEDS TO BE. OUR PROTECT
STUDENTS PLEASE BE WELL BEING
EDUCATE. WHAT ABOUT THE USE OF
COLUSA. I HAVE. TO CONFESS THE
LIVE OF EACH IN THE STATE WE THE
POWER KNOCKING TO HARM DURING
AND FOR I'M NOT FALLING ONE
SENATE AND- THE- TO THE DEATH OF
THE FOR ESPECIALLY FROM.
INFRACTIONS AN OPPORTUNITY SUCH
AS THIS TO BE. TO THE OUR-
BECAUSE THEY WERE HELP YOU TO
PRISON PIPELINE. YOU SHOULD KEEP
. OVER ACTUAL OF BUT SHE DID A
ON HOW. AND PERFECT. OF COMMON
LEMONS YOU I URGE YOU AGAIN TO
VOTE IN FAVOR OF SB TWELVE
SEVENTY THREE AND I THINK YOU
GOT THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
TODAY. AND TO SHARE MY STORY AND
OBERNOLTE. AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND I'M GLAD TO ANSWER.
ANY OF YOUR QUESTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE LAN WE
WILL NOW BEGIN WITH AN WITNESSES
HERE IN A ROOM ONE TO. IS OF S.
B. TWELVE SEVENTY THREE. SCENE
NINE WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY AT
THE TELECONFERENCE OFFICES WILL
TAKE TEN MINUTES OF TESTIMONY
ABOUT A MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE FROM THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWELVE SEVENTY THREE. WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE TO
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WELCOME YORK MONEY IT WILL BE ON
THE BACK OF YOUR RECORDS AND YOU
WANT ONE HELLO WE ARE CLOSED OFF. FROM WORK AT. YOUR THANK YOU
I'M THREE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MEMBERS MY
NAME IS SALLY KING I'M WITH THE
ADVANCEMENT PROJECT CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN THREE FIFTEEN FOR
YOUR CALL HAVE. NUMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE'RE PROUD TO
CO SPONSOR THE BILL AND URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M THREE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS RIGHT
HELLO YOUR LAW SCHOOL BOARD WE
ARE A STRONG PARTNER SB. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT THREE TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WAS AT THREE
TWELVE. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THIS IS KELLY HARDY
WITH CHILDREN NOW AND SUPPORT
THANK. THANK YOU I'M THREE
THIRTY NINE PEOPLE I HAD. ONE
THREE THREE NINE. ANY YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AFTER THAT I DON'T
KNOW THE DELIBERATE AND
BECOME AND- THANK YOU RYAN THREE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING KAREN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ENOUGH WITH
KNOWLEDGE AND I'M A LEGISLATIVE
COORDINATOR AT PUBLIC ADVOCATE
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT SB TWELVE
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAME MODERATOR HAVING HER FROM
ALL THE SUPPORTERS WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR
FROM ANY OPPOSITION WE DO HAVE
AB ONE LEAD. A POSITION THE- ON
RECORD LUCIA MISHLER. ARE YOU ON
THE LINE. OKAY. OKAY SO LET'S
MOVE ON TO ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE IN OPPOSITION OF
TWELVE SEVENTY THREE. THANK
MILLION VICE CHAIR I WOULD BE
ALRIGHT IF I WERE TO. GIVE ABOUT
A MINUTE OR TWO- PRESENTATION
SINCE MISS- MUTCHLER WASN'T ABLE
TO WRITE HER TESTIMONY I
CERTAINLY. THANK YOU. THE
THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS OF THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
AND NUMEROUS LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT GROUPS MANY OF WHICH
REPRESENTS SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICERS WHO SWORN DUTY IS TO
PROTECT THE CHILDREN ENSURE
THEIR SAFETY ON CAMPUS.
INCLUDING THE CLAREMONT PL A IN
THE PLA'S OF CROP MONOCLE'S
FORESEES NEWPORT. UPLAND SANTA
ANA BURBANK. INGLEWOOD ARCADIA
RIVERSIDE. THE ONLY SCHOOL
PLEASE FOR TEN CULVER CITY PO
WAYS ALL ARE EXTREMELY OPPOSED
TO- SB TWELVE SEVENTY THREE A
MEASURE THAT WOULD ENDANGER OUR
SCHOOLS. TEACHERS RESOURCE
OFFICERS AND ESPECIALLY THE
STUDENTS. THIS ILL CONCEIVED
BILL SEEKS TO PROTECT THOSE WHO
ENTER SCHOOL GROUNDS TO HARM
OTHERS. CURRENT LAW PROVIDES
THAT ANY PERSON WHO WILLFULLY
THE SERBS WILL SKIP OVER THAT
PART I THINK IT WAS TAKEN CARE
OF IN THE AMENDMENTS MY
APOLOGIES- I. THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS IS THAT.
THE GOAL OF THE SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICERS TO PROTECT THE KIDS.
AND THIS BILL WOULD MAKE IT MUCH
MORE DIFFICULT BECAUSE- MANDATED
REPORTERS WILL NO LONGER BE
MANDATED TO REPORT TO THEM FOR
MANY OF THESE CRIMES- THAT ARE
OCCURRING ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES
INCLUDING BRINGING. A DEADLY
WEAPONS ON CAMPUS- ASIDE FROM
FIREARMS. THERE'S SOME OTHER
THINGS- THAT THIS BILL WOULD
ALSO NO LONGER REQUIRE THESE
MANDATE REPORTERS PROVIDE-
CONTACT TO LAW ENFORCEMENT- SO
WE'RE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
ALSO I KNOW THAT THE ADVOCATES
HAVE. A MENTION THAT WHILE
THEY'RE STILL ALLOWED TO REPORT
OR JUST NOT MANDATED TO REPORT
HOWEVER THERE'S SECTION THE BILL
THAT STRIPS THE CIVIL IMMUNITY
PROTECTIONS FROM THESE
REPORTERS. AND SO THAT'S A
CONCERN FOR US BECAUSE NOW
PEOPLE WHO MAY REPORT AND GET IT
TO INCORRECT- WILL BE SOLELY
LIABLE FOR MAKING SUCH A REPORT
WHEREAS RIGHT NOW THEY HAVE THE
PROTECTIONS UNDER THE MANDATED
REPORTER LAWS SO FOR THOSE AND
MANY OTHER REASONS THAT I WON'T
GET INTO RIGHT NOW WE REMAIN.
STRONGLY REQUEST THE- MISTER
SHERMAN- DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES HERE IN OPPOSITION TO
SB TWELVE THIRTY THREE SEIGNER-
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ARE VERSUS WILL
TAKE TEN MINUTES OF TESTIMONY
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD PLEASE.
PLEASE PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF SB TWELVE SEVENTY THREE WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB TWELVE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MATTER MODERATORS
WOULD MIND CHECKING THE LINES
ONE MORE TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'VE GIVEN EVERYBODY AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB TWELVE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MATTER
MODERATOR AND THANK YOU TO ALL
OUR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WILL NOT BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE MEMBERS.
DO ANY F OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS- SENATOR
KAMLAGER. YEAH I JUST WANNA SAY
THAT- EMINEM BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME I
MOVE IT- YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S
JUST IMPORTANT TO SAY. THAT NOT
EVERY SOLUTION. NEEDS TO INVOLVE
LAW ENFORCEMENT I THINK YOU
KNOW. SCHOOL SETTINGS ARE ABOUT
LEARNING. AND THERE ARE SO MANY
WAYS. THAT ADULTS ARE INTERESTED
IN- INNOVATIVELY CREATIVELY.
COLLABORATIVELY FINDING WAYS TO
ENSURE THAT RESPECT. AN ORDER
ARE HAPPENING IN SCHOOL
SETTINGS. I MEAN WE JUST HAD A
SITUATION HERE WHERE PEOPLE WERE
UNHAPPY WITH A VOTE. AND THEY
SCREAMED OBSCENITIES. INCREDIBLY
DISRUPTIVE. NO ONE THOUGHT TO
CALL LAW ENFORCEMENT. TO SETTLE
THAT. AND SO I THINK THE OLD.
MORE OFTEN THAT WE DECIDE THAT
EVERY PROBLEM DESERVE SOMETHING
IN THE PENAL CODE. THE GREATER
WE SET OURSELVES UP FOR FAILURE
. AND WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
OTHER WAYS TO SOLVE PROBLEMS TO
RESOLVE CONFLICT TO ASK FOR
ENGAGEMENT IN SO MANY SCHOOLS
PARENTS VOLUNTEERS ALUMNI ARE
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN MAKING SURE
THAT SCHOOL SETTINGS. HAVE THE
KIND OF CULTURE THAT PROMOTES
BOTH CIVIL DISCOURSE. YOU KNOW
AS WELL AS LEARNING AND OTHER
FORMS OF ENGAGEMENT SO IT
BECOMES TIRESOME TO THINK THAT
EVERY ANSWER HAS TO BE AN
ADDITIVE TO THE PENAL CODE LAW
ENFORCEMENT DOESN'T WANT TO HAVE
TO BE THE SOLUTION TO EVERY
SINGLE THING. AND WE HAVE TO
COME UP WE HAVE TO AT SOME POINT
IN KNOWLEDGE THAT THE HUMAN
CONDITION INVOLVES TENSION. AND
AS LONG AS YOU'RE NOT VIOLENTLY
ATTACKING SOMEONE OR DOING
SOMETHING ILLEGAL SOMETIMES
TENSION IS OKAY. AND SORT OF A
PRESSING SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH
THIS NOTION THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
SHOULD BE ENGAGED IS NOT HEALTHY
AND MANDATED REPORTERS ARE NOT
ALWAYS APPROPRIATELY TRAINED IN
OFTENTIMES THEY ARE RECORDING
WITH BIAS. AND THEY ARE
INCREDIBLY CONSERVATIVE IN WHAT
THEY SAY BECAUSE THEY'RE NERVOUS
ABOUT BEING LIABLE FOR SOMETHING
SO I DON'T WE SHOULD ALSO A RACE
FROM OUR MIND THE THINKING THAT
MANDATED REPORTERS ARE CLOSE TO
GOD IN WHAT THE REPORTING WHAT
THEY SEE. SORRY FOR THE RANT
BECAUSE I KNOW WE'VE BEEN HERE
REALLY LONG TIME. BUT I JUST HAD
TO SAY THAT AND I'M GONNA BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR COME. YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. I'M
CENTER COMMAGER YOU MOVE THE
BILL YEAH. OKAY. ANYONE ELSE.
I'M SO JUST FOR THE RECORD ARE
THE SERGEANTS CONSIDER PEACE
OFFICERS. YEAH THE ONES HERE.
THERE IF. THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE
NOT.
GOT IT OKAY PERFECT- SO WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR COME LONGER
THE MOTION IS. DO PASSED BUT
FIRST REFER. TO HAVE THE RIGHT
ONE. DO PASSED BUT FIRST WE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- LET OF THE
SULTAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. OH
SORRY I APOLOGIZE THE NUMBER
THIRTY. WHEN- YOU GUYS HERE ANY
LONGER THAN YOU NEED TO BE BUT I
JUST THINK THIS IS A COMMON
SENSE MEASURE WE'VE JUST SEEN
OVER THE LAST COUPLE YEARS THE
NUMBER OF KIDS. AS YOUNG AS FIVE
YEARS OLD BEING HANDCUFFED AND
ARRESTED BY POLICE AND IT MAKES
ABSOLUTELY NO SENSE AND ONE
PARENT JUST WON A RECORD HE SAYS
HE SEVEN YEARS OLD HE'S NOT A
CRIMINAL. AND AT SOME POINT YOU
HAVE TO QUIT TREATING KIDS LIKE
THEY'RE ADULTS AND LIKE ANY ACT
OF MISBEHAVIOUR WILLFUL DEFIANCE
AS WE'VE SEEN AFRICAN AMERICAN
LATINO KIDS HAVE BEEN EXPELLED
FROM SCHOOL ADDED NORMA'S RATE
COMPARED TO THEIR WHITE
COUNTERPARTS BASED ON WHAT IS
WILLFUL DEFIANCE NOT BRINGING
HOME WORKER AND I HAVE AN
OPINION PAPER DID IT DO CLASS
WORK BEING SENT TO THE PRINCE'S
OFFICE AND BE REFERRED TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND I COMMAND LA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT BOARD
MEMBER- GEORGE MCKENNA FOR
TAKING THE INITIATIVE TO MOVE TO
REMOVE UNIFORM OFFICERS OFF THE
CAMPUSES I MEAN WHEN I WENT TO
SCHOOL WITH HIM UNIFORM OFFICERS
AND IT'S STILL NEED FORM THERE I
MEAN WILL THERE BE TIMES WHEN
YOU NEED TO CALL LAW ENFORCEMENT
YESTERDAY BUT WHEN YOU HAVE A-
KINDERGARTEN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
SCHOOL KIDS ACTING OUT A NORMAL
BEHAVIOR. AS REQUIRE A POLICE
RESPONSE SO AGAIN I HOPE YOU
FIND THIS TO BE A COMMON SENSE
BUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU FOR MUCH AND I
ROUGHER AND WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A REPEAT OR TIMER. OKAY I
DON'T CONSULTANCIES CHOLERA SB
TWELVE SEVENTY THREE BRADFORD TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D SHOW BOTH. TROUBLED
NOT VOTING COM LONGER COM LONGER
AYE SKINNER. SKINNER AYE WIENER. WE WILL CALL THE ROLL OPEN OR
ARE ABSENT MEMBERS. AND ONE MORE. SENATOR BRADFORD- YOU HAVE SB. THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE. ALL
RIGHT GOOD NOT LEAST THIRTY
SEVENTY ONE WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
THE SECRETARY OR CDC ARE TO
INCREASE THE PAY SCALE FOR THOSE
WORKING WHILE INCARCERATED OVER
A FIVE YEAR PERIOD THIS BILL
REQUIRES THAT THIS ADJUSTED PAY
SCALE BE RAISED TO ADEQUATELY
ALLOW AN INCARCERATED PERSON TO
AMONG OTHER THINGS AFFORD
QUARTERLY PACKAGES PURCHASE
EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS AND
MAINTAIN FAMILY CONNECTIONS
EXISTING LAW THAT. STATES THAT
CDC ARCHER REQUIRED EVERY ABLE
BODIED PRISONER IMPRISONED IN
ANY STATE PRISON AS MANY HOURS
OF FATEFUL. IN EACH EVERY DAY
DURING HIS OR HER TERM OF IN
IMPRISONMENT APPROX FOR FIFTY
EIGHT THOUSAND INCARCERATED
PEOPLE ARE ASSIGNED JOBS THAT
HELP MAINTAIN AND OPERATE-
STATE'S PRISONS WE HEARD ABOUT
SOME THE DAY THE OP- OP TO
OPTOMETRIST OR OPTOMETRIC SO
MAKING GLASSES AND- EVEN
UNDERGARMENTS AT SENATOR-
KAMAGRA SHARED. THESE. CAN LEAD
TO YOU KNOW. BANK ONE POINT
HOPEFULLY OUTSIDE BUT THEY ALSO
DO WORK SUCH AS MAINTENANCE AND
CLARKEN CONSTRUCTION LABORS WELL
THESE JOBS WITHIN CDC OURS.
SEPARATE FROM THE PRISON
INDUSTRIAL AUTHORITY JOINT
VENTURE PROGRAM AND THE FAR
CAMPS CAN PAY AS LITTLE AS EIGHT
CENTS. FOR OUR AND AS MUCH AS
THIRTY SEVEN CENTS PER HOUR
INCARCERATED STAFF IN FIRE CAMPS
MAKE UP TO AS MUCH AS THREE
DOLLARS AND NINETY CENTS PER DAY
WHILE THOSE EMPLOYED BY. CAL P.
I A CAN MAKE AS MUCH AS ONE
DOLLAR PER HOUR THIS IS EXPLOIT
THIS EXPLOITATION OF AN
UNACCEPTABLE AND HAS MADE IT
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT TO. FOR
INCARCERATED PEOPLE TO PAY THEIR
CENTER ITEMS AND EVEN HAVE FUN
FOR. A FAMILY CONTACT AND EVEN
THEIR RESTITUTION AS A RESULT
MANY INCARCERATED PEOPLE FORCED
TO LEAN ON LOVED ONES FOR
FINANCIAL SUPPORT WE JUST SAW.
EARLIER IT'S ALSO ABOUT PHONE
CALLS AND BE ABLE TO MAKE. PHONE
CALLS HOME ON WITH THESE HIGHER
WAGES THEY WILL BUILD A FOR TO
MAKE THOSE EXPENSIVE PHONE CALLS
OF THE WAGES EARNED BY THE
INMATE IN THE MONEY TO PUT INTO
A MH TRUST ACCOUNT. BY FAMILY OR
LOVED ONES IS SUBJECT TO A 50%
BEING. THE TECHNICIAN. ARE WE
THAT THAT RESTED AMOUNT FOR
INCOME INDIVIDUALS IS ABOUT SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS HOWEVER AN
INMATE CAN WORK AN ENTIRE YEAR
AS A LABOR AND MAKE EIGHT CENTS
PER HOUR AND AT THE END OF THE
YEAR THEY WOULD HAVE ONLY MADE A
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR DOLLARS
WOULD SEVENTY TWO OF THOSE
DOLLARS GOING TO RESTITUTION
MAKING AN INSIGNIFICANT DENT IN
THE TOTAL MODELED. BY PROVIDING
CURSORY PEOPLE WITH A FAIR WAGE
SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE CAN HELP
PEOPLE FIVE FINANCIAL
RESTITUTION FOR CANTEEN ITEMS
AND I HAVE THE MEANS TO STAY IN
CONTACT WITH FAMILY AND SAVE
MONEY FOR ENTRY EXPENSES THIS
BILL WILL COME WILL CONTINUE TO
BE WORKED WITH DELTA ME
IDENTIFIES CIVIC CHIEF. SO
TRICKS AS WELL AS THE CROWD A BY
REQUEST THE FUND THIS INCREASE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AS ESTEBAN NEWNESS WITH
ANTI RECIDIVISM. AND ALSO DRAW
OSBI WITH COMMUNITY
INTERVENTIONS I RESPECT WEST
RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD WE WILL NOW PROCEED
WITH OUR WITNESSES ARE LEAD
WITNESSES ESTEBAN OON YES ARE
YOU ON THE LINE HE SAID THAT- I
APOLOGIZE NO WORRIES- IT A LONG
DAY. YOU'RE HAS- THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ESTEBAN UNIONS AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION. CALIFORNIA PRIDES
ITSELF ON BEING A LEADER IN
ADVOCATING FOR FAIR AND JUST
WAGES FOR OUR LABOR FORCE
INCLUDING GIG MIGRANT AND
FACTORY WORKERS TO NAME A FEW.
HOWEVER AS IT OFTEN OCCURS THERE
IS ONE FORGOTTEN POPULATION
INCARCERATED LABOR FORCE. THE
LABOR IS ALL THIS CALIFORNIA
WITH DOCUMENTATION OF THIS
PRACTICE DATING BACK TO EIGHTEEN
FIFTY ONE. EVEN TODAY CALIFORNIA
RELIES HEAVILY ON PRISON LABOR A
PAYS INCARCERATED WORKERS
UNFAIRLY AND I'M JUST WAGES.
ALTHOUGH THE PRICE OF GOODS
BEING SOLD TO OUR INCARCERATED
POPULATION CONTINUES TO RISE
THEIR WAGES HAVE NOT BEEN
INCREASED SINCE THE EARLY
NINETEEN NINETIES. INSIDE
PRISONS CANTEEN GOODS ARE MARKED
UP AT 65% OF THE RETAIL PRICE.
IN ORDER TO BUY A BASIC BAR OF
SOAP. WHICH COST AROUND TWO
DOLLARS AND TWENTY FIVE CENTS IN
PRISON SOME INCARCERATED WORKERS
WOULD HAVE TO WORK OVER FIFTY
SIX HOURS. RAISING WAGES FOR THE
INCARCERATED WORKFORCE WOULD
REDUCE RECIDIVISM AND LESSEN THE
BURDEN ON CALIFORNIA FAMILIES.
IN NINETEEN NINETY VOTERS PASSED
PROP ONE THIRTY NINE A STATUS IN
THE JOINT VENTURE PROGRAM WHICH
REQUIRED THE WAGES FOR
INCARCERATED WORKERS WORKING
UNDER THE JOINT VENTURE PROGRAM
TO BE COMPENSATED. TO THE WEIGHT
AS COMPATIBLE WAGES COME
COMPARED TO THE WAGES OF NOT
INCARCERATED PEOPLE WORKING
DOING SIMILAR WORK. AS A RESULT
PEOPLE WORKING UNDER THIS FREE
UNDER THE JOINT VENTURE PROGRAM
ARE PAID AT LEAST MINIMUM WAGE.
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN A PART OF
THIS PROGRAM HAVE A NEWS AND
PERCENT RECIDIVISM RATE COMPARED
TO CALIFORNIA'S 55% FOR THEM
FURTHERMORE THE ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS REPORTS.
THAT NEARLY 65% OF FAMILIES
BECOME UNABLE TO PAY FOR THEIR
VERY BASIC NEEDS WHEN I
HOUSEHOLD MEMBER GOES TO PRISON.
70% OF THOSE FAMILIES WERE
RAISING CHILDREN. NOT ONLY ARE
PEOPLE UNABLE TO PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL FINANCIAL SUPPORT
WHILE INCARCERATED DUE TO THE
CURRENTLY LOW WAGES- THE AVERAGE
INCARCERATED PARENTS CAN- THIRTY
SIX THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS IN CHILD SUPPORT. AND
MANY HAVE TO ASK FAMILY FOR
MONEY. TO COVER BASIC FOOD
HEALTH AND DAILY NEEDS. THE
MEAGER EARNINGS FROM PRISON WORK
ASSIGNMENTS CAN BE ESSENTIAL TO
A PERSON SUCCESS AND EVEN
SURVIVAL. WHEN THEY RETURNED TO
THEIR COMMUNITY BY PROVIDING THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR INCARCERATED
WORKERS TO EARN THEIR FAIR OR
UNFAIR UNJUST WAGES INCARCERATED
PEOPLE WOULD BE ABLE TO AFFORD.
BASIC FOOD HYGIENE PRODUCTS
PURCHASED QUARTERLY PACKAGES
STAY IN COMMUNICATION WITH THEIR
FAMILY AND PURCHASE EDUCATIONAL
MATERIALS. THE FIVE YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION SCHEDULE MAKES IT
FEASIBLE TO GET TO A POINT WHERE
INCARCERATED WORKERS WOULD BE
ABLE TO PAY OFF LARGE AMOUNTS OF
THE RESTITUTION. WHILE HAVING
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET THE
FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITY TO
THEIR PLEASE. REPAIR FOR
SUCCESSFULREENTRY THEREBY
PROMOTING PUBLIC SAFETY FOR
THESE REASONS I PUT ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE SUPPORT SB THIRTY SEVENTY
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RESTAURANTS ARE WE DO HAVE A SIX
SECOND LEAD WITNESS. WE DROVE
OUR SPRING ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
YES I AM I APOLOGIZE WOULD YOU
MIND PRONOUNCE YOUR NAME ONE
MORE TIME. SURE MY NAME IS USED
FEATURE OF THE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MA'AM PLEASE PROCEED. AARON
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS ONLY BE
DRAFTING. CO FOUNDER OF THE WORD
FREEDOM COALITION PROBLEM
SPONSORED SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
ONE AND CONDITION OF KERN COUNTY
WILD CARDS RATE I WAS FORCED TO
WORK IN DIVERSE SELECTION OF
JOBS WITH PAY RATES RANGING FROM
ZERO TO FIFTEEN CENTS AN HOUR. I
CUT GRASS ON YOUR CREW AT&T
MERCHANDISING ARNAR CLEARED AND
EDUCATION ASSISTANT. ALL THE
JOBS INCLUDED TEN DOLLARS OR
LESS. MONTHLY REALIZATION OF
WALKING AWAY FROM CANTEEN WINDOW
WOULD TO VIRUSES SO ONE TWO DAYS
AT A POSTAGE STAMP. MY VERY
EXISTENCE. AT THE BLACK WOMEN'S
INDEPENDENCE IS KEY. BEING SELF
RELIANT IS IMPORTANT. BUT WAS
LAID WHICH IS I HAVE TO CALL
HOME FOR FINANCIAL SUPPORT
BECAUSE I COULDN'T PROVIDE FOR
MY OWN BASIC NEEDS AS AN ADULT.
THE LEGALIZATION THAT I WORKED
EVERY SINGLE DAY FULL TIME
HOURS. NO MEDICAL BENEFIT OR YOU
WILL TAKE TIME WHAT ALARMING. I
KNOW I'M GOING TO SAVE MONEY TO
PLAN FOR SUCCESSFUL REENTRY. NO
I'M MANAGING WERE RE ENTRY WILL
LOOK LIKE WITH INCREASED PRISON
WAGES. IT WILL LOOK LIKE SELF
SUFFICIENCY SELF RELIANT. AND
IMPROVE REHABILITATIVE EFFORTS.
TODAY I IMPLORE YOU TO VOTE I ON
SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH- CEDAR AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR MISPRONOUNCE YOUR
NAME- EARLIER TODAY WELL NOW-
PROCEED WITH WITNESSES ARE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE HERE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. C. NINE. WE
WILL NOW ASK- MODERATOR WOULD
YOU MIND- C. HOPE. WELLNUMBER
ONE TWO WITNESSES WHEN DOES A
FIVE YEAR THE TELECONFERENCE ARE
VERSUS WILL NOW TAKE TEN MINUTES
OF TESTIMONY. IN MODERATE IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE FROM THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
INTO IN. SUPPORT OF SB. THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. NINE THREE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS ALAN
INDEPENDENT OF THE INTERNATIONAL
BEAT THE COLLISION AND WE ARE A
PART OF THE BILL. THANK YOU I
HAVE ONE MORE LIGHT IN HERE
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT. WHY
THREE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU CAN ALSO A CO FOUNDER OF
THE HISTORIANS YOUNG COALITION
WE ARE PROUD BECAUSE BUDGET SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE AND ALSO
ONCE YOU- SO THE PORT FROM THE
YOUNG WOMAN THREE AND SEVEN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND TICKING
NOISE ONE MORE TIME JUST TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM ALL
OUR SUPPORT WITH THIS IS. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR IN HAVING HEARD FROM
ALL OUR SUPPORTERS WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE
FROM ANY OPPOSITION WE DO HAVE-
ACTUALLY WE DO NOT HAVE ANY LEAD
OPPOSITION. WILL NOT MOVE ON TO
WITH WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
HERE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. CENE
NINE. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE OR VERSUS
WILL TAKE TEN MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY. MATTER MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE PROPERTY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF IT SB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE WE WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE.
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I DO OF ONE
MINING HERE TO JUST BE ONE
MOMENT HERE. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR.
YEAH. THANK YOU I WANT TAKE A
COMMENT FROM LYING AT. THREE
FIFTY THREE. ONE SECOND ONE
THREE FIVE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HIMY NAME IS THE ONLY ONE YOU
ARE CALLING ON BEHALF OF LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN I'M NOT SURE DON'T
SUPPORT ARE YET BUT I'M IN A
STRONG SUPPORT AND VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY SEVENTY
ONE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR. HE
WHICH IS YOUR CHECK OKAY. OKAY
SO- THANK YOU TO ALL OUR SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL NOW
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR
MEMBERS TO ANY MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. AND. YEAH
THAT YOU KNOW FAMILY MEMBERS
FRIENDS AND SOMETIMES EVEN
ATTORNEYS END UP SUBSIDIZING
INCARCERATED PEOPLE'S TIME IN
PRISON- AND SO IT ACTUALLY COSTS
. FOLKS WHO ARE IN PRISON TO BE
IMPRISONED AND IT COSTS THEIR
VILLAGE- IT COSTS ARE VILLAGE
FOR SOMEONE TO BE IN PRISON AND
SO I YOU KNOW I PEOPLE I HAD
THIS WITH A CA THREE WHY DO YOU
WANNA YOU KNOW SEE PEOPLE AS
HUMANS- THAT DESERVE TO MAKE
SOME SORT OF DIGNIFIED WAGE. AND
THE COST OF BEING INCARCERATED
IS INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE. AND WE
DON'T REALLY TALK ABOUT THAT AND
SO I AM ACTUALLY APPLAUDING THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT. HOW HARD PEOPLE WORK IN
PRISON AND NOW MEAGER THEIR
WAGES ARE- AND IF THERE'S A WAY
TO TRUST ACCOUNT SO THAT THINGS
CAN BE DEPOSITED FOR THEM WHEN
THEY GET OUT. YOU KNOW WE SHOULD
BE THINKING CREATE ABOUT BEING
HOW TO HELP FOLKS WITH FINANCIAL
LITERACY PLANNING AND THEN HOW
TO HELP THEM WHEN THEY GET OUT-
BECAUSE THAT'S THE CYCLE OF
REHABILITATION RATHER THAN
ASKING FOLKS WHEN THEY LEAVE TO
BE PERFECT TO MIGHT NOT MAKE ANY
MISTAKES AND TO DO THIS WITH
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING. YOU KNOW IN
THEIR BANK ACCOUNTS SO. NUMBER
THANK YOU SENATOR COMMA TO HAVE
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
THEIR SKINNER. YES THANK YOU
THIS IS. THIS IS VERY NEEDED AND
WHILE IT WILL OBVIOUSLY HAVE A
COST AS WAS POINTED OUT IN THE
TESTIMONY. WE. WHAT WE ARE OW
PAYING THOSE IN OUR PRISONS THAT
WHO HAVE JOBS HARDLY EVEN COVERS
WHAT WE THEN CHARGE THEM FOR
THAT WHICH IS IN THE COMMISSARY
OR FOR EVEN NET RIGHT NOW. WE
ARE DURING THE PANDEMIC WE
REDUCE THE COST TO MAKE ALMOST
NO COST FOUR PHONE CALLS IN FACT
BUT WHEN WE HAVE NOT. BE THE
EVEN THE ABILITY TO CALL YOUR
FAMILY. HAS BEEN EXTRAORDINARILY
EXPENSIVE SO. IT'S WE'VE GOT
THAT SITUATION AND AT THE SAME
TIME. THOSE WHO ARE INCARCERATED
ARE NOT ABLE TO SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES AND IN MANY CASES THEIR
FAMILIES ARE THEN NEEDING TO BE
SUPPORTED BY THE STATE. AND SO.
OR THEY COME OUT OF PRISON WITH
VERY HIGH DEATHS AND ALREADY
LIMITED ABILITY TO GET OUT OF
EMPLOYMENT WHICH JUST CONTINUES
THE CYCLE OF NOT ONLY POVERTY
FOR THE INDIVIDUAL BUT FOR THEIR
FAMILIES. AND SO. IS NOT A SMART
SYSTEM IT DOESN'T LAND LIKE SO
MANY THINGS WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING. IN ON THE BILL'S IS
IT DOESN'T LEND TO PUBLIC SAFETY
BECAUSE IF YOUR FAMILY IS NOT
SUPPORTED THEN THEY'RE PUT IN
DESPERATE STRAITS WHEN YOU
RETURN IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO
GET. A GOOD JOB THEN YOU'RE PUT
REAL QUALITY. JOB TRAINING IN
BEING EMPLOYED WHILE YOU'RE IN
THE FIRST RATED BENEFIT ALL US.
WE ALSO PROVE THE GOODS THAT ARE
MADE THERE. AND WILL BENEFIT THE
INDIVIDUAL. AND OF COURSE THEIR
FAMILIES SO I REALLY APPRECIATE.
OUR CHAIR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. I REALIZE IT'S GOING TO
HAVE IT IF WE ACTUALLY DO THIS
IT WILL HAVE SIGNIFICANT COSTS
BUT IT'S ABOUT TIME TO DO IT.
YEAH. THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER-
ANYWHERE ELSE. I JUST LIKE TO
HAVE JUST BASICALLY STATE THAT-
FOR THE RECORD I BELIEVE THAT
EVERYONE SHOULD BE WORKING AND I
I'M NOT SURE HOW THIS
INCENTIVIZES PEOPLE TO WANT TO
WORK OTHER IN COURT. RATHER HAVE
SO I'M ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN
EDUCATION- OR WORKING- TO BE
MOTIVATED INCENTIVIZE TO
ACTUALLY WORK AND HAVE SOMEONE
SITTING IDLY IN THIS AND SO- FOR
THOSE MEASURES I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY AND-
DO WE HAVE A MOTION. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR COME LONGER.
M. IN THE MOTION OF SENATOR BUT
FOR WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE. YEAH I
HAVE A TEN MINUTE CLOSER IF YOU
DON'T MIND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WE DO HAVE A MOTION THE MOTION
IS. DO BUT FIRST WE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
MEDICA'S HEALTH IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. S. P.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE IT CHAU BOGUE I
TROUBLE GUY COME LONGER KAMLAGER
AYE SKINNER. SKINNER I WINNER
WINNER I AM. PERFECT AND THE
BILL DOES PASS FIVE TWO ZERO.
RIGHT YES WE HAVE A COUPLE VITAL
ONLY'S FIRST YOU HAVE TO YOU
HAVE TO VOTE ONLY ITEMS SO
COUNCIL CAN YOU. DO I NEED TO
READ WHEN YOU WANT IT WILL YOU
NEED TO ASK FOR MOTION YEAH CAN
I GET A MOTION ON- SEPARATELY
ARE RIGHT OKAY. WE NEED A
MOTION. ON THIS VOTE ONLY ON. S.
B. TEN FORTY TWO BY SENATOR
GROWS OUR MOTION AND SET THE
TEMPERATURE. OKAY. YEAH NO
COMMENTS SO MOVED. OKAY ALL
RIGHT SB TEN FORTY TWO GROVE
BRADFORD- MR PEROT THE TROUBLE
OKAY FIVE ABOAGYE COM LONGER
COME LONGER KNOWS SKINNER.
GROWTH GROUPS CAN EARN NO.
WIENER WIENER NO BRADFORD.
ABSTAINED BARBARA EFFORT OF
STAINED IT'S- ONE TO THREE. THE
BILL FAILED OKAY THAT MEASURE
FAILS NEXUS S. B. THIRTEEN
THIRTY THREE BY SENATOR BATES.
THERE WERE A MOMENT- SHE TOOK
OUT- MID TO BILLS AND NUMBER OF
THE SECTIONS ME. IT'S STILL.
OKAY SO YOU AND EVERYONE ELSE IS
STILL SO CLOSE- S. B. THIRTEEN
OUT WE NEED A MOTION. GEN IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR JOE BALK
SB THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE BATES
BRADFORD NEW BRADFORD NOTRE
BOGUE TROUBLE GUY COME LONGER
COM LONGER KNOWS SKINNER.
SKINNER NOT VOTING WIENER WIENER
NO IT'S ONE TO THREE ONE TWO
THREE THE MEASURE FAILS. NOW
MEMBERS ARE WE CONCLUDED OUR
GENDER NOW WE'RE GONNA LOOK TO
CALL WE HAVE A LOT OF
OUTSTANDING ITEMS THAT ARE. WILL
START TALK. JOHN AS MEMBERS NINE
OH FOUR BATES THE CURRENT VOTE
IS FOUR ZERO WIENER. WIENER AYE
HIGH FIVES OUT FIVE ZERO- SB
NINE OH SIX PORTANTINO THE
CURRENT VOTE IS ONE AS TWO TWO
ZERO FIVE CHAIRS VOTING I'D
WIENER. WIENER I THREE ZERO.
ZERO THREE ZERO. SB NINE
NINETEEN JONES THE CURRENT VOTE
IS TO DO ZERO SHARES VOTING I.
SKINNER. WE NOW THIS IS JONES SB
NINE NINETEEN. JONES THE CALIBER
ONE NOT VIEWED OKAY. THERE ARE
NO AMENDMENTS. OKAY SKINNER
SKINNER NOT VOTING WIENER.
WIENER NOT VOTING THE VOTE IS
TWO TWO ZERO ZERO THAT MEASURE
FAILS S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE
JONES- BRADFORD. THERE WAS AT
THIS POINT IT'S ONE ZERO- WITH
BRADFORD NOT VOTING. THIS IS
OKAY. WE IF WE RESEND IT WITH
NOW IT'S WELL WE'D HAVE TO
RESCIND THAT AND GRANT
RECONSIDER WHEN IT FAILS WE
CAN'T HEAR THE GIVEN THE SAME
DAY. NOW WHAT DO WE WHAT DO WE
DO YOU IN THE OTHER COMMITTEE
WHERE- IF IT'S IF IT PASSES YOU
CAN RESCIND IN HERE THE SAME DAY
IF IT FAILS YOU CAN RESCIND
GRANT YOU CAN GRANT
RECONSIDERATION IN HERE AT THE
FIVE DAY ALL OF FALLING HEARING
WHICH WE AT THIS POINT THIS CALL
DEADLINE FRIDAY. BERNIE SANDERS. BUT WE CAN WE CAN OFFER
RECONSIDERATION. WELL YOU CAN
STILL DO RECONSIDERATION BUT WE
MIGHT HE MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO DO
IT. BUT YOU KNOW IF PEOPLE
REALLY WANTED TO HEAR IT WE
COULD GET TOGETHER ON THURSDAY
pLET'S I MEAN AT THIS POINT WHY
DON'T WE GRANT YOU CAN DO GREAT
CONSIDERATION AND WE CAN SEE IT
TODAY. GRAHAM MISTER JONES
CENTER JONES RECONSIDERATION ON
A S. B. NINE NINETEEN NINE
NINETEEN- S. OKAY SO S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE JONES THE
CURRENT VOTE IS ONE TWO ZERO
WITH THE JOB OF GOING ON A CALM
LONGER. COME LONGER AYE SKINNER
. THIS IS THE LICENSING ONE. NOW
BUT HE AGREED TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION ON THE ONE ON THE
LANGUAGE. FOUR YEARS. IF YOU ARE
YES SO IF YOU WANT. NOT VOTING
OKAY SKINNER NOT VOTING WIENER
UP WIENER AYE OKAY.
ADVERTISEMENT OKAY THE VOTE IS.
FOUR ZERO. FOUR ZERO THIRTEEN
SIXTY FIVE ALL RIGHT. SB NINE
EIGHTY SIX NUMBER THE VOTE IS.
THREE ZERO- WIENER. WIENER AYE
VOTE IS FOUR ZERO MEASURES OUT.
FOUR ZERO NINE EIGHTY SIX SB TEN
OH EIGHT BAKER THE VOTE IS TWO
TO ZERO A CHOI BOGUE. TEN A
EIGHTY SIX- IT HAS TO THE PHONES
AT JAILS AND PRISONS. NOT VOTING
THIS TROUBLED NOT VOTING-
SKINNER SKINNER I WINNER. WINNER
I'D THE VOTE IS. FOUR ZERO FOUR
ZERO AS THREE TEN OH EIGHT IS
OUT. K. CONSENT CALENDAR-
SKINNER SKINNER AYE WIENER
WIENER I'D THE CONSENT CALENDAR
HAS FIVE ZERO ZERO EXTENSION CO
OWNER. ARCHULETA R. S. B. TEN
SEVENTY SIX ARCHULETA- BRADFORD. THIS IS THE- THE LEAD PAINT
ONE. THE ACCOUNT IS TWO ZERO
EIGHT CHAU BOGAN WIENER AS ICE.
BARBARA BRADFORD I COME LONGER
COME LONGER AYE SKINNER SKINNER
I. PHOTOS FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO
IMAGES OF THIS BETWEEN SEVEN SIX
SB. FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT THE
VOTE AS A GLAZIER. THE VOTE IS
THREE ZERO. GLAZIER JACKET AND
MY OUT OF ORDER YEAH SORRY OKAY-
VOICE HOLD ON BUT I CAN GO BACK
TO A DIFFERENT BILL. THAT THAT
WAS A GOOD SIGN I DON'T I'M NOT
CALLING THE ONCE WE GOT OUT. SO
ANYTHING I DON'T CALL EVERYBODY
SHOULD BE ON- I WILL DOUBLE
CHECK BUT. ALL THE OTHER ONE
FOUR ONE SIX SEVEN OKAY BUT I
WILL GO TO NUMBER THIRTEEN- S.
B. THIRTEEN THE- THAT ONE'S
ALREADY AT THAT ONE'S ALREADY
HAS ALL THE MOVES- SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN HERTZBERG- THE VOTE
IS THREE TO ONE COM COM LONGER.
COME BY SO IT'S FORTY ONE. WE'RE. ONE THIRTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
ZERO. AS OF AN HOUR IT
FOURTEENTH SB FOURTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT GLAZIER- VOTERS THREE TWO
ZERO COM LONGER. COMMA I SKINNER
SKINNER AYE THE VOTE IS FIVE
ZERO FOUR TWO SIX EIGHT FIVE
ZERO LET MEASURES OUT. SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO STERN HE
DID SOME AMENDMENTS. MOSTLY
MOMENTS. AT THE VOTE IS THREE TO
ONE THREE TO ZERO AT THIS POINT-
SKINNER. SKINNER I'D- FOUR ZERO.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWOS OUT FOUR
ZERO. SB EIGHT THIRTY FOUR
WIENER THE VOTE IS TO ZERO COM
LOCKER. COMMA- I SKINNER. IT'S
EIGHT THIRTY FOUR WIENER. WIENER
AND SKINNER AYE FORTY ZERO.
THREE EIGHT THREE FOUR FOUR ZERO
IMAGES ARE. AT FROM TWELVE
TWENTY EIGHT WIENER- VOTERS
FORTY ZERO SKINNER. SKINNER AYE
FIVE ZERO ZERO SB TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT. SB TEN EIGHTY EIGHT
BRADFORD THE VOTE IS TWO TWO
ZERO SKINNER. SKINNER AYE WIENER. YES WHEN ARE AYE THE VOTE IS
FOUR ZERO. OR ZERO TEN EIGHTY
EIGHT SB TWELVE SIXTY TWO
BRADFORD THE VOTE IS THREE ZERO
. SKINNER SKINNER AYE WIENER.
WIENER I'D THAT'S FIVE TWO ZERO
S. B. TWELVE SIXTY TWO ZERO FIVE
ZERO- S. B. TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE- VOTERS THREE ZERO WIENER
. WHEN OUR EYES THE VOTE IS FOUR
ZERO. THE DRUGS NOT VOTING. OKAY
NO TROUBLED NOW SO THE VOTE IS
FOUR TO ONE SB TWELVE SEVENTY
THREE IS OUT FOR THE ONE. AND
THAT SHOULD BE IT GO. SURE. I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
INDIVIDUALS TO PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S TESTIMONY IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS AND RIDING TO THE
SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE THEM CLINCHER TESTIMONY
IN THE FISHER HEARING RECORDS
AND AGAIN THANK YOU IN WITH. ONE
FOR PATIENTS GRAYSON ALONG DAY
AND WE HAVE CONCLUDED. COMPLETED
AGENDA OF THE SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE WE STAND
ADJOURNED.